HAVE BEEN -- PULLED FROM OUR
AGENDA NUMBER NINE SB FOUR
EIGHTY SIX BY -- CENTER BATES
AND ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE BY CENTER STONE
THERE.
TOO AGENDA ITEMS ON CONSENT
THAT'S A ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
FOUR FIFTY TWO BY JONES CENTER
JONES AND ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
SB SEVEN A SIX BY CENTER
GALGIANI.
I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT IS BEEN
NOTICED ON OUR AGENDA THAT SB
TWO SEVENTY SIX AS BEING THE
FIRST OR BUSINESS HOWEVER -- AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR AS A
COURTESY TO CENTER PORTANTINO
WE'VE DECIDED TO ALLOW HIM TO
PRESENT HIS BILLS -- FIRST --
PRIOR TO THE HEARING SB -- TWO
SEVENTY SIX FOR ALL THE PEOPLE
IN THE AUDIENCE I WANT REMINDER
OF OUR COMMITTEE RULES AT WHICH
WE HAVE -- FOLLOWED CONSISTENTLY
THIS YEAR.
OUR PRACTICE IS IS THAT SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION ON EACH BILL HAS A
MAXIMUM OF SIX MINUTES TO
TESTIFY PER SITE TOTAL SO
HOWEVER MANY WITNESSES HE GOT
SIX MINUTES TOTAL.
WE FIRST BEGAN WITH THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL THEN WE
TAKE THE PUBLIC COME FROM THE
PROPONENTS THEN WE MOVED TO THE
POT OPPONENTS.
WHEN WE TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE BACK MICROPHONE THAT IS
LIMITED TO NAME AFFILIATION AND
THE POSITION ON THE BILL WHICH
IS BASED IN SUPPORT ARE IN
OPPOSITION?
THERE'S NO DISCUSSION OF THE
BILL OUTSIDE OF THAT ANY FURTHER.
EFFORT AT TESTIMONY OUTSIDE OF
THESE LIMITATIONS -- WE WILL ASK
YOU POLITELY -- HOPEFULLY HAVING
JUST BEFORE POLITELY CUT YOU OFF.
WELL WE'RE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
SEE CHILDREN PRESENT -- WE ARE
NOT PERMITTING.
CHILDREN -- TO TESTIFY -- TESTS
MAY BE LIMITED BELTS AND
ADOLESCENTS WHO CAN SPEAK ON
THEIR OWN BEHALF AND BE HALF OF
THEIR FAMILIES.
ALSO PLEASE REMEMBER THAT
COMMITTEE RULES DO NOT ALLOW FOR
ANY.
DEMONSTRATIONS THAT MEANS -- ANY
SORT OF VERBAL -- REMARKS --
CLAPPING BREWING HOLDING SIGNS
AND IT STRUCK THE VIEW OF OTHERS
IN THE HEARING ROOM.
IF YOU DO WISH TO SO IT SHOWS
SUPPORT FOR ANY REMARKS OR
ANYTHING YOU MAY DO THIS THAT'S
FINE THAT WILL BE ACCEPTABLE YOU
CAN WAVE YOUR HANDS -- IN
ADDITION I WANNA MAKE NOTE THAT
THE SERGEANTS IN THE ROOM ARE
HERE TO MAINTAIN ORDER IN THE
HEARING ROOM.
AT ALL TIMES IN THE SURE THAT
ARE HEARING RULES ARE IN ARE ARE
ARE ENFORCED -- THEY WILL.
ALSO HELP DIRECT WITNESSES AS WE
HAVE I THINK -- NUMEROUS
WITNESSES -- FOR SOME OF OUR
BILLS HERE TODAY AND I WILL NOW
ALLOW THE SERGEANTS TO GIVE
INSTRUCTION ON HOW THEY INTEND
TO PROCEED THIS AFTERNOON WITH --
OUR WITNESSES SO -- I WILL NOW
TURN IT OVER TO OUR SERGEANTS
FOR FURTHER EXPLANATION THANK
YOU SIR JUST A COUPLE MINUTES.
OF YOUR TIME IF YOU WOULD
SEATING IS VERY TIGHT OBVIOUSLY
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF FOLKS IN HERE
SO IT'LL BE FIRST COME FIRST
SERVE.
IF YOU NEED TO STEP OUT -- TO
USE THE RESTROOM HOPEFULLY WE
CAN IDENTIFY ANY GET YOU BACK IN
IF YOU TAKE A PHONE CALL PLEASE
TAKE IT OUTSIDE MAKE TREES
SILENCER LIKE TRONIC DEVICES
RIGHT NOW.
THE WHEN YOU LEAVE YOUR SEAT MAY
BE FILLED SO AGAIN IF YOU LEAVE
TAKE YOUR ITEMS WITH YOU WHEN WE
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT WE'RE GONNA
START DOWNSTAIRS FIRST WE'RE
GONNA GO ROW TO ROW STARTING
FROM THE FRONT THE BACK WE WILL
DIRECT YOU.
SO THAT EVERYONE GETS A CHANCE
TO SPEAK THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
GALLERY THEN WE WILL BRING IN
THE REST OF THE FOLKS IN THE
HALLWAY TO THE BACK DOORS AND
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY GETS A
CHANCE.
THE WILL BE THERE TO GUIDE FOLKS
AND PROVIDE ASSISTANCE IS NEEDED
THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP THINGS
SAFE AND MOVING ALONG SO IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS PLEASE FIND
ONE OF US.
WE HAVE COLOR DEVICES ON WERE
STANDING AROUND THE ROOM.
OTHER THAN THAT LET'S BE SAFE
LET'S DO THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT THAT WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN THIS
HEARING WE'RE FIRST GOING TO
TAKE UP.
I SHE SAID POINTING I WOULD DO
IS TAKE UP YOUR BILLS AND FOLLOW
ORDER.
OKAY SO FIRST ITEM WILL BE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN SB SIX HUNDRED
BY CENTER PORTANTINO WELCOME.
AND THANKS STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF -- TO INCLUDE AND
EXPAND THIS TO INCLUDE
MEDICARE'S -- SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
DO THAT AND TAKE THE THE CHAIRS --
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL SIX
CENTER WILL MAKE CLEAR WITHOUT A
DOUBT THAT THE STANDARD
FERTILITY PRESERVATION SERVICES
WHEN A MEDICALLY NECESSARY
TREATMENT MAY DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY.
CAUSE INFERTILITY ARE COVERED
ARE COVERED BENEFIT BECAUSE THE
LAW DOES NOT EXPLICITLY SPELL
OUT EACH AND EVERY COVERED
SERVICE THERE'S CONFUSION ABOUT
WHAT FERTILITY PRESERVATION IS.
MANY PATIENTS HAVE BEEN DENIED
COVERAGE DESPITE THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE REPEATEDLY
CONSISTENCY OVERTURNING HEALTH
PLAN DENIALS OF COVERAGE FOR
FERTILITY PRESERVATION THESE
WRONGFUL DELAYS IN THE NILES
CONTINUE. TO REGULARLY RECORDS
COVERAGE WITH PROMPT APPROVALS
FOR CARRIAGE COULD CALL FOR
ACCESS NO FRANKLY NO ONE SHOULD
BE A SHOULD HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN.
GETTING TREATMENT FOR CANCER AND
LOSING THEIR FERTILITY -- WE
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT -- WE'VE
TRIED OBVIOUSLY TRIED THIS
BEFORE AND I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR WORKING WITH MIKE -- STAFF
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I HAVE A FEW WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU SIX
MINUTES ONLY.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON GERMANIC MANY
MEMBERS HI MITCH ROSEN A
REPRODUCTIVE ENDOCRINOLOGIST AT
UCSF AND DIRECTOR OF OUR
FERTILITY PRESERVATION PROGRAM.
I WORK WITH PATIENTS ON ALMOST A
DAILY BASIS WHO ARE FACING
TREATMENT.
FACING IMMINENT MEDICAL
TREATMENT WHO COULD SAVE THEIR
LIVES BUT OFTEN AT THE COST OF
THEIR FERTILITY.
THESE PATIENTS ARE GENERALLY IN
SHOCK AND OVERWHELMED BY THEIR
SERIOUS DIAGNOSIS.
THEY HAVE TO MAKE COMPLEX
MEDICAL DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
CANCER TREATMENT.
AND THENON TOP OF THAT THEY
MUST QUICKLY DECIDE IF THEY MAY
ARE THEY MIGHT WANT TO HAVE
CHILDREN SOME DAY.
IF THEY DO THEY MUST TAKE
IMMEDIATE STEPS TO PRESERVE
THEIR FERTILITY.
ADVOCATES SUCH AS SHOWS ON A KEY
OF THE ALLIANCE FOR TELL
PRESERVATIO SITTING WITH US
TODAY.
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE TO OBTAIN COVERAGE FOR
INDIVIDUAL PATIENTS ALL
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEWS FOR
CANCER PATIENTS HAVE OVERTURNED.
YET WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS AND I'LL
WRITE THE NILES FOR THIS MEDICAL
NECESSARY TREATMENT.
DESPITE OUR CLINICAL SO OUR
CLINICS BEST EFFORTS TO OBTAIN
COVERAGE WE USUALLY ARE UNABLE
TO GET CLEAR DECISIONS IN TIME.
TO ALLOW THE PATIENTS TO UNDERGO
AN PRETTILY PRESERVATION
PROCEDURES PRIOR TO THE START OF
THEIR CANCER TREATMENT.
WHY IS THIS HERE SO IMPORTANT
RECENT STUDIES HAVE SHOWN MANY
PATIENTS ARE SO COMPARTE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT FUTURE
PARENTHOOD?
THAT THEY MAY NOT CHOOSE THE
RECOMMENDED THERAPIES THERE IS
EVIDENCE FOR EXAMPLE THAT
SUGGESTED ABOUT ONE THIRD OF PRE
MENOPAUSAL BREAST CANCER
PATIENTS DON'T INITIATE OR WILL
STOP THEIR TAMOXIFEN EARLY.
DUE TO FERTILITY CONCERNS WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE COVERAGE FOR
FERTILITY PRESERVATION.
SO WHILE WE HAVE KNOWN FOR A
LONG TIME THAT PATIENTS LEFT
INFERTILE FROM CANCER TREATMENT
SCORE WORSE I MEASURES OF
QUALITY OF LIFE AND UNRESOLVED
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY WE NOW
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS ISSUE.
CAN EVEN COMPROMISED THEIR
MEDICAL TREATMENT AND LEAD TO
WORSE OUTCOMES.
SB SIX HUNDRED WILL CLEAR FIVE
EXISTENCE OF COVERAGE FOR
MEDICAL NECESSARY FERTILITY
PRESERVATION.
SET THE TIMELY TREATMENT CAN BE
OBTAINED.
THANK YOU AND ON BEHALF OF UCSF
SRM MY PATIENTS AND MYSELF I ASK
FOR YOUR RIVALS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHANNON SMITH
CALLING ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY FOR REPRODUCTIVE
MEDICINE WAS CO SPONSORS OF BILL
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
YEARS SO I'M HERE FOR QUESTIONS.
HI AM CHOICE REINECKE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR FERTILITY
PRESERVATION AND WE ALSO HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS -- AND JOIN
TOGETHER TO TRY TO HELP PATIENTS
GET THIS COVERAGE IN TIME --
BECAUSE IT'S IRREVERSIBLE AND
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES REPORT
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
MIKE MIKE FROM PLEASE.
TURN.
IT ON TURN MEMBERS ALTAMONT IN
SMITH WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
I ALWAYS A CALL WITH CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION SUPPORT.
OKAY A SCENE OTHER WITNESSES AT
THE MICROPHONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME UP.
ACTUALLY YOU CAN PLEASE MAKE
SOME ROOM FOR THE OPPOSITION IN
FRONT.
RIGHT AWAY AROUND. THIRTY SIX
MINUTES MAX.
MAX I THINK I'LL BE SHORTER THAN
THAT GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
GENERALLY WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS -- AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TO HEAR
OUR CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL --
YOU KNOW CAP MUST OPPOSE THIS
BILL WE VIEW IT AS A BENEFIT
MANDATE AT WHICH WILL INCREASE
CONSUMER PREMIUMS -- ALWAYS
SYMPATHIZE WITH THE ISSUE
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW CURRENTLY
DEFINED HOUSE STATES COVER
BENEFITS UNDER THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT -- STATES REQUIRED TO
SLUDGE SELECT A BENCHMARK PLAN
THAT DEFINES HEALTH RELATED
SERVICES AND EQUIPMENT REFER TO
IS THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS --
SEVERAL BENEFIT MANDATES HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED THIS YEAR AND IN
AND IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
REACHED RECENT YEARS AT EVERY
TURN -- OUR MEMBERS REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CUMULATIVE
IMPACT OF BENEFIT MANDATES ON
PREMIUMS PARTICULARS WE FACE AN
INHERENT PRESSURES IN AN
INVOLVING MARKET -- YOU KNOW THE
TOTALITY OFTHE MANDATES BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR EQUAL
SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS -- AND
SO YOU KNOW THE COST OF THE
MONTHLY PREMIUM IS A PRIMARY
CONSIDERATIONS FOR CONSUMERS
WHEN THEY'RE SELECTING A PLAN.
I'M IN THE SO FAR CALIFORNIA'S
ON A MUCH BETTER JOB IT COMPARED
TO MOST OTHER STATES IN KEEPING
COVERAGE AFFORDABLE -- BUT WE
STILL HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY -- AND WE FEEL
THAT IT'S YOU KNOW IMPERATIVE TO
KEEP -- KEEP THE COST OF CARE.
LOW.
SO A COMBINATION OF THESE
FACTORS CONSUMER PRICE
SENSITIVITY AND EXCEEDING.
YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY EXCEEDING
THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS
MAKE IT A PART PARTICULARLY BAD
TIME TO PASS NEW BENEFIT
MANDATES.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SEVENTY RECKONS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WE TOO ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL I THINK EVERYONE AT
THIS TABLE AND IN THIS ROOM
HEART GOES OUT TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SUFFERING
FROM CANCER OTHER DISEASES THAT
MAY CAUSE INFERTILITY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO HAVE A LOT
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THIS WOULD GO BEYOND CANCER
PATIENTS AND INCLUDE OTHER
INSTANCES FOR WHICH THEY WOULD
BE SEEKING TREATMENT.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LENGTH OF COVERAGE ENERGY BURKE
TALKED ABOUT A ONE YEAR OF
STORAGE WE CERTAINLY DON'T THINK
THAT THAT'S PROBABLY A REALISTIC.
EXPECTATION SO WE WOULD HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO ABANDON EMBRYOS WHAT
WOULD BE THE LENGTH OF SERVICE
AND THE GENERAL COST.
NEXT TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA'S
LOOKING AN IMPOSING AN
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE ALONG WITH
SUBSIDIES TO ASSIST PEOPLE IN
ACCESSING CARE WE THINK WE NEED
TO BE EXCEPTIONALLY PRICE
SENSITIVE TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
LOOKING TO PURCHASE COVERAGE.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE BACK FROM.
HEARING SARKISIAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WHERE OPPOSED DUE TO THE
INCREASED HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS
FOR EMPLOYERS AND AND RELEASE
ALL RIGHT NEED NAME.
LARGE ASIAN POSITION JOHN WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE F. AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS ECHO THE
SAME COMMENTS CAPITA CLICK.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES.
THE QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
PORTANTINO FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD -- I TO HAVE A
PASSION AND HEART FOR
INDIVIDUALS GETTING CANCER
TREATMENT AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF IF IT IS GOING TO
RESULT IN INFERTILITY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S THAT THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AND CHILD
VERY NEEDS TO BE ABLE STORE
THEIR EMBRYOS.
I DO HAVE TWO QUESTIONS ONE THE
WAY READ THE BILL IT MAKES IT
SOUND LIKE WHAT YOU ARE
PROPOSING IS ALREADY IN LAWYERS
CLEAR FINER CODIFYING IT I
COULDN'T FIND THAT IN THE
STATUTE CAN YOU DIRECT ME TO
WHERE THAT IS.
OR CAN SOMEONE SORRY.
AND ACTUALLY THAT'S THE GREAT
QUESTION BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT OUR
FRUSTRATION IS -- EVERY APPEAL
HAS BEEN OVERTURNED AND SO WHY
NOT MAKE IT CLEAR SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO SO SHOULD
GENERAL GIVE YOU THE ACTUAL.
CYLINDER THE KNOX KEEN ACT IT'S
A BROAD UMBRELLA OF MEDICALLY
NECESSARY SERVICES FOR INSTANCE.
IF YOU LOOK FOR AN APPENDECTOMY
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO FIND IT.
AND SO WHAT YOU WILL FIND OFTEN
IS IF YOU LOOKING EVIDENCES OF
COVERAGE WHAT YOU'LL SEE IS
INFERTILITY.
AND INFERTILITY IS MOST OFTEN
NOT COVERED.
SO THERE'S A BEEN A CONFUSION
ABOUT FERTILITY PRESERVATION
UNDERSTANDABLY MOST PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW THE PROVISION.
AND FERTILITY PRESERVATION AND
JUST TO BACK UP THE DAMAGE THE
JUST ISSUED A CEASE AND DESIST
ORDER.
AGAINST ONE OF THE PLANS IS
FEELING TO PAY.
OKAY.
SO THEY ARE CONVINCED IT IS
COVERED BENEFIT OKAY I'M GLAD I
MEAN I'M NOT SAYING I'M GLAD YOU
CAN FIND BECAUSE I CAN FIND IT
AND AND MY STAFF CAN FIND I
APPRECIATE STAFF.
IS THERE CAN I AM CAN HEALTH
PLANS RESPOND PLEASE IF -- YOU
KNOW MY MEMBERS ARE FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS NO STATUTE
REQUIRING THIS COVERAGE THERE'S
BEEN NO REGULATIONS ISSUED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HAND MANAGED
HEALTHCARE.
REGARDING THIS COVERAGE AND A
BILL IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN WAS VETO THAT WAS.
EIGHTY NINE TWELVE AND THE VETO
MESSAGE MESSAGE READS WHY I
UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE TO
PRESERVE FERTILITY WHERE
POSSIBLE SUCH COVERAGE WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED.
A FOR INDIVIDUAL COVERAGE AND
SMALL GROUP COVERAGE.
AND SO I MEAN THAT'S THANK YOU.
THAT'S THE THE CLARITY THAT I
HAVE FOR MY MEMBERS THANK YOU
AGAIN AND AT SENATOR MY SECOND
QUESTION IS IT -- HIM FOR LIFE
NOT GONNA.
SAM NINE TO BED -- I GUESS YOU
GATHER HARVEST FIFTEEN EMBRYOS
YEAH.
YOU ONLY NEED ONE OR TWO WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE REST OF THEM IS
THERE SOME KIND OF MECHANISM FOR
I THINK THOSE SOLAR I I THINK
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION AND WHAT
THE ADVANCES IN FERTILITY.
HARVESTING EGGS IS BECOME JUST A
SUCCESSFUL -- AND SO MORE AND
MORE FERTILITY EFFORTS ARE ARE
ARE EIGHT BASED AS OPPOSED TO
EMBRYO BASED MENU IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK TO THAT.
AND THE FIRST THE STE YOU CAN
ALSO CLARIFY THE OTHER ISSUES AS
WELL.
ONLY A DOCTOR ROSEN'S BRING TO
THE THE OVERSIGHT HARVESTING AND
AND THE EMBRYOS BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS.
ON THE TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
THE MANDATE WE WERE LOOKING TO
ADD THIS AS COVERAGE BECAUSE IT
WAS NOT YET THE STANDARD OF CARE.
AND THAT'S WHEN WE WERE LOOKING
IN PREVIOUS BILLS TO ADD IS A
MANDATE.
IN THE INTERIM IT HAS BECOME THE
STANDARD OF CARE WE WERE
THINKING ABOUT DOING ANOTHER
BILL ACTUALLY MEANT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HE SAID WELL
NOW THAT IT IS THE STANDARD OF
CARE IT MEETS THE CRITERIA FOR
BEING MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
AND YOU DO NOT NEED A SPECIFIC
STATUTE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY WITH SB ONE
SEVENTY TWO TWO YEARS AGO WE
ACTUALLY STE.
PAUSE TO THE BILL BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T THINK WE NEEDED IT WE
JUST IN PARTICULARLY MS ROENICKE
WORKED ON VERY HARD WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
TO HAND WALK THESE PATIENTS
THROUGH THE INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEW PROCESS AND EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THE CANCER PATIENTS.
THEIR DENIAL WAS OVERTURNED BUT
THE ONLY PATIENTS WHO COULD GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS WERE THOSE
WHO WERE ABLE TO PAY FOR THE
SERVICES UP FRONT.
AND GET REIMBURSED BECAUSE THIS
COULD TAKE WEEKS OR MONTHS TO
GET RESOLVED AND SOMEBODY MIGHT
LITERALLY HAVE.
A WEEK OR TWO TO GET.
SERVICES SO IN IN IN IS TO THE
THE A GOOD EMBRYO QUESTION YOU
KNOW YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THE
STANDARD OF CARE.
THANK YOU.
SO REALLY QUICKLY -- SO.
LET'S OVER TEN YEARS AGO ECHO
PRESERVATION WASN'T REALLY
ESTABLISH KERR SO AS WE WERE IT
WAS IN THE EXPERIMENTAL PHASE.
AND THEN IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
IT BECAME MORE OF US IT BECAME
MORE OF A STANDARD CARE
ESTABLISH AND NOW IT'S AT A
POINT WHERE.
HAS EQUAL SUCCESS TWO EMBRYOS SO
ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE STANDARD
OF CARE.
EXEMPTION OR THE THE INCLUSION
WASN'T INCLUDED IN THE ORIGINAL
NEGOTIATED LANGUAGE AT THAT WE
DID IT.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE OR
THIRTEEN WHAT I'M WHAT I'M
SAYING IS I'M NOT ABOUT I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THE LANGUAGE THERE
I'M JUST SAYING AS FAR AS PART
OF THAT.
THE IN THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY HOW
WE TREAT PATIENTS BECAUSE YOU
HAD SOME CONCERNS ABOUT EMBRYOS
AND YES THEY WANTED TO AMBER IN
ONLY NEEDING LET'S SAY WANTED TO
EMBRACE WHAT WOULD WE DO WITH
THE REST OF THOSE EMBRYOS.
THE WHERE THE TREND IS AT THIS
POINT IS MOSTLY TO FREEZE AXE
OKAY NOT EMBRYOS BRITAIN SO --
THERE WE DO STILL DO THAT ON
OCCASION BUT THERE ARE -- IT'S
DEFINITELY THE TENDENCY IS FOR
X. TWO X. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND IF I COULD ADD
ACTUALLY CHAIR -- THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WERE HERE'S ON
THE ORIGINAL.
LAWS WERE CREATED WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE ADVANCEMENTS INFERTILITY
THAT WE DO TODAY SO.
ACTUALLY SORRY TO INTERRUPT BUT
I SEE THE TENT THAT PRESENCE OF
A QUORUM AND I WOULD LIKE TO
CALL THE ROLL.
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CAN.
CAN HEAR STONE.
STONE HERE DOURADO GROVE.
GROWTH HERE HER TADO LEYVA
MITCHELL.
THE BILL HERE MITCHELL HERE.
MORNING MORNING HERE RUBIO.
WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU.
BUT WITH THE I'D SO THERE'S A
MOTION ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SEEING NONE.
SIR PORTANTINO I MEAN IT'S
PRETTY SHEET TO YOU CARRYING
THIS BILL TO BE SURE THAT --
THAT WE CONTINUE TO ALLOW THESE
PATIENTS TO BE ABLE -- TO TO TO
BASICALLY HAVE YOU KNOW HAVE THE
OPTION -- FOR FOR HAVING
CHILDREN AND THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR STONE WHICH
LIKE CLOTHES.
WE ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE THANKS
VERY MUCH -- SO AGAIN THE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE MANTA
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible] FOR
NEIL
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- PRESENTING -- SB
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WHICH WILL
REQUIRE -- HOSPITALS THAT HAVE A
BUILDING THAT IS NOT COMPLIANT
WITH THE JANUARY ONE TWENTY
THIRTY SEISMIC SAFETY STANDARD.
TO REPORT TO THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT WHAT SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED IN EACH BUILDING OF
THAT HOSPITAL I'LL BE BRIEF
TODAY AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I
THINK THERE'S A FEW PEOPLE HERE --
WITH SOME OTHER IT BILLS AND I
DON'T WANT TO TAKE TOO MUCH TIME
BUT OUR HOSPITALS ARE SPEND
BILLIONS TO MEET CURRENT SEISMIC
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THE
BUILDINGS WILL NOT COLLAPSE.
THE MAJOR EARTHQUAKE PROTECTING
PATIENTS EMPLOYEES AND FAMILIES
AS OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO ALL OF
OUR HOSPITALS WILL MEET THIS
REQUIREMENT HOSPITALS MUST NOW
TURN TO THE TWENTY THIRTY
REQUIREMENT WHICH REQUIRES THEM.
TO ENSURE THEY WERE IN TIRES
FACILITY IS FULLY OPERATIONAL
AFTER AN EARTHQUAKE AND
ACCORDING TO A RECENT RAND STUDY
THIS WOULD COST HOSPITALS.
THIRTY FOUR TO A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS -- WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT COST ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE CONSIDER HOW TO CONTROL COST
GROWTH IN HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IS
FRANKLY SOMETHING EVERYBODY
WANTS TO DO.
SB SEVEN FIVE EIGHT CURRENTLY
REQUIRES HOSPITALS REPORT THE
LOCATION O THEIR SERVICES TO
THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE HELPFUL AS
WE FOCUS ON THE TWENTY THIRTY
MANDATE -- WE ENCOURAGE THOSE
WHO WILL TESTIFY WITH CONCERNS
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION AND I
THINK THAT'S THE MAIN -- TAKE
AWAY HERE WAS WE REALLY NEED TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION BECAUSE THE
DOLLARS ARE SIGNIFICANT THE
CLOCK IS TICKING AND WE NEED TO
ALL COME TOGETHER AND HAVE A
REASONABLE CONVERSATION AND I
RESPECT.
THAT THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING UP TO
NOW AND HOPE IT CONTINUES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT
CATHERINE ALSO SCOUT THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
I THINK THE UTHOR SAID IT BEST
ALTHOUGH WE WOULD ADD TO THE
HOSPITALS ARE COMMITTED. TO
PROVIDING CRITICAL SERVICES POST
DISASTER I WE ARE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO DISCUSS THE
REALITY OF THE COSTS RELATED TO
THE TWENTY THIRTY MANDATE LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUING THAT
CONVERSATION.
AND THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BACK LIKE FRONT HONEY
DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORUM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- SEEN.
PEOPLE MICROPHONE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME UP [inaudible]
AMONG THE SORRY SORRY.
HI WELCOME SIX MINUTES TOTAL TO
INTERVIEW.
MR TURN MEMBERS AT TAYLOR
JACKSON OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION CNN HAS A CONCERN
POSITION ON SB SEVEN FIVE EIGHT
BECAUSE THE BILL IS CURRENTLY IN
A WHAT WE BELIEVE IS A
SUBSTANTIVE SPOT FORM.
IT HAS BEEN MADE CLEAR TO US THE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL IS TO
MAKE A BROAD ELIMINATION OF
HOSPITAL BUILDING SEISMIC SAFETY
STANDARDS.
THIS IS NOT AN EXTENSION OF TIME
LINES BUT AN ATTEMPT TO TAKE
AWAY HEALTH CARE FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AT THE VERY MOMENT
THEY'LL NEED IT MOST.
RIGHT AFTER A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE
JUST KEEPING A HOSPITAL STANDING
IS NOT ENOUGH YOUR CONSTITUENTS
WILL CONTINUE TO DELIVER BABIES
HAVE HEART ATTACKS OR STROKES.
AND RECEIVE TREATMENT FOR THE
LIKELY CRUSH INJURIES A MAJOR
SEISMIC EVENT CAUSES DO WE
REALLY WANT LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS
AND PARAMEDICS TO SPEND THEIR
TIME POST DISASTER.
MOVING PEOPLE FROM A TWO HUNDRED
BED HOSPITAL TO ANOTHER FACILITY
TO COUNTIES OVER I WOULD
PERSONALLY PREFER THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO FOCUS ON DISASTER
VICTIMS AND THE ROLE AS
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL.
THIS BILL IS A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT AND NURTURE THE NURSES
ARE TO THIS COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO
ON SB SEVEN FIVE EIGHT TODAY.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK MENDOZA
WITH THIS YEAR YOU WE ARE ALSO
OUT OF CONCERN -- POSITION THE
BASIS FOR OUR CONCERNS IS THAT
THAT SPONSORED THE BILL THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
HAS INDICATED THEIR INTENTION TO
USE THIS.
AS A VEHICLE TO ADDRESS THE
BROADER QUESTION OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THE TWENTY THIRTY SEISMIC.
A DEADLINE AS HE ARE YOU
BELIEVES IN UPHOLDING THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN PASSING
THE TWENTY THIRTY STANDARD WILL
ENSURE THAT HOSPITALS ARE NOT.
NOT ONLY USING STATE STRUCTURES
POST EARTHQUAKE.
BUT WHAT THEY ARE USEFUL IN THE
PROVISION OF LIFESAVING
EMERGENCY AND OTHER -- HEALTH
CARE TREATMENT IN THE WAKE OF A
MAJOR SITES MAKE OF IN
CALIFORNIA.
HOSPITALS HAVE HAD TWENTY FIVE
YEARS SO FAR TO PLAN FOR
COMPLIANCE.
THEY HAVE TEN MORE YEARS BEFORE
THEY ARE SUBJECT TO THE STANDARD
AS HE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA KNOWS
THAT WITH EACH YEAR WHILE OUR
MEMORIES OF NORTHRIDGE AND SAN
FERNANDO FATE.
THE POSSIBILITY OF A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE INCREASE AS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR MOVING
FORWARD TO ENSURE CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO LIFE.
SAVING EMERGENCY SERVICES IN THE
EVENT OF AN EARTHQUAKE DISASTER
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
MUST EXPRESS OUR CONCERN WITH SB
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT AS IT COMES
BEFORE YOU AND COMMITTEE THANK
YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THEIR FLOCKS CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE ALSO HAVE
THAT CONCERNS POSITION IT WOULD
LIKE TO BE INVOLVED IN
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD --
AS WE REPRESENT WORKERS IN
HOSPITALS AND IN THE BUILDING
TRADES WHO WOULD BE PERFORMING
THE SEISMIC UPGRADES THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SEEN OTHER --
WITNESSES AT THE MICROPHONE
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBER
CENTER STONE THANK YOU MISTER --
SENATOR PORTANTINO I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD TO START THE
CONVERSATION -- TWENTY THIRTY IS
JUST A SHORT ELEVEN YEARS AWAY
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
NOT BILLIONS BUT HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AT MANY
SMALL HOSPITAL DISTRICTS DON'T
HAVE A SPECIAL SUMMON MY RULE
AREAS.
AND IF IT'S FULLY IMPLEMENTED AS
A LAWS WRITTEN THEY WILL GO OUT
OF BUSINESS AND THERE WILL BE NO
JOBS FOR NURSES ARE WE KNOW
PLACES. FOR FOR PATIENTS AGO SO --
WE THIS BILL IS BASICALLY
INSTIGATING A CONVERSATION THAT
NOBODY IS HAVING ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ADDRESS A SEISMIC
RETROFITTING OF HOSPITALS TO
MAKE THEM SAFE. FOR OUR PATIENTS
WALL OF THE SAME TIME
UNDERSTANDING THE THE ECONOMICS
AND FINING NEWER TECHNOLOGIES TO
ALLOW US ACCOMPLISH THESE GOALS
AND COST EFFECTIVE WAYS SO THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE A TO A TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR DAY CHARGE
IN A HOSPITAL BECAUSE WE INVEST
ALL OVER MONEY IN A AND
RETROFITTING THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE NECESSARY BUT THE CONCERNS
ARE WELL TAKEN -- BUT THE STUFF
JUST STARTS THE CONVERSATION WE
NEED START TALKING ABOUT IT NOW
AND I'M DELIGHTED TO TO MOVE
YOUR BILL.
OKAY ANY OTHER BUT S. CENTER
MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD INTO ADDRESS.
THE CONCERNS OF THE OPPONENTS
SOME.
WE DEALT WITH THIS ISSUE WHEN I
CHAIREDTHE HEALTH COMMITTEE IN
THE ASSEMBLY. TO RECURRING
CHALLENGE IN A BALANCING ACT OF
ON THE ONE HAND PROTECTING THE
SAFETY OF PATIENTS AND HOSPITAL
WORKERS AS A PRIMARY PRIORITY
FOR ALL OF US.
AND ON THE OTHER HAND HAVING
PATHWAYS TO RETROFITTING IN.
SAFETY SEISMIC RETROFITTING.
SO THAT WE DON'T TAKE AWAY.
AN EMERGENCY ROOM ACCESS IN A
RURAL AREA -- THAT COULD LEAD TO
LOSS OF LIVES BEFORE THE
EARTHQUAKE SO.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH THE OPPONENTS -- ON THEIR
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHOR AS WE
MOVE THIS FORWARD AND TRY TO
FIND THAT CORRECT BALANCE BUT IN
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD
IN.
I THINK WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR STONE.
OKAY.
A SCENE OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS I JUST WANNA SAY THAT --
FIRST OF ALL -- I IF FOR THE
OPPOSITION I HEAR YOUR CONCERNS --
AND CERTAINLY WE DO NOT.
THE NOT LOOKING FOR A YOUNG.
IT'S A FRAZIER YOUR CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS IS GONNA BE OVERLY
EXPANSIVE AND AND WHAT'S BEEN
REALLY THINKING ABOUT -- WHAT
HOW DO WE KEEP PATIENTS SAFE
DURING A DISASTER AND I?
AND BUT I I HAVE NO I HAVE SOME
CONFIDENCE I HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
CENTER PORTANTINO IN TERMS OF
THE NATURE OF DISCUSSION
CERTAINLY I EXPECT THAT WE WILL
BE CONTINUING GAUGED WE KNOW
THAT THIS BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM STARS A LOT OF OPEN
QUESTIONS THERE -- BUT CERTAINLY
I THINK WE WANT YOUR INPUT AND
ORDER FORM THE BILL THAT SHE
TAKES AND IT TURNS OUT THAT
SOMETHING PLACE WHERE YOU'VE
THAT -- THAT -- THERE'S
CONSIDERABLE CONCERN I THINK YOU
KNOW THERE WILL BE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES BUT I THINK THIS
IS IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO
HAVE AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL
BE PART OF THAT CONVERSATION BUT
ALSO CERTAINLY WANT.
TO KNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE --
YEAR CONCERNS ABOUT WILL WHERE
EXACTLY THIS GONNA LAND AND WANT
TO BE SURE THAT WE DON'T LAND IN
A PLACE THAT -- THAT CERTAINLY --
SIMILAR NURSES WHO ARE ARE
PROFESSIONALS WHO WORKING IN THE
HOSPITAL FEEL THAT IS IT IS
UNSAFE SO -- SO WITH THAT I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT LOOK
FOR TO THE ON GOING CONVERSATION
SO THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STONE US THERE PORTANTINO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE OUT
BRIEFLY -- AND ELIMINATING THE
MANDATE IS NOT.
IN IN THE BILL AND YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS.
AND THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES BECAUSE TRUE TO WHAT
WE'RE AFTER HERE IS A IS A
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION.
AND SO THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING
THE BILL IN WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY SO THE BILL IS -- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CAN
BUY AN ICE STONE.
STONE I'D TO RAZA GROW.
GROVE I HER TADO LEYVA MITCHELL
MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES WILL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU FOR
MY CENTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR LETTING US GO
FIRST PORTION.
HEY WILL NOW RETURN TO SPECIAL
ORDER -- CENTER STONE'S VICE
CHAIR.
IF YOU WANT TO HEAR.
OKAY MORE EMOTIONAL YEAH
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND I WILL
.
OKAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
WELCOME TO THE CAPITAL FOR HERE
TO HEAR NOW.
SB [inaudible]
TWO SEVENTY SIX DOCTOR PAN
[inaudible]
SIGN UP [inaudible]
SENATE [inaudible]
THIS.
OKAY TO REMIND THE AUTHOR IN THE
PROPONENTS OF THE WILL HAVE SIX
MINUTES -- WITH THE WITNESSES
AFTER SENATOR PENN MIXES
PRESENTATION.
AND CAM OKAY THANK YOU.
VICE CHAIR SENATORS.
I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE TO
PRESENT SB SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY SIX THE BILL THAT
MAINTAINS AND RESTORES INTEGRITY
TO MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS TO LEGALLY
REQUIRED VACCINES FOR SCHOOL
ENROLLMENT.
THE FIRST WAS STATE THAT I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND I THINK THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS --
AMENDMENTS SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
ENSURES THAT STUDENTS WHO TRULY
NEED A MEDICAL EXEMPTION WILL
RECEIVE EXEMPTION WALRUS KEEPING
THE SAME CHILDREN SAFE AT SCHOOL
BY ENSURING THAT THERE'S
COMMUNITY MUNITY.
THIS BILL PROTECTS THE RIGHTS OF
THESE CHILDREN TO ATTEND SCHOOL
ENSURES CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO GO ABOUT THEIR
COMMUNITY WITHOUT BEING AT RISK.
OF BEING INFECTED WITH SERIOUS
PREVENTABLE DISEASES.
THERE HAVE ALREADY BEEN SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX CASES OF
MEASLES I HOPE THAT'S THE MOST
RECENT NUMBER BECAUSE IT KEEPS
GOING UP REPORT IN THE UNITED
STATES THIS YEAR WITHOUT BREAKS
OF THREE HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
CASES IN NEW YORK CITY.
A HUNDRED NINE EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETY NINE CASES IN ROCKLAND
COUNTY NEW YORK SEVENTY FOUR
CASES IN WASHINGTON STATE FORTY
AND FORTY THREE CASES IN
MICHIGAN.
ALL OF THESE OUTBREAKS OF
SPREADING COMMUNITIES WITH LOW
VACCINATION RATES.
THEY HAVE ALSO BEEN OVER THIRTY
MEASLES CASES IN CALIFORNIA THIS
YEAR INCLUDING THREE SEPARATE
CASES AND AT LA ACTS AND THE
MOST RECENTLY HAD TWO CASES HERE
IN SACRAMENTO THEY ARE JUST
REPORTED.
MANY OF THESE INVOLVED
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE WHO OFTEN
CATCH MEASLES OVERSEAS AND THEN
RETURN TO CALIFORNIA WITH THE
DISEASE.
IN FACT JUST YESTERDAY SHASTA
COUNTY REPORT AN INFANT TOO
YOUNG TO BE VACCINATED IS
CONFIRMED HAVE MEASLES WHO WAS
INFECTED BY UNVACCINATED WOMAN.
AS REPORTED IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE WELL MEASLES HAS BEEN
BROUGHT TO CALIFORNIA ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS THIS YEAR UNLIKE OTHER
STATES.
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT SUFFERED A
LARGE OUTBREAK.
MEASLES OUTBREAK LIKE THE ONE
THAT WE EXPERIENCED THAT BEGAN
AT DISNEYLAND TWENTY FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIFTEEN BECAUSE THIS
LEGISLATURE TOOK ACTION.
BY PASSINGSB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
THAT BEGAN RESTORING TO MEDIUM
UNITY TO NEIGHBORHOODS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN FACT SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN HAS
BEEN.
SUCCESSFUL IN RAISING STATE
VACCINATION RATES FOR EACH AND
KINDERGARTEN ENTERING CLASS
ABOUT 95% ENOUGH TO BEGIN
RESTORING THIS COMMUNITY THE
SHIELD THAT PROTECTS OUR
COMMUNITIES.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS
PROTECTIONS ALSO BEING
UNDERMINED.
BY A HANDFUL OF UNSCRUPULOUS
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE PROFITING
FROM PUTTING CHILDREN AT RISK
AND MAKING OUR SCHOOLS LESS SAFE.
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN DID NOT
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGE THE GRANT
TO MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS BY
PHYSICIANS AND FACT THE
EXPECTATION WAS THAT EACH CHILD
WOULD BE VALUED BY THEIR OWN
PHYSICIAN WHO RIDLEY CARE FOR
THEM.
AND WHO THEN EVALUATE WHETHER
THEY NEED AN EXEMPTION BY
APPLYING THE STANDARD OF CARE.
HOWEVER AFTER THE PASSAGE OF SB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN WHAT WE ACTUALLY
WITNESS WERE PHYSICIANS TO
ADVERTISE EXEMPTION FOR CASH ON
SOCIAL ME IN THE INTERNET.
MANY OF THEM WHO ARE NOT THE RED
CHILD'S REGULAR PHYSICIAN.
IN FACT WE'D SEE SOME PARENTS
POST -- ON SOCIAL MEDIA THAT
THEIR CHILD THE CHILD'S ACTUAL
POSITION TO REGULAR POSITION
REFUSED TO GRANT THE CHILD
MEDICAL EXEMPTION SO THEY TRAVEL
TO GO PURCHASE ONE FROM A
DISTANT POSITION.
AN INVESTIGATION BY THE VOICE OF
SAN DIEGO OF MEDICAL EXEMPTION
SUBMITTED TO THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SHOW THAT ONE PHYSICIAN TO
ADVERTISE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS ON
HER WEBSITE ISSUED ALMOST A
THIRD OF ALL THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS IN SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THE POSITION WHO ISSUED THE
SECOND MOST NUMBER OF MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHO WAS NOT A
SPECIALIST IN PEDIATRICS IS
ACTUALLY ON PROBATION WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD FOR GROSS
NEGLIGENCE IN THIS ARE AND
TREATMENT OF PATIENTS.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT PROMINENT
ANTI VACCINE PHYSICIAN DR BOB
SEARS WHO'S ALSO ON PROBATION
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD FOR GROSS
NEGLIGENCE AND REPEATED
NEGLIGENT ACTS. FOR GRANTING AN
APPROPRIATE MEDICAL EXEMPTION%
ISSUE THE FOURTH GREATEST NUMBER
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS AND SACK IN
THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
THE RESULT OF THESE BAKER
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS WAS MORE THAN
A TRIPLING OF THE NUMBER OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IN THE STATE.
BUT MORE CONCERNING AS INITIALLY
REPORTED BY THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES.
THERE ARE SEVERAL SCHOOLS OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTION RATES ABOVE
20% AND EVEN SOME AS HIGH AS 50%.
MANY STUDENTS AT THESE SCHOOLS
ARE AT RISK FOR A MAJOR OUTBREAK.
THESE SCHOOLS WITH THESE LOW
VACCINATION RATES REPRESENT THE
TENDER BRED DISEASE WILDFIRE
THAT CAN HARM THE BROADER
COMMUNITY.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT ALLOW A
HANDFUL OF UNSCRUPULOUS
POSITIONS TO PUT OUR CHILDREN IN
DANGER.
PARTICULARLY BABIES TOO YOUNG TO
BE VACCINATED IN CHILDREN WHO
GENUINELY NEED A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
AND THAT IS WHY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS ARE THE SPONSORS OF
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX ALONG WITH
THE PARENTS OF ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA.
POSITIONS ARE HOLDING THEMSELVES
INTO COLLEAGUES ACCOUNTABLE TO
PRACTICING QUALITY CARE BASED ON
SCIENCE TO KEEP THE PUBLIC SAFE.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX WERE REQUIRED
POSITIONS IN THE FUTURE TO
SUBMIT REQUESTS FOR MEDICAL
EXEMPTION TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT LIKE HEALTH PREVAIL
YOU ATION.
THE BILL REQUIRES BASIC
INFORMATION FROM THE POSITION
INCLUDING YOUR NAME IN LICENSE
NUMBER AND THE REASON FOR THE
EXEMPTION.
THE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
OR HER DESIGNATE A REVIEW THAT
REQUEST AND ISSUE AN APPROVAL OR
DENIAL WITH AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
APPEAL WHEN CLARIFYING
INFORMATION SUBMITTED.
REQUESTS WILL BE EVALUATED USING
EVIDENCE BASED GUIDELINES
PUBLISHED ANNUALLY BY THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES.
THESE GUIDELINES INCLUDE
CONTRADICT ASIANS AND
PRECAUTIONS FOR AVOIDING OR
DELAYING VACCINATION WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE END OF CARE.
I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT THESE
GUIDELINES ARE OFTEN VERY UP THE
CAUTIONARY BECAUSE EVEN IF
THERE'S A REMOTE CHANCE OR MAYBE
HARM THAT BECOMES A PRECAUTION.
CURRENT STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT
TO THE ISSUE A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
TO CURRENT STATE LAW.
IT REQUIRES THAT THE ISSUE
MEDICAL EXEMPTION POSITIONS MUCH
VERIFIED THAT THE CHILD'S
PHYSICAL CONDITION OR MEDICAL
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE SUCH THAT THE
MUSICIANS.
IS NOT CONSIDERED SAFE.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX WILL PROVIDE
THE OVERSIGHT REQUIRED TO ENSURE
WIDELY ACCEPTED.
EVIDENCE BASED STANDARD OF CARE
SAFETY GUIDELINES ARE APPLIED
FOR MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS ARE
ISSUED SO OTHER CHILDREN ARE NOT
ENDANGERED.
CURRENTLY MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS ARE
ISSUED BY FAMILIES THE BY
POSITIONS TO FAMILIES TO SUBMIT
THEM TO SCHOOLS UNFORTUNATELY
THIS MEANS THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ON WHICH CHILDREN
HAVE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
THAT'S SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
REQUIRE ALL EXISTING MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS BE FILED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TE PART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH DREAMED TO REMAIN VALID
AND THESE EXEMPTIONS WILL BE
INITIALLY GRANDFATHERED WITHOUT
REQUIRING FURTHER REVIEW.
HOWEVER TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
WE ARE POWERING STATE AND COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICERS WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO INVALIDATE
INAPPROPRIATE EXEMPTIONS TO MAKE
COMPROMISE THE SAFETY OF
CHILDREN IN PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE SUBMISSION OF MEDICAL
POSITIONS TO PUBLIC HEALTH
PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT PROVIDES
IMPORTANT INFORMATION TO CONTAIN
AN OUTBREAK.
IN THE EVENT OF AN OUTBREAK
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS HAVE TO REQUIRE AND
VACCINATED STUDENTS REMAIN HOME
TO PREVENT SPURRED FURTHER
SPREAD DISEASE IN THE SCHOOL AND
IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE NEED FOR THIS INFORMATION
FORTUNE WAS ILLUSTRATED BY A
MEASLES OUTBREAK THAT OCCURRED
IN THIS.
AREA LAST SPRING WHEN IN
UNVACCINATED CHILD WAS INFECTED
WITH MEASLES IN EUROPE.
AND RETURNED WITH THE DISEASE
THE CALIFORNIA.
THIS CHILD THEN TRANSMITTED THE
DISEASE TO OTHER VENN BACKS THE
CHILDREN.
INCLUDING CHILDREN OF A OF A
FAMILY WHO LIKE TO PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS THE LIGHT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS THAT THEIR
CHILDREN VACCINATED.
IN TRUTH THEY HAD PURCHASED
INAPPROPRIATE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
FROM THAT POSITION HUNDREDS OF
MILES AWAY.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE THEY LIED
THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS DO NOT
KNOW AND DO NOT FOLLOW UP UNTIL
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE WEREN'T
AFFECTED BY THESE EXAM TO
CHILDREN AND WHEN THEY DID THE
TRACING BACK IT WENT BACK TO
THIS FAMILY.
HAVING MEDICAL EXEMPTION
INFORMATION COULD HAVE PREVENTED
FURTHER SPREAD OF THE DISEASE.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX IS ABOUT
KEEPING OUR STATE AND COMMUNITY
SAFE FROM PREVENTABLE DISEASE.
THE REPORTS OF MEASLES OUTBREAKS
THIS YEAR UNDERSCORE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO PASS SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX TO MAINTAIN THE HARD
WON GAINS WE MADE AND WITH SB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN WE MUST NOT LET
A HANDFUL UNSCRUPULOUS POSITIONS.
SEEKING THE PROFIT FROM FAKE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS TO UNDERMINE
THE SAFETY OF OUR SCHOOLS AND
OUR COMMUNITY.
YES I AM PLEASED.
TO INTRODUCED THREE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX WE HAVE DOCTOR
SERGIO FLORES A TRUSTEE AND
ELECTED TRUSTEE OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
WITH DOCTOR ERICA PAN WHO BY THE
WAY IS NO RELATION TO MYSELF.
WHO IS A PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY?
ANALYSTS ARE HERNANDEZ AT THE
PARENT OF A MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILD WHO NEEDS WE NEED A
COMMUNITY BEAUTY TO KEEP HER
CHILD SAFE.
WITH THAT I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB TWO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WELCOME DOCTOR FLOOR IS --
DOCTOR ERICA PAN AND MISS
FERNANDEZ -- DOCTOR FLOORS ARE
YOU GONNA START THANK YOU.
AND IF I NAMES LIKE REMIND YOU
YOU. SIX MINUTES COLLECTIVELY
NOW ALL KIND OF REMIND YOU WHEN
YOU GET CLOSE.
WELCOME WE WELCOME YOUR
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS A
RESEARCHER FLOOR ISN'T HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE OVER FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AS A PROUD CO SPONSORS OF SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX I AM CURRENTLY
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF A LARGE
EIGHT HUNDRED PHYSICIAN MEMBER
MEDICAL GROUP IN SAN YOU'LL
SHARK ME MEDICAL GROUP.
I ALSO WAS ELECTED BY MY LOCAL
AND STATEWIDE PEERS TO SERVE ON
THE BOARD OF THE MEDIC MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE INCIDENT MEDICAL QUALITY
AS WELL AS A SEND YOU COUNTY
MEDICAL SOCIETY.
IT IS TIME FOR THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY TO DO ITS PART TO CALL
OUT THOSE AMONG US WHO ARE
NEGLECTING THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
TO THEIR PATIENTS.
AND THE PUBLIC AT LARGE.
TRANSPOSITIONS WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT COMMUNITY IMMUNITY IS
AN IMPORTANT ROLE WE PLAY IN
PROTECTING OUR PATIENTS.
VACCINES SAVE LIVES AND ARE
ESSENTIAL IN HELPING US CONTROL
DISEASES THAT NOT LONG AGO WERE
MORTAL THREATS TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
TODAY WE MUST PASS SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX AND IS FOR THE HIGH
STANDARD OF CARE AND AND
SCRUTINY WHEN GRANTEE MEDICAL
EXAMS AS IS MAINTAIN ACROSS THE
STATE.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX DOES JUST
THAT IT REMOVES THE ABILITY FOR
ANY POSITION TO ACT OUTSIDE OF
THE ACCEPTED STANDARD OF CARE.
AND GET AWAY WITH IT.
PRACTITIONERS TAKE A NOTE TO
RESPECT THE HARD ONE SCIENTIFIC
GAINS OF THOSE POSITIONS WHO
STEP WHO LOOK WHO CAME BEFORE US.
UNFORTUNATELY A HANDFUL OF OUR
CARLY'S WHO BRAZENLY ADVERTISE
THE SALE OF MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
VACCINATIONS ARE NOT LIVING UP
TO THAT'S BOTH.
AND HAVE PUT OUR STATE COMMUNITY
IMMUNITY AT RISK.
PASSAGE FOR PUBLIC SPACES LIKE
SCHOOLS GROCERY STORES AND PARKS
ARE UNSAFE FOR THOSE WO ARE
MEDICALLY COMPROMISED IN CANNOT
RECEIVE VACCINATIONS.
THE FACT THAT MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
FOR VACCINATIONS HAVE MORE THAN
TRIPLED.
CANNOT BE RECENTLY EXPLAINED.
THAT IS BECAUSE MOST OF US IT IS
A MORAL THAT A SMALL HANDFUL OF
PHYSICIANS ARE ALLOWING PARENTS
TO PURCHASE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
FOR THEIR CHILDREN WHO SHOULD
OTHERWISE BE VACCINATED.
THERE IS NO REASON FOR ONE
PHYSICIAN TO WRITE A THIRD OF
THE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
AS REPORTED EARLIER WE SHOULD
NEVER ALLOW THIS TO HAPPEN AND
WE SHOULD ACT TO PUT THE STOP TO
THIS UNSCRUPULOUS BEHAVIOR.
THESE PRACTITIONERS UNDERMINE
THE INTEGRITY OF PHYSICIANS WHO
GRAN NEEDED MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
FOR VACCINATIONS FOR THE SMALL
NUMBER OF PATIENTS WHO TRULY
NEED THEM.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO OUR PATIENTS
CARE AND HEALTH.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO ENSURING
THAT THEY ARE SAFE TO PLAY AT
THE PARK OR GO TO SCHOOL.
THAT IS WHY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND I ARE CO
SPONSORING AS BE.
TWO SEVENTY SIX GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN HEALTH COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR ERIC UPON I AM
HERE TO REPRESENT THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY I AM THE
INTERIM HEALTH OFFICER FOR
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
I'M ALSO A PRACTICING PEDIATRIC
INFECTIOUS DISEASE SPECIALIST.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE AS A
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL.
CLEARLY NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED TO COME TOGETHER AS A BROAD
COMMUNITY TO PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND MAINTAIN
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY.
WE'VE ALREADY HAD MORE CASES OF
MEASLES IN CALIFORNIA IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THEN ALL OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IN A
SERVICES GO BAY AREA THIS YEAR
WE'VE ALREADY HAD TEN CASES.
IN OUR COUNTY WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CONFIRMED CASE YET BUT WE HAD TO
ACTIVATE OUR PUBLIC HEALTH.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TO START TO
RESPOND TO ALL THE REGIONAL
CASES AND WE FOLLOWED UP AN
ALMOST NINETY CONTACTS IN
EXPOSED PERSONS.
IN ADDITION TO THE ONE IN A
THOUSAND RISK OF DEATH OR BRAIN
FUNCTION FROM MEASLES AND HIGH
HOUSE POSITION READS.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE IS
SIGNIFICANT AND EXPENSIVE.
WE ESTIMATE THE RANGE OF EXPENSE
PER CASE IS ABOUT TEN TO THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
DISNEYLAND MEASLES OUTBREAK
PUBLIC HEALTH COSTS WERE
ESTIMATED TO BE ONE POINT FIVE
TO THREE POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA.
WE KNOW AND SEE THAT OUTBREAK
START IN CLUSTERS OF
UNVACCINATED PERSONS.
THIS PUTS THOSE ARE VALID
REASONS NOT TO BE IMMUNIZED AT
RISK.
OF SEVERE DISEASE.
WELL THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE WE
HAVE SEEN THAT IT IS NOT ENOUGH.
WE DON'T HAVE CURRENT DATA AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT UNAWARE
INVALID EXEMPTIONS HAVE BEEN
GRANTED BUT WE DO HAVE PLENTY OF
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE OF ANTI AGING --
CLINICS HYPERBARIC MEDICINE
CLINICS IN ONLINE EVALUATIONS
FOR HIGH FEES RATHER THAN
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS PROVIDING
THESE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
REQUIRING PUBLIC HEALTH APPROVAL
OF ALL MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS WILL
PREVENT THIS INAPPROPRIATE
PRACTICE.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX WHICH WILL GIVE US
AS PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS THE
TOOLS WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITY FROM VACCINE
PREVENTABLE DISEASES THANK YOU.
ON A MINIMUM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HERE IN
THIS BILL MY NAME IS ALYSSA
HERNANDEZ AND I'M REPRESENTING
THE THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS OF
VACCINATE CALIFORNIA SPONSOR OF
SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX MY SON NOAH HERE
WAS BORN WITH A FATAL LIVER
DISEASE CALLED BILIARY ATRESIA
AT SIX MONTHS OLD HE RECEIVED A
LIFE SAVING LIVER TRANSPLANT.
BECAUSE OF HIS TRANSPLANT HE IS
NOW AN AMINO SUPPRESSING DRUGS
FOR THE REST OF HIS LIFE HE WILL
NEVER BE ABLE TO BE VACCINATED
AGAINST.
DISEASES LIKE MEASLES OR
CHICKENPOX AND EACH OF THEM
COULD BE LIFE THREATENING FOR
HIM.
A SIMPLE COLD PUTS MY CHILD IN
THE HOSPITAL.
HE RELIES ON HIGH ON A HIGHLY
VACCINATED COMMUNITY TO SHIELD
HIM FROM EXPOSURE HE DESERVES TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL AND ME
FEEL SAFE.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE IN VACCINES
AND PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN
ELDERLY AND EVERYONE ELSE WHO
SYSTEMS ARE IMMUNE COMPROMISED.
THIS BILL IS CRUCIAL TO MY
FAMILY AND THE MILLIONS MORE
LIKE MINE.
I URGE YOU TO PASS THIS BILL TO
MAKE IT SAFE FOR ME TO SEND MY
CHILD TO SCHOOL THANK YOU.
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO ASK ALL
OTHER SUPPORTERS AT THEY WOULD
KIND THE LINED UP ON YOUR RIGHT.
HAND -- COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE -- ERR
GAS ON BEHALF OF THE MARCH OF
DIMES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
FOR DAVID IS AS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
THE ARREST AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
VACCINATE CALIFORNIA FROM PALO
ALTO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DR SANTA NEED OF A CONSTANT
PEDIATRICIAN SAN FRANCISCO URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
WE GIVE.
DOCTOR BOB OILS OF POSITION SAN
DIEGO -- CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES FOR CMA SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR.
MARIA SPUR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TIM VALDERRAMA WITH THE WHITE
MEN GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA.
SOCIETY OF HEALTH SYSTEM
PHARMACISTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIBBONS WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE AT THE
STATE AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. TWO MEN
REPS IN THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEVIN PROUTY REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF THE ASTHMA
ALLERGY AND IMMUNOLOGY THANK YOU.
JERRY HICKS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND SUPPORT.
CAN HIM SAID GENERAL
PEDIATRICIAN WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE HERE IN ROSEVILLE --
CULTURE OF THE MEDI CAL TO THE
SOUTH BY THREE PANEL -- SPEAKING
AS INDIVIDUAL IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE HI DAVID GROSSMAN
MEDICAL DIRECTOR CLINIC BY THE
BAY FREE CLINIC IN SAN FRANCISCO
AS SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
DOUGLAS MURPHY CHILD
PSYCHIATRISTS GENERAL
PSYCHIATRIST SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY IN PRIVATE PRACTICE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND
THE CENTER BECAUSE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL MCCABE INTERNAL MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN PRESIDENT OF THE
PLASTER NEVADA COUNTY MEDICAL
SOCIETY SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE SOCIETY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEIL RENTS MEDICAL SOON AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY SPEAKING
SUPPORT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
ENTER YOUR FIRST YEAR MEDICAL
STUDENT AT WESTERN UNIVERSITY OF
HEALTH SCIENCES HERE'S BEACON
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RENEE FAN FROM UC DAVIS SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CMA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I'M ONLY WHEN FIRST YEAR MEDICAL
STUDENT OF ANYTHING DAVIS SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE SPEAKING OF SUPPORT
AND HAVE A CMA BECAUSE FOR OF
SUCH A MEDICAL STUDENT
CALIFORNIAN ARTS UNIVERSITY
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
SERRA MAY SMITH MD PHD STUDENT
AT UC IRVINE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THAT SPEED. TWO SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU.
DR MARTY BOMB A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES FOR CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
BRING DELAY -- PEDIATRIC
RESIDENT LOMA LINDA UNIVERSITY
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
DR THOMAS PEDIATRICIAN AT LOMA
LINDA AND IN SUPPORT.
DOCTOR ROBIN MILLER FROM LOMA
LINDA PEDIATRICIAN SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
DR JANE HAN OF PEDIATRIC
RESIDENT FROM THE MULLIN THE
UNIVERSITY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
BRENT MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
CHRISTIE NO WAY MEDICAL STUDENT
AT UCSF BEGINS APART.
ARTS -- NINETY SEVEN INTERNISTS
AND PEDIATRICIANS SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT.
MAKE A GARG I'M IN INTERNAL
MEDICINE DOCTOR IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND A MOM OF SIX MONTH OLD SON
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. THREE XIN
ARANA INTRO MEDICINE POSITION
SAN FRANCISCO ALSO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
I'M AND YOU CAN DOLLARS FROM THE
SENEGAL COUNTY MEDICAL SOCIETY
AND SAN DIEGO IMMUNIZATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
DODD KAREN CYBER PAST PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS PRESIDENT
ELECT DISTRICT FIVE LA COUNTY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER VACCINATED CHILDREN
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT YOU.
DR LIM GRANDISON PEDIATRICIANS
COUNCILS MEDICAL SOCIETY
PRESIDENT SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I MAY ROLE -- BOARD OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY --
CARDIOLOGISTS IN PRACTICE IN
TORRANCE CALIFORNIA IMMEDIATE
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DR SCOTT MORRISON A PRACTICE IN
SAN JOSE M. AN INTERNAL MEDICINE
RESIDENT FELT MEDICAL CENTER AND
I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR MORRIS AIR IN
THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF THE RE
ENTRY RESOURCE CENTER MOBILE
MEDICAL UNIT IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY.
THE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE NATIONAL
PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE AND I
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION.
DR PERCY'S PATEL PEDIATRICIAN IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DR ROMERO SANTIAGO RESIDENT
PHYSICIAN HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA SPEAKING STRONG SUPPORT AS
THIS MAXIMIZE THE TO LIVE OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH RESOURCES THANK
YOU.
BUT GRIFFIN SEVEN INTERNAL
MEDICINE PHYSICIAN IN SAN
FRANCISCO SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
STRIDES ARE INTERNAL MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN IN SAN FRANCISCO ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PATRICK SANGER PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
FATHER OF TWO YOUNG DAUGHTERS
SPEAKING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ENTER GARDNER OPPOSITION IS
SAFETY NET CLINIC IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND A FATHER OF A TWO
YEAR OLD A SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
A DOCTOR KATIE MEN -- PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENT IN SAN FRANCISCO
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DR JULIANA MOCHRIE PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENT IN SAN FRANCISCO
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DR JONI ADDINGTON LIGHT --
GENERAL INTERNAL MEDICINE SAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DR LARRY BALBOA I HAVE A PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN AND SAN FRANCISCO
I SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF IMMIGRANTS WHO -- IT
FOR MY COUNTRY WHO DO NOT HAVE A
CHOICE.
DOCTOR THOMPSON I PRACTICE
INTERNAL MEDICINE IN TERMS OF
SKILL SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DR NAILS AND I PRACTICE INTERNAL
MEDICINE SAN FRANCISCO SPEAKING
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
DOCTOR THEA SAMA FROM A PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN INTENT CISCO ALSO
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DOCTOR MAGGIE GRAYA PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN SAN FRANCISCO
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR JOHN LANDFALL
THEM A GENERAL INTERNIST IN SAN
FRANCISCO SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI I'M DOCTOR FOR TREATING THE
PEDIATRICIAN CONSENSUS KOBE
AREAS BECOME THE AFTER THE A. P.
SPEAKING A STRONG SUPPORT.
HI DOCTOR LYDIA MALEK NEAR
PEDIATRICIAN IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS AND THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT.
DR SAMUEL BACK IS SOME A
PEDIATRIC RESIDENT DOWN IN
OAKLAND AND I'M VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YOU.
DR RAJIT SHARIA SACRAMENTO
PEDIATRICIAN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND I'M STRONG
SUPPORT.
DOCTOR CATHERINE FITS WATER AND
TAX SACRAMENTO PEDIATRICIAN I AM
SPEAKING A STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M DOCTOR MERAMEC FROM FAMILY
MEDICINE -- EDITOR AT REGIONAL
MEDICAL CENTER IN CALIFORNIA I
AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
ACTUALLY ABRAHAM A MEDICAL
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS JACKIE WILLIAMS A
MEDICAL STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AND
I'M SPEAKING STE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS CARLY MATTER AND
I'M A FIRST YEAR MEDICAL STUDENT
AT UC DAVIS AND I'M SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAMEIS JUDY GIVES A COME
A CONCERNED PARENT FROM SONOMA
COUNTY AND I'M SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S DOCTOR CAMBRIA GIRL
I'M A PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS
ANGELES AND MOTHER OF TWO
CHILDREN AND I'M HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
I AM DOCTOR SIR JOHN AND MY
PEDIATRICIAN LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
IF YOU.
HI MY NAME'S DR TITANIC LANE I'M
A PEDIATRICIAN FROM LOS ANGELES
ARE REPRESENTING A PIECE STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI I'M DOCTOR VIRGINIA KEY
PEDIATRICIAN FROM LOS ANGELES
REPRESENTING THE AP SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S RACHEL I GRAB MY
BEFORE YOUR MEDICAL STUDENT AT
UCSF AND ALSO A FORMERLY UNDER
VACCINATED CHILD -- SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DR LISA MORENO PEDIATRIC
RESIDENT LOS ANGELES IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
YOU'RE A RESPECT TO THE SPEAKER
MY NAME IS DOCTOR CATHERINE
KINZER ALSO PEDIATRICIAN -- IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU DR GRANT CRESSMAN
PEDIATRICIAN LOS ANGELES AND
BOARD MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER TO THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I'M DR VERONICA RAN UP THE
PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS ANGELES AND
A MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY.
OF PEDIATRICS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LYDIA BORN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
WE ARE THE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANASTASIA WHOLESOME A
FIRST YEAR MEDICAL STUDENT UC
DAVIS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MCKENNA RICE AND A
FIRST YEAR MEDICAL STUDENT AT UC
DAVIS INSTRUCTS FOR THIS BILL.
MAYOR MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE LATE ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN SPECIALTY
CARE COALITION REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PEDIATRIC
SUB SPECIALISTS IN SUPPORT.
I AM DOCTOR MONA PATEL ON BEHALF
OF FIVE THOUSAND BOARD CERTIFIED
PEDIATRICIANS I'M THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS CO CHAIR FOR
THE MEDICAID AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS.
PRACTICING PEDIATRICIAN AND
MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN ARE FULLY
IMMUNIZED IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JACQUES KORABL ALSO CO CHAIR OF
THE STATE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS IN CALIFORNIA STREET
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
PAGE YOUR TO FOR THE MEDICAL
SENATE LEVEL IN THE UNIVERSITY
ALSO FORMALLY UNDER VACCINATED --
SPEAKING AND STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA MARQUEZ
I'M INSTRUCTS THE PART AND I'M
FROM ALLEN I WORK AT CHILDREN'S
USC HOSPITAL AS ADVOCATE.
THANK YOU -- RETURN AS A MEDICAL
STUDENT AND STRONG SUPPORTER
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JENNY CHANG A
MEDICAL CENTER AT LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE I'M
ACTUALLY PUBLIC HEALTH STUDENT
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
DR KEVIN KING A PEDIATRICIAN IN
FRESNO ANIMUS FROM SUPPORTERS.
AND DR JAMIE BRAND THEM A
PEDIATRIC HOSPITALS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TO KEEP OUR
CHILDREN OUT OF THE HOSPITAL'S.
I AM DOCTOR JOE AGAIN -- A
PEDIATRICIAN AND MEMBER OF
EIGHTY AYE STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
I AM DOCTOR FIND A PEDIATRICIAN
IN NUMBER THE EIGHT PM STRONG
SUPPORT AS WELL THANKS.
DOCTOR CHEN NAY PARKER I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN IN EASTERN MADERA
COUNTY AS WELL AS A FELLOW OF
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND A MOTHER OF THREE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KATHERINE FLORES MAARTEN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ADMINISTRATION
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KATHY BURKE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE HEALTH OFFICER'S
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH BANDAGE GRANDMOTHER OF
EIGHT LIFE ON CALIFORNIA VOTER
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALLEN STELLAR ARE IN
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
CATHERINE FERGUSON OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS FROM VENTURA COUNTY
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SUZANNE STEWART ON MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND SUPPORT.
HI DOCTOR HANDED CAM FROM LOS
ANGELES WITH EIGHTY P. IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DR HILLARY SEIDENBERG A
PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS ANGELES WITH
THE ACADEMY AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S DOCTOR JENNIFER MEN
AND THE PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS
ANGELES AND A MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S AMANDA DEGEL PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL ON US
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOCTOR KEVIN
SAYING I'M A PEDIATRICIAN LOS
ANGELES -- AND I'M ALSO A FORMER
THEY COULD HAVE IT CREE
PHYSICIAN REPRESENTED WITH
AMERICAN CAN PEDIATRICS AND SOME
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M DOCTOR JENNIFER JOHNSON I'M
A PRACTICING PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS
ANGELES AND DEVELOPMENTAL
BEHAVIORAL PEDIATRICS FELLOW IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI DOCTOR PRINCETON LEAVE FROM
SANTA MONICA A PEDIATRICIAN IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO DOCTOR RYAN LAM
PEDIATRICIAN LOS ANGELES A
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DR VINCENT CHAN FROM LOS ANGELES
WITH AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M DR LANA CHIU
PEDIATRICIAN IN LOS ANGELES HERE
WITH THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M SORRY CAR I GUESS ON ME I'M
A MEDICAL STUDENT FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE HE WAS ASSEMBLY --
COUNTY MEDICAL SOCIETY AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JONATHAN YOU MEDICAL STUDENT IN
THE BAY AREA WE'RE HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE SPELL THANK YOU.
HI I'M KAREN'S AN AUTO I'M A
PARENT AND A VOLUNTEER WITH
ACCIDENT CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU HI DOCTOR JENNY HUNG --
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
I'M ALSO A PEDIATRICIAN SERVING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN SOUTH
BAY A LOS ANGELES THANK YOU.
HI AND TOUCH HER PRINCE ALL
ALONE A PEDIATRICIAN AND
TORRANCE CALIFORNIA -- AS WELL
AS A MEMBER OF THE ACADEMY
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD ATERNOON DOCTOR NAME
ATTORNEY PEDIATRICIAN AND SOUTH
BAY LOS ANGELES ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
AND ALL OF THE PATIENTS WHO ARE
AT RISK OF ON TO RECEIVING.
MAXING PREVENTABLE DISEASES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE TICKET.
MY NAME IS ANITA SHIVKUMAR IN A
MEDICAL STUDENT AND A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GET A MEDICAL STUDENT
AT STANFORD AND CMA BUSTER OF
POLICY ON ICE SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PAVING TRAIN I'M A
MEDICAL STUDENT AT STANFORD AND
A MEMBER OF THE CMA AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
DR DANI UP EMERGENCY POSITION
AND IN LA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THE GOOD AFTERNOON MATT
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF KAISER
PERMANENTE IN SUPPORT.
KOBE PRESIDING I AM A LOBBYIST
IN THE CAPITOL BUILDING AS WELL
AS A WASHINGTON UNIFIED SCHOOL
BOARD TRUSTEE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I'M YES BEEN AVOID TRAINING BOTH
FAMILY MEDICINE AND EMERGENCY
MEDICINE PRACTICING IN SUMMER
AND YOU KNOW IN STRONG SUPPORT
I'M ALSO A PAST MEMBER A BOARD
MEMBER OF KELLY SAID.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KELLY BOYD I'M
A STUDENT AND I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I'M ALEXANDER VOID AND
I'M A STUDENT AND I'M SUPPORT IN
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU BLOOM ELLEN AZTLAN AND
THE MEDICAL STUDENT UC DAVIS --
ALSO VICE CHAIR OF THE MEDICAL
STUDENT SECTIONS YOU MAY
RELATIONS AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IF YOU WERE GONNA
GO UP TO THE GALLERY NOW.
IF YOU'RE PROPONENT.
A PEDIATRICIAN REPRESENTING
LUCILLE PACKARD CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI DOCTOR MINDY LEE -- ALSO
REPRESENTING PACKARD CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL FROM PALO ALTO IS FROM
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DR NANCY RIVERA PEDIATRICIAN
IMPALA I'LL TELL ALSO
REPRESENTING LUCILLE PACKARD
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DOCTOR THEY'VE EVOLUTION I'M A
PEDIATRICIAN IN PALO ALTO ALSO
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
IF NOT WE'RE GOING TO INVITE THE
OPPONENTS TO COME UP. TO THE
TABLE WE CAN MAKE ROOM PLEASE
[inaudible]
IMMIGRANT.
MUCH GOES ON SO I WELCOME AS WE
A ALLOW -- OUTLINED THE RULES
EARLIER YOU'LL HAVE SIX MINUTES
COLLECTIVELY.
BUT WE WELCOME YOU.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO START BY?
FELLOW CITIZENS I AM DOCTOR
NICOLE CHIRAC.
I AM A BOARD CERTIFIED
PEDIATRICIAN AND HAVE PRACTICED
MEDICINE FOR THE PAST NINETEEN
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA.
I BELIEVE IN VACCINES I
VACCINATE MY PATIENTS IN MY OWN
CHILDREN BUT I CANNOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IS TOO
EXTREME.
I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
THOUSANDS OF DOCTORS WHO OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE PATIENT
AND THEIR DOCTOR IS SACRED.
AND PATIENTS HAVE A RIGHT TO
HAVE THEIR MEDICAL TREATMENT
DETERMINED BY THEIR DOCTOR.
NOT A GOVERNMENTAL APPOINTEE.
THIS BILL WILL ESSENTIALLY
DESTROY THE SANCTITY OF THE
DOCTOR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP.
LIKE MY COLLEAGUES I HAVE
WITNESSED CASE IS A VACCINE
INJURY SOMETIMES RESULTING IN
DEVASTATING NEUROLOGICAL ILLNESS.
AS DOCTORS WE ARE CALLED TO
CAREFULLY CONSIDER THE UNIQUE
MAKE UP OF OUR PATIENTS WHEN
ADMINISTERING VACCINES TO
PREVENT VACCINE INJURY.
SHOULD THIS BILL BE PASSED THE
MEDICAL DECISION OF WHETHER OR
NOT VACCINATING WILL BE SAFE
WILL NO LONGER BE IN THE HANDS
OF THE PHYSICIANS.
INSTEAD A PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL
WITH MINIMAL KNOWLEDGE OF THE
PATIENT WILL BE FORCED TO
DETERMINE SAFETY USING ONLY THE
CDC GUIDELINES FOR CONTRA
INDICATIONS AND PRECAUTIONS.
THESE GUIDELINES ARE TOO NARROW
AND DO NOT INCLUDE ALL POSSIBLE
CONDITIONS LEAVING CHILDREN WITH
GENETIC IN CHRONIC IMMUNE
DISORDERS VULNERABLE.
THAT IS WHY THIS BILL IS
CALCULATED TO INCREASE VACCINE
INJURIES ESPECIALLY AMONG
MEDICALLY COMPLEX CASES.
I SPOKE WITH THE CDC AND THE CDC
THEMSELVES REPORTS THEIR
GUIDELINES ARE INTENDED TO BE
USED IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
DOCTOR SPECIFIC KNOWLEDGE OF THE
PATIENT.
AND ARE NOT INTENDED TO BE USED
ALONE AS AN ABSOLUTE
DETERMINATION OF CARE.
THE DOCTOR IS IN THE BEST
POSITION TO MAKE THE ULTIMATE
DECISION.
USING THE GUIDELINES AS SUPPORT
IF NEEDED.
THE TRUTH IS THERE IS NO REAL
PROBLEM AND THIS BILL ISN'T
NECESSARY VACCINE EXEMPTIONS
HAVE DECREASED.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL VACCINATION
RATES ARE ABOVE THE 95% NEEDED
TO PROVIDE HER COMMUNITY.
AND THE CONCERN FOR POSSIBLE
FRAUDULENT MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IS
NOT FOUNDED AS THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD HAS DONE ITS JOB
AND INVESTIGATED A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE CASES.
AND HAS FOUND.
ZERO IF THE DOCTORS PRACTICING
OUTSIDE THE STANDARD OF CARE IT
IS THE JURISDICTION OF OUR
STATE'S MEDICAL BOARD TO POLICE
THIS.
THIS BILL DELEGATES POLICING
NORMALLY DONE BY OUR STATE'S
MEDICAL BOARD TO A HEALTH
OFFICER.
HOW IS IT JUST TO HAVE A HEALTH
OFFICERS OPINION OVER POWER THE
PATIENT'S OWN PHYSICIANS OPINION?
NOT ONLY IS IT ON JUST BUT IT IS
A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT TO HAVE AN
EDUCATED DECISION WE CAREFULLY
CONSIDER BE OVERTURNED BY A
HEALTH OFFICER.
WHO IS NOT ADEQUATELY INFORMED
AND HAS NO RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
UNIQUE PATIENTS?
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IN CLOSING
THAT WE MUST BE CAREFUL WHEN
GIVING ANY MEDICATION TO A
PATIENT AND VACCINES ARE NO
DIFFERENT.
WE CAN DO GREAT HARM IF WE APPLY
A UNIVERSAL ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH.
THIS BILL IS DANGEROUS TO THE
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN OF
OUR STATE AND FINALLY IT'S
DANGEROUS TO THE MEDICAL FREEDOM
OF THE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU.
ROB [inaudible]
HELLO LADIES.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
PLEASE WE WE HAVE RULES.
YOU'RE TAKING TIME AWAY FROM THE
OPPOSITION THEY USE ARE OFF
ANALYSTS ANNUAL SPACE TO THIS TO
THIS SO BY VACCINES MY FAMILY'S
RESPONSIBLY AND I WRITE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION FOR THE LESS THAN 1%
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED
PROTECTION.
THIS BILL NOT ONLY DOES NOT
SOLVE THE PROBLEM IS STATES BUT
IT PUTS MANY PEOPLE IN HARM.
FIRST QUESTION WHAT PROBLEM IS A
BILL TRYING TO SOLVE TOTAL
EXEMPTION RATES HAVE GONE DOWN
NOT UP FROM FOURTEEN THOUSAND TO
FOUR THOUSAND SINCE SB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN YES THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION RATES HAVE GONE UP
FROM POINT TO TWO POINT 7%.
BECAUSE THOSE WHO PREVIOUSLY HAD
PERSONAL EXEMPTIONS COUNTY
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IT IS NATURAL
THAT AND EXPECTED THAT THE
NUMBER WILL GO UP.
SO WHO ARE WE TWENTY SAVE FOR
RECEIVING EVERY DAY WE HAVE MASS
MEDIA HYSTERIA OVER MEASLES BUT
WHO IS DYING NUMBER OF DEATH
ZERO IN FACT MAYBE ONE
INDIVIDUAL IN THE PAST TEN YEARS.
THE CURRENT VACCINATION RATE BY
THE CALIFORNIA.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
STATES THAT ALL KINDERGARTEN
INDEXING RE TO OVER 96%.
SOLD LACK OF VACCINATIONS CANNOT
BE THE REASON FOR THIS SO CALLED
EPIDEMIC.
IF WE ANT TO SEE LIVES LET'S
FOCUS ON REAL PROBLEMS HOMICIDE
AND SUICIDE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEENS THE CDC DATA SUGGEST
TWENTY CHILDREN DIE PER DAY.
IN THE TWO FIVE TO TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLDS MEASLES ZERO SUICIDE
TWENTY PER DAY.
NEXT PROBLEM THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE THE DEFINITION IT IT IT
DOES CHANGE THE DEFINITION OF SB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN LAW WHO PUT IN
WHO QUALIFIES FOR MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS.
HE HAS CHANGED A WAR TO CONTRA
INDICATION.
WHICH MEANS ESSENTIALLY COMA
BRAIN DEATH YOU KNOW SEVERE
ANAPHYLAXIS.
NUMBER ONE THE BILL EXCLUDE
CONSERVATION FOR ALL THE SERIOUS
CONDITIONS LISTED ON THE SHEETS
WE WILL GIVE YOU.
IT ALSO WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIAL DOES THAT DOES
NOT KNOW YOUR CHILD CITY HERE
AND CHECK FOR BOXES FOR CONTRA
INDICATIONS ONLY.
THIS IS A TRAVESTY THIS IS THIS
BILL NUMBER TWO I TREAT MANY
FAMILIES WERE VACCINE IN YOUR
FIRST CHILD.
DO YOU THINK IT'S REASONABLE AND
RESPONSIBLE TO TELL THE FAMILY
THAT THE MOST TAXED EITHER
SECOND CHILD WHEN THEY HAVE.
TO DO WITH THE WHOLE LIVES HAVE
CHANGED NUMBER THREE BEHIND
RIGHT OVER HERE IS DOCTOR
CHRYSLER AND DOCTOR LEE.
AND MANY OTHER FAMILIES WHILE
ASKED TO STAND UP AFTER THE
TESTIMONY WHO WILL HAVE A
VACCINE YOUR VACCINE IN YOUR
CHILDREN THAT DO NOT FIT THIS
NARROW DEFINITION OF COUNTRY
INDICATION.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WHILE VACCINE
CAUSING INJURY IS NOT AT TRIAL
HERE OVER FOUR BILLION WITH A B..
CABIN P. TO VICTIMS OF VACCINE
INJURY THE THE NATIONAL
CHILDHOOD INJURY COMPENSATION
ACTS SO NO ONE CAN DENY THERE'S
NO VACCINE INJURIES NO ONE WE
ARE NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOCIETY WE DOCTORS TO BE
HYPOCRITICAL TO DO FIRST DO NO
HARM.
IT IS OUR JOB TO ANALYZE A
PROTECT THE 1% THANK YOU YOUR
TIME IT I NOT OKAY TO SACRIFICE
ANY CHILDREN TO BRING DOWN THE
NUMBERS FROM POINT SEVEN TWO
POINT 3% THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY -- WE NOW
LIKE TO INVITE THE OPPOSITION TO
START LINING UP ON THE RIGHT
SIDE OF THE BOTTOM FLOOR IN A
GALLERY IF YOU BE ON THE LEFT
SIDE.
OKAY.
IF YOU IF THE OPPOSITION COULD
JUST INTRODUCE OURSELVES BY NAME
AND WHERE YOU'RE FROM.
WE LIKE TO HEAR WHO YOU ARE.
LIMITED TO THAT PLEASE.
DOCTOR LINE ONLY EMERGENCY
MEDICINE SEPARATE YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR NICOLE CHIRAC SACRAMENTO
DOCTOR AND MISERABLE SAN ANGELES
BECAUSE ISSUE.
DOCTOR MELANIE KEESLER FAMILY
MEDICINE LOS ANGELES THANK YOU
DR CHARLES PANIC OF FAMILY
MEDICINE SANTA ANA CALIFORNIA.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN ON
THE BOTTOM IF.
YOU COULD PLEASE TELL US WHO YOU
ARE AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE FIFTY SUPPORT
WHATEVER CHECK WITH EDUCATE
ADVOCATE WE SERVE FAMILIES WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILDREN AFTER
RANCHO CUCAMONGA.
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
ROOM AMEREN BURCHETT NINE OPPOSE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ROOM [inaudible]
IN.
I OPPOSE SB.
TWO THIS IS THE LATEST
GOVERNMENT PLEASE.
THERE'S NO.
NO CLAPPING YOU CAN DO THIS.
SO THIS THAT'S OF THE THIRD TIME
NOW I'VE MENTION THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE ANY OUTBURSTS WERE
GONNA ASK GOOD FORTUNE SERGEANTS
DESPERATE YOU OUT.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP AN ORDERLY
MEETING WE NEED TO SHOW RESPECT
FOR THE PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS
ARE GONNA RUN ON EARLY MEETING
SO WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
BUT YOU GOT TO FOLLOW THE RULES.
NEXT WEEK -- PLEASE.
I'M JOSHUA COLEMAN FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL MY
SON UP THERE IN A WHEELCHAIR IS
GONNA BE KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL.
VACCINES FOR DINNER WILL CHAIR
ARE YOU IN FAVOR OR OPPOSE I AM
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS ADRIAN HALF'S
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THAT AFFECTS MY
CHILDREN THANK YOU.
ALEX OWNS ON BEHALF OF A VOICE
FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY IN
OPPOSITION.
IT WOULD BE MY BECAUSE I OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN HUNLEY PRESIDENT OF OUR
KIDS ARE CHOICE REPRESENTING
OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND CONCERNED
CITIZENS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
TARA NORTON VICE PRESIDENT OF
OUR KIDS ARE CHOICE ALSO
REPRESENTING OVER TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND CONCERNED PARENTS OF
PARENTS UNITED FOR KIDS AND WE
VEHEMENTLY AND STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
DR TIFFANY BEAR BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS ASPEN PARTY I POSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BECKY CARNEY I'M IN
SENATOR MORE LOOKS DISTRICT I'M
A PARENT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AMBER BASICALLY I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO WONDERFUL BOYS WHO
WOULD BE IMPACTED BY THIS BILL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
DR MARY KELLY CERTAIN FAIR OAKS
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO SEVEN
SIX FOUR ON THE BEHALF OF MY
PATIENTS WHO NEED.
EXEMPTION MCCUE.
CHEN PRIMARY FROM SAN DIEGO I'M
A SPECIAL ED -- PARALEGAL I'M
HERE REPRESENTING CLIENTS IN
FIVE COUNTIES ALONG WITH THREE
HUNDRED MILITARY SPOUSES THAT
COULD NOT ATTEND TODAY THANK YOU.
JULIANNE APPEARS FROM O'NEILL'S
CALIFORNIA.
MOTHER OF A CHILD WITH OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTION I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VICTOR DISILLUSIONED
SCARE I LIVE IN CARMICHAEL AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
TINA GORMAN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE.
WHEN THE SILVER SPIRITUAL
THERAPISTS AND PRESIDENT OF
MILLION MAMAS MOVEMENT AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU?
BUT I FATIMA DREAD REPRESENTING
NOTHING ELSE OF MONTEREY COUNTY
ALSO FOUNDER OF WE DARE TO CARE
CALIFORNIA HAVE TWO CHILDREN ONE
THAT IS MEDICALLY FRAGILE THAT
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY.
AND MY CHILD HERE HAS --
REPRESENTING CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES OF CALIFORNIA WITH
A HEARING IMPAIRMENT AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GALINA MONTRE REGISTERED NURSE
AND THE MOTHER OF TWO SPECIAL
NEEDS KIDS STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
ONLY NAY GETS CUT WHEN MOM AND I
ARE 2% FACEBOOK GROUP OF TWENTY
THOUSAND OF MEMBERS AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PAULA HIS LAST GAME
WITH EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND
EMPOWER FAMILIES A CALIFORNIA
I'M THE MOTHER OF THE VACCINE
AND YOUR CHILD AND A TEACHER.
OF SEVERAL VACCINE INJURED
STUDENTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS -- IN A CANOE QUOTE I
AM A MOTHER OF SIX KIDS AND A
REPRESENTATIVE ONE THOUSAND AND
FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE RUSSIAN
SPEAKING PEOPLE.
AND I WORRY WERE STRONG LEVELS.
MY NAME SHANNON HI I'M FROM
FRESNO AND THE MOTHER OF VACCINE
INJURED CHILD AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LISA SORTS FROM KINGS
FOR CALIFORNIA I AM A MOTHER OF
A VACCINE INJURED CHILD AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JESSICA DREW CARMICHAEL
CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF TWO I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BRANDY VON SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LEARN THE RISK I
USED TO WORK FOR MERCK
PHARMACEUTICALS THIS AGAIN IS A
SPONSORED BILL.
AND I REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED
DOLLARS THOSE PARENTS THIS
SCIENTIST RESEARCHERS DOCTORS
PEOPLE WHO ARE FOR MEDICAL
FREEDOM WHICH YOU NEVER PASSED
THE BILL WITH A SLIPPERY SLOPE
LIKE THIS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STACY JOYLESS I AM A
BOARD CERTIFIED HOLISTIC LICENSE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE IN SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND I FIERCELY OPPOSE
THIS CRUEL AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DOCTORSHANNON KRONER
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES I'M AN
EDUCATIONAL THERAPIST THAT WORKS
WITH VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
AND I STRONGLY STRONGLY DOCTOR
PAN OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ROSE IN
UNION I AM A PARENT OF A CHILD
THE VACCINATION EXEMPTION I AM
ALSO A PATIENT ADVOCATE WITH THE
DIAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
DR BRIAN ANDERSON FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY MODESTO.
IN A GRANDPARENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JESSICA DENNING SCIENCE TEACHER
REPRESENTING THE SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY YELLED.
WHO STRONGLY OPPOSES -- THEY
HAVE THEY HAVE THROWN OUT ALL
THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE FOR
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS SERRA HILL
AND I'M PART OF THE CHILDREN'S
HEALTH CLUB COLLISION AND I HAVE
A VACCINE INJURED SIDE WITHOUT
AN EXEMPTION IS ONLY TWENTY
MONTHS OLD AND I NEED TO PROTECT
HIM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DENISE YOUNG FROM LOS ANGELES.
MOTHER OF TWO FORMER FIZER
EXECUTIVE I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A NEW BY THE
ADVOCATE FOR THE HEALTH FREEDOM
MOVEMENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND I'M FORMALLY OVER
VACCINATED.
HI MY NAME IS WALTER AND THE I
NAME IS.
MY NAME IS JOE HAWKINS AND I'M
FROM SANTA MONICA CALIFORNIA AND
I'M REPRESENTING MANY VACCINE
INJURY PERRANCE FROM SANTA
MONICA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS COREY MEANIES ON THE
LOS ANGELES ORGANIZER FOR LEARN
THE RISK I AM A VACCINE INJURED
ADULTS WITH THE VACCINE INJURED
TWENTY TWO YEAR VETERAN HUSBAND.
TO VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN AND
I CAN SLEEP AT NIGHT AND I
OPPOSE SB TWO SEVENTY SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI LARRY DELLAVEDOVA AND THE PR
DIRECTOR FOR THE NATIONAL HEALTH
FEDERATION I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL IS A VIOLATION OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND AGREES
OVERREACH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TERRY
WORK I'M A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN
AND THE SURVIVING PARENT OF A
VACCINE INJURED CHILD.
MY LATE SON THOMAS WOULD BE
FORTY FIVE IF HE WERE STILL
ALIVE.
I'M ALSO THE AFRICAN AQ RECTOR
FOR THE NATIONAL VACCINE
INFORMATION CENTER AND WE ALL
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHANNON THOMPSON I'M
FROM SAN DIEGO I'M A PRO BONO
SPECIAL EDUCATION ADVOCATE
REPRESENTING EDUCATE ADVOCATE
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN CASTRO I'M
AND SENATOR RUBIO DISTRICT I'M A
MOTHER OF FOUR WITH AN INJURED
BACKS VACCINE DAUGHTER WHO ALSO
HAVE CEREBRAL PALSY THANK YOU.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
HI I'M FELICIA WOFFORD FROM LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN I HAVE TWO CHILDREN
ONE MEDIC MEDICALLY FRAGILE THIS
WOULD IMPACT GREATLY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AND I DO
REPRESENT ABOUT A HUNDRED PEOPLE
THAT COULD NOT MAKE IT FRIENDS
AND FAMILY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROLAND WOFFORD ALSO
FROM LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA.
I URGE YOU. TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
DEBORAH SCHAEFER CHILDREN'S
HEALTH COALITION TEACHER AND
MOTHER OF THREE MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
ATTORNEY KRISTIN DENNIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S HEALTH
COALITION.
WE STAND FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M CRISTINA MECKLENBURG THIS IS
MY DAUGHTER SHE WAS VACCINATED
LAST YEAR BY THE MMR VACCINE AND
SHE RECEIVED OCULAR POLICY I
STRONGLY OPPOSES.
MEDICAL BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANGELA HICKS I'M HERE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY ON BEHALF OF
MY SEVERELY VACCINE INJURED
CHILD WHO WOULD NOT QUALIFY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE YOUR BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M STACEY SANTLEY I MEAN
SENATOR BATES -- DISTRICT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
DOCTOR BOB SEARS PEDIATRICIAN
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE BORN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
PLEASE WITH MY NAME IS LEE
HAVING ADULTS PROUD PARENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
CATHERINE JOHNSON I AM THE
MOTHER OF TWO AND A SPEECH
PATHOLOGIST AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
TAMMY BELCHER ALSO SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGISTS MOTHER
THREE MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN
AND I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS IGOR KNOWS A LIFETIME
FATHER OF THREE KIDS AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE THESE BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS MARY JOHNSON PHYSICAL
THERAPIST FOR DIGNITY HEALTH I
REPRESENT CHILDREN WITH MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
INCLUDING TWO OF MY OWN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS KNOWN JOHNSON AND I'M
ELEVEN AND I'M VACCINE INJURED I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AINSLEY JOHNSON
AND I'M THIRTEEN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL AND I'M ALSO
VACCINE INJURED.
MY NAME IS MADELINE THE DUSKY MY
YOUNGER SISTER IS VACCINE
INJURED AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M SHARON THUNDER FROM SAN
DIEGO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ONE ZERO I'M A PARENT
OF A FAX.
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILD AND I
WERE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PEGGY WALTERS MOTHER
OF TWO AND A STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR STANTON HOME A
PEDIATRIC CHIROPRACTOR FROM SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANGIE GAVIN FROM AND
SENATE AS CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE PERSON IN
A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
NICOLE MIDDLETON MOTHER OF TWO A
LIFELONG CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
YVONNE SLATER PREVIOUS SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA NO SENATOR PAN NO YOU
MAY NOT HAVE MY CHILD Q..
MY NAME IS SANDRA RUN FOR WILSON
I'M FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA
I'M A SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST AND I'M A MOTHER OF
TWO FOR MEDICALLY.
FRAGILE CHILDREN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS YOLANDA BANKS READ
FROM PEOPLE CULTURE COMMUNITY
AND SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE MOTHERS.
AND FATHERS TRUE DRINK THINKERS
BILLS AT THE THING FROM SELF I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL HAVE
FOURTEEN GRANDCHILDREN AND WE
ARE THE KEEPERS YOU CARRIERS ARE
HOLDERS OF LIFE YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE HAVE A RIGHT TO CHOICE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LANI ONE ROAD THE
HEBREW CULTURE COMMITTEE HIM
MYSELF STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL FOR ALL THE CHILDREN THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TRACY SAID TWYLA
I'M A PARENT AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MY LOVE FOR THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS HOLLY ONE FADING I AM
THE MOTHER OF TWO ONE VACCINE
INJURED RECOGNIZED BY YOUR
VACCINE INJURY COURTS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR BRIAN HOOKER.
I AM A RESEARCH SCIENTIST AND
THE SCIENTIFIC ADVISER FOR FOCUS
FOR HEALTH I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF MY
VACCINE INJURED CHILD THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOANNA HEDRICK I MAY
SACRAMENTO NATIVE I AM IN YOUR
DISTRICTS SENATOR PAN I AM THE
MOTHER OF TWO HEALTHY
UNVACCINATED CHILDREN.
I DO NOT CONSENT I OPPOSE THANK
YOU SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LAURA SHEPHERD
FROM SAN DIEGO MOTHER OF TWO
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
KAREN HARRIS FROM SANTA MONICA
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR NOTING
VOTING NO ON THIS VERY FAULTY
AND UNNECESSARY BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI MARINA NADAR AND I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
BECAUSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WILLIAMS OVER BELL AND PHYSICAL
THERAPY ASSISTANT AND THEN
TURNED TO FOR KIDS NAY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME SURGICAL IT FOR CHECK A
FATHER OF FOUR I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED HIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
I READ A CHRISTIAN THE NURSE AT
KAISER I'VE SEEN TOO MANY
VACCINE INJURIES TOO MANY AND
I'M A MOTHER OF TWO AND I'M A
FAMILY MEMBER OF TWO INJURED
KIDS. FOR WITH VACCINES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S CASEY CLAYTON
FROM TO HAVE TO BE CALIFORNIA.
AND I MAY SUPPOSED TO THIS BILL
AND I JUST LIKE TO SEE MY
DAUGHTER WAS ALSO VACCINE
INJURED.
OCULAR POLICY OF THE SIX NERVE
RIGHT AFTER RECEIVING HER MMR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER CLAYTON
I'M ALSO FROM JACQUI CALIFORNIA
I'M A PEACE OFFICER I'M A FATHER
OF FOUR BEAUTIFUL GIRLS ONE OF
WHICH IS VACCINE INJURED AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO SB TWO
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO I'M CHRISTY EXCEPT IN
THOUSAND OAKS CALIFORNIA I'M A
PARENT OF A BOXING INTER CHILD
AND REPRESENT THE OTHER FAMILIES
THAT COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE ARE TAKING CARE OF THEIR
BACKING INTO CHILDREN IN A POST
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RACHEL RONNIE OF
TUSTIN CALIFORNIA I'M A TEACHER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KAREN ROE SAYS I AM
AN EDUCATOR AND AN ORDAINED
MINISTER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MOLLY COOPER OF
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LEE DUNDAS I WAS A
VACCINE INJURED IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES I AM A PARENT I AM AN
ATTORNEY I SIT ON A
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE THAT I
WAS APPOINTED.
TO BY ED ROYCE.
I FORMALLY PROSECUTED FELONY
ISRAELI DA'S OFFICE AND I
REPRESENTED A FORTUNE.
FIVE HUNDRED SIMILAR TO VACCINE
INTERESTS AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED AND I BELIEVE THESE
ISSUES NEED TO BE FURTHER
REVIEWED ON THE LEGAL SIDE
BEFORE ABOUT CAN BE HAPPY THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
MY NAME IS IDA GEEKY AND FROM
ORANGE COUNTY I'M A CLINICAL
NEUROPSYCHOLOGY DOCTORAL STUDENT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARIA BE DONE I AM
FROM NORTH HIGHLANDS CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE A VACCINE INJURED CHILD
AND I'M SHOWING THAT AGAINST HIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NICOLE MY TELLS AND
THEN FOR SAN DIEGO EN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
I'M REALLY A CORNER OF
SACRAMENTO HAVE THREE CHILDREN
PLEASE VOTE NO.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE FORD I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND THE FOUNDER OF THE
VACCINE INJURY AWARENESS LEAKING
CULVER CITY WHERE NATIONAL NON
PROFIT.
DEDICATED TO RAISING AWARENESS
ABOUT VACCINE RELATED INJURIES
STRONGLY OPPOSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M VICTORIA HOME AND I
OPPOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANALLY SWELLS I AM IN
SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA MY CHILD IS
MEDICALLY FRAGILE I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ON THE
COULDN'T SO OFTEN ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE USER.
MY NAME IS MARINA GOGA AND THE
SHOULDER OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A LOT OF IT -- FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
CATHERINE TERRACE SUCK FROM
SACRAMENTO ALSO POSING.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANNA DAVID OFF FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND THE
MOTHER OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
TONY FOR THE BEST THE THE
PROVIDER OF TWO THEY'RE MY KIDS
THEY'RE NOT YOUR GUINEA PIGS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THEN HONEY CUT ON THE
FOUNDING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
MOMS ACROSS AMERICA AND WE'RE
THE ONES THAT FOUND LIFE YOU SEE
WE'D KILLER.
IN VACCINES AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS DRACONIAN BILL.
AND THE BRAIN WASHING MY THAT IS
HAPPENING IN THIS FACILITY THANK
YOU TODAY.
HI MY NAME SHE KNOWS GRAHAM I'M
OF AT A FIREFIGHTER I'M A MOTHER
OF FOUR CHILDREN I HAVE ONE
CHILD WHO IS SEVERELY MEDICAL
FRAGILE MEDICALLY FRAGILE.
THIS BILL WOULD IN BACK IMPACT
HIM SIGNIFICANTLY I OPPOSE THIS
BILL NEGOTIATE AND NO VOTE FROM
EACH ONE OF YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DENISE I YOU ARE FROM
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF THE
THOUSANDS OF PARENTS WHO THINK
VACCINATING IS A LAW.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE HARDER
FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
THE KING OF THE PAN I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS COLLEEN
MICHAELS I MADE BUSINESS OWNER
AND A MOTHER AND I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR JONES I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A CLOWNISH OF
JUNGLE NAM STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LIVE OF CARBON FIBER
MOM OF SIX NONMEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
BUT I AGAINST THE CENSORSHIP BUT
THE STATE THANK YOU BRING ON
CHILDREN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS LUCAS AND
TOOK I'M STRONGLY OPPOSES THE
USER.
MY NAME IS OLGA COSTS TO CALM A
PARENT AND A MOTHER OF FOUR I'M
A CO FOUNDER -- MEANT NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION MAMA'S MISS
MINISTERING BEHALF OF A LOT OF
MOMS WE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
SPEAK YOU.
MY NAME IS TO ME LIKE TO MY FAVE
MOTHER OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSED.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANNA KOURNIKOVA
I'M FROM CITRUS HEIGHTS I AM AN
EDUCATOR AND A MOTHER OF THREE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
QUEUE.
MY NAME IS NICOLE BIELIK FROM
SAM'S A SCOUT I AM FAXING
INJURED AND I ADOPTED A VACCINE
INJURED KID.
SHE CANNOT GET A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S DINEEN HINES AND FROM
SAUSALITO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S COURTNEY -- QUEST I'M
FROM OCEANSIDE CALIFORNIA AND
I'M ROOM REPRESENTING MY FAMILY
AND FRIENDS WHO HAVE BEEN
FOREVER CHANGED AND HARMED BY
VACCINE THANK YOU.
AND TO BE THE KUBIAK FROM SAN
DIEGO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME TO GET A LOCAL I.
CURVATURE OF CHILD CARE.
I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED THESE BE
[inaudible]
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
I'VE BEEN CLOSE COAST CHILDCARE
PROVIDER I'M FATHER FOR STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL HAS BE TO THANK YOU
SIR.
NINA KUSHNER CHIP CARD MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WE INCLUDES CO STUDENT STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
I AM AMBER GRAFTON FROM LAKE
ELSINORE CALIFORNIA I'M HERE
REPRESENTING MY DAUGHTER WHO
CURRENTLY HAS A VALID MEDICAL
EXCEPTION I OPPOSE THE SPELL
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M JEANNE O'BRIEN FROM TO
MACULA CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF
THREE WHO CURRENTLY OF MAGIC
MEDICALLY FRAGILE AND WOULD NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO ATTEND PUBLIC
SCHOOL I AM VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
HI I'M JOIN A QATARI DIG MEN
CONSTITUENTS OF SENATOR STONE A
PARENT OF A VACCINE INJURED
CHILD.
THE MENTAL HEALTH THERAPIST I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THE
QUEUE.
AMANDA TEN I THINK MOTHER OF
FOUR FROM THREE DOES I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS CAROLYN RUBIO I'M A
VACCINE INJURED ADULT WITH
FAXING INJURED CHILDREN FROM LA
PALMA CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M SANDY BERGMAN FROM BACK
OF ALL CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF PARENTS UNITED FOR
KIDS AND MY SON.
TO SEE WHO IS SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
BY THE VITAMIN K. SHOT WHO WANTS
TO GO TO MEDICAL SCHOOL TO STUDY
SPORTS MEDICINE.
RESPONSIBLY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOHN BURTON AND I AM
ALSO FROM BACK A BILL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
HI THANK YOU MY NAME IS JULIE
MAKESHIFT MAN ANY DE.
I AM IMMUNO COMPROMISED AND
REPRESENT MY MEDICALLY FRAGILE.
FAMILY WITH HIM A HISTORY OF
IMMUNE PROBLEMS AND I POSE A
SPELL THANK YOU.
HI HI MY NAME IS THERESA BELLY.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
SIR.
MY NAME IS SVETLANA BUT THREE
SCORE MOTHER OF THREE AND
THEY'RE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THE MAN.
MY NAME IS SURGERY WILK I'M A
FATHER ELEVEN KIDS.
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL
[inaudible]
THE USER.
MY NAME IS WITH HIM SURE BUT I'M
A RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTITIONER
LE STRONGLY OPPOSES THE BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS LEAH BLEACHER I'M A
PEDIATRIC INTENSIVE CARE NURSE
OF TWELVE YEARS I'M CERTIFIED BY
THE ASSOCIATION OF CRITICAL CARE
NURSES I'VE SEEN FAR TOO MANY
CASES OF VACCINE INJURY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KAREEM BAKER FROM
LOCKER SANTA AND MY MOTHER OF
FOUR AND I REPRESENT THE
FAMILIES OF MY COMMUNITY WITH
FAXING INJURED KIDS THAT I
OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN GOT ARGO
BEVERLY HILLS CALIFORNIA I AM
THE MOTHER OF A MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILD ALONG WITH OTHER
VACCINE INJURE MEMBERS OF MY
FAMILY.
FINE I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANDREA CREWS -- OF IT
IS STRONG OPPOSE THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS MARK PERSONAGE
WRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS RUTH TERRACE I'VE
LOST MY LITTLE BROTHER TO
VACCINE TO MY SIBLINGS.
GOT INJURED MY SON GOT INJURED
BY VACCINES I STRONGLY OPPOSE
YOU.
MY NAME IS AMY MEANT SMITH I'M
FROM SAN DIEGO I'M A MOTHER OF A
CHILD WHO WAS -- HAD.
THREE SEPARATE VACCINE REACTIONS --
I'M A FORD.
SEPARATE BACK THE REACTIONS ON
THREE DIFFERENT OCCASIONS AND HE
WAS COMPENSATED BY THE NATIONAL
VACCINE INJURY COMPENSATION
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
SORRY HEREBY FAR CORDELL FROM
SAN DIEGO MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS REBECCA E. STAFF
PALAIS CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS WELL AS MY
HAS BEEN LIEUTENANT COLONEL JACK
EAST AT THE UNITED STATES MARINE
CORPS RETIRED THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MAUREEN PLUCK MARIN COUNTY
ATTORNEY.
MOTHER WAS RECOMMENDED TO GET A
FLU SHOT SHE GOT A LS DIED
WITHIN TWO YEARS.
Q. VACCINE INJURED KIDS.
JUDICIALLY TESTED MEDICAL
EXEMPTION THAT DOES NOT STAND UP.
UNDER THIS BILL I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE HOME.
ALEX MEYER NBA I LOST MY CAREER
BECAUSE OF VACCINES I HAVE A
DAUGHTER WHO SPREAD MEASLES FOR
THREE YEARS AFTER MEASLES
VACCINE.
I'M WITH CHILDREN'S HEALTH
DEPENDS ROBERT F. KENNEDY'S
ORGANIZATION I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
AND MASON MARIN COUNTY I OPPOSE
ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY Q..
SUMMER BOGER FROM SAN DIEGO I'M
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL AND I'M ALSO
FROM THE SALT LAKE COUNCIL AND I
ALSO AND THE SECRETARY FOR THE
EAGLE FORUM.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE VACCINE INJURY IS THE
REAL DANGER TO OUR THANK YOU.
I'M PATRICIA LEE AND FOR SAN
DIEGO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL I HAVE MANY FRIENDS WHO A
VACCINE THANK YOU HOLDREN.
MILLER AND SEEN AS CALIFORNIA
DOCTOR PHYSICAL THERAPY AND PHD
STUDENT I STRONGLY OPPOSES VALUE.
CARE MORALES AN EDUCATOR FROM
SAN DIEGO MY SON BEGAN HAVING
SEIZURES AFTER D. TAPI STOP
BREATHING AND NEARLY DIED IN
SPENT FOUR DAYS IN THE PEDIATRIC
ICU.
IF THIS BILL PASSES HE MOST
LIKELY NOT GET A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION IF YOU VOTE FOR THIS
BILL IS A CRIMINAL ACT AGAINST
THOSE WHO NEED MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS.
MY NAME IS JANET LEVITAN MD I'VE
BEEN A PEDIATRICIAN FOR OVER
THIRTY FIVE YEARS I CAME HERE
FROM OHIO TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE IF IT HAPPENS
HERE CAN MORE EASILY HAPPEN
ELSEWHERE THANK YOU.
I'M DR LINDY WOODARD I'M A
PRIMARY CARE PEDIATRICIAN UP
FORTY YEARS I PRACTICE IN MARIN
COUNTY CALIFORNIA THIS BILL
WOULD SERIOUSLY GET IN BETWEEN
ME AND MY PATIENTS AND WHAT I
BELIEVE IS RIGHT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SABINA SANA MEN M. D.
FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS I'M IN
WOODSIDE CALIFORNIA AND I HERE
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT.
VACCINE DAMAGED CHILDREN.
THANK YOU.
BRANDON CARTER.
FATHER AND HUSBAND.
HOW MAY HAVE MY FAMILY WE OPPOSE
THANK YOU SIR?
BUT IT WAS RUN WHALEN FROM
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
BUSINESS EXECUTIVE IN THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY AND YOU
SPORTS COACH HERE ON BEHALF OF
MY WIFE AND THREE KIDS.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSES
UNNECESSARY WORDS THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS KELLY ZACK'S I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SPELL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JESSICA HALL AND A
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR NIELSEN
AND I'M HERE TO OPPOSE THE BILL
I HAVE TWO CHILDREN AND I'M ALSO
AN EDUCATOR.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTY LOVELL --
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA I AM AN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST AT THE
SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VICTORIA CORAL AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHERRY CORAL FATHER
OF THREE ME AND MY FAMILY
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO THE GALLERY AND GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO VOICE OUR OPINIONS WELCOME.
NANCY TOOL POOR.
EDUCATOR GRANDMOTHER OF TWENTY
TWO FORCE FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S ROCKERS SHORROCK
FATHER FIVE IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR KATIE LONG I
AM A GRADUATE OF THE UC DAVIS
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAM A
LOCAL PEDIATRICIAN AND FOR THE
TRUE EVIDENCE BASED REASONS
PRESENTED BY MY COLLEAGUES.
AND OUT OF RESPECT FOR MY
PATIENCE I ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS APRIL ROBBINS AND I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT MY VACCINE
INJURED SIGNED.
AN IBM IN THE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNY HENSLEY I OF
THREE AMINO COMPROMISE CHILDREN
A AND DO NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TENURE SANTOS OF A
VACCINE INJURED SON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S BRITNEY NELSON I AM --
BUSINESS OWNER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE A VACCINE
INJURED DAUGHTER WHO WOULD NOT
HAVE QUALIFIED UNDER THIS BILL
SO I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HI I'M TANYA COLLINS FROM
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS
BILL I HAVE TO VACCINE INJURED
CHILDREN AND ONE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL I WILL PULL
HER OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M MARSHALL VANDERPOOL I'M A
TEACHER AND MANDATED REPORTER
THEY'RE INJECTING NEUROTOXINS
INTO OUR CHILDREN AND I OPPOSE
THAT.
THANK YOU.
I'M LAURIE FOR VAL I'M A PUBLIC
EDUCATOR A FORMER A REGIONAL
CENTER BOARD OF DIRECTORS MEMBER.
AND A MOTHER OF A SEVERELY
VACCINE INJURED CHILD.
I VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM.
ELAINE STEIN MOM OF TWO ONE
SEVERELY VACCINE INJURED I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU THEM.
AARON HANDLER I THE VACCINE
INJURED SON I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
JULIE BELLAMY ANNA SACRAMENTO IF
TO VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CHRISTINE I CAN SEND FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH.
I HAVE TWO SONS WITH VALID
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS WHO WOULD NOT
QUALIFY FOR THEM UNDER THE SPELL
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE SENATOR PAM.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIE SALAZAR
I'M REPRESENTING MY UNVACCINATED
THRIVING CHILDREN AND I OPPOSE
THANK YOU SHAME ON YOU.
PLEASE.
BE RESPECTFUL PLEASE.
MY NAME IS ALLISON THROW FROM
ORANGE CALIFORNIA PARENT OF
THREE ONE WHO IS AN ANAPHYLACTIC
SHOCK VICTIM AT THIRTEEN MONTHS
OLD WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS
ENVISION A PARENT.
AND WITH THE QUALIFYING AND LIFE
DEPENDENT MEDICAL EXEMPTION
SPEAKING IN STRONG OPPOSITION I
THANK YOU.
PLEASE ENTER ZERO RECORD LABEL
EXECUTIVE -- ON SEVERAL
BUSINESSES WELL IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM A FATHER OF THREE THE ONE
IN WHICH IS IS A MEDICALLY.
HAS BEEN COMPROMISED AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BECAUSE HER.
DR IVANA SABAH FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA AND I POSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KELLY LIAM A
CONSTITUENT OF JONES AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
TOUGH FOR DAHLE CONSTITUENT OF
SENATOR JONES STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN TAKAMORI WESTMINSTER
MOTHER OF FOUR WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
I AM VICKY WILLIS FROM SAN JOSE
MOTHER OF FIVE ONE SO SEVERELY
VACCINE INJURED AND HIS MEDICAL
AS I'M SHOULD WOULD NOT BE VALID
UNDER THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
HI MARCELLA CANNERY HUMAN FROM
MILL VALLEY I HAVE A SIX YEAR
OLD VACCINE INJURED SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILD WHOSE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION WILL NOT QUALIFY UNDER
THIS BILL [inaudible]
EVEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS SEVEN GLASS GO
AMASSED A FATHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
CHOI GARNER MOTHER OF TWO IS
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I HAVE
A SEVEN YEAR OLD AUGHTER HE'S
ENROLLED IN SCHOOL TO MEDICAL
EXEMPTION AND THIS WOULD
INVALIDATED THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ERIN SAUNDERS FROM
SEBASTOPOL CALIFORNIA I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY.
AND MY STUDENTS I'M A TEACHER
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL CALVIN JUNIOR RESIDENT
OF SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA FATHER
OF TO WIN HOPEFULLY MORE -- AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
HEY MY NAME IS ANY MINOR I MAKE
HAS A CONSTITUENT OF MR MONEY IN
I HAVE ONE MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILD WHO WILL BE GREATLY
AFFECTED BY THIS FAR.
I'D GREATLY OPPOSE THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
I AM RICHELLE HARTLEY AND I AM
IN SENATOR MUNNINGS DISTRICT AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU.
THE CORTINAS FROM SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY I HAVE A MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILD WITH THE LEGIT A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION I POST THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHELSEA IN A
CABBAGE I HAVE TRAVELED ABOUT
TEN HOURS FROM COACHELLA VALLEY.
TO REPRESENT A GROUP OF ABOUT
EIGHTY FIVE PEOPLE TO TELL YOU
THAT WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LISA L. COEDS I
AM A LIFELONG DEMOCRAT ANY
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TAMMY RAMOS I AM
FROM A LEASE TO BE HOW
CALIFORNIA I AM A MATERNAL CHILD
REGISTERED NURSE WITH KAISER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S NATALIE PAF RAP I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AT KAISER AND A
MOTHER OF A VACCINE AND YOUR
CHILD IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GILLIAN CLASS I AM
ALSO A REGISTERED NURSE AT
KAISER PERMANENTE A I HAVE TWO
VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN WHO
HAVE LEGITIMATE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND THEY WOULD NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL
IF THIS PASSES THEY WILL BOTH BE
PULLED OUT MY WILL BE FORCED TO
HOME.
SCHOOL THEM.
STRONGLY OPPOSES THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KATHY PAINTER I'M A
CERTIFIED NATURAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONER THIS BILL VIOLATES
THE NUREMBERG CODE WHICH STATES
THAT EVERY MEDICAL PROCEDURE
MUST HAVE INFORMED CONSENT THANK
YOU.
YOU OPPOSE THE BILL I OPPOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HEARING US MY NAME IS LAURIE
SCHWARTZ I REPRESENT UP PARENTAL
RIGHTS DOT ORG WE ARE FIVE
THOUSAND STRONG.
AND THIS BILL IS REALLY ABOUT
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS AND PARENTAL
RIGHTS TO MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS
WITH THEIR DOCTORS.
AND I ASKED YOU RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU OPPOSE THE
SPELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI AM SEIZE ON A DOCTOR PAN
PLEASE STOP THIS EVIL YOU DO
OPPOSED TO PLEASE I OPPOSE THIS
THING AND YOU PLEASE SAVE YOUR
SOUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MEET THE VACCINES ARE
SPREADING THE NEWS ALL THINK
THAT'S WHAT SPREADING IT YOU
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
[inaudible]
NEXT PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS A LEASE AGAINST
I'M HERE FROM TORRANCE
CALIFORNIA PROTECTING.
PARENTAL RIGHTS ARE BASIC HUMAN
RIGHTS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
MY NAME IS TAMERA TAURUS I'M
FROM TO HAVE TO BE CALIFORNIA I
HAVE A VACCINE INJURED SON AND
TWO OTHER CHILDREN WHO NEED
THEIR MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS BUT
WOULD NOT QUALIFY UNDER THIS
BILL.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE TORRES I
AM SIXTEEN YEARS OLD AND I'M
FROM TOUCH ME CALIFORNIA I
FORCIBLY.
OPPOSED TO THIS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BILL THANK YOU AND THE SISTER OF
AN OLDER BROTHER WHO IS AFFECTED
INJURED.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR CAROL BALL
FROM RICHMOND CALIFORNIA I'M A
REGISTERED DEMOCRAT AND HAVE
BEEN FOR MANY YEARS I PLAN TO
EXIT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BECAUSE THROUGHOUT THE KIND YOU
OPPOSE THAT OR PARTY'S SUPPORT
IS.
STANDING ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
THE ISSUE ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WITH THESE BILLS ARE HAPPENING
SO I WILL BE LEAVING HIS
DEMOCRATIC MA'AM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
WERE SERIOUSLY KIND OF KEEP IT
UNDER CONTROL OKAY LET'S BE
RESPECTFUL NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
MY NAME IS TRISH Là AB I
STRONGLY OPPOSES FELL I HAVE.
TWO CHILDREN.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.
OUR CHILDREN AND THEIR DOCTORS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FROM SAN
FRANCISCO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GABRIELLE STEPHANIE
SENATOR PAN I BELIEVE YOU'RE
COMMITTING CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY MUSIC FOR YOU TO DEAL
RIGHT BILL OR SUPPORT.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS NICK A PATH COLLIE
AND I'M FROM CORD TO MADERA
CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE A SON WITH
AN AUTOIMMUNE DISORDER WHO HAS
HAD THE SAME PEDIATRICIAN SINCE
HE WAS BORN.
AND NOT SO I WANT MAKING THE
DECISIONS FOR MY CHILD THANK YOU
OPPOSE. ONE IS IN FRENCH
LIFELONG CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
OPPOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LISA MARIE CLINICAL NUTRITIONIST
FROM SAN DIEGO AND I ALSO HAVE
AN AT RISK CHILD SO I WOULD HAVE
TO PUT OUR TO SCHOOL IF THIS
PASSES AND IT'S VERY IN
CONSTITUTIONAL THANK YOU AYE
OPPOSED THANK YOU.
PEPPER NICHOLSON FROM SAN DIEGO
AN EDUCATOR AND MOTHER WHO
STRONGLY OPPOSES SAYS THANK YOU.
AND I'M A REGISTERED CREEK.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MATT.
I'M BLESSED WITH.
TWO ALWAYS ON THE AXE NATIVE
CHILDREN.
I AM BLESSED THEY ARE HEALTHY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU SIR
WE'RE ALL YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LINDSEY MIKE
RODNEY FROM TESTING CALIFORNIA I
AM AN ATTORNEY AND MOTHER OF
THREE KIDS.
AND DOCTORS AND PARENTS KNOW
BASS I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
HI DOCTOR HEIDI HOOK.
AND I FOR MY SYSTEM FOR MY
CHILDREN FOR MY PATIENTS AND FOR
MY HIPPOCRATIC OATH I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S LAURA MINARD A
REGISTERED NURSE IN A HOLISTIC
NURSE COACH AND MY TWO CHILDREN --
VACCINE INJURED ONE OF THEM
WOULD NOT QUALIFY UNDER YOUR
BILL AND THEY DESERVE TO GO TO
SCHOOL.
THANK YOU WRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS TRINA PROGRAMS FROM
IRVINE CALIFORNIA MOTHER TO
GRANDMOTHER FOR I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JACQUELYN DE MICHON FROM DANA
POINT EDUCATED GRANDMA OF SEVEN
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MANY SAFE -- FOR THE FOR KIDS
HELL TO NOT TALK SENATE THAT I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NATALIA FILLING SKI AND I'M A
RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTITIONER IN
POLICY MCAFEE TECHNOLOGIST AND
MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN ONE OF
WHOM IS MEDICALLY FRAGILE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
BACK TO THE OFFICE ASK YOU TO
THANK YOU.
I'M LEVEL AND THAT IS.
AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL SACRAMENTO
THANK YOU.
REMOVE THE GERMAN GIVE UP A NOTE
BOOK THIS BILL SACRAMENTO.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S A LANDFILL IN SKI
AND I OR BOTH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
INDEED ALL SILENCE FROM WHERE.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AMANDA MERECE I'M
FROM SANTA ROSA THEY STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWO SEVENTY SIX AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE HIPPOCRATIC
OATH THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS FRANCESCA WAS BARSKY
FROM LOOKING TO CALIFORNIA WIFE
OF A MARINE WHO FOUGHT TO
PROTECT OUR CONSTITUTION AND OUR
COUNTRY.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CRYSTAL DUNN I
HAVE TWO TWIN BOYS ARE WILL BE
T RISK AND I ALSO REPRESENT
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT CAN'T BE
HERE THE HAD VACCINE INTO
CHILDREN.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS WITH THE SALE
KELLY AND I HAVE A VACCINE
INJURED CHILD.
AND MY OTHER TWO WOULD NOT -- BE
ELIGIBLE FOR A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
SO THAT WOULD LEAVE ME WITH NO
OTHER CHOICE BUT TO LEAVE
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
GIVE ME THE RESEARCHERS DUKE
SACRAMENTO STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS NADIA AND THIS IS
HOPE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
BUT I WANT TO SAY I AM A FULL
TIME MINISTER HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND JESUS LOVES YOU.
PAN THANK YOU.
I'M KAREN CLEANER SACRAMENTO I
OPPOSE THIS BILL I'M ALSO
SPEAKING FOR MY SISTER WHO IS IN
A WHEELCHAIR CAN I GET DOWN THE
STAIRS AND SHE HIGHLY OPPOSES
THIS BILL.
TO AND I AM YOUR CONSTITUENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I MEAN A JACKSON'S STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE SELLARS MOTHER OF
VACCINE INJURED AND MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILD THAT I WILL HAVE
TO LEAVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IF THIS BILL IS PASSED I
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
MY I AM MASS FULL FROM CV VALLEY
VACCINE INJURED AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LISA STARK IN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CAITLYN MCCORMICK
REGISTERED NURSING LICENSE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
PLEASE BEGIN MIKE.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER FRISELL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TINA HOW TO I'M A
VETERINARIAN TO HOLD A LICENSE
IN GERMANY AND IN THE UNITED
STATES.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I
THINK IT'S DANGEROUS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARYLAND BURKE INYO
FROM UPON THE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
TOBY CORTESE FROM MORGAN HOW
CALIFORNIA MOM I'VE SIX ONE
VACCINE INJURED AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
CHOICE LEAST SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUENTS OF
SENATOR PAN STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
CHARLES AWAITING FROM SACRAMENTO.
DOCTOR PAN I'M IN YOUR DISTRICT
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
NINA NURSING STUDENT MOTHER OF
TWO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
TOLLIE FATHER OF TWO OF THEM
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU
SIR.
IT IS ALL WORDS.
I FUNDS OF SIX CHILDREN I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
UNTIL BAY TREE AND CEO OF THE
INFORMED CONSENT ACTION NETWORK
I REPRESENT THIRTY NINE MILLION
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THAT ARE ON
AWARE THAT NO VACCINES BEEN
THROUGH PROPER CARE YOU OPPOSE
EAGLE SAFETY STUDY WORK THE BILL.
I'M OPPOSE THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU.
SUZANNE MOTHER OF TWO OVER
VACCINATED CHILDREN STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS ALYSSA I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
NAME IS BRIAN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME'S AMBER ACTION I HAVE TO
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AMY VAN LING SENATORS DISTRICT
SEVEN AND FOUR CHILDREN AND AYE
OPPOSED TO SPELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
VERY BARS GRANDPARENT VACCINE
INJURED CHILD I OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE LINDSEY GRADUAL OTHER OF
THREE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
FULLY UNVACCINATED DAUGHTER HAVE.
YOU'RE GONNA YOUR TYRANT THANK
YOU SIR TYRANT.
PLEASE THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER
PLEASE [inaudible]
SIR.
THE SERGEANTS.
BACK TO TREAT THESE AS OF THIS
COURT.
PLEASE COME BACK TO TERRY CITY
AS INFORMED CONSENT IS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KEITH ROBERTS I AM
A MOTHER OF A VACCINATED INJURED
CHILD WHO HAD ENCEPHALITIS.
I ALSO HAVE RELATIVES WHO HAVE
PASSED AWAY DUE TO VACCINE
RELATED INJURIES.
ON MY OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
IN ACROSS NOVA MOTHER OF THREE I
OPPOSE AT THIS BILL.
IT'S ON CONTACTS ADDITIONAL
THANK YOU.
REBECCA NELSON ORANGE COUNTY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA NOT
PHARMA THANK YOU.
I HAVE PAUL NELSON ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THE TYRANNY
SO NATURALLY I WOULD OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY WHERE ANY OF THE PEAKERS
OF THE TOP THAT ARE PER
OPPONENTS SAY NONE WE'RE GONNA.
GO BACK TO THE BOTTOM FLOOR HERE
ON THE RIGHT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
BEGIN [inaudible]
OKAY.
HI MY NAME PARTY ON THE NEW CORA
SACRAMENTO I HAVE NINE GRINS
THOMPSON DAUGHTERS.
ON A STRONG ON POLLS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MAX -- FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BECAUSE I WHEN WE WANT TO
MAKE MY OWN DECISIONS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KATE AMOUNT MOM OF
THREE I'M.
A POST THANK YOU.
SLOW A COOL CHICK GOT THREE KIDS
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE DEAL
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS MARK AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NATALIA I'M OPPOSE
HUMBLE MONEY MAY FEEL I AM
THIRTEEN AND ME AND MY FAMILY
COMING FROM SAN FRANCISCO JUST
FOR A TEN SECOND SPEECH AND AND
I'M FROM A FAMILY WITH FIVE
GENERATIONS OF HEALTHY AND
VACCINATED.
CHILDREN IN THE NOTES AND I AM
HERE TO FIGHT FOR MY RIGHTS TO
STANDS COOL.
YOUNG MAN.
IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO YOUR
POSTING PLEASE MOVE ON NEXT
BAKER PLEASE.
MY NAME IS TIE HERE MAY FEEL AND
I'M I LIVE IN AND YOU WANT TO
LIVE AND NOT DIE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LADY LE ODYSSEY THE
CHAMBERS EVEN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES THANK YOU AND I'M FOR
THE HEBREWS OF YA OUR LEVINE.
MYSELF THINK THAT ACCORDING TO
OUR CHILDREN NEXT BIGGER PLACE.
TEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
MY NAME IS OBVIOUS CHAMBERS OF
THE HEBREW CULTURAL COMMUNITY
AND MOTHER OF THREE UNVACCINATED
CHILDREN WHO HAVE NEVER HARMED
ANYONE OR HAD MEASLES OR
CHICKENPOX AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AND I OPPOSE YOU SENATOR
PANIC YOU.
NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
I MEAN YOU BY CHAMBERS OF THE
HEBREW CULTURAL COMMUNITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND WE OPPOSE YOU PAN.
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
MY NAME IS MY NAME IS KIM CAME
FROM SHASTA COUNTY WORKED IN
MEDICAL COULD FILL FOR TEN YEARS
WORKED IN THE ER ONCOLOGY MED
SURGE ALL OVER THE PLACE -- ARE
YOU NEED TO PRESERVE.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PATIENT
AND DOCTOR I OPPOSE AS WELL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PETER COAST OF ON HOW
I AM A FATHER OF FOUR KIDS AND I
OPPOSES BUILDING USER.
MY NAME IS OLIVER POPOFF AND
THEY HAVE THREE KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS DEALING ATTORNEY OF A
MOTHER OF THREE HEALTHY KIDS AND
I'VE OPPOSED TO SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU.
IN THE COMMENTS FROM SACRAMENTO
AND POSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
pFOURTEEN HEALTHY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THE RENO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU MY NAME IS
SOPHIA CATTLE.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES THANK YOU.
NAME IS THE ANA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES THANK YOU.
THE NAME IS -- GIVING TO LEARN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS LILIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL MR PENDING -- MUCH
NEXT BAKER.
MY NAME IS KATE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EVELYN A BRANCH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS RON RENTS AND I ALSO
POSES BILL THANK YOU.
JAMES CACKLE IN A STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
WITH ANNIKA AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
IT WAS NOT ALL YOUR MONSON AYE
MOTHER OF THREE AND THEN
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
THIS IS MY FRANK YOU MICHAEL HE
DOESN'T SPEAK ENGLISH HE ALSO
THANK YOU.
NEXT WEEK -- PLEASE.
MY NAME IS HELEN THE BRAZIL COME
FROM SACRAMENTO AND A MOTHER OF
FIVE AND I'M STRUCK A POSE THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS BRETT SALES I'M FROM
SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I
SUPPORT MEDICAL FREEDOM THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS CASSIE THIBODEAU
RESIDENT OF SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA.
MOTHER OF THREE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL MY CHILDREN
HAVE THE RIGHT TO DISSIPATE AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION -- PLEASE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS SHANNON FREED MS A
CONSTITUENT A CENTER MONEY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS LILY I HAVE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS THAT ARE VACCINE
INJURED WHEN THERE'S A REGISTER
SHOULD BE A CHOICE I STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB TWO SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BRANDON CLARK AND
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL AND I
SUPPORT -- MEDICAL FREEDOM THANK
YOU SIR BEHALF OF DOCTOR SAVY
AND ALL BLACK COMMUNITY THANK
YOU.
MY MEASURE GARAGE ONLY BECAUSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M ELENA MCCORVEY A MOM OF
THREE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
SUPPORT MEDICAL FREEDOM.
THANK YOU.
BUT NOT OF A RUSSIAN CAR -- I'M
STILL BE OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE
MY OFFERING CHILD WAS INJURED
FROM THE IT WORKS IN.
THE QUEUE.
MY NAME IS FLOODING THE CRITIC
FROM SACRAMENTO FIVE KIDS I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL TWO
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO THE CALICO DUKE I AM VERY
STRONG THE POOR.
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS
LARISSA CAUSTIC I'M A RESIDENT
OF CITRUS HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA I'M
ALSO A REGISTERED NURSE.
CURRENTLY PRACTICING AT KAISER
I'VE SEEN WAY TOO MANY CHILDREN
AND ADULTS INJURED FROM
OXIDATION I'M STRONGLY OPPOSING
AS BE TO TWENTY SIXTH THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
EILEEN AND IMPROVE THE FROM
SACRAMENTO HI MOM OF FOUR AND
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSES DANGERS
BILL THANK YOU.
GILLIAN ACCRUED SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I AM A REGISTERED
NURSE AND MY MOM AND GRANDMOTHER
AND I'M SIMPLY A POSTED THANK
YOU.
AUGUST CIRCLE SCHEME REGISTER
NEAR FROM CALIFORNIA SACRAMENTO
AND I'M STILL NOT OPPOSE AS BE
TO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HI MY THEM WITH THAT WILL COME
FROM SACRAMENTO.
I HAVE TO HELP SHIELD THEM.
TWENTY SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN. FOR
GROUND THEN SHOOT.
AYE OPPOSED HIS BE TWO SEVENTY
SIX THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME THIRTY ON THE
KITCHEN COUNTER MY MOTHER OF
NINE I AM A PAUSE THIS BILL
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PRESS CORPS VIEW
PELUK TO I HAVE ELEVEN KIDS ONE
KIDS DISABLE [inaudible]
NOR.
HIS BE.
TWO SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS PETER PULL TO I
ALSO OFFICE OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
HER.
MY NAME IS MARINA BECAUSE
LEBANON FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE THREE
HEALTHY CHILDREN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANGELA CITRIC BUT
OPPOSES BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MINE YET AND I ASK
YOU TO STE OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
MAINTAIN THE PATIENT DOCTOR LEE
Q..
MY NAME'S ARENA LAST I HAVE
TWENTY THREE NIECES AND NEPHEWS
AND ON THE FUTURE MOM AND AYE
OPPOSED TO SPELL THANK YOU.
THE NAME MY NAME YOU BOTH I HAVE
TWENTY THREE TO GET.
I POSES DEAL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS FELIX FIFTH MONTH AND
I'M THIRTY YEARS MASSAGE
THERAPIST.
TREAT ME PATIENCE AFTER THE
VACCINATIONS.
AND FATHER -- FORM AND OPPOSED
HIS BIGGEST HER.
MY NAME IS ON THE VICE MONTH.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME THE CALIFORNIA TIME -- I
MáS I AM WAS OUR FIVE KIDS AND
GRANDMOTHER. THREE KIDS.
AYE OPPOSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ARENA SYMONENKO AND
I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR AND AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ENOUGH PROBABLY
I'M A MOTHER OF THREE AND I WORK
AT SUTTER.
ROSEVILLE HAS A REGISTERED NURSE
AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NELLIE SLOVENSKI AND
I'M A MOTHER OF TWO AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GALINA SINGLE MOTHER
OF FIVE ONLY OPPOSES BEEN.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER GARDELLA
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND
I'M HERE EPRESENTING FIVE
INJURED.
A VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN IN
OUR FAMILY HIGHLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL IF YOU.
MY NAME IS CONSTANCE FAN GROSS
I'M A LICENSED NURSE I'M A
GRANDMOTHER OF TWO VACCINE
INJURED CHILDREN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL WE CAN ALL
OPPOSE ANYTHING LIKE IT THANK
YOU.
THE REQUESTED -- FORMERLY ISIS
MARINE.
POSES ON COST TO BUILD THE
CANCER.
MY NAME IS ZERO EMISSION
GUARDIAN CALL NOISE BOYS THESE
THE DEAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MIKE NO A BILL TWO SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS REYES YUJIN COULD I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WELL IN CUBA.
AS BEING NORMAL A TWO SEVENTY
SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME LIKE THERE'S A BILLABLE.
HI WHO HAVE SEVEN CHILDREN SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN.
ARE NOT.
OF BILL. TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME ALEX HE MY CHILDREN
THROUGH THE THIRTY GOOD
INCIDENCES.
SEVENTY AREA UP WITH THEM.
C. B. C.. TWO SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANNA ROS RESPIRATORY
THERAPISTS MOTHER OF THREE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BUT I'M STILL GOING THROUGH
[inaudible]
NO MORE.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I AM MEDIA COVERAGE YOU I HEAR
SEVEN CHILDREN AND THROWING YOU
THROUGH.
CHILDREN IN HERE.
GIVEN GIVEN CHILDREN I'M NORTH
COULD THESE SUPPORT THIS VIEW
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LADY MEDICAID THIS.
I HAVE POST.
SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BEN AND PLEASE KNOWN
TWENTY SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS IRENE AS IN CHOKE I'M
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR NO ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IT WAS THE TOUCH OF A
CULTURE TO A SCHOOL TEACHER AND
A PARENT AND UP WAS THIS BILL
THANK YOU KNOW.
YOU NAME IS COREY APPEARS YOU
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE MANUKA PETROL.
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NATALIE TURNING AT
SKI MOTHER OF TWO I OPPOSE THIS
BILL STRONGLY PLEASE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SURE WHAT I SAY I'M A
BAPTIST MINISTER AND I AND
OPPOSE THIS -- STATUS IMPOSITION
ON PARENTAL RIGHTS IS TERRIBLE
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS WILL IT CUT OPEN
LITTLE I AM OPPOSED HIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS NICHOLAS I HAVE
ENOUGH AND I OPPOSE THIS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL AND THE
SERB BATTLE BETWEEN GOOD AND
EVIL THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS IVAN IVAN OFF I AM
A FATHER ONE CHILD.
I PERSONAL NO FAMILIES THAT HAVE
A THAT'S INJURED KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS VICTOR CRIMINALS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LET ME LET CANNELLA
CHOKE I HAVE TWO CHILDREN AND I
POLLS THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OLGA PUSH COLEMAN AND
AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE EFFICIENCY
MY CLOSEST FRIEND CONTRACTED
LUPUS FROM THE HPV VACCINES HAS
BEEN FIGHTING FOR HER LIFE FOR
THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
AND IS CURRENTLY ON DIALYSIS
TOTAL KIDNEY FAILURE I POSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
I WOULD WILL SOLUTIONS CUT OUT
ON A MOTHER OF FIVE BUT NO MY
SON.
THE IN BOXING THE INJURY.
PLEASE LOOK CHOOSE MONEY OVER
THE SOULS.
I HOPE WITH THE GROUP THE QUEUE.
I AM THIRTY ON THE FORMING I AM
NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NAME IS NOT VALID PERISH RAIMES
MOTHER OF FIVE KIDS ON AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER IS A BRITISH GUY
OPPOSED HIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HEATHER PHARES MOTHER FOR
CONSTITUENT TO TED GAINES AYE
AYE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I ANALYSTS WHO FUNDAMENT BAR.
I LIVE WITH HIM RESPONSIBLE FOR
TUPAC'S IN THESE INJURED
CHILDREN.
BECAUSE I TRUST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE BE TOOK
FROM VICTORVILLE CALIFORNIA I
STAND FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM AND
CHOICE.
I SUPPORT DOCTORS AND ADVOCATE
FOR THEIR PATIENTS YOU POSE A
BILL AND I OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER MURPHY FROM
VACAVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE
A SON THAT DIED FROM TEED UP AND
FLU SHOT AND THEN I HAVE TO VOTE
A MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN AS
WELL I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
MY NAME IS SANDY OLSEN I'M FROM
TURLOCK CALIFORNIA AND CO
FOUNDER OF A CENTRAL VALLEY
ADVOCATES FOR PARENTAL RIGHTS
I'M A MOTHER OF SIX AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
RACHEL WILLIAMS FROM RIVER BANK
CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
TRACY KINCHELOE BOTHERED TO
FIREFIGHTER IN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
NATALIE KINCHELOE.
MOM OF TWO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LEAVE FEEDBACK -- MOTHER OF TWO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
LESLIE MILLS FROM ON A CREEK
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS IDEA MY MOOD.
I AM A CAPITAL I MEAN I'M A
BEHAVIOR TECHNICIAN FOR CAPITAL
AUTISM SERVICES.
AND ON THE BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO MUSLIM COMMUNITY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS SYLVANO APPLEMAN I'M
A MOTHER AND A GRANDPARENT OF A
OF A VACCINE ENTRY CHILD TO BE
REALLY AFFECTED BY THE SPILL.
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS WERE ASSURED
ON TO TWO SEVEN SEVEN ARE YOU
OPPOSE I'M VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO
SO MUCH STUNNING WITNESS TO THE
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
LAY LIKE CATS MOTHER OF TWO
MOTHER OF VACCINE INJURED CHILD
WHO WOULD NOT ATTEND HIGH SCHOOL
IF THIS BILL PASSES I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
BRITAIN I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
ATTEND SCHOOL OF THIS BILL
PASSES I AM FAXING INJURED THANK
YOU SIR.
MARK APPLEMAN.
HAIFA I OPPOSE THIS BILL I AM
WATCHING THE SYSTEMATIC
DESTRUCTION OF THANK YOU SIR
PERSONAL FREEDOM THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WE WERE.
MARIA CAM -- FROM RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND I DEMAND THAT YOU UPHOLD THE
PROMISES YOU MADE AN S. P. Q..
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID BALL AND
A CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR PANTS --
LIFELONG CALIFORNIANS.
AND IF THIS BILL GOES THROUGH I
WILL HAVE TO CONSIDER MOVING OUT
OF STATE TO CONTINUE MY DAUGHTER
DISSERTATION I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
TRAVIS MENDOZA HEY WERE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THE BIKE THE PROMISES OF SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN TO BE.
CONSIDERED WHILE JUDGING FOR
THIS BILL I STRONGLY OPPOSE IF
YOU.
MY NAME IS KATRINA AND I OPPOSE
THIS MEDICAL TYRANNY THIS IS NOT
JUSTICE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS COLLEEN
O'DONNELL I AM A UNITED STATES
CITIZEN AND I DO LOVE THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY HOWEVER THIS
BILL I STRONGLY OPPOSE MY FRIEND
HAS BEEN VACCINATED AND HAS HAD
ADVERSE REACTIONS.
THIS IS NOT NECESSARY I HAVE A
WONDERFUL DOCTOR THANK YOU WE
TRUST THE PLAYING FIELD.
THANK YOU.
HERALD O'DONNELL NEVADA COUNTY
GRANDMOTHER FOR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THE VOICE WAS FROM SAN JOSE I'M
RETIRED AND DISABLED VETERAN AND
GRANDFATHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU FOR FREE
TO PULL THE BIKE TORTURE MOUTH
SO WE CAN HEAR YOU.
DOCTOR LEE LANI BUTTON COURT I'M
A TIRE PRESSURE FROM SAN JOSE
AND A MOTHER OF TWO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
REBECCA HARGREAVES ALSO FROM
MORGAN HILL CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
I'M DR VIRGINIA GARDEN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL YOUR
DOCTOR.
MY NAME IS EERIE DID AGO I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL BECAUSE IT
AGAINST OUR HEALTH.
RIDER.
UNDER MUCH OF WHAT IS ALREADY
BUT MANY OF THEM JUST GET IT'S
ALREADY AMENDED IMAGES BECAUSE
WHY.
I'M OPPOSED THE BILL THANK YOU
SIR.
THIS.
IS IT.
THANK YOU.
THIS ADULT.
THANK FOR DOCTORS YOU DO YOUR
JOB WE DO OUR JOB THANK YOU ON
THAT POST YOU OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LUDMILLA CURVE JANKO
FRESNO CALIFORNIA I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN AND ONE INJURED DUE TO
VACCINATION.
AND MULTIPLE CASES IN MY FAMILY --
I OPPOSE ON THIS MASS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AGAIN NOT IN THE CURRENT FROM
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STRONG OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS LUKE MEAL I'M FROM
PRESIDENT I'M A POLLS OF THIS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ELAINE CATCHER
GONNA HAVE FIVE BEAUTIFUL
HEALTHY CHILDREN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL I AM FROM SEVENTY Q..
IN A THIRTY AYE OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SIX ON I HAVE
THREE KIDS I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO.
I MOTHER EIGHT CHILDREN.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
REBECCA GINNY FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AXE ON JEWISH AND
I ON A MOTHER OF THREE CHILDREN
I WORK IN A HOSPITAL IN A STRONG
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS YOU GET TO CHOOSE AND
I WORK IN HOSPITALS WELL AND
I'VE SEEN TOO MANY INJURIES AND
I OPPOSE THE BILL HAS TO BE TWO
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
KF WE CAN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
MOTHER OF THREE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIE B<c.cyan>.</c>
AM NATURAL HEALTH SPECIALIST
THEM STRONG GAP OF THIS MESS.
I MAKE ACHIEVING A THEY'RE GONNA
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
IT'S ON A TOTALLY AYE OPPOSED
HIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ON OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EILEEN I'M IN IRAN
AND I AM MOM OF TWO AND A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS YOUR AGASSI
ACCOMPLICES BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OKSANA AYE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CELO NOT AYE OPPOSED
AS NEW.
COMPOSURE.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR COLLEEN
LINDSTROM AND IT IS MY JOB TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE AND BEING HEALTHY
AND I ASK THAT WE DO THAT ALL
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU AYE OPPOSED FIGURE
MUCH.
MY NAME IS LAURA VERY MINIMUM
MOTHER OF FIVE CHILDREN AND ONE
OF THEM HAS IMMUNE.
ISSUES AND I'VE ASKED THAT YOU
SUPPORT GIVING THE RIGHT TO HIS
DOCTOR TO MAKE THE DECISION IF
HE SHOULD HAVE A MEDICAL YOU
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SIX ON MY MOTHER FOR
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME ISLOU BOWL OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LEE BY MY REGISTERED
NURSE I'VE SEEN A LOT OF VACCINE
CHILDREN THAT ARE INJURED THE
VACCINES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
IMPACT MY OWN THANK YOU AND
THEIR MEDICAL EXEMPTION NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NATALIE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TO LAND A KURODA'S
AND I'M OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I AM AARON MASSING GIL I'M A
CLINICAL HERBALIST AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
ME A LIKE IS INJURED THIS IS MY
DAUGHTER I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S ROB HARRISONFROM ON
THE CREEK AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BRIAN T. FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA MY LINE OF
WORK ALLOWS ME TO WORK A LOT OF
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS TO TAKE AN
OATH. TO DO NO HARM.
THANK YOU SIR -- OPPOSES BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LINDA JEWELL I
REPRESENT MY FAMILY AND THREE
OTHER FAMILIES THAT COULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY TOTALING FIVE
CHILDREN.
AND ALL OF US VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE
THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RUTH MORELIA
SOONER SENATOR PAN THE LINE
BEHIND ME WRAPS AROUND THE
BUILDING TWICE.
THANK YOU WE STRONGLY OPPOSES
THE GOVERNMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RICK
HELD ACNE NOW I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SECU.
MY NAME IS KAYLA WHILE BEEN ON
THEM FROM UKIAH I'M THE MOTHER
OF THE MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILD
WHO WILL LOSE HER MEDICAL
EXEMPTION IF THIS BILL PASSES.
MY HUSBAND AND I ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NATALIE ARNETT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M JUST SIREN IT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU I'M NANCY SHAR I MEAN
ARE AND FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE LABOR AND DELIVERY NURSE
MATERNAL CHILD CARE FORMER PRO
VACCINE NURSE WHO IS SO AGAINST
IT NOW.
AND HAVE DAMAGE CHILDREN EVEN MY
DOG.
THOSE OPPOSING SUPPOSE THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE ELIZABETH
SHOWING FROM RIPPING CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT CENTRAL VALLEY
ADVOCATES FOR PARENTAL RIGHTS
WITH OVER SEVEN HUNDRED MEMBERS
AND WE ALL OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RILEY PROCESS
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LUCY DROSTE RIPPING
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GINNY BORN FROM ANTI
GAY CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TYLER BORN ALSO FROM
RIBBON I'VE BEEN A PAID
FIREFIGHTER FOR FOURTEEN YEARS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL USER.
MY NAME IS JODY CAO CAD NO I'M
AN RN FROM UP IN CALIFORNIA AND
I PUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KELLY SWEARING FROM
RIPPING CALIFORNIA A MOTHER OF
FIVE CHILDREN. NINE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
DANIEL SERVER IN CALIFORNIA FIVE
BEAUTIFUL UNVACCINATED CHILDREN.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR HI I'M
LAUREN SUMA MOTHER OF TWO THIS.
AFFECTS MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILDREN.
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THIS
STATES -- AGE POPULATION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NICOLE ALLEN I'M A
MOTHER OF SIX CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS MAY ALLEN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS LISA LONG OCCUR FROM
MARIN COUNTY.
UNTIL THE PROFIT MOTIVE IS OUT
OF THIS QUESTION HERE SHOWS
LITTLE OR NOTHING AT THE BILL
OPPOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH X.
BAKER.
I AM DAVID LONG OCCUR FROM MARIN
COUNTY I'M OPPOSED AND WHEN
RACHEL CARSON WROTE THANK YOU
SIR APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
NEXT BECOME PLEASE.
THE CABLE COMPANY SAYS YOU THINK
YOU.
NEXT WEEK -- PLEASE.
ADD STARTED AT A THANK YOU.
I'M LOCKED UP HIS THRONE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO WITH VACCINE
INJURED CHILDREN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ELLEN SIMONIS I HAVE
THREE STRONG HEALTHY WEALTHY
WISE CHILDREN THAT HAVE NEVER
BEEN MAX UNAIDED.
THAT HAVE NEVER HAD AN
ANTIBIOTIC AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK WRONGLY THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY OF ALL
MURDERS I'M FROM REDDING
CALIFORNIA I'M A VACCINE
EDUCATION SPECIALIST AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHERINE
SWEENEY AND I'M ALSO FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I AM ERA KIRKWOOD FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA PARENT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I AM JESSICA VAN HILL HEART IN
HERE FROM MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU AND I HAVE A LETTER
FOR YOU SENATOR COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO YOUR HEART I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL AS A PRIME IS IT.
IS IT IS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF THE
DEGRADATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MICHAEL HEART FROM MODESTO
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES THANK YOU
SIR.
HELLO SENATOR PAN AND HEALTH
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KATHERINE
LATE NINE FROM ORANGE CALIFORNIA
I'M A MOTHER OF TWO BOYS ONE
THAT SUFFERED PERMANENT BRAIN
DAMAGE FROM VACCINES.
HIS BROTHER WILL BE ALLOWED TO
GO TO SCHOOL IF THIS BILL PASSES
SO I AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THE
CUBAN.
HELLO MY NAME IS SERRA THERE AND
I'M A SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER
AND I REPRESENT MY CO TEACHER AS
WELL RACHEL RICARDO AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE THINKING
THEM.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRIS CARDO SEE I TRAVELED HERE
THIS MORNING FROM BURBANK
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS YURI LOCAL THEM
FROM A REAL IN THE CALIFORNIA.
I AM GRANDFATHER WAS FOR FIVE
GRANDKIDS.
I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO HIS
BILL AND PLEASE THANK ALL MAKE
ANY CHANGES FOR MY GRANDKIDS AND
THANK YOU SIR.
JESSICA BURLINGAME I HAVE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS BASED ON THE
TERM THE DETERMINATION OF TWO
MEDICAL DOCTORS UNDER CURRENT
LAW.
AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EMILY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AUTHOR OF SB TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANDREAS AND ALAN I'M
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING MY FAMILY AND
MY CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE SOME RECORD RAVE
SAN LEANDRO CALIFORNIA I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE I FLY HERE
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA ON A
MOTHER OF THREE CHILDREN.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I
OPPOSE YOU TO SENATOR PENN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SPEAKER PLEASE.
TENNIS LOVER DOMINICAN I'M FROM
WEST SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL MY KIDS HAVE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION THAT HAD A REALLY IS
THANK YOU ALMOST DIE FROM
VACCINES THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS RICK MILLER
MONSTER NINE AND THEN I AM A
GRANDMA AND I AM VERY STRONGLY.
SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JULI KIßM OF AND
I'M FROM WAS AGREEMENT I HAVE
MEDICAL EXAMINATION BASED ON THE
ELEGY SO MY SON AND I WILL NEVER
VACCINATE MY CHILD OVER MY DEAD
BODY BODY.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS TANYA LITTLE SCAM A
MOTHER OF EIGHT CHILDREN AND
THREE GRANDCHILDREN AS STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THIS VIOLATES
HUMAN VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS YOUR FAN I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES IS MY DAUGHTER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME'S BENJAMIN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS OXANA I'M A MOTHER
OF TWO AND I VACCINATE MY
CHILDREN FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS
OF THEIR LIFE.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN SICK FOR TWO
YEARS AND THEN I STOPPED WHICH
IS TEN YEARS AGO AND HAVE NEVER
BEEN HEALTHIER AND STRONGER SO I
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
MY NAME THEM MAYA.
MY BROTHER BEEN VACCINE INJURED
AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE.
MY NAME IS JESSICA I ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SUSAN OUT AND I'M
FROM CONNIE AT LEYVA IS DISTRICT
AND THIS BILL WOULD HARM MY
CHILDREN I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
FOR NAME IS HEATHER KOVAC FROM
SOUTH LAKE TAHOE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND BOUGHT AN
UNINFORMED POLITICIANS WHO THINK
THEY CAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
OF OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU.
NAME IS LAUREN YEAH COLLEGIAN
FROM SOUTH LAKE TAHOE I OPPOSE
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX WITH EVERY
FIBER OF MY BEING BECAUSE THANK
YOU ARE THE MOST QUALIFIED TO
MAKE MEDICAL THE CIVIC YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ASHLEY NICHOLS AND
I AM FROM SOUTH LAKE TAHOE AND I
HAVE TWO CHILDREN WITH MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS -- AND HI OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S MATT ALLEN.
FROM DISTRICT THIRTEEN HOW FROM
A CALIFORNIA.
I CAME HERE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS POPPY FROM CINEMA
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S Là AND AMERICANS I'M
FROM CINEMA CALIFORNIA.
THE MOTHER OF TWO AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TYLER AMERICANS AND
I'M ALSO FROM CINEMA CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALLISON IS A LOT FROM
LOS ALTOS CALIFORNIA.
I STRONGLY OPALS THESE
AUTHORITARIAN BIãU AND SO
SHOULD YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JULIA AND I'M FROM
REDWOOD CITY CALIFORNIA.
AND I HAVE I AM A FATHER OF TWO
KIDS AND THESE BIãU WILL HARM
MY KIDS IF THE MAGICAL EXEMPTION.
GETS LIKE THAT AND ALSO EVEN
BEEN ALLEN THAT WAS THE CALL
DROPPED HIS BILL.
IS NOT APPROVING SO PLEASE YOUR
POST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO I AM CAROLYN STALEY FROM
LIVERMORE AND BACKS AND INJURED
MYSELF.
MOTHER TO MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROSE FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A GROTESQUE EXAMPLE OF
GOVERNMENT OVER REACH I CAN'T
EVEN BELIEVE ARE YOU OPPOSE
SADDAM THEM. TO YOU POLITICIANS
ABOUT YOU OPPOSE THE BILL MA'AM.
THANK YOU THINK THEY CAN EXPECT
HER.
MY NAME IS LAURIE FIELD I'M FROM
LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA AND YOU
WHEN I ALL KNOW WE NEED TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER CORCORAN OF
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ON A BASS AND A
MOTHER OF THREE TWO OF WHICH ARE
SEVERELY INJURED.
VACCINE INJURED AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THIS IS VERY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS NIETZSCHE PROMISCUOUS
I AM FROM PENRHYN CALIFORNIA I
HAVE TWO VACCINE INJURED
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA LOPEZ I'M
HERE REPRESENTING MY FAMILY AND
MY BEST FRIEND WHO COULD NOT BE
HEARD TODAY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M CHRISTY POLICE SO FROM LAKE
FOREST -- I HAVE TWO VACCINE
INJURED CHILDREN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M CRISTINA JOHNSON FROM
LAGUNA BEACH CALIFORNIA I AM THE
MOTHER OF A VACCINE INJURED
CHILD I DID NOT BY HIS MEDICAL
EXEMPTION HE UNFORTUNATELY
EARNED IT.
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT MYSELF THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS JAMES FULLER TEN AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU TRIPS.
MY NAME IS JULIE FULLER.
TEN I HAVE A HEALTHY SIGN THERE
AND I'M A POST THIS BELL.
IT'S REALLY STRANGE TO SEE YOUR
HEATH MISTY RUNNING AWAY.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK WHAT ARE
TAKE UP THE USER SAY COUNTY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS PAUL KIARA
I'M FROM OLD DEL CAL.
FOR ACCOUNT ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THE HUMAN.
I'M DAVID KIARA AND I'M FROM
OAKVILLE AS WELL AS MY BROTHER.
WITH MY BROTHER AND I POSES BILL
THE HUMAN.
MY NAME IS ADAM CAROLLA I
STRONGLY ARE FROM OF THE
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL THE HUMAN.
MY NAME IS ERICA KIARA OAKDALE
CALIFORNIA I VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DENISE RENTALS BILL
BURKE I AM FROM GRASS VALLEY
CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE TWO UNVACCINATED
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MCKENNA HAMILTON
I'M A MILITARY WIFE AND MOTHER
OF A MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILD WHO
LOOSES MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMBER FRENCH I'M
FROM TRUCKEE CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR HEARING
OUR VOICES THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN BY
LEWIS MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I ALSO
REPRESENT MY MOTHER.
MERRY CRAFTSMAN HER HUSBAND AND
MANY FRIENDS THAT COULDN'T MAKE
IT TODAY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS COLIN LEWIS FROM
NEVADA CITY I'M A FATHER.
I SUPPORT MEDICAL FREEDOM AND
PARENTS RIGHTS.
IT SEEMS TO ME THERE ARE MORE --
DO YOU OPPOSE THE BILL I OPPOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT BAKER PLEASE THANK YOU
YOU'RE YOU'RE FINISHED THANK YOU.
AND I'M ROBERT BURKE FROM NEVADA
CITY I AM THE FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER OF VACCINE INJURED
CHILDREN.
BY.
SONS DOCTORS NOT UNETHICAL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION
ACCUSER THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SERRA HAILING FROM
NEVADA CITY CALIFORNIA I HAVE
TWO VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS IRENE AND I LIVE IN
THE BILL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
MY SISTER CANNOT BE HERE BUT HE
OPPOSES THIS BILL TO THANK YOU.
LADY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS COURTNEY TAYLOR
I'M FROM MCKINLEY FILL I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN WHO HAVE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS FOR NOT FAKE.
AND THEY WILL BE HARMED BY THIS
BILL SO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEFFERY HAYES FROM
THE CAN THE BILL AND I OPPOSE SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU FOR FREE
TO MOVE THAT MAKE UP TO YOUR
MOUTH.
NICOLE BILL AND I CAME FROM
HEIGHTS WILL AND I REPRESENT
FIVE FAMILY MEMBERS THREE OF
CHILDREN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHOSHANA MARTINEZ
SEVEN CALABASAS CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL MAKE
YOU.
AMANDA MILLER LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I'M A CPA AND A CMA
PAN YOU'RE A LIAR I OPPOSE AS
THE THE QUEUE NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE MATHIS
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
WHERE THERE IS REST THERE SHOULD
BE CHOICE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
YOU SENATOR PAN.
PLEASE.
LET'S BE RESPECTFUL.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR VANESSA PASS
OFF I'M IN VENTURA COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS BRIAN KELLY FROM
WOODLAND HILLS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
I'M ALEX BE FOOD FROM MOM TO LOT
BY -- OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BORIS LOG OF STRUGGLE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
MENTION THE ROCK I STRONGLY
OPPOSE HIS BILL THANK YOU.
NAME IS MIKE AND MY NAME IS MIKE
IN MILLER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE HUMAN.
MISTY MY NAME IS NOAH MILLER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM MY NAME IS
JULIAN YOU'LL IN A OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOUNG MAN.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA MILLER.
FROM THE ANTI TO VACCINE INJURED
CHILDREN ADULTS NOW NICE
STRONGLY.
WITH THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA CURTAIL
FROM DANVILLE CALIFORNIA AND OUR
FAMILY STRONGLY OPPOSES THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KATHY CLIFFORD I'M
A MOTHER OF SIX MY OLDEST IS
VACCINE INJURED PERMANENTLY
DISABLED AND IF THIS BILL PASSES
WE WILL BE MOVING TO NEVADA.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS KENDALL SCHRAMM
I'M FROM RICEVILLE I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I THINK IT
SAYS SOMETHING THAT BEN ALLEN
ALSO.
THIS BILL THEY GIVE THEM.
I NAMES MICHELLE MURPHY AND I DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT MEDICAL CARE
SHOULD BE LEGISLATED I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS JUST A COVER NEARING
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS ALYSSA KILLALA AND I
HAVE FOUR CHILDREN I OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE ONE OF MY CHILDREN
HAS ALLERGIES AND COULD HAVE AN
ANAPHYLACTIC RESPONSE IF SHE HAD
THIS VACCINE SOON AS MUCH AS
WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MY NAME IS VARIETY GRUBS AND I'M --
IN YOUR DISTRICT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BY FOR KIDS I HAVE REAL
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LAURA BURR HANDS I'M
FROM EL DORADO HILLS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA WESCOTT I'M
FROM MONTEREY COUNTY.
A FAMILY OF FIVE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THE CHINA AND STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MONIES ME TO MEET WITH THE
CONSUMER I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
A YEAR POSES THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS A SOFTER AYE OPPOSED
HIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS A GLORIFIED NUKE I'M
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GOOD IN THIS SEVEN
AND I'M OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I'VE INTO ANOTHER VEHICLE NO.
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU NAME IS
LOGAN OLSEN I'M FROM TURLOCK
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS JIM NIELSEN I'M FROM
TO A CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I MADE NIELSEN OFFER DRAW
CALIFORNIAN I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
AND RACIAL WAY IN MY ARMS AND
SAN RAMON CALIFORNIA IN THE
MOTHER OF A MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILD AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS A NINE THANK YOUNG
MAN.
MY NAME IS CONNOR AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WE GET LIMITED TO THE ADULTS
PLEASE WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
MY NAME IS JAMISON AYE OPPOSED.
SIR MY NAME IS HEIDI GLEISNER I
LIVE IN WALNUT CREEK CALIFORNIA
I AM THE PARENT OF A MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILD AND ICE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE VILLAIN AWAY THEN
WE'RE LIMITING IT TO ONLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY ROAD TO ADULTS AND
ADOLESCENTS WILL BE ALLOWED TO
SPEAK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
ENFORCE THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE A
LOT OF SPEAKERS YET TO COME
FORWARD.
I WOULD LIKE TO GET THIS DONE
BEFORE TWELVE O'CLOCK TONIGHT SO.
IF YOU PLEASE -- IT HERE TO
THOSE RULES WE WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT.
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE BE IN A WAVE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL
THANK YOU.
OKAY AS KIM -- I'M A MOTHER OF
THREE KIDS ASSOCIATE IN
BIOLOGICAL SO -- SCIENCES --
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU -- MY
NAME IS NATALIA ONE HOT AND ALSO
OPPOSES BUT THANK YOU.
HI VICTORIA.
I OPPOSE THESE BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JASMINE HARVEY YOU
KNOW SOMEONE THAT WAS EMPTY
MEDICAL ASSISTANT FOR BOTTOM IF.
I WAS IN NURSING SCHOOL I NEVER
GOT ANY EDUCATION.
IN SCHOOL ARE IN JOB AT IN A JOB
PLACEMENT ABOUT IT YOUR POSTINGS
UNTIL.
I MYSELF OKAY TO POSE MA'AM I
STRONGLY OPPOSE ANY AND YOU
BETTER REMIND YOU WILL GET.
EXTRA PLEASE.
NEXT WEEK -- PLEASE.
MY NAME IS MARTY ABELARD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS PLEASE LOVE
LIVE IT IS COOL AND ARE OPPOSED
SB TO SEVENTY MAKE THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE ALLOWS
ARREST COOL I REPRESENTED MY
KIDS THREE OF THEM AND MY FAMILY
A FATHER BROTHERS SISTERS FIVE
FAMILIES COULD MAKE IT HERE.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TANYA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THE NAME FEDERAL THEY SAID.
I POLLS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IS THERE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RUDY AMONG PULLED HIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS A FIGURE NOW WHICH I
HAVE A VACCINE INJURED BROTHER
AND I BELIEVE THE CHOICE SHOULD
BE MADE BY MY PARENTS NOT BY
RICHARD PAN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU A YOUNG LADY HI MY
NAME IS ART YOU'RE GONNA CHIME
OF VACCINE SURVIVOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU
SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS X. SENATOR NAY
WHICH AND I'M REPRESENTING THOSE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE WHO
OPPOSE THE BILL MA'AM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT BAKER
PLEASE NAME IS ENTERING OF EVERY
NEW CANNELLA MOTHER FOR AND TO
MY KIDS HAVE SEVERE ALLERGIC
REACTIONS.
AND I'LL JUST ASK YOU TO LET US
KNOW -- HAVE THIS EXEMPTIONS
THANK YOU.
HELLO HELLO NOW IF -- FOR RANCHO
CORDOVA AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS SHAWNA MCGREGOR KING
I'M A VACCINE INJURED ADULT WITH
VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN AND I
OPPOSE THIS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS VIOLET KING AND I'M
IN.
I'M A VACCINE INNER CHILD AND I
OPPOSE HIS BILL STRONGLY THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
I AM TRACEY ALCAMO RICH I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CATHERINE BENSON FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GREEN UP POWERS FOR MONTEREY
COUNTY I REPRESENT THE LATINO
COMMUNITY AND I HAVE A VACCINE
INJURED CHILD AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AS A CONSTITUENT OF PAN AND A
VACCINE INJURED AT ALL I HIGHLY
HIGHLY.
WANT YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THREE SALAS CHILD DEVELOPMENT
SPECIALISTS I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND SAVANNAH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DIANE ANON THE
SORIANO FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
EVEN BEN ALLEN OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I DON'T KNOW THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMBER HEINTZELMAN
I'M A COLLEGE STUDENT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THIS BILL DIRECTLY
AFFECTS MY CHILDREN AND CHANCE
TO GAINING A DEGREE FOR MYSELF I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA SAM TO
STOMACH I HAVE IN FACT SEEN IN
THEIR INFANT PLAN HIGHLY OPPOSE
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
BUT IT'S NOT THE GENERAL FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA IN A
HIGHLY OPPOSES.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS TERRY MILLER ON
BEHALF OF MY CHILDREN AND FROM
DUBLIN CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BY MICHAEL MILLER FROM DUBLIN
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS DALE CALL MY MILL
VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
HELLO MY NAME OTHER THAN THAT
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LEE C. B. FUN OF A
THANK YOU.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL AS WELL THANK
YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS IAN I AM.
MORE FOR THESE BILLS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PETER AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
THANK YOU PLEASE BEGIN THE MIKE
SO WE GET AREA MY NAME IS A
PROPOSED ORDER.
BUT IT'S NOT AS A BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ME TO RISE IN --
MY HEALTH DOES NOT COME FROM
MAXINE'S IT CALMS FROM MY IMMUNE
SYSTEM AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BE
TO SEC USE HER.
MY NAME IS OLGA RISING AYE
OPPOSED THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNY CONSTANT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CATEGORY I LIVE IN
BRENTWOOD CALIFORNIA I HAVE A
VACCINE INJURED CHILD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRIS SALE
GARCIA AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI THERE MY NAME IS SAVANNAH
SHARP I LIVE IN ANTIOCH
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TIFFANY LOOK AT
AND I LIVE IN BENICIA CALIFORNIA.
AND AS A PRACTITIONER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE IN
FIRST DO NO HARM IT SO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTY BERLINER I
LIVE IN PALMDALE CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CRAIG BERLINER I
LIVE IN PALMDALE I'M A VACCINE
INJURED FATHER WITH THE VACCINE
INJURED MOTHER AND DAUGHTER AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS IT IS LOVELY CARE OF
TWENTY ONE GRAND KIDS AND THE
AYE OPPOSED IS BE. TWO SEVENTY
SIX THANKS.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS LESS YES SO CAN I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
OPPOSE PLEASE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TAMARA AND I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS JULIA
MCGINNIS SOMEONE INFORM THE
MOTHER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KIRSTEN BRANCH
FROM CONTRA COSTA COUNTY I AM
THE MOTHER OF TWO SONS WHO ARE
NOT SECOND CLASS CITIZENS NOR
EXPENDABLE I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
HEARING FROM US MY NAME IS
SHAYNA BRESLOW I'M CALLING I AM
HERE FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
MOTHER AND MEMBER OF THE CTA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI AND THIS WILL NEVER FROM
PIEDMONT CALIFORNIA MY DAUGHTER
LOST THREE YEARS OF HER LIFE TO
AUTO IMMUNE AND SATELLITE IS
FROM THE CHICKEN POX VACCINE.
I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
YEAH JOHNSON I'M A CONSTITUENT
OF NANCY SKINNER -- DR ERIC UPON
AN EARLIER -- QUOTED ONE IN A
THOUSAND DEATHS FROM MEASLES
THAT IS AND SECTOR POSIBLE
MENTALLY AROUND ONE IN TEN
THOUSAND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SIX NEXT
BAKER PLEASE.
RON KENNEDY PHYSICIAN SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA.
I OPPOSE THE IDEOLOGY WHICH
STANDS BEHIND.
THIS BILL HAD ACCUSER SO THANK
YOU YOU'RE WELCOME THANK YOU.
I'M NATALIE BALDWIN -- A
CONSTITUENT AT NANCY SCANNERS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MELA LAST CALL I'M A
MOM OF FIVE FROM SACRAMENTO AREA
AND THEY STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VALERIE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS TO SEVENTY
SIX BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI I WENT THE ECONOMIC TO FULLY
VACCINATED CHILDREN WHEN VACCINE
INJURED CHILD FROM PLACENTIA MY
FAMILY AND I OPPOSE THE SPELL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PAIGE MCKINNEY I'M
FROM ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M CHRISTINE RAINER I'M A
THERAPIST AND I ALSO FROM ORANGE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA THE DAUGHTER
HE'S VACCINATED I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RHONDA YELLIN I'M
FROM SAN PEDRO THIS BILL WILL
TAKE AWAY MY DAUGHTER'S RIGHT TO
GO TO SCHOOL AND WILL NOT
PROTECT OUR DOCTOR PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP PAN.
SENATOR BEN ALLEN YOUR CO AUTHOR
TO USE.
THEM DOES NOT SUPPORT THIS THING
DOWN MY FAMILY AND I OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S KATIE GALLAGHER I'M
FROM SAN CARLOS I'M A MOM OF TWO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
IAM HEATHER MORE IN FROM SAN
CARLOS MOM OF TWO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M DOCTOR DEANIE SCHULTZ
ALPHA I'M A CO FOUNDER AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH COALITION ADVOCACY AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARYLAND MAN
FREDDIE ON FOR MERCED I'M A
GRANDMOTHER I'M STANDING HERE
BEFORE -- REPRESENTING MY
GRANDCHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME STATE AND
DAVIS SUMMER AS IN A VELCRO ON
THE GROUNDS OF PERSONAL FREEDOM
OF THE THIS -- BILLS OVERSTAFFED
I STRONG OPPOSE IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KERRY SIX AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I
AM FROM AMERICAN CANYON THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS A LAKE -- ERAGON AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HE HELLO MY NAME IS JAMIE JING
CLOSE ACT I AM A MOM AND A
HEALTH EDUCATOR I COME FROM
CINEMA COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU FOR THE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JENNA DEREK AND
I'M FROM SEBASTOPOL CALIFORNIA
I'M A MOTHER OF THREE IN A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
WELL THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME
TO HEAR US TODAY MY NAME'S AND
NELSON I'M FROM DIXON CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS IN I'M A MOM OF
TWO BUCKS TODAY THE CHILDREN ONE
OF THEM IS A VACCINE INJURED NOW
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LOVE THE CARD IF FINE
FROM SACRAMENTO I HAVE A CHILD
WHO WAS INJURED BY THE VACCINE
AS WELL AS UNCLE OF THREE OTHER
CHILDREN WHO WERE.
INJURED BY DRUG SCENE.
AND I AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS LARISSA
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
DENNIS WILL NOT A FATHER OF
THREE WEST SACK STRONGLY OPPOSES
BE TWO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'M FATHER OF THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BE.
THANK YOU SIR.
SIX HELLO MY NAME IS OLGA I'M A
MOTHER OF THREE CHILDREN AND A
STRONG LEVELS AS BE TO SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU.
HI I'M CAREY DAVIS FROM
LIVINGSTON CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NOT VALID IN
COLLEGE I AM FROM WHERE
SACRAMENTO I AM I AM OFF TO
CHILDREN.
I WAS ENJOYED BY ABOUT SIN AND I
WANT TO PROTECT MY CHILDREN AND
I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU
HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JUNE SCHAEFER CENTER
OF SANTA ROSA.
THIS BILL DIRECTLY IMPACTS MY
ABILITY TO PACK MY MEDICALLY
FRAGILE SON I OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY MAIN MY NAME'S PATRICIA
SCHAEFER.
I'M FROM.
CAN ROSA CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WOULD DAMAGE MINE
MEDICALLY CHALLENGE.
BRANCH OUT AND AYE OPPOSED TO
BUILD STRONG THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANDROMEDA EDISON I'M
FROM TO HUNG A LOS ANGELES I'M A
MOM AND THE RECIPIENT OF THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PRESIDENTIAL
VOLUNTEER SERVICE AWARD. FOR MY
WORK IN HUMAN RIGHTS EDUCATION
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CASSIDY M. HUFF
I'M FROM ALTADENA CALIFORNIA IN
A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KHAN TO EDISON I'M
FROM TO HUNGER LOS ANGELES ND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS FIONA QUICK I'M FROM
SUNLAND LOS ANGELES AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LAURA QUICK I'M FROM
SUNLAND LOS ANGELES AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M CATHERINE QUICKTIME
EDUCATOR FROM SUNLAND.
AND DOCTORS ARE NOT SELLING
EXEMPTIONS AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LAUREN I'M AWFUL
I'M FROM ALTADENA CALIFORNIA I
REPRESENT A GROUP OF ABOUT FIFTY
HOME SCHOOLERS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWO SEVEN THANK YOU
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LISA HENDERSON I'M
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NICK ANDERSON --
COMMERCIAL CALIFORNIA FATHER
THREE STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TONY LET
DIAMOND I REPRESENT BODILY
SOVEREIGNTY AND FREEDOM OF
CHOICE AND FORM COULD.
POSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR MICHAEL
DIAMOND TO PRIVATE PRACTICES
REPRESENTING ALL MY PATIENTS
[inaudible]
AND THANK YOU FOR VOTING NO ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU POSTS.
MY NAME IS JAMES YOUR KEYS I'M
FROM LODI CALIFORNIA FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
HEARING ME ON THE SHOW MARINO --
IN RED REGISTERED NURSE FOR
FORTY YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL ON PROTECT MY
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MY ASSURE BOX I'M A
RESIDENT SACRAMENTO CITIZEN OF
THE UNITED STATES AND A
IMMIGRANT FROM THE COMMUNIST
SOVIET UNION AND I FIRMLY
OPPOSED HIS BAIL THANK.
YOU.
I MARINO NEIL FROM CARMICHAEL AS
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL FOR THE
SAKE OF MY CHILDREN'S HEALTH
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TIM ON A REGISTERED
NURSE I HAVE TWO DAUGHTERS THAT
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
AND SOVIET UNION.
ROOMS ARE FEW AND OPPOSED HIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS MAGGIE I GOT SOME FOR
MORE OF A CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
FOR HI MY NAME IS JAMIE FOXX
SAID I'M WITH MOTHERS FOR
MEDICAL FREEDOM.
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO AND AYE
OPPOSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NICOLE DORFMAN AM I
AM FROM MORE OF A CALIFORNIA AND
AS A HEALTH CARE.
PRACTITIONER I BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL DOES A GRAVE INJURY TO THE
MEDICAL PROPOSED THE BILL MA'AM
I AM STRONG LIKE YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE PRATT FROM
BOTH IN CALIFORNIA I'M A MOTHER
OF THREE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
I AM STEVEN PRATT I'M FROM FALLS
IN CALIFORNIA FATHER THREE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
I AM CATHOLIC PRIDE IN A MOTHER
OF THREE AND A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER THE DAVIS.
JOINT UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JANINE THOMAS FROM
GEORGETOWN CALIFORNIA I ASK YOU
TO JOIN ME AND MY OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHEILA SCOTT FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA I STRENUOUSLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I AM CEREMONY HUGH FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M CHOI DICKMAN FROM LINCOLN
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND ON BEHALF OF MY
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD SON WHO'S
VACCINE DAMAGED WILL NEVER HAVE
A NORMAL LIFE.
THANK YOU.
I'M RACHEL GATES I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND DOCTORS YOU
KNOW YOU PATIENTS BEST THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LUKE MILLER AND
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S TERRY HAMILTON I'M A
FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS IN HUMANE
BILL IT'S UNNECESSARY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JOANNE THORPE --
SENATOR NIELSEN IS MY SENATOR I
AM IN OUR IN OUR BRIDGES TO
NURSE WORKING NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS IN THE ICK YOU.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL FIVE FOR
UNDERMINING THE JUDGMENT OF
PHYSICIANS IN THE ENTRY THANK
YOU PRIVATE HEALTH RECORDS OF
CHILDREN AND THEIR EXTENDED
FAMILY.
I AM DENISE WILLIE FROM DUNSMUIR
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
I AM LAKE IN LESSER FROM MISSION
VIEJO AND I STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK CHAIRMAN.
JERRY LESSER FROM MISSION VIEJO
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BY -- EUGENIA.
HIS VILLA NO PLEASE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RON CARL I'M A FATHER
OF THREE CHILDREN I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS MARINA I IMPOSED THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS WENDY DENNY I AM FROM
PETALUMA MOTHER OF TWO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL PINKER TEN
OF THE DIRECTOR OF A PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES MY WIFE IS A
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST.
WE'RE FROM CINEMA COUNTY WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S TERRY SMALL INS I'M
FROM EUREKA CALIFORNIA
GRANDMOTHER OF EIGHT CHILDREN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I'M CLOUT AT COCA OUR MIDWIFE
FROM BACK AVAIL I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MONACO PAN OUT SHE MOTHER OF
FOUR WORK IN SKILLED NURSING
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
HEY -- MOM OF FIVE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
GRANDMOTHER OF NINE STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY MY
NAME'S DIEGO AVALON A RESIDENT
OF MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND
LIKEWISE WISH TO ADD -- MY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU
SIR.
HI MY NAME IS VICTORIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS ABOVE CARMEL OUT I
MOTHER OF THREE KIDS I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THINK THANK YOU.
NAME IS MARINA I WORK IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EMMA FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL HI MY POLLS
THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS YELIZAVETA THAT
ENSURE COME FROM SACRAMENTO AND
I'M A MOTHER OF THREE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S CLAIRE LANGLEY I'M
FROM PETALUMA AND I'M A CLINICAL
HERBALISTIN A MOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JULIE -- STORAGE AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL I
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO THANK YOU.
FOR MY NAME IS RON CALDERAS AND
FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KARENA ASTERAS GOT IN
I'M WORKING IN MEDICAL FIELD A
MOTHER OF TWO AND I'M AGAINST
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TANYA FROM SACRAMENTO
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS LAURIE SAID DEBORAH I
WAS FROM SACRAMENTO.
I HAVE THREE KIDS AND A STRONG.
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
NAME IS ANDRE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS ANASTASIA AVOID COOL
AND MOM OF FIVE WHO HELPED THE
BOYS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JAMIE
REESE I'M FROM FORT BRAGG
CALIFORNIA -- I'M A MOTHER OF
THREE AN ATTORNEY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RICH ROACH I AM
FOR MEDICINAL I HAD AN
ANAPHYLACTIC REACTION TO A
VACCINE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CONSIDER
FAMILY MEDICAL HISTORY WILL NOT
PROTECT MY CHILDREN I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S MILLER FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS MOTHER OF TWO AND MORE
TO COME.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
RECUPERATION THANK YOU.
DENNIS FOR PROJECT FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS AND I OPPOSES BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS SET ON A TRIPLE
NINE MY MOTHER OF SIX AND I'M
OPPOSED HIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE LAW ARE YOU --
MAZA I DON'T SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M THE THIRD GOMEZ -- AND THAT.
I AM A VICTIM OF THE MYSTERY OF
OXIDATION AND THAT'S WHY I WAS
THROWING UP WITH THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS INNA.
I MáS THERE I DON'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JANA AND I DON'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE MINK.
DOCTOR OF CHIROPRACTIC A
CONSTITUENT OF CHERRY HILL.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A MELON AND PLEASE
LET MY DOCTOR THE WHAT'S ROB
RIGHT FOR MY KIDS.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS MAIL
THANK YOU MA'AM LESS.
HI MY NAME'S EAGLE POSITION I'M
FOR THAT -- FOR I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS SEAN GARDNER I'M
AN AMERICAN I OPPOSE THIS BE TWO
SEVEN SEVEN I OPPOSE SB TWO
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU SIR AND I'M
THE BY THE OWNER OF MY
BIOLOGICAL PROPERTY THANK YOU
SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARTHA I AM
SOON TO BE MODEL TO AND I THINK
IT WILL GET BETTER SO THAT I CAN
CHOOSE FUTURE FIRMICUTES.
AND I OPPOSE AS BE TWO SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS LOWER I'M OPPOSE
AS BE IT
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU SIR YES
MY NAME IS SUMMER AND WE OPPOSE
THE BILL SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CAROL TAYLOR I'M A
GRANDMOTHER PROUD GRANDMOTHER OF
TWO AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
STRONGLY THANK YOU MA'AM.
VERONICA TAYLOR I AM OUT POST TO
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JANE GOODMAN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF
TWO AND ANSWER OF A VACCINE
INJURED CHILD I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TANYA AND I'M
UP HERE AND THEN I STRONGLY --
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE UNLESS THIS
YEAR OF SKI AND A MOTHER OF TWO
AND AYE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A CONCRETE THE
MOTHER OF TWO AND OPPOSED -- TO
BILL TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU
MA'AM.
I'M GLORIA CHAVEZ I'M AN ELDER
OF MY TRIED AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR DUG HOLES SAID
I'M A PEDIATRICIAN FOR MODERATE
CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT A HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN AUTISTIC KIDS.
OF THOSE HUNDRED SIXTEEN FIFTY
ARE SPECIFICALLY VACCINE DAMAGED
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE NATURE.
MY NAME IS R. G. I'M FROM SAN
DIEGO AND I WAS VACCINE INJURED
AS A CHILD I KNOW THERE ARE
RISKS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JESSICA FRIEDMAN I'M
A REGISTERED NURSE AND I'M A
MOTHER OF THREE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TINA KIRBY FROM
SAN DIEGO ON THE MOM OF TWO ONE
IS A SEVEN ALL TO STICK BOY.
THAT WOULD BE DENIED IT COULD
EDUCATION IF THIS BILL -- PASSES
I OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS GRACE WEINSTEIN
FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL IF YOU.
ACTUALLY BAKER ALSO FROM SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
ELEMENTARY TEACHER AS WELL AS A
MOTHER OF THREE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EUGENE AND HOW -- AYE
OPPOSED. SEVEN SIX THE AT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
INEVITABLE SHOOK AND I'M OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THE RETURN CALL OF
AND A MOTHER OF THREE AND UP
STRONGLY OPPOSED THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS RITA TO ZERO
AND THE SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST AND A HALF TO
CHILDREN WITH.
VALID MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS IN A
STRONG OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LEASE THEY
OFTEN OFTEN FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB TWO SEVEN SIX I WAS MAXINE
INJURED WHEN I WORKED IN A
HOSPITAL FROM GETTING HEPATITIS
B. SHOT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S AUGUST PERICA AND I'M
FROM RANCHO CORDOVA CALIFORNIA
AND I UP.
I SAY NO TO THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THE MAGICIAN I
STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL.
NAME IS EXPENDITURES AND AYE
OPPOSED AS SEVEN JUST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CARMEN DELICACY -- PLASTER
COUNTY MOTHER OF SEVEN FOR
VACCINE INJURED.
MY HUSBAND AND I HAVE ALSO HAD
INJURIES PLEASE PLEASE.
DON'T LET THIS PASS FOR BABIES
OUT OF SEVENTY Q..
THE MICHAEL DOUGLAS DO AND HOPE
TO SURE PROVED TO BE TRUE FALSE.
APRIL THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS PRETTY CHRISTENSEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSES THOUGH I HOPE
THAT YOU ALL FEEL WITHIN YOUR
HEARTS TO MAKE YOU MINE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE OF THE CARE OUT
OF I'M A MEDICAL ASSISTANT
MOTHER AND MY CHILDREN
VACCINATED BY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL FOR RIGHT OF CHOICE
THANK YOU.
JOSHUA SRI FRENCH CAM CALIFORNIA
FATHER OF FOUR OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS A MIND SHREVE I AM
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN YEARS OLD AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SPELL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS CRYSTAL STREET I'M
FROM FRENCH CAM CALIFORNIA
MOTHER FOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
Q..
LOCAL FISHER SAN JOSE.
VACCINATION RATES ARE 95% SO
HERD IMMUNITY IS OBTAINED AND
THIS BILL HURTS THOSE THAT HERD
IMMUNITY IS SUPPOSED TO PROTECT.
I OPPOSE THE SIGNAL.
MY NAME IS CANDACE TIME FROM
PALO ALTO I'M A MOTHER OF THREE
ONE SEVERELY VACCINE INJURED
CHILD.
AND ICE I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BEST MORALIS I'M
FIRMLY THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
BUT HE WAS A BROWN MORALIS I
FROM WITH THE CALIFORNIA AND
THEY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I NAME IS MARCO MORALIS IPHONE
ONLY FILL CALIFORNIAN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNA PERRY I'M FROM
OUT HOW CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS GOOD ENOUGH I AM A
MOTHER OF THREE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL I CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY FOR THE FREE THAT YOU
DID NOT TAKE AWAY.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK -- I'M
OKSANA PERCH I HAVE THREE
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL THANK YOU.
NAME IS ANDRE PURCHASE LIVE IN
AT A LOCAL CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS THAT THE OTHER LEAN
SKI MY MOTHER ONE CHILD I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M THE TELEGRAPH OF PRESCHOOL
TEACHER IN SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M SO LONG THE RECALL AND
MOTHER OF THREE CHILDREN I
STRONG GLOBAL THESE BILLS THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE JOHN HAWK
ALONG A STRONG GLOBAL THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANGELICA STALLMAN I'M
FROM REDWOOD CITY I STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SPILL NO MEDICAL
PROCEDURE WITHOUT INFORMED
CONSENT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RACHEL COOLEY I'M
FROM PALO ALTO AND I ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU
MA'AM.
FRANCESCA CURRENTLY FROM HIGHLY
HOLD CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF THREE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
NAME IS KRISTEN WOULD I'M IN
SENATOR BILL DODDS DISTRICT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M ALLISON FINCH A DAUGHTER OF
AN EIGHT YEAR OLD LITTLE GIRL
I'M FROM PETALUMA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU.
MY NAME IS AT WAR GUARDIAN I'M A
RESPIRATORY THERAPIST AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DENIED SURGERY FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE COMMISSION.
MY NAME IS IRENE A CARPENTER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE I'M A MOM OF
THREE IN A MEDICAL ASSISTANT
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ALEXANDER KISSER
HOME A FATHER OF TWO KIDS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
NAME IS VICTORIA KISAH IN A
MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN AND A
SURPLUS.
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU. THIRTY MISTER SEND
MOTHER OF FOUR AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
I AM AM I BEATING VENDOR
HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M JACOBIAN MENDER FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE USER.
I'M AS WERE ACTIVELY NIGHT
BECAUSE THIS BILL GIVE.
I'M NO ACTUALLY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I AM ATTY ACKERLEY AND I OPPOSE
ITSELF THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AMY CHAMBERLAIN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND THAT'S ARMSTRONG AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NAME IS REAGAN I
I AS LINKING CODDLING FROM AGAIN
CALIFORNIA I WAS INSERTED BY
VACCINE AS A CHILD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU -- MY NAME AND MY NAME
IS ANASTASIA AND I HAVE TWO KIDS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OXANA MAKE A GALLON.
I AM A PARENT THROAT TRICKIN
CHILDREN [inaudible]
I OPPOSE.
SB.
TWO SEVEN TWO SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU.
AND TO TELL THE OF TO CHANCHAL
AND I'M A MOTHER O THREE
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU -- MY NAME IS ENOUGH SO IN
JANKA I AM OPPOSE SB.
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS A CONTINUOUS
SUCH COLA I AM FROM WEST
SACRAMENTO I AM A MOTHER OF TWO
KIDS AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED
HIS BILL AS BE TWO SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TINA FEY I'M
FROM WHERE SACRAMENTO AND FATHER
OF TWO KIDS.
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE THE THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I I BEAT THE SUCH GO FAR FROM
SACRAMENTO.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SUMMER DENARD
AND I'M A MOM.
AND PUBLIC SCHOOL COUNSELOR.
AND I'M FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS WHITNEY I'M FROM
LINCOLN CALIFORNIA.
I AM AN ADULT.
CHILD OF VACCINE INJURY AND HAVE
A VACCINE INJURED CHILD AS WELL
I OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WILL ELLIOTT FROM ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA NAY STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MANDY KERRY AND
I HAVE TWO CHILDREN ONE THAT IS
MEDICALLY FRAGILE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BECAUSE OF THE SAGA
IN AND FROM THE GROUND OR
CALIFORNIA IN STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER HOURS AGO
FROM GARDEN GROVE AND THE MOTHER
OF ONE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL HAVE VACCINE INJURY IN MY
FAMILY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NAY RICHARD FORMER I
HAVE TO FIXING THE INJURED KIDS
AND THEIR MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
WILL BE INVALIDATED BY THIS BILL
I STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
I'M JOHN I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED
HIS BILL [inaudible]
IN THE THE LESS VERY TALL SIX
THANK YOU SIR ALL BLOOM AND ARE
LESS.
THANK YOU SIR DISEASE THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY.
MY NAME IS ELSA GO THROUGH BUT
AND OPPOSES BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS THAT THERE'S A
CONSERVE A IN A STRONGLY OPPOSES
THOUGH THANK YOU.
I THANK MY NAME IS VALENTINA THE
SERVER AND I BOTH THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME RECOGNITION I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS VICTORIA FROM
ON THE LOCAL OFF HIGH STRUNG OUT
POSTS OF THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO BERMAN IS INJURE ON FROM A
CITY FOR A LITTLE APPLES THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S NOT SOLELY APPLES THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS JUST SEND THE
LAYMEN I AM FROM PLACERVILLE AND
FROM A MOTHER OF FOUR CHILDREN
AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS WENDY PLANK I'M
A MOTHER OF THREE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M DR ESTHER HALL
CHIROPRACTOR AND MOTHER OF THREE
FROM EITHER A COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES FELL THANK YOU.
I'M KATIE ANDERSON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M CATHERINE BOND I LIVE IN EL
DORADO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S GENESSEE BOND AND I AM
FROM SOMERSET CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BECKY BRESEE I HAVE
THREE CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE FOR ALTHOUGH
I'M FOR ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANKS.
MY NAME IS A CEREMONIAL INCOME
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL BIGGEST.
THE NAME IS BORDERS I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SELENA A MOTHER OF
TWO CHILDREN AT THE STAKE FIVE
YEARS FOR MY DAUGHTER TO
RECOVERED AFTER AFTER BOOKS IN
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSES BILLS THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS AVAILABLE CORN AND I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
OUR ROOM PETER.
RICHARD YOU SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA HI BOYS [inaudible]
THESE BILLS [inaudible]
YOU.
ON THE TIME FROM SACRAMENTO I'M
A MEDICAL WORKER FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS MOTHER OF SIX I'M OPPOSED
HIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MARIA MENOUNOS.
MARIA MENU AND GO FROM
SACRAMENTO AND AYE OPPOSED TO
SPILL I ALSO HAVE.
LATER.
I ALSO ON THIS IDENTICAL FROM
SACRAMENTO I ALSO OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF LOVE NESTERENKO THE ANTELOPE
CALIFORNIA FOR NHà AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS UNDER XIN
SHOULD COME FROM SCISSORS FIVE
CALIFORNIA AND THEN -- FATHER OF
THREE I'M OPPOSED AS BILL
BECAUSE OF WE HAVE.
TO I MUST HAVE A CHOICE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN A LOT OF MOTHER OF FOUR
OPPOSED THIS BILL.
YOU.
MY NAME IS MARK TO REST OF A
FATHER OF FIVE KIDS I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO.
I AM SPITTLE STONE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
THE BALLOT THAT ALSO MOTHER OF
FOUR KIDS AND I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M MORE CRESSMAN ANIMAL A
STRONGLY OPPOSES THE BILL.
THANK YOU HIS ARREST MAN I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU I AM DOCTOR AMY COE
ENORMOUS CONSTITUENCIES SENATOR
SKINNER I STAND WITH SENATOR BEN
ALLEN A MAN OF HIS WORD AND THE
HARVARD SINGLE -- PILGRIM HEALTH
STUDY SHOWS MA'AM I OPPOSE THE
BILL MUCH STUDY SHOWS FREEZING
GREAT ON THE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
BEING WRITTEN.
OLIVER MEYER COUNSELING
PSYCHOLOGY AND MAY AS A MANDATED
REPORTER I WOULD HAVE.
TO TURN MYSELF IN IF I WERE TO
LET ANYONE SEREMOS CHILD WITH
VACCINE AGAIN OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA OF AN IV
THIS TO HAVE A VACCINE INJURED
CHILD.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I
LIKE SENATOR PAT TO KEEP HIS
WORD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NAME IS ROBBIE I MEAN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI I'M JENNIFER TO LUGGAGE I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND SMALL
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DENISE SMITH I'M FROM
LA ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA I AM A
HOLISTIC NUTRITIONIST I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NADIA AND I AM
A MAMA FOR UNVACCINATED HEALTHY
KIDS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL SACRAMENTO.
VICUNA.
HI MY NAME IS ANNA S. OF A DANKO
I HAVE TWO KIDS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALL I AND I POSES BE
TWO SEVEN TO SIX BECAUSE KIDS
GET INJURED AND THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM.
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS BILL IF YOU
CAN PROTECTION OF OUR CHILDREN
YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS ROMAN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU ROOM.
HI MY NAME IS IRENE DOESAFFECT
TOOK AM OPPOSES BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LOOKS ON AYE MOM OF
SIX KIDS I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM.
YOU COULD ARENA FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE TALLEST WELCOME I'M OPPOSED
HIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIA AND OPPOSE
THIS BILL LET US KEEP OUR
FREEDOM FREEDOM TO CHOOSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIA I'M
STRONGER OPPOSED HIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A RESULT KRYCEK
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
THANK YOUNG MEN.
AND MY NAME IS PUT THAT ALL I'M
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS THAT OHN OF THE
CAR TO MY MOM OF TWO AND AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU DAVID.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL ECHO THREE
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN I POSTED THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME MY NAME IS WITH
ELIGIBLE AND AYE OPPOSES BILL
THE USER.
MY NAME IS OLGA DID OF AYE MAMA
FIVE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AS BE
TO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS CARLY IRISH I'M FROM
OUT WATER CALIFORNIA AND I'M
HERE WITH THREE OF MY CHILDREN
TO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM.
AMY ONE S. FROM AMERICAN CANYON.
AND I'M A MOTHER OF AN OF
VACCINE INJURED CHILD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
BURKE ONCE TEACHER FROM AMERICAN
CANYON I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MICHELLE LEMAY CITRUS HEIGHTS I
WORKED IN THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY THIRTY THREE YEARS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
DR MARKEL MAY FROM FERRIS
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS ABOUT THE CHEN
SCOTT AND I'M A MOM AND I'M
SHOWING DOUBLES THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KO CHODA AND NINE
FOUR THAT'LL.
FOR AND FROM THE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
IN A RESERVE A DIMINISH CHOKE
AND I'M STRONG GLOBAL SO THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TRACY SLAP CIVIC FROM
SAN MARCOS CALIFORNIA I'M A
VETERAN AND A MOTHER OF A
VACCINE DAMAGE CHILD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SPELL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR RACHEL WEST
OF A BOARD CERTIFIED FAMILY
PRACTITIONER I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF A COUPLE.
HUNDRED OF MY PATIENTS WHO ARE
VACCINE INJURED -- AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO DON'T WANT TO
CONTINUE VACCINATING THEIR
CHILDREN OR THEIR SIBLINGS WOULD
BE FORCED TO TAKE YOU UNDER THIS
POST I OPPOSE THIS BILL STRONGLY
BECAUSE SO MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRA HACK Là
AND I'M FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS STEVE SLOT CIVIC ON
FIRST RESPONDER.
MY CHILD WAS INJURED WITH A
VACCINE ENTRY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
MY MOTHER IN VETERAN BONNIE
MILLIGAN PLEASE PROTECT THE
DOCTOR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP BY
OPPOSING.
TO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
SACRAMENTO MOTHER OF THREE MY
KIDS IN PRIVATE SCHOOL FOR FIVE
YEARS. 80% OF KIDS NOT
VACCINATING SCHOOL DON'T SEE ANY
RISK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THIS
BILL STRONG WITH.
ALL MY NAME IS NATALIA I'M
OPPOSED HIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANDREA I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO I AM OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU UNDER.
MY NAME IS VALENTINA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GIVEN.
HI MY NAME IS KATIE A FROM
ORANGE WELL AND I WANT TO HAVE A
CHOICE FOR MY KIDS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE COMMISSION.
MY NAME IS DYLAN INFORMATICA AN
ANTELOPE CALIFORNIA I AM BOTH
HIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NOW IT'S ACCOUNT CO
I'M A REGISTERED NURSE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AS BE TWO SEVEN
SIX EIGHT IS A IS HARMFUL AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS ROSITA STRETCHES I AM
A REGISTERED NURSE AYE OPPOSED
SB TWO SEVEN SIX I HAD A CHILD
INJURED WITH THE VACCINES.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AS BE TWO
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU SIR.
I'M HERE'S MEN AND ONLY HAS MADE
IN THE SUPREME COURT HAS RULED
THAT MAN AND WOMAN HAVE
SOVEREIGNTY IN AUTHORITY OVER
THE SELF AND OPPOSE REFILL SIR
THAT GOVERNMENT HAS NO AUTHORITY --
THANK YOU NEXT BEAKER THE COVER
THANK YOU SIR DISHES GOVERNMENT.
IS A FICTITIOUS LEGAL ENTITY
WHICH LITERALLY DOES NOT EXIST
EXCEPT IN THE MIND OF THE HUMAN
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS LENA CISCO ENOUGH
FROM AND ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CRISTINA CISCO FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I AM ELEVEN WERE CISCO FROM CODE
AND TO THIS CRISIS.
I HAVE ELEVEN GRANDCHILDREN SO I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE SURE ABOUT FROM
SACRAMENTO -- REGISTERED NURSE
IN THE FATHER OF TWO I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
FRANCISCO CONCERNED PARENT OF
FOUR CHILDREN.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS JAMES PETERS TAYLOR
OF RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA I'M
VACCINE INJURED AND MY SON'S
MEDICAL EXEMPTION IS NOT FAKE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA SHERMAN'S
I'M FROM PARIS CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOM OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BUILD MY FOREMAN VACCINES NEARLY
KILLED ME AND MY SON HAS BEEN
INJURED BY THEM.
THE BOOK SOMETHING IS NOT FAKE.
MY NAME IS ANDRE SHERMAN SOME
FROM PARIS CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MARINA SUCH GO FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS MOTHER ONE WITH ANOTHER
ON THE WAY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M KRISTEN RUSHED OFF FROM
FREMONT CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
WHEN THE NEEDLE?
WE NEED TO AVOID ON A POST AS
BILL.
THANK YOU FROM MY CELLULAR RADO
AND I'M THIRTEEN YEARS OLD AND I
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA HOW.
FOR CALIFORNIA I MEAN HERE WERE
CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSE THIS BILL
THE KENNEDY MUSIC THAT HAS NOT
ALTHOUGH I'M FROM HERE
CALIFORNIA FIFTY YEARS ON I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ON A MOTHER
ADELINE A MOTHER TO FIVE
CHILDREN I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
MY HUSBAND AND FIFTY OTHER MOMS
WHO CAN IT BE CARE.
AND I'M -- I STRONGLY OPPOSES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS JANE AND FROM
SAN MATTEO A DOCTOR AND A MOTHER
OF TWO CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LISA JENKINS I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
WAS PARENTS UNITED FOR KIDS I'VE
BEEN PERSONALLY AFFECTED BY
VACCINES AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ERIN FOR OUR
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M A
MOTHER OF A VACCINE AND YOUR
CHILD AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DOT -- DARCY
KENDRICK MAKAR PROCTOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS EARTH PLAN DO YOU
THINK HE WAS SCHEME HEALTH
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
LISTENING TO ALL OF US.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND DOCTOR PAN I KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
YOU'RE GONNA STOP THIS BILL IS
TO LEARN MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
BEING HERE.
HI MY NAME'S AND BEHOLD FROM
BATON DAY BEACH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M NATALIE CLEMENTI AND I AM
A VACCINE INJURED MOTHER OF TWO
I VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
IT GETS AS IT'S AGAINST OUR CON
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I'M RYAN HEN FROM FULL SOME CALL
CALIFORNIA THIS IS MY SON CONNOR
WHOSE VACCINE INJURED AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR CONOR.
JENNIFER HANDFUL SOME CALIFORNIA
MOTHER OFTWO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I RANCHO CORDOVA CALIFORNIA.
JESSICA FRY RANCHO CORDOVA
CALIFORNIA.
I AM A TEACHER AND A MOTHER OF
THREE I OPPOSE THE SPELL THANK
YOU MA'AM.
JERRY BOY IN SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA AND I'M A MOTHER OF
TWO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK THANK YOU.
JOSH TILLMAN SAID IT WAS A
CALIFORNIA FATHER TO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
CRISTINA DONE FAIR OAKS
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SEEK FLEA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MAN.
AND PLAY FAIR OAKS CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
FAMILY FLAV FROM FAIR OAKS
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU
CHRIS RAMSEY GRANITE BAY
CALIFORNIA AND MEDICALLY INJURED
THANK YOU SIR.
MARINA RAMSEY -- I OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AMANDA BELKNAP AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL MY SON
IS VACCINE INJURED.
THANK YOU.
NAMES A DAILY RICHARDSON MY
GRANDSON IS VEXING INJURED AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS ELLA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALINA MY KIDS HAVE
BEEN HURT BY VACCINES.
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL DON'T DO
THIS TO US PLEASE.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS CHEN MERRY POWERS I'M
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND A
MOTHER OF TWO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN IN MY NAME IS CYNTHIA CHAVEZ
THEM FROM VENTURA CALIFORNIA.
I AM A CRITICAL CARE NURSE OF
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS SURELY SHOCKER I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES AND SENATOR PAN.
YOU SAID THIS WOULD NOT HAPPEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE STILL I AM A
LAWYER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS TO THE
RIGHT THING THANK YOU FOR
TESTIMONY AND NEXT SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS TALLY A GRAPH FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF
FIVE ONE MEDIC MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILD.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF HIM AND MY
FAMILY ANYONE ELSE.
WHO CAN'T BE HERE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO WORK I STRONGLY OPPOSES
THE COMMUNE?
HELLO GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
JULIE THE PLEA DEAL BECAUSE I
MOTHER OF THREE KIDS AND THREE
GRANDKIDS PLEASE DO I DO NOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL STRONGLY
RECOMMENDED I DO IT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MA'AM HE DID A MUCH
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VERONICA PRE DO COME
A REGISTERED RESPIRATORY
THERAPIST AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE O'NEILL DURAN.
A CONCERNED PARENTS OF ELK GROVE
AND I COUNTY COMMITTEE OF SAFETY
SACRAMENTO.
WE HAVE OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
REGISTERED MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE OPPOSE THIS AN ALL UNLAWFUL
ACTS GOVERNMENT SO BE.
ON NOTICE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WEEK -- PLEASE DOCTOR HEART
STRAIGHT CHIROPRACTOR MARIN
COUNTY CHILDREN ARE BORN WITH A
DEFICIENCY OF VACCINES THANK YOU
SIR MAX OWES A BILL -- SCIENCE
THANK YOU SIR.
THE NAME IS ANNA NICOLE WHEN AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S
TAKING AWAY OUR FREEDOM AS BANDS
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS OLGA FONT OF AN
APPARENT TO CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS JAN FERRIC FROM SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
INCIDENTALLY GUNTER ON BEHALF OF
MY FAMILY IN TWO KIDS A OPPOSED
HIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
I NEVER FELL OF ACUTE OFF AND
FUNDS OF THE KIDS.
I'M STRUGGLE.
AGAIN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED.
MY NAME THE DUKE TO CENTRAL AND
THEN I IN GAINES THESE BILLS.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS HEADED NUMBER SCHOOL
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OLGA SOME SLOWER PHD
RESEARCHER MOTHER OF THREE KIDS
FOR STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
A MY NAME IS MARIE.
BRANDON'S COURTESY TO ESTIMATE
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
MY NAME IS COURTNEY AGRARIAN
FROM BACK OF BILL AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KERRY ROYAL I
AM FROM ON IT COULD CALIFORNIA.
I AM THE MOTHER OF A TWO YEAR
OLD IMMUNE COMPROMISED CHILD.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PLEASE DO THE RIGHT THING.
THANK YOU.
IS A SEAT HI MY NAME IS SHELLY
CLUES I'M FROM LACK OF ALL
CALIFORNIA I'M A HOMESCHOOLING
MOM OF THREE MY OLDEST DAUGHTER --
BEING PERMANENTLY DISABLED FROM
THE T. THAT BACK SCENE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MICHELLE'S AB FROM BACK --
CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF TWO
SEVERELY IMMUNE COMPROMISED
CHILDREN AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KAMALA.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE CHAVEZ I AM
FROM BACK A BILL I AM THE MOTHER
OF TWO A MULE COMPROMISE
CHILDREN I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PATRICIA PUT GONNA
SAN PABLO AND I AM VACCINE
INJURED AND SO IS MY SON I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WOULD ALLOW ME TO GO
TO COLLEGE.
MM.
BUT I'M ISRAELIS ALSO FOR RICH
FOR CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S ALEX MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THE LEVEL ROSE CON
I STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS TANYA I'M GOING
CONCERT FROM SUCH AS CUTS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE BIG COMPOST
I DROVE UP FROM ORANGE
CALIFORNIA I'M A MOTHER FOR AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SOPHIA COMPASS I
COME ALL THE WAY FROM ORANGE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS OLIVIA CAMPOS
I'M FROM ORANGE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LOUISE NAMAN AND
SENATOR NIELSEN DISTRICT A
MOTHER OF TWO AND A STRONGLY
OPPOSES.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NO WELL FOSTER A
HOME EDUCATOR FROM CARMICHAEL
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS LEE LOW WOOD FROM
SANTA CRUZ.
AN EDUCATIONAL THERAPIST AND A
MOTHER OF A MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILD WHO WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
GO TO SCHOOL OF THIS BILL PASSED
NAY STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRIS FLEX HUG
FROM BEAUTIFUL SIMI VALLEY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MY NAME IS KAREN THOMPSON FROM
SIMI VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR AMY COBURN I
WORKED AS A PRIMATE MEDICINE
VETERINARIAN FOR MANY YEARS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AS BE TWO
SEVENTY SIX I'M FROM THOUSAND
OAKS CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M LISA LOPEZ
FROM MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA I'M THE
MOTHER OF A MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILD HAS A VALID EXEMPTION
UNDER SB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN SHE BELIEVES
THAT DO THE NARROWLY DEFINED
TERMS PLEASE.
I AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL PLEASE
DO THE RIGHT THING.
I'M DR CHERYL SCOTT WORKING
KAISER PERMANENT T. ROSEVILLE.
AND I HAVE ON BEHALF OF THE
HUNDREDS OF WOMEN I'VE.
CHILDREN I'VE CARED FOR IN THE
LAST THIRTY EIGHT YEARS IN
MOTHER BABY WHO BEEN VACCINE
INJURED.
I THINK RAMLI OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL RENNER FAIR OAKS
CALIFORNIA I DEFINITELY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S BILL -- HERA.
AND FOR MOUNT SHASTA CITY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
DOCTOR HE SU WAITING FROM SANTA
BARBARA FOUR YEARS AGO YOU SAID
YOU IN AND INTERFERE WITH THE
DOCTORS ARE LEARNING YOU POSE A
BILL AND I OPPOSE THIS BULLARD
YOU OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PERSON.
WHILE I'M FROM SANTA BARBARA A
LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD HAVE TO
LEAVE IF THIS PASSES AND I
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
LUCAS SAYS SAUSALITO CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CARE ATA AND
PAN DECIDES TO LOOK AT ALL THE
ENERGY AND YOUR CHILDREN AND
DECIDES TAKE AWAY OUR FREEDOM
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
RODNEY IRA FROM ROSEVILLE.
FATHER OF ACTION INNER CHILD AND
A STRONG REPOSE VEGAS HER.
MY NAME'S KENDALL VUNG I'M FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA I HAVE A
SON THAT WAS AFFECTED BACKED BY
VACCINES WITH THE A COMPROMISED
IMMUNE SYSTEM AND WITHOUT THIS
MEDICAL EXEMPTION YOU WOULD DENY
HIM.
HIS EDUCATIONAL RIGHT.
I PROPOSE THANK YOU.
HI I'M JUST CA CANADA HELLO.
FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA MOTHER
AND I DON'T NEED A PHD THAT
INFORMED CONSENT I KNOW THE REST
AND I WILL NOT RISK MY CHILD
THANK YOU MA'AM.
YOUR POST IN.
LOW THIS TO KNOW.
MA'AM.
I ASSUME YOU'RE.
UBER PALE CONSENT.
THANK YOU.
AND SOFIA PELLEGRINI I LIVE IN
WATER PARK CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE A VACCINE INJURED BROTHER
WHO LOST HIS SPEECH AND MOTOR
SKILLS I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
NINETY MY NAME IS WENDY
PELLEGRINI AND I'M FROM CINEMA
COUNTY.
I'M PRO MEDICAL CHOICE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA RISER JEVONS
I'M FROM MENDOCINO COUNTY THIS
IS A CORRUPT.
DANGEROUS MEMBER YOU'RE OPPOSED
JAIL AND I OPPOSE IT THANK YOU.
YEAH MY NAME IS MIKE MATTINGLY A
FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND LIKE
THE MEL BROOKS BEFORE ME AYE
OPPOSED TO THIS INQUISITION
THANK YOU SIR.
CIVIL DISTURBANCE A LOCAL FOR
NOW AND ON THE POST THESE BILLS
[inaudible]
YOU.
MY NAME IS UNTIL IT THIS LINK OF
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA FIVE ZERO
NINE I AM A POOL OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME'S ART ON THIS GROUP OF
AND AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL KIM AND
I NAME IS ALEXANDER TO SPANK
WHEN I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME VITALIS THROWS ON FATHER
OF FOUR CHILDREN AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS OLGA AND A MOTHER OF
FOUR CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARIA AND I'M FROM
NEW CASTLE CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE
FOUR CHILDREN AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH THE
LEGACY Là AND I AM A MOTHER OF
SIX CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SVETLANA BECAUSE A
LITTLE MORE SENSE.
I HAVE FIVE CHILDREN AND I'M
STRONG THE UP WITH THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GALINA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME'S TO RESET I'M A MOTHER
TO A VACCINE INJURED CHILD'S AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK FOR YEARS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME -- MY SON ALMOST DIED
FROM VACCINES SO WHAT KIND OF
FATHER WOULD I BE IF I DIDN'T
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND I DON'T LIKE THE SMIRK YOU
HAVE THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE NEXT WEEK --
PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS FAIRLY SOME FELT
FROM WRITTEN.
MOTHER OF THREE HI MY NAME IS
CERTAINLY SOME FILLED FROM
REPPAN MOTHER. THREE ONE OF THEM
STOP BREATHING AFTER THE
VACCINES I STRONGLY OPPOSES
ABOUT.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT BAKER
PLEASE.
HI I'M FROM BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA TAYLOR I AM
FROM BRAZIL CALIFORNIA.
I AM THE MOTHER OF FOUR THAT ARE
VACCINE DAMAGED AND GRANDMOTHER
OF TEN AND I VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
HI MY NAME'S JAMES TAYLOR I'M
FROM BRAZIL CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE YOUR SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA I AM A
BAY AREA MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KATHY HAVE EARLY
MOTHER THREE I HAVE ONE VACCINE
INJURED CHILD AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE ON A MARTIN
I'M FOR MAN TAKE A MOTHER OF
THREE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING US TODAY
MY NAME IS DEANNA LIVE AKIO I'M
FROM STOCKTON CALIFORNIA I HAVE
THREE CHILDREN AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MY AND ECHOES MY
SENATORS MIKE MCGUIRE MY SON
WOULD BE THROWN OUT OF SCHOOL IF
THIS BILL PASSED PLEASE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALLISON LASSEN I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN THAT WERE INJURED
BY VACCINES -- I AND MY SON HAS
A LEGITIMATE MEDICAL EXEMPTION
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JACOB
LASSEN -- I'M FROM SEBASTOPOL
CALIFORNIA AND I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS IAN WILKERSON AND
I'M A CINEMA COUNTY RESIDENT.
I HAVE OF THE FATHER OF A SON
WITH A LEGITIMATE.
MEDICAL EXEMPTION WHO WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL IF THIS
BILL PASSES [inaudible]
BECAUSE HER.
MY NAME IS MARK MARK TAYLOR OF
FROM CINEMA CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
SB TWO SEVEN SIX ALONG WITH MY
FAMILY AND A GROUP OF PEOPLE
FROM CINEMA WHO COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS ANGELA FERGUSON I'M
FROM CINEMA COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND I HAVEN'T IMMUNO COMPROMISED
CHILD WHO DOES NOT FIT THE CDC
CRITERIA IF THIS BILL PASSES.
AND WILL NOT BE ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL WITH HER MEDICAL
EXEMPTION THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS SHEILA RICHARDSON I'M
A RETIRED NURSE I'M FROM CINEMA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL SENATE TO POUND THANK
YOU DO THE RIGHT THING FOR THANK
YOU MA'AM.
MALAYSIA FROM SANTA ROSA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HER YESTERDAY I'M
ARIEL FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND I ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M CHRISTINE CALLAWAY FROM
SANTA ROSA I WAS VACCINE INJURED
AS A CHILD AND I HAVE A
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILD OF MY
OWN.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
WANTING KNOWLEDGE YOU ALL FOR
LISTENING TO ALL OF OUR OPINIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
MICHAEL INTO -- ST I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE I WORK IN
CRITICAL CARE PUT ON THE VALLEY
HOSPITAL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
HI MY NAME IS WINDOW FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND PER THE
UNESCO AGREEMENT ON BIO ETHICS
IN INFORMED CONCERNING -- POSTED
A LIGHT ONLY OPPOSES THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELIZABETH GRANT
THIS IS MY SON MILES GRAHAM WE
ARE FROM WOULD SAY CALIFORNIA
AND WE ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S CHRIS FROM
CARMICHAEL CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
OWNER AND MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BROOKE FROM EL
DORADO COUNTY AND THE MOTHER OF
THREE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE GUESTS
ARE FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA
AND I HAVE A VACCINE INJURED
SOME THAT WOULD NO LONGER
QUALIFY FOR A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
UNDER THIS BILL.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWO SEVEN
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL GESSNER ON
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND
THE FATHER OF TWO CHILDREN ONE
WHO IS MET -- MEDICALLY INJURED
FROM VACCINES I DO NOT BELIEVE
THE AND CORPORATE SPONSORED
STATE GROWTH LIKE THE HUMAN LEE
OPPOSES THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN ERDMAN I'M A
PROGRESSIVE ACTIVISTS FROM SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AND I WAITED A LONG
TIME IN A HOT HALLWAY TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL VERY STRONGLY THANK
YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE -- ADMIN I
AM THE MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN
WHO HAVE RARE TERMINAL ILLNESSES.
A ON THEIR ILLNESSES ARE NOT
COVERED BY THE A. C. I. P. ACIP
GUIDELINES AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
SENATOR PAN AND COMMITTEE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE MY NAME IS MARY
CATHERINE SKATE FROM A FROM
REDDING CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
HI THANK YOU FOR HEARING US
TODAY MY NAME IS SANDY WOODS AND
I AM FROM REDDING CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS STACY AND FROM
EL DORADO COUNTY.
AND I OPPOSE THEM DISAPPOINTED
WE NEED TO BE BACK HERE AS YOU.
PROMISED US ALL THESE IMPORTANT
THINGS TO BE OPPOSED THEM THANK
YOU -- BURKE KHAIRUL ELDORADO
COUNTY -- FIREFIGHTER I HAVE --
TO MEDICALLY EXEMPT KIDS LOVE
FOR THEM TO STAY AND BE ABLE TO
GO ON CUTS SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA
AND HOW 2% OPPOSED.
USER RATING THANK YOU SIR.
HI TERRY MARQUIS FROM EAGLE ROCK
IN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE THING.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMY KENNY FROM
DANA POINT A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER AND A MOTHER I
WHOLE HEARTEDLY.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI AMLA ZERO HAAS FROM TRUCKEE
CALIFORNIA NUTRITIONAL THERAPY
PRACTITIONER HELPING TO RECOVER
VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
CHARLOTTE VON I STROLLED
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS ISABEL JOHNSON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
WONDERFUL SERRA AND AYE OPPOSED
HIS BILL AS WELL THANK YOU SIR.
RAQUEL FOR LAND I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE OAKLEY CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NO OF BERLIN THEM
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND AYE
OPPOSED TO SPILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EVA I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I AM A MOTHER AN
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SPELL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S CARISSA STOCKARD I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY I AM A
TEACHER A MOTHER OF TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS TO BE TRIED OF A SURE
HEARD I'M A MOTHER AND AN
EDUCATOR IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND I PLEAD WITH YOU
TO DO THE SAME.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHELSEA FRIEDMAN I'M
FROM POSSIBLE CALIFORNIA I'M A
LICENSED MIDWIFE AND MOTHER OF
TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TUESDAY BENEFIT AS
NIGHT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL I'M A NURSE MIDWIFE AND I
HAVE TWO COUSINS THAT WERE THAT
HAVE SEVERE AUTISM FROM THE MMR
VACCINE.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS LYDIA SHAFTS OFF
MOTHER OF TWO FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS AND I GUESS.
I OPAL IS BILLED AS BE.
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU MA'AM OR
SUPPLEMENT.
MY NAME IS NICOLE LIKE HE'S
OCCUR I CAME HERE FROM WHAT SAID
CALIFORNIA.
I MENTION TOURNEY MY MOTHER OF
TWO CHILDREN WITH COMPROMISED
IMMUNE SYSTEMS WHO WOULD BE
DENIED THEIR RIGHT TO AN
EDUCATION.
IN PUBLIC EDUCATION ARE YOU
OPPOSE MOUNT CORNEA I AM OPPOSED
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER CONLEY I'M
FROM PORTOLA VALLEY I HAVE FOUR
CHILDREN ONE OF VACCINE INJURED
AND I HAVE A GRADUATE DEGREE IN
BIOCHEMISTRY I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER Là LEE
AND I'M FROM MENDOCINO COUNTY.
I HAVE A SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD AND
I AM ALSO AN EDUCATOR.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LISA ABOUT EM FROM LA
COUNTY.
AND I HAVE THREE CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S MOLINA WALLACE MORE
FROM LAKE TAHOE CALIFORNIA AND
WE HAVE PERSONAL FAMILY MEDICAL
HISTORY.
AND THIS BILL WOULD JEOPARDIZE
OUR CHILDREN WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NAMES DOWN ALL ASH -- I OPPOSE
BILL TWO SEVENTY SIX MY KIDS IN
A ROOM VACCINE NEVER BEEN IN THE
HOSPITAL FOR BEING SICK.
IF THIS GUY -- PASSES THEY CAN'T
GO TO MIDDLE SCHOOL OR HIGH
SCHOOL GEN OF PEOPLE THANK YOU
SIR -- SIMILAR OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS KERRY MAKE MAN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE AS
BE TO SEVENTY MM.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CAN.
TO FULLY VACCINATED VERSUS
VACCINATED CHILDREN THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ERICA I'M FROM
HUMBOLDT COUNTY I HAVE FOUR
CHILDREN AND TWO GRANDCHILDREN
THREE HAVE BEEN VACCINE INJURED
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
REALLY SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
THE WHEN CHRIS SEVENTY YEAR OLD
DEMOCRAT FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
THIS IS ANNA FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY
I HAVE A VACCINE INJURED SENT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARIE SAM A MOTHER OF
TWO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KEVIN DE SELBY AND
I'VE OF FATHER OF A VACCINE
INJURED BOY IN.
ANOTHER MEDICALLY FRAGILE ONE
AND AND THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
ATTEND SCHOOL IF THIS BILL
PASSES I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
THANK YOU SIR.
LIMON MOBILE FROM SAN LUIS
OBISPO CALIFORNIA A RETIRED
FORTY YEAR SPECIAL EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATOR AND TEACHER WHEN I
CAME HERE TODAY TO STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SPELL.
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU PATIENT ON
DOCUMENT.
NEXT BIGGER RELATIONSHIP.
HI MY NAME IS TANYA FEATHER
CIRCUM OF ON FOR ROSA CALIFORNIA
I HAVE FOUR KIDS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELENA DRUBBING
YOKE ON ROM SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND THEY WORK FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND AYE OPPOSED
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS EDDIE TACTFUL
BONNER AND FROM GRANITE BAY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AS BE.
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU MA'AM.
RACHEL GREEN FRIENDLY CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK
YOU.
TAMERA VIRTUE I AM A REGISTERED
NURSE NURSE I ROSE BILL I HAVE
VACCINE INJURED FAMILY MEMBERS I
OPPOSE THE GIVEN.
HI MY NAME IS ERICA SO SANTA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CARLOS ORTIZ AND I
SUPPORT MEDICAL FREEDOM.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS JACQUELINE I AM
DAHLE I AM A COMBAT VETERAN
INJURED MAXINE INJURED VETERANS.
TO AUTOIMMUNE DISEASES.
THANK YOU ROOM.
MY NAME IS AMANDA AND I'M FROM
GALLERY CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL BELL
AND ARE.
NEVER CAN FACTS THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS A LEAN MARKHAM
I'M A MOTHER AND I DO NOT
SUPPORT THIS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT YOU WILL NOT
YIELD AND SPEAKS THANK YOU A LOT
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MANY YOUNG COMPARED I'M A
MOTHER THREE ONE FAXING
COMPROMISE THIS BILL REVOKED BY
TWO DAUGHTERS MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS WILLIAM PERRY I'M
FROM MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS LENA I HAVEN'T SO I
AM MOTHER OF TO MY YOUNGEST SON
HAD ADVERSE REACTION REPORTED BY
DOCTOR UNDER THIS BILL WILL NOT
QUALIFY FOR MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ENABLE EVANS FROM
MONTEREY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU
MA'AM.
MY NAME IS DARIUS SEVENS ON FROM
MARINO CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
STEVE EVANS FROM MONTEREY
CALIFORNIA I'M WIDE AWAKE.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND WE ARE ALL REGISTERED VOTERS
ACCUSER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M TANIA PER SHOCK MOTHER
HEALTH EDUCATOR AND CITIZEN OF
THIS FREE COUNTRY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ALYSSA DONE FROM
DISTRICT SIX AND AYE OPPOSED HIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SYMPTOMATIC SOME
IN OUR AN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
ANY BILL HAD INCLUDING THIS ONE
THAT.
TAKES AWAY THE DOCTOR'S RIGHT.
TO PROVIDE INFORMED CONSENT
ASSUME ANY PATIENTS THANK YOU
MAKING DECISIONS FOR TESTIMONY.
HELLO MY NAME IS PRISCILLA
MICHAEL I'M A PHYSICIAN AND I AM
EDUCATED ABOUT VACCINES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
RESIDENTS SIR FINISH ODD CEO OF
A TECH COMPANY IN THE BAY AREA.
PLEASE DON'T TURN A DEAF EAR TO
ALL OF US HERE WHO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND ACCUSER UP
ON SOME SLEEP ACOSTA MONEY.
HI MY NAME IS A NINETY LAN I'M A
RESIDENT OF FAIR OAKS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AMY WILD SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
BROWN'S CALL THE FROM FALLS IN
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M VALUE IN HIGHER.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR CHARGES FROM SANTA
CRUZ.
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK
YOU.
THEN A CASH AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JADE CHILSON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
PICK UP CHILDREN MENDOCINO
COUNTY THIS IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THIRD.
THIRD CHILSON TREMENDOUS YOU
KNOW COUNTY THIS IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROSE AT A CASH AND I
STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU IN.
AND TONY SANCHEZ FROM MERCED.
IN A STRONGLY OPPOSE THE GIVEN.
UNDER THE PEARSON I'M FROM
GRAVINA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DONLEY FROM MARIPOSA AND DON'T
PASS THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M DO NEED TO LEAVE FROM
CAMERON PARK AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
YEAH I AM SARAH HARRISON FROM
AREA CALIFORNIA.
DROVE UP TO THE AT TODAY JUST
THE STATE THAT I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANKS FOR COMING.
HELLO I'M EVELYN DANFORD HOWARD --
FROM SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THAT
VIOLATES OUR DOCTOR PATIENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I MELANIE AMBER I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DEEP DORADO I'M
FROM PLEASANTON CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED THIS BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALL OF THIS GO
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NINA ANDERSON I'M
FROM NEW CASTLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THE RAIN COURTESY PHONE VENTURA
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S JULIANA CARMEN FROM
KERN BILL CALIFORNIA AND THEY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
JEFF ANDERSON FROM NEWCASTLE
CALIFORNIA ALL WHO VOTED FOR SB
TWO SEVEN SIX WILL JOIN THAT
SENATOR PAN.
IN THE PANTHEON OF YOUR OPPOSE
SIR THANK YOU THIS IS FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
JOY JOHNSON FROM PLEASANTON
CALIFORNIA MILITARY SPOUSE
VACCINE INJURED AS A CHILD I
STRONGLY OPPOSES THANK YOU.
JOHN WHY DUGAN FROM WALNUT CREEK
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUENTS OF
STEPHEN GLAZER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
ON THE NUMBER ONE MONEY FROM
CASTRO VALLEY I'M A MOM OF FOUR
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS A BLAST OF COLD FROM THE
LAFAYETTE MOTHER OF THREE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MORGAN STAR FROM PLACERVILLE
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL.
THANK YOU.
REALLY BALDY PEDIATRIC
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST FOR MORE
INFO CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
CINDY ROSADA FROM DISTRICT ONE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU -- S FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL COLLINS SACRAMENTO
DISTRICT SIX BY THEIR OF THREE
VACCINE INJURED I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THERE ARE MASON DISTRICT ONE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
IS EMMA HARM A CONSTITUENT OF
SENATOR MONNING AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
JASMINE PALOMINO FROM MODESTO
CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF THREE
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE GIVEN.
DAVID PALOMINO FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY.
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MELODY ANDERSON FROM GLEN ELLYN
I'VE MOTHER THREE CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU RELIEF FROM GLEN ELLYN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
THANK YOU.
MEREDITH FITZGERALD FROM NAPA
CALIFORNIA MOTHER OF TWO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SESSION DAVIS
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I HAVE
THREE CHILDREN AND A MASTERS IN
SOCIAL WORK WHO'S COULD ABOUT
YOU STATES THEM.
THE INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO SELF
DETERMINATION IS YOUR POST FROM
GUARD AND I THANK YOU POSES
MAKES HER TESTIMONY.
HI MY NAME IS CASSANDRA CRANDALL
FROM ALBERTA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARIANNA GATHER
SOME I'M FROM ROSE FOR
CALIFORNIA.
AND I POSED AS BEASTS TWO
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS EVELYN I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT --
VIOLATES HUMAN RIGHTS THANK YOU
MA'AM.
MY NAME IS SCARLET LANE I TRUST
MY DOCTOR I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOUNG LADY.
MY NAME'S GRIN THE A PENGUIN IN.
A NEW MISLED US ALL WHEN YOU
TOLD US YOU WOULD PROTECT YOU
OPPOSE THE BILL.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
MY NAME IS JANA GIPSON.
AND I DEFINITELY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS ALLEY HAGER FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA STRONGLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M KEY SHOWS ARE A FROM
TURLOCK CALIFORNIA TO MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN BOTH WITH
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS I OPPOSE THE
BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M LIZ PORTER I'M FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I HAVE THREE CHILDREN
ONE EXTREMELY MEDICALLY FRAGILE
I LOVE MY DOCTOR I TRUST MY
DOCTOR IS WONDERFUL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MARIA RIVERA FROM YORBA LINDA
MOTHER OF VACCINE INJURED
CHILDREN WHO SUFFERED
ANAPHYLACTIC ALLERGIC REACTION
TO A VACCINE COMPONENTS.
AT THE FAULT OF KAISER
PERMANENTE TAKE. NINE CAN SENSE
TO THIS I'M GOD THE BILL YOU CAN
BALLOT MEDICAL EXEMPTION THANK
YOU NOW FOR MY DAUGHTER THANK
YOU.
NEXT WEEK -- PLEASE.
THE LETTER K. [inaudible]
THANKS.
HI SHE NOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT [inaudible]
ONE SURGEONS.
BEER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADULT
SPEAKERS PLEASE -- ADOLESCENCE.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS NICOE I'M
COMING FROM LAKE ARROWHEAD
CALIFORNIA I'M SPEAKING ALSO FOR
MY TWO CHILDREN WHO ARE -- WHO
ARE GENETICALLY VULNERABLE AND
MY OWN VACCINE INJURY AND MY
FAMILY OF ACTING HISTORY AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE?
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHARITY I'M HERE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND A MOTHER OF
FOUR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- EVERYONE
FOR LISTENING MY NAME IS JESSICA
CRITTERS MILLER I'M FROM MISSION
VIEJO CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS MY DAUGHTER MIA --
MY HUSBAND WAS -- VACCINE INJURY
TO MY DAUGHTER HAS A GENETIC
PREDISPOSITION NIGHT COMPLETELY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M RACIAL HARRIS FROM
WESTMINSTER CALIFORNIA THANKS
FOR HAVING US -- MOTHER OF FOUR
CHILDREN AND WE AT SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALIZED CARE AND WE
OPPOSE THE SPELL THANK YOU FOR
COMING.
I MADE CHAU REEKIE AND I COME
FROM ROBINSON RANCH ORANGE
COUNTY AND I HAVE THREE CHILDREN
I HAD A BROTHER THAT DIED FROM A
VACCINE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SPELL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER DILLON I
COME FROM GUARDING GROWN UP
CORPS -- SKINNY GARDEN GROVE AND
A MOTHER OF TWO MEDICALLY
EXEMPTION -- AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CUT YEAH FLORES I'M
FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH I AM A
MODEL AND AN EDUCATOR AND I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSING THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANDREA WAYNE I'M FROM
STANTON CALIFORNIA -- I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME Q..
CAROL NELSON FROM BY SO YOU'RE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SHERRY BAKER FROM BY SAID
CALIFORNIA NINE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S DUSTIN HOLY FATHER.
TO AND THIS IS AN OVER REACH OF
GOVERNMENT THANK YOU SIR ARE YOU
CLOSE CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SHERRY EL DORADO I
AM FROM ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KAREN STEWART I'M
FROM ELK GROVE MOTHER OF TWO AND
WE'RE A MILITARY FAMILY AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU FAST YEAH IT RIGHT
OUT FOR MARIA CALIFORNIA -- WIFE
OF ACTIVE DUTY MARINE MOTHER OF
THREE AND A STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
STILL COMMITTEE -- FROM MERRY
MARIETTA STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MAUREEN DEFEND
THIS ROM REDDING CALIFORNIA
MOTHER OF FOUR AND I ALSO
STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANKS THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE THE
UNDERWEAR IF I'M A REGISTERED
NURSE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
FROM THOUSAND OAKS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
MARIE MEREDITH FROM MERCED AND I
AM A MOTHER OF FOUR AND MY
HUSBAND AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
KEVIN DE HOPE FROM BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
ALICIA DE HOPE FROM BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
CAN BAG WILL FROM INTO
CALIFORNIA CENTER PAN ALREADY
CITY WOULD BE BRING SOMETHING
LIKE THIS UP BEFORE SO I OPPOSE
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS RACHEL LASSEN I AM
VACCINE INJURED AND BECAUSE I AM
MEDICALLY FRAGILE -- I HAVE
RECEIVED A MEDICAL EXEMPTION SO
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M ROBIN.
VAN AND FROM MODESTO CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL PLEASE DO NOT TAKE MY
CHILD'S MEDICAL EXEMPTION AWAY
AFTER YOU PROMISED YOU WOULDN'T
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING IS
OUT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BRANDY LASSEN MODESTO
CALIFORNIA.
MY CHILD IS MEDICALLY FRAGILE
HER MEDICAL EXEMPTION IS NOT
FAKE I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME'S MICHELLE BOW NINE
FOR MISSION VIEJO MOTHER OF
THREE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NICOLE CHAVIS FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
I HAVE A VACCINE INJURED CHILD
AND I HAVE A VALID MEDICAL
EXEMPTION AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THE GIVEN.
HI MY NAME IS GENDER MERRY
TOPPING I FROM WAT I CALIFORNIA
AND I'M HERE TO OPPOSE SB TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX BECAUSE A MAN TWO
THOUSAND TWO MY FINALS DIAGNOSE
FEEDBACK AS TO MONEY USED TO
KILL SEMI.
Là MYELITIS THANK YOU AND IS
CURRENTLY SEVENTEEN WILL BE
DEPENDENT ON ME FOR THE REST OF
HIS LIFE.
NEXT THANK YOU [inaudible]
DESPITE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME'S ELAINE HOW IT.
I AM THE MOTHER FIVE CHILDREN
AND THREE STEP CHILDREN FOUR OF
THEM ARE VACCINATED FOUR OF THEM
WERE INJURED I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED ALSO THIS IS A VIOLATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE.
LARA SLOMAN I'M FROM ALSO BROWN
TO CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE TO
VACCINE INJURED CHILDREN AND ONE
WITH A MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
THANK YOU THOSE.
HI MY NAME IS MELISSA CASTRO I'M
FROM REDLANDS CALIFORNIA.
AND I HAVE FAMILY THAT'S VACCINE
INJURED AS WELL AS TO MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN THAT HAVE VALID --
FACT FEED EXEMPTIONS AND I DO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU GOD BLESS YOU
GUYS THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LISA HAVE A REP
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA NINE
THREE GRANDCHILDREN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND FEEL IT TO
BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL Q..
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA WILL BORN
I AM FROM ELDORADO HILLS
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL I'M A MOTHER OF TWO
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN IN
THIS BILL WOULD HARM THEM.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEFFREY PERRINE FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I STRONGLY
AGAINST THIS CAN PAN THANK MAKE
HIM RUN AGAIN SO I WILL SIGN IT
BECAUSE YOU THINK YOU.
THE NEXT RECORD PLEASE VOTE YOU
OUT HI MY NAME IS BARBARA
WAKEMAN AND I AM OPPOSE THIS
BILL THEY GIVE THEM.
FROM CATTLE GROW CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
I AM BARBER OUR THIRD FROM ELK
GROVE AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI I'M PATTY MENDOZA AND I HAVE
TO VACCINATE CHILDREN WITH
AUTOIMMUNE DISEASES.
THE HAVE IT PEACE MAY STRONGLY
OPPOSES THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS A VALERIUS I'M
MEDICALLY FRAGILE -- I'M FROM
ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
TERRY.
AND I HAVE AND I MY NAME IS
TERRY IS IN ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA
AND I AM OPPOSED THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MANUAL REELS IN
A FROM ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA AND I
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS DOREEN KENJI MY NAME
IS DURING CAN JIM FROM NORTH
HOLLYWOOD -- I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS LINDSAY WAGNER AND I
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO IMPLORE YOU
TO ADDRESS THE BIGGER ISSUE
WHICH IS THE HI SEVERE OPPOSE
MA'AM.
THE TOPIC MEMORY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDED TO
THESE THAT'S WHAT THE MY NAME IS
CARLA CORONA I'M FROM BACK OF
BILL CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME'S CHRISTINE AND THESE
ARE MY PHILLIP FIVE CHILDREN IN.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. SIX THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ALL.
NEXT IMAGE JUST SIDE DOC OUR AND
I'M FROM NEVADA AND AYE OPPOSED
TO SPELL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ERICA DOC OUR AND I
HAVE THREE CHILDREN AND MY
HUSBAND AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
YOUR BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M ROBIN SHOULD A STIR FROM
SANTA ROSA MY MOM TO TWO KIDS
WITH MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS DUE TO
GENETIC DIFFERENCES FAMILY
HISTORY AND ALLERGIES.
I'VE WAITED FOR HOURS TO TELL
YOU I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
MY NAME IS ANNE MARIE BECAUSE
THOSE WORKER I TEACH CHILDREN
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS IN SANTA ROSA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
MA'AM.
MY NAME IS SHERRY GAFFORD I'M
FROM MOUNTAIN HOUSE CALIFORNIA I
HAVE THREE CHILDREN TWO OF WHICH
ARE VACCINE DAMAGED AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL WHERE
THERE'S SMOKE THERE'S FIRE AND
THAT.
HE EXPECTS PLEASE.
AND I POSSIBLE.
MY NAME'S MOTION SADEGHI FROM
FAIR OAKS CALIFORNIA I HAVE BEEN
THE MOTHER OF TWO MEDICALLY
FRAGILE CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME'S COMMON SADEGHI FROM
FAIR OAKS CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS MEGAN DOOR FROM
ORANGEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THE BILL.
MY NAME IS LAURA GALVIN I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN THAT HAVE A MEDICAL
AB SENT EXEMPTION BASED ON DNA --
TESTS AND I'VE WORKED WITH MY
DOCTOR TO DO THAT I STRONGLY
OPPOSE REMOVING THE PHYSICIAN
FROM THIS EQUATION.
THINK ABOUT.
MY NAME IS JODY ALFARO I'M IN
OUR AND AND A MOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS SANDRA COLUSA THESE
ARE MY TWO CHILDREN CHOOSE THE
FRAGILE TYPE ONE DIABETIC WERE
FROM VALENCIA CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MERRY COLUSA FROM SANTA CLARITA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
MA'AM.
MY NAME IS MARIA SALADO FROM
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE CUBAN.
MY NAME IS IRENE A PACKAGE I AM
A MOTHER OF TWO AND A STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I'M ANDREA FATHER OF TWO I
OPPOSE FORCED VACCINATION AND
OPPOSES BILL USER.
JACK OF OUR ELK GROVE OPPOSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- WHEN HIS MILANESE
ARE AS WELL SENATOR PANTS
CONSTITUENT AND I PUT THIS BILL?
THANK YOU MA'AM.
TEENS ARE AS WELL FROM L. GROW
BY VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
STEPHANIE SIR I HAVE A DEGREE IN
IMMUNOLOGY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
NAME IS BRINGING THEM IN FROM U.
K. BUT CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AS BEING.
TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
BUFFY STAMPER FROM BEAUMONT AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
EGGMAN.
MY NAME'S DAVID LEE FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILLS WILL THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS MARIA SHASHIKALA.
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS THE COMMON NAME IS
ROMAN I'M FROM THE TWO SIDES THE
CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS RAJ JOHNSON I'M FROM
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
THIS BILL LEGISLATING MEDICAL
MEDICINE IS GOING TO BE IT IS
ASK YOU.
NEXT BAKER PLEASE.
MY NAME IS SUCH A GOOD A PER SUB
I AM FROM JIM BELTS -- DISTRICT
ANTARCTICA AND I AM A FATHER OF
TWO KIDS OFF MEDICALLY FRAGILE
KIDS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROSE I'M FROM
ROCKLAND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME'S KERR JEEP GRAND OUR
I'M FROM ROSEVILLE AN XRAY
TECHNOLOGIST MY WIFE IS A
PHARMACIST I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS A JESSE RECORDER
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA FATHER OF
ONE WIFE IS A REGISTERED NURSE
FOR KAISER RIGHT POSES BILL THE
USER.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHOI FRETS I
WORK WITH ARE CALIFORNIA DOCTORS
AND HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO CREATE
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA THROUGH THE
DEATH CERTIFICATE DATA CAPTURE.
AND I THINK THAT I I OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT SENSORS DOCTORS
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
PUBLIC HELP THEM.
THANKS SO MUCH.
MY NAME'S -- WILLIAM FRITZ AND
FROM SANTA ANA -- DOWN IN ORANGE
COUNTY -- I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS JONATHAN MAY
FROM A LEASE OF YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA.
WE MUST ALLOW DOCTORS TO MAKE
METAL THAT MEDICAL DECISION
THANK YOU SIR PRICING YOUR POSES.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS CRYSTAL MAY FAMILIES
AVAIL CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE HUMAN.
MY NAME IS JULIE THIS METHOD IT
SHOULD BE BETWEEN A DOCTOR AND A
PATIENT.
A NAME IS PHIL CLAYTON I'M FROM
SET YOUR SIGHTS CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
I BELIEVE IT'S BETWEEN PARENTS
AND DOCTORS THANK YOU SIR
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY.
HELLO -- MY NAME IS HEATHER
PADILLA WE'RE HERE FROM REDDING
CALIFORNIA AND OUR FAMILY
OPPOSES THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MAX THE SHOW COME
FROM SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR.
HI MY NAME IS LEAH WAS ON AN WE
HAVE EIGHT CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS ERICA KNOWING FROM
TRACY CALIFORNIA I AM THE MOTHER
OF SEVERAL MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILDREN WHO HAVE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS THAT WILL NOT BE
VALID UNDER THIS BILL I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER NO I'M
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD AND WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS PURE EVIL I
STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS A BY LIKE KOPPEL FROM
WOODLAND AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
I'M IS MARGIE DEFELICE I'M A
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT AND A
CALIFORNIA LICENSED MIDWIFE AND
I'VE SUPPORT THE PHYSICIAN.
UP PATIENT RELATIONS WITH YOUR
OPPOSE MA'AM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CRESCENTA.
IN PELICAN ON I'M FROM WOODLAND
CALIFORNIA I'M A ARE AND THEN
THE CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIFE.
I OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS MELISSA WOULD AND
I'M FROM SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA
AND SENATOR PAN I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU LOOK AT THE CDC WEBSITE AND
LOOK AT ADVERSE REACTIONS TO
VACCINES THANK.
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
HELLO MY NAME IS QASIM A GRANNY
I'M FROM SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA I
AM A MOTHER OF TWO AND MY
HUSBAND CAN BE HERE WE BOTH AND
FOR CHILDREN EVERYONE ELSE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DATE AND WOOD FROM
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL -- HEALTH IS A
CHOICE THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY.
HI MY NAME'S ERIN MCGREGOR I'M
HERE REPRESENTING MY HUSBAND AND
OUR DAUGHTER I BELIEVE THE
DOCTORS TO RETAIN THE RIGHTS TO
MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS WITHOUT
INTERFERENCE YOU I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS SUE BURROWS
THORPE I'M A RETIRED TEACHER.
AND SO ARE REPRESENT FOR MEMBERS
OF MY FAMILY WHO ARE FIXING
INSURANCE.
MY OLDER SIS AND CIVIL APATHY
FROM VACCINE INJURY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
RUSSELL CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
HI I'M -- ON THE DOCTORS ARE
CHEN I'M A PHYSICIAN FROM THE US
NUMBER COUNTY.
AND DIE I ALONG WITH HUNDRED
ABOUT THE POSITION FROM
CALIFORNIA OF FROM VISIT FOR FOR
CONSENT -- OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS IN A BIND RANKA
I'M A MOM OF THREE KIDS AND
NUMBER REGISTERED NURSE AND
APPLES THE BILL THE SEVENTY SIX
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS MAY CAL BONDARENKO --
FOR WEST SACRAMENTO ORIGINALLY
CAME FROM RUSSIA SOCIALIST
COUNTRY AND I DO NOT LIKE WHEN --
COUNTRIES TELL ME WHAT TO DO
WITH NOT TO ASSUME YOUR
PROFESSOR THANK YOU AYE OPPOSED
THE NEW.
TESTIMONY.
HI CHRISTINE ALEXANDER OF COLFAX
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS OLGA LITTLE ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M CHRISTINE SMITH FROM
LOS ANGELES I'M A SINGLE MOTHER
AND I DISAGREE WITH MANDATORY
APPLICATION OF ACT FAXING
ASSUMING OPPOSED THEM.
WAS A SPANK YOU FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION THANKS FOR COMING.
SERRA LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA.
RICHARD PAN ALL I CAN SAY IS MY
GENERATION COMING FOR YELLOW.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL.
CASES WE RESPECT í
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU SIR.
I AM QUITE A MASON FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
I AM JACK MASON I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I ST
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU MAN.
HEY I'M AMBER I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I'M A
TEACHER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL I FEEL LIKE THE PARENT
OF THAT PATIENT THE QUEUE OCT
RELATIONSHIP SHOULD BE COOPER
TESTIMONY.
HI I'M DILLON AND FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU DILLON.
HI MY NAME IS LAUREN NORRIS AND
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL OUR
BODIES ARE CHOICE THANK YOU NOT
THE CDC'S FINANCIAL GAINS CHOICE.
THE NEXT BIG CHOI.
THANK YOU.
I'M JOHN AND NORRIS --
SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE THIS THANK
YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS REINA CUEVAS AND A
MOTHER OF FOUR AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BRITTANY CHAVEZ I'M
FERMENT TAKE A CALIFORNIA I AM A
MOTHER OF THREE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE LIQUOR TO MOBILE
I'M FROM SECOND A COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK YOU.
NIKOLAJ CALL SOMEONE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS IAN FRY FROM
PLEASANTON CALIFORNIA.
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK
YOU SIR PAST I WILL HAVE TO
LEAVE THE THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
RESEARCH TESTIMONY.
HELLO MY NAME IS SAMANTHA MARTIN
ST.
FROM SANTA CLARITA CALIFORNIA.
AND I VERY VERY MUCH STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS DEVIN KIJKEN DAHLE
I'M A REGISTERED NURSE FOR
MODESTO MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND
I'M ALSO MOTHER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS LET ME LOOK TO SEE
AND GOT MY MOTHER OF FIVE KIDS
IN THE FIVE GRAND KIDS I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MAY.
NICK CLIFFORD SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
PLEASE DO YOUR HOMEWORK PLEASE
DO YOUR HOMEWORK THANK YOU SIR --
HELLO MY NAME IS YOUA IN A
NORMAL AND THEY HAVE A FOR KIDS
THREE OF THEM HAVE.
HAVE MEDICAL EXEMPTION AND ASK
YOU PLEASE -- OPPOSED HIS BILL
THANK THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARIE PEREZ MY
HUSBAND AND I ARE FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA.
WE LIVE IN DOCTOR PANS DISTRICT.
WE HAVE FIVE CHILDREN THREE
GRANDCHILDREN TO OUR VACCINE
INJURED WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY.
MY NAME IS TINA ARE DELIGHTED
AND I'M ALSO CUTS TO ENSURE THE
CONSTITUENTS OF DOCTOR PANS THE
MOTHER OF THREE CHILDREN
INCLUDING. ONE PERMANENTLY
VACCINE INJURED SON ALL THREE OF
pMY CHILDREN HAVE A MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS.
AND WE ICE MY HUSBAND AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING US ALL
SPEAK TODAY AND I HOPE THAT
YOU'LL HEAR SOMEBODY SAY.
THAT WE OPPOSE THE SPELL
HUMANITY LOAN FROM SUCH AS THANK
YOU -- BRENDAN MALONE FROM
CITRUS SITES I OPPOSE ANY BILL
THAT TAKES AWAY PERSONAL
FREEDOMS AND THAT INCLUDES THIS
BILL YOU SIR.
HI MERCEDES GERHARD FROM ALAMEDA
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
SERLING TO CHEAT -- I AM FROM
CASTRO VALLEY MIKE AND I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF BABA KASKI.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO I AM LEE SAYS A PART I'M
FROM ALAMEDA MY SON HAS A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS ACTED UPON A
FROM ALAMEDA MAY FROM THE
PURCHASE BILL THE HUMAN.
MY NAME'S LEXAN JOHNSTON I'M
FROM ICHMOND CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU MA'AM.
TEAMS JJ LAST BURKE SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY STRONGLY POSSIBLE THANK
YOU SIR.
THEY'RE A FIGUEROA SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS MELISSA ALVAREZ I AM
FROM FREMONT CALIFORNIA A
SENATOR BOB CAO SKIS
CONSTITUENTS ON I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK
YOU MA'AM.
MY HUSBAND HEARD ABOUT HER
PRESSURE FROM LAUGHLIN AND I
OPPOSE -- THIS BILL AND ANY --
MEDICAL CORPS ASIAN IN ALL ITS
FORMS THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS LISA MILLER AND I'M
FROM HOLLISTER CALIFORNIA I AM
FAXING INJURED AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS MATT ABOUT HELP FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA SEIZURES
SHOULD NOT BE NORMAL I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO I AM VERY BEYOND THIS
ADULT.
THIS BILL PLEASE JUST ADULTS AND
ADOLESCENTS THANK YOU.
I AM MAD MICHELLE TH<c.cyan> FROM</c>
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR HEARING US
OUT MY NAME IS WENDY BRAZIER
FROM ORANGE FAIL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
EXHORTATIONS.
HI HI MY NAME IS COREY BRAZIER
AND I'M FROM ORANGE FAIL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CORY.
A MAJOR CáC AN H. ORANGE VEIL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE I DO BELIEVE IT
INFRINGES APART PERSONAL CIRCUIT
RIGHT SIDE EIGHTY OUT WERE THE
UNIFORMS THANK YOU SIR
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY.
HELLO MY NAME IS CAMILLE CALLING
MY SON ATTENDS A PRIVATE
CHRISTIAN SCHOOL IN NEVADA CITY
CALIFORNIA AND THREE SEPARATE
DOCTORS HAVE TOLD ME NOT TO
VACCINATE HIM I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
CURRENT MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
PROTECT THE MEDICALLY FRAGILE IF
THIS BILL PASSES ONLY THE DEAD.
LOW TECH DID MY NAME IS JESSICA
GRIFFIN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES
THE BILL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DANIEL FATHER OF FIVE
I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL THANK
YOU AND HELLO MY NAME IS CHELSEA.
AND I HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER WHO
WAS INJURED BY VACCINES SO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
HI I'M KELLY LYDA FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS WE HAVE. TO FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT ARE INJURED FROM
THE MUSICIANS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS PENTIUM FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA I HAVE A
CHILD WHO HAS A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION AND A CHILD WHO DIED
FROM A VACCINE INJURY.
I ASKED A RICHARD PAN TO PLEASE
KEEP HIS PROMISE TO ALLOW.
A VIGOROUS VACCINE EXEMPTION.
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU OPPOSE THE GIVEN THE
CLAPPING PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS LAUREN AND I AM
FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS DEBBIE
I'M FROM PLEASANTON HOW MY BOYS
HERE EYES THEN SEBASTIAN AND AYE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL FINALLY
OPPOSE.
THANKS FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
HELLO MY NAME IS NIKKI I'M FROM
LIVERMORE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU MA'AM.
THIS ORIGINAL OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MEGHAN HARLOW I HAVE A DEGREE IN
ALTERNATIVE MEDICINE I'M FROM
GRASS VALLEY CALIFORNIA MOTHER
THREE AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEANETTE TARZI AN EMR
PRESENTING BUTTE COUNTY -- I AM
A VACCINE INJURED MOTHER OF TWO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I AM SLAVIA DAY FROM SAN MATTEO
AND I'M FOR MEDICAL FRIEDMAN
AGAINST IS OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS PHIL DAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I OPPOSE
ONE SIZE FITS ALL MEDICINE.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS GRACE ERICKSON I'M
PART OF NANCY SKINNER'S DISTRICT
AND I POSE THIS DANGEROUS AN
UNPRECEDENTED INTRUSION IN
TOWARD PAY YOU CAN MOUNT
RELIGION SEX FOR TESTIMONY.
MY NAME IS RUN AMOS I'M FROM
CLAYTON CALIFORNIA I AM A
BIOCHEMIST.
AND I HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT MY
DOCTOR MAKES HEALTHY AND CORRECT
CONNECTIONS THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS RAIN AMOS I AM
FROM ANY A CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M AIMS GREG REAVER I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY OPPOSES
BILL A MINUTE FUNCTIONAL
MEDICINE THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS ALLISON FRY
HENDERSON DISTRICT THIRTY NINE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS IN A BUNCH AND GO
FROM CITRUS HEIGHTS I'M A
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
WHEN MY NAME IS SLAVA THAT FROM
SUPERSIZED I'M JUST STONE
OPPOSED HIS BILL THANK YOU?
MY NAME IS MELISSA ALSOP I'M
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA IT'S
MY SECOND TIME HERE IN A MONTH I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IT'S AN OVER REACH A GUN YOU
MA'AM.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS ANNA
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO.
I MOTHER FOR IN A STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HELLO I'M LACEY SCOTT MOTHER OF
TWO I AM IMMUNE COMPROMISED SO I
DON'T OPPOSE VACCINES BUT I DO
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND HOW IT'S
WRITTEN FOR THE CONTRACT
OCCASION SECTION OF IT THANK YOU
MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS A RIGHT TO FAR AS
SOME FROM SAN JOSE AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE HUMAN.
HI MY NAME IS MERRY MONTH FAR AS
ON THE HOME SCHOOL MOTHER FROM
SAN JOSE ALTHOUGH THIS BILL
DOESN'T DIRECTLY AFFECT MY
FAMILY I DO FEEL THAT IT IS
WRONG AND THAT I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BELL BECAME.
MY NAME IS SKY DOYLE AND FROM
NAPA AND THIS IS MY SECOND TIME
HERE THIS MONTH I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY MOTHER OF TWO THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS HEATHER I'M HERE FROM
SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL I HAVE A CHILD WHO
SUFFERED SEIZURES ACTRESS FOR
MONTHS VACCINES SO I THANK YOU
EVEN MAXINE THANK YOU FOR
TESTIMONY.
HI MY NAME IS HARVEY ALL I COME
FROM SIRIUS I'M A MOM OF TWO
KIDS -- I TOTALLY UP WHAT WILL
POST THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MIGUEL IPHONE TO
CITIES AND I'LL POST.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR KAPLAN
OSBORNE AND I HAVE A FRIEND
WHO'S BABY DIED WITHIN. TWO
HOURS AFTER A VACCINE AND ALSO
MY STEP SON IS AUTISTIC WITHIN
HALF AN HOUR AFTER VACCINE.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
CONSIDER MERE OPPOSE THANK YOU
ANOTHER DOES MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS RAIN HANNAH AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CARE GRACE I'M FROM
REDDING CALIFORNIA I HAVE A
BROTHER WHO IS AUTISTIC BECAUSE
OF VACCINES THAT I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU IN THE MYSTERY
THRILLER AGNEW MOTHER OF THREE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RITA CURRENCY ANIMUS
CITIZEN OF CALIFORNIA AND MY
GRANDFATHER WAS A PEARL HARBOUR
SURVIVOR MY FATHER A MARINE
VETERAN COMBAT VETERAN.
AND I AM A RETIED US CENSUS GO
FIREFIGHTER PARAMEDIC I'VE SEEN
WAY TOO MANY SEIZURES IN THE
FIELD INCLUDING IN DOCTORS
OFFICES FROM YOUR POST I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHERS.
IN OPPOSITION LAST CALL.
SEEING NONE.
OF A CHAIR BEFORE WE BEGIN
QUESTIONS OF ASPEN PLEASE ALLOW
MY WITNESSES.
STATE TO BE AT THE FRONT OF
TAKES SOME OF WHICH IS HAVING A
SO THEY CAN DECIDE WHICH THREE
THE RIVER ON THE TABLE.
SENATORS -- THIS IS THE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS SENATOR [inaudible]
MONEY.
WHICH IS THAT YOU GOT THAT.
ONE I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MASS PHONE
AND RESPECTFUL HANDLING OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT MUCH APPRECIATED.
INTO THE AUTHOR -- DOCTOR PAN I
APPRECIATE -- YOUR EFFORTS TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS -- IN -- HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR YOU AND
THEN I THINK FOR SOME OF THE
WITNESSES.
NUMBER SIDES -- SEVERAL OF THE
WITNESSES SUGGESTED THAT THE
MEDICAL EXEMPTION WOULD BE
REMOVED.
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATION IS IT
YOUR INTENT TO REMOVE THE
MEDICAL.
EXEMPTION FORCE NOT AND WE'RE
PROTECTING THE MEDICAL EXEMPTION
I WOULD PROTECTING THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION FROM FRAUD.
BUT PROTECTING THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION FROM.
FORTUNATELY -- WE SEEN THIS
BEFORE HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
WHERE.
WE'D EXPECT AND ACTUALLY THE
VAST MAJORITY OF POSITIONS DO --
PRACTICE -- BASED ON THE BEST
SCIENCE BASED ON PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC PHONE FORTY WHAT WE'VE
SEEN AFTER TWO SEVEN SEVEN IS
THAT WE HAVE PHYSICIANS WHO ARE
REALLY TRYING TO MAKE MONEY.
BUT THEN.
HURTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH -- AND
THE ISSUE IS NOW AS WE HAVE
SCHOOLS WITH LARGE NUMBERS
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS AS I POINTED
OUT IN THE VOICE OF SAN DIEGO --
INVESTIGATION OF THE TOP WRITERS
AND MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS WERE
PEOPLE WHO WERE ADVERTISING FOR
THEM TO HAVE -- YOU KNOW THAT
THEIR CHALLENGES OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD -- THAT IS NOT WHAT WE
WANT WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO GENERALLY NEED TO ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO TRULY HAVE A
GENUINE MEDICAL EXEMPTION WE'LL
GET WE'LL HAVE THOSE AND THOSE
THOSE OF MEAT AND THEIR CHILDREN
NEED TO BE PROTECTED.
IN YOUR VIEW -- IS A GOOD
MEDICAL PRACTICE.
TO PROVIDE AN EXEMPTION WITHOUT.
MEETING WITH THE PATIENT.
CERTAINLY YOU SHOULD BE MEETING
WITH THE PATIENT ARE ACTS OF
REGIONAL EXPECTATION WOULD BE
THE CHILD'S PHYSICIAN WHO'D BE
DOING EVALUATION FOR THE
EXEMPTION THEY SHOULD.
CERTAINLY NOT BE SELLING THEM
AND WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS WE SEE
PHYSICIANS TOO MANY IN MY HEART
EVEN TEACHERS AS A FAMILY
PHYSICIANS.
WHO ARE BASICALLY ISSUING
MEDICAL EXAMS AS THE PATIENTS
THAT FOR THAT'S THE ONLY REASON
THEY'RE QUITE SEEN THEM?
FOR AND THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
SHOULD BE HAPPENING.
SO THANK YOU IN IN MY DISTRICT
FROM. THIRTY ONE SCHOOLS FALL
UNDER THE 95% VACCINATION RATE
SOME DRAMATICALLY BELOW THAT IS
CLOSE 70%.
FROM.
MY QUESTION I GUESS FOR THE
OPPONENTS FIRST AND THEN I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE
PROPONENTS -- FOR THE OPPONENTS
SOME IS THERE A PARENT IN THE
OPPONENTS GROUP.
NOW LET ME AS ONE OF THE DOCTORS
THEN -- IS IT FROM.
OKAY WELL AS PARENTS AS DOCTORS
[inaudible]
IS AN NINE THE IMMUNIZED CHILD.
SAFER IN A CLASSROOM WHERE OTHER
STUDENTS ARE IMMUNIZED.
WHERE IS SEEN NINE IMMUNIZE
STUDENT?
SAFER IN A CLASSROOM WHERE THE
OTHER STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
IMMUNIZED.
THAT'S MY QUESTION.
THE PLEASE AS THE QUESTION.
WELL I SEEN THAT BACKS.
TRANSACTION IS NOT ALWAYS A 100%
IF YOU LOOK AT AT THIS MOMENT A
LOT OF THE VACCINE.
SPREADING AT YOU KNOW IN IN THE
SCHOOLS -- NINETY FOUR IS THERE
ANY CIRCUMSTANCE I MEAN ASK IT
THIS WAY.
IS THERE ANY CIRCUMSTANCE.
IN WHICH AN NINE IMMUNIZE CHILD.
WOULD BE BETTER PROTECTED IN A
CLASSROOM WHERE THE OTHER
STUDENTS.
HAVE BEEN IMMUNIZED.
THAT CERTAINLY CAN BE TRUE AND
AT THE SAME TIME BUT MAJORITY OF
THE VACCINE THE MAJORITY THE
DISEASES THAT ARE SPREADING
RIGHT NOW THE SCHOOLS.
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
IMMUNIZATION RATES.
BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE A NINETY
SIX POINT 5% IMMUNIZATION RATE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE WHAT WEST
LIKE HARVARD YOU KNOW --
PROCESSES OUTBREAK 1100% OF ALL
THE CHILDREN.
HAD FULL IMMUNIZATION AND THE
EIGHTEEN STUDENTS THAT WERE NOT
UNIONIZED DID NOT.
CATCH THE DISEASE SO AT THAT YOU
KNOW TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT THAT YOU ARE IMMUNIZED
OR NOT EVEN AS MANY TIMES.
WHETHER REGARDLESS OF YOUR
VACCINE STATUS.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THAT.
THAT THAT PROTECTION IS THERE
THANK YOU WE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
PARENTS TODAY.
WHO TOOK PRIDE IN THE FACT THAT
THEIR CHILDREN WERE NOT
IMMUNIZED -- WITH THEIR CHILDREN
BE AT GREATER RISK IF THEY
TRAVELED TO A DEVELOPING NATION
WHERE THERE WAS AN EPIDEMIC OF
PROTESTS THIS OF POLIO.
YOU HEARD FROM A LOT OF CHILDREN
AND PARENTS TODAY THAT HAVE
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN THAT
WOULD BE AT RISK.
SO THERE ARE LOTS OF PLACES
AROUND THE WORLD.
THAT THEN IT IN ME IMMUNIZATIONS
RATES COULD BE VERY VERY LOW AND
SPEAKING OF SOMEONE GETTING --
INFECTION BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE UNITED STATES.
SO WE HAD IT IN HIS READING HIGH
LEVEL ICE OF THE IMMUNIZATION
AND BUT THAT'S THE WELL IT'S
EVEN WITH HIGH LEVELS OF
IMMUNIZATIONS.
NONE OF THE INFECTIONS NOT OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW ACTUALLY HAPPENING YOU
KNOW.
IN THE SCHOOLS IF YOU LOOK AT
THE DISNEYLAND IT WAS ALL NOTS
WITHIN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
NOT A 85% OF THE MONTHS CASES
THAT YOU HAVE SEEN IN THE UNITED
STATES HAVE BEEN.
RAINY NIGHT STE SO SO WHAT'S
CLEAR IS THAT YOU'RE NOT JUST AT
RISK IN A CLASSROOM YOU CAN BE
AT RISK AT DISNEYLAND -- ON AN
AIRPLANE OR ON A BUS IS THAT
TRUE.
LET ME LET ME DEFER TO THE OTHER
DOCTOR BECAUSE I THINK YOU
WANTED.
TO OFFER A COMMENT YEAH I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT I I DON'T THINK
WHAT'S ON THE TABLE TODAY IS
WHETHER OR NOT VACCINES.
ARE VALUABLE BECAUSE THEY VERY
CLEARLY AREN'T BEING IMMUNIZED
IS VALUABLE.
BUT WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT IS --
ATTEMPTING TO VACCINATE A VERY
SMALL PERCENT OF THE POPULATION
WHO ARE MEDICALLY FRAGILE AND
WHO CAN HAVE SERIOUS REACTIONS
RELATED TO THAT.
AND SO THE AND IT ISN'T GOING TO
CHANGE THE OVERALL HERD IMMUNITY
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND IN OUR
CLASSROOMS IT WON'T AFFECT THE
RATE OF EPIDEMICS THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING.
IN MEASLES BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING IN SCHOOL CLASSROOMS.
RELATED WHEN WHEN YOU LOW HEARD
OF MUNITY THANK YOU WHEN YOU
HAVE A CLASSROOM THAT HAS 70%.
OR LESS IMMUNIZATION DOES THAT
POSE A RISK OF A CONSTITUENT
ABSENT A CRIME SO RUDELY IT THEY
HAVE AN IMMUNE COMPROMISED CHILD.
THEY WOULD LIKE THEIR CHILD TO
ATTEND THE PUBLIC SCHOOL THERE
FEARFUL OF THAT CHILD
CONTRACTING A POTENTIALLY FATAL.
DISEASE BASED ON A LOW LEVEL OF
IMMUNIZE STUDENTS IN THE
CLASSROOM ABSOLUTELY I THINK
THAT A CHILD WHO IS ON IMMUNIZED
WILL BE PROTECTED BY HAVING A
HIGHER IMMUNIZED.
RATE IN THEIR CLASSROOM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE PROPONENT.
YES I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO
THAT -- AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIAL BOWS AND SEVEN CISCO
COUNTY TALKING AND COLLEAGUES
ACROSS THE STATE.
I HAVE SEEN CLUSTERS OF UNPACKS
OF HIGHER RATES A WHOOPING COUGH
IN SCHOOLS WITH LOW VACCINATION
RATES.
AND I ALSO AM VERY CONFIDENT
THAT THE UNDER VACCINATION
CLUSTERS ARE WHAT'S DRIVING THE
CURRENT OUTBREAK THE CURRENT
INCREASING MEASLES IN THE
COUNTRY AND IN THE STATE.
AND THERE WAS SOME TESTIMONY
EARLIER THAN -- WE DON'T HAVE.
EVIDENCE OF FATALITIES FROM THE
MEASLES WHAT ARE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH RISKS OF MEASLES.
BUT AGAIN I A WOOD RESTATED IN
THOUGH ONE OF THE PUBLIC DISMAY
WITH ONE IN A THOUSAND CANYON
AND SOCIALITE AS WHICH IS A
BRAIN INFECTION OR DEATH.
THERE'S AN ISRAELI FLIGHT
ATTENDANT RIGHT NOW IS IN A COMA
FROM -- THERE'S A LARGE OUTBREAK
IN ISRAEL RIGHT NOW WHICH IS
ALSO DRIVING UNDER.
VACCINATED POPULATIONS IN NEW
YORK STATE -- AND AGAIN IT'S ONE
OF THOSE AND I KNOW THAT IN NEW
YORK CITY RIGHT NOW IT WAS
ACTUALLY OVER A WEEK OR TWO AGO
THEY SAID THERE ARE FIVE
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT.
MEASLES CASES SO THE VERY
SERIOUS DISEASES AS A HIGH
FIDELITY RATE FOR INFECTIONS IS
PREVENTABLE.
IN A CHILD WHO'S NOT.
YET.
THE APPROPRIATE AGE FOR MEASLES
VACCINATION BE PUT AT RISK IF.
YES BECAUSE TYPICALLY.
INFANTS TO NOT GET VACCINATED
UNTIL TWELVE TO FIFTEEN MONTHS
OF AGE SO THOSE ARE THE ONES WHO
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO PROTECT.
THANK YOU AND IF I COULD MISTER
CHAIR.
JUST TO COUPLE FINAL QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR.
I THINK THERE'S SOME CONFUSION
AS TO WHAT YOUR BILL.
DOES AND DOESN'T DO AND I'D LIKE
TO JUST ASK HOW DOES A FAMILY
WHO.
HAS A HISTORY IN THEIR FAMILY --
OF LET'S SAY -- A COMPROMISE
CHILD AND THEN A SIBLING IS BORN
THEY'RE WORRIED.
ABOUT THE HEALTH OF THAT.
NEW BORN ON UNDER YOUR BILL.
WHAT IS AVAILABLE TO THAT FAMILY
TO PROTECT THE HEALTH OF A
NEWBORN OR THERE'S HISTORY IN
THE FAMILY?
OF IMMUNE REACTION OF
IMMUNIZATION REACTION -- AND SO
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS IS THAT THE
PHYSICIAN -- WOULD -- FIVE FOUR
IF.
THE CHILD IS AT RISK.
IN THE FOR RECEIVING A
VACCINATION -- WHEN THEY
APPROACH SCHOOL AGE ALTHOUGH
OFTENTIMES SO HAVE THE CONDITION
AND WAY BEFORE THEY ENTER SCHOOL --
THEY CAN THEY WOULD FILE A
REQUEST TO THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HOUSE.
WHICH SHOULD BE REVIEWED AND
THEY WOULD BE REVIEWING IT BASED
ON THE SCIENCE THAT'S WHAT THE
CDC ACIP RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
BASED ON I WOULD BE NOTE THAT WE
WOULD NOT BE THE FIRST STATE TO
DO THIS THE STATE OF WEST
VIRGINIA HAS BEEN DOING THIS
SUCCESSFULLY.
THEY'VE NOT HAD ANY PROBLEMS --
WITH PEOPLE WHO NEED TO TRULY
GET JET MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS TO
GET THOSE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS --
SO THAT WE WHAT WE NEED TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE WHO REALLY
THE CHILDREN WHO REALLY DO NEED
TO MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS BECAUSE
THEY CAN IF THEY CAN HAVE THE
SAFETY VACCINATED.
AS YOU POINTED OUT WE NEED TO BE
SURE THAT THE OTHER KIDS AROUND
THEM ARE SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
THEM PROTECTED AND THAT THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL REALLY IS ABOUT.
THANK YOU AND THEN ACTUALLY I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE MOTHER WHO
TESTIFIED EARLIER -- YOU HAVE I
BELIEVE AN IMMUNE COMPROMISED
CHILD.
YES IN WHAT AGE IS YOUR CHILD IS
TWO YEARS OLD.
AND I THINK IN YOUR TESTIMONY
YOU SAID YOU WOULD.
LIKE HIM TO BE ABLE TO ATTEND
PUBLIC SCHOOLS [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
AND WHAT WOULD IT TAKE FOR YOU
TO HAVE THE CONFIDENCE.
THAT YOUR CHILD COULD SAFELY
ATTEND.
A PUBLIC SCHOOL -- JUST THE
HEALTH OF OTHERS THAT FAT PEOPLE
IMMUNIZE THEIR KIDS AND THAT I
DON'T YOU KNOW HE CAN'T HAVE
THESE LIVE VACCINES AS MEASLES
AND AND CHICKEN POX AND SO THOSE.
THOSE DISEASES ARE DEADLY TO MY
SON -- THEY PUT IN AUTOMATICALLY
IN THE HOSPITAL AND THERE'S
HARDLY ANY SURVIVAL RATE FROM IT
SO -- I NEED I NEED TO BE SURE
THAT THE KIDS IN THE SCHOOL ARE
IMMUNIZED.
WOULD YOU SEND YOUR CHILD TO A
SCHOOL WHERE FEWER THAN 70% OF
THE CHILDREN WERE IMMUNIZED.
ABSOLUTELY NOT THANK YOU -- IN A
I JUST GONNA CLOSE WITH A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS AGAIN.
I RESPECT EVERYBODY HERE TODAY
PROPONENTS OPPONENTS.
THE OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL
THEY'RE PASSIONATE AND THEIR
PASSIONATE BECAUSE THEY CARE
ABOUT THE HEALTH OF THEIR
CHILDREN.
THEY CARE ABOUT.
THE HEALTH OF THEIR FAMILIES
[inaudible]
BUT ARGUING THAT YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT IS BEING
VIOLATED.
WHEN THE STATE SEEKS TO REGULATE?
VACCINATIONS TO PROTECT.
BROADER COMMUNITIES THAT'S WHERE
THE INDIVIDUAL CHOICE IS NOT
JUST AN INDIVIDUAL CHOICE.
WE WENT THROUGH THIS WITH.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN PEOPLE ARGUED I
SHOULD BE ABLE TO CHOOSE WHAT I
WANT FOR MY CHILD [inaudible]
YES.
UNTIL THAT CHOICE.
INTERFERES WITH THE POTENTIAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF MY CHILD OR
MY GRANDCHILD AND THAT'S WHERE
OUR JOB HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
IS TO TRY TO THREAD THE NEEDLE
IN FIND A WAY THAT PRESERVES
YOU'RE RIGHT TO PRESERVE YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR PHYSICIAN.
TO ENGAGE YOUR PHYSICIAN GET HER
OR HIS BEST ADVICE.
AND THEN AS NECESSARY SEEK A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
S. AS WELL FOUNDED IN SCIENCE
BUT TO USE PERSONAL CHOICE AND
USE THE DOCTORS EXEMPTION AS A
WAY TO FULFILL.
PERSONAL CHOICE THAT MIGHT PUT
OTHER CHILDREN AT RISK.
IS WHERE FOR ME IT CROSSES THE
LINE.
YEAR RIGHT TO YOUR CHOICE SHOULD
NOT.
INTERFERE WITH THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
CONVERSATION I'M SORRY TO TAKE
TIME MY CALL WE'VE BEEN HERE FOR
A LONG TIME I FIGURE.
THIS DESERVES OUR FULL ATTENTION
AND CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THAT ARE RUNNING
CENTER MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND LET ME
THANK YOU -- SENATOR STONE --
FOR YOUR COLUMN -- MANAGEMENT OF
THE LE HEARING TODAY YOU KNOW
WE'VE HAD A WEEK FULL OF BOB
VERY EMOTIONAL TESTIMONY AN
EMOTIONAL BILLS AND EVERYTHING
FROM POLICE TRANSPARENCY -- TO
THIS BILL -- ON THAT'S WHAT WHY
WE'RE HERE AND IT'S ALWAYS
IMPORTANT AND A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR RESIDENTS OF THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD TO ENGAGE IN BE PRESENT
THIS PROCESS SO I APPRECIATE
THAT.
I ALSO APPRECIATE -- THE
CIVILITY LARGELY THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO ENGAGE ON AND SO I
APPRECIATE THANK YOU I THINK THE
SERGEANTS FOR HELPING TO MANAGE
THE PROCESS.
SO WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE SEEN -- TO THE PUBLIC TODAY
HAVE THE UP TO BE SAME.
AS I LISTEN VERY CLOSELY TO THE
OPPOSITION. ONE THING THAT
STRUCK ME.
AND PERHAPS IT'S AN ISSUE OF
SEMANTICS BUT I THINK THE DANGER.
IN US GETTING LOST IN SEMANTICS
IS I THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
VERY DIFFERENT POPULATIONS.
AND SO IF.
THROUGH THE CHAIR WHOEVER SO
CHOOSES ON THE PANEL COULD.
WALK ME THROUGH THIS WE HAVE
HEARD.
REFERENCES TO MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILDREN.
IMMUNE COMPROMISED CHILDREN
VACCINE COMPROMISE CHILDREN AND
VACCINE HARM TO CHILDREN AND I'M
CLEAR THAT THOSE ARE ALL THE
SAME POPULATION.
SO A MOMENT AGO YOU SAID -- THAT
THE PERCENTAGE -- YOU TALK ABOUT
IT WAS A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN
[inaudible]
AND SO [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
IMPACTS WHICH OF THOSE
POPULATIONS FOR TALKING ABOUT
CHILDREN WHO WERE ALREADY
TRAGICALLY BEEN VACCINE HARM.
I GUESS THERE'S AN ASSUMPTION
THAT OTHER CHILDREN THE FAMILY
COULD ALSO BE SUSCEPTIBLE BUT
CAN WE TALK ABOUT.
HOW DO YOU DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
OF POPULATIONS ALL REPEAT
MEDICALLY FRAGILE BECAUSE ALL
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN?
ARE.
THE AXING COMPROMISED
[inaudible]
CORRECT.
IF YOU YOU WE JUST SAW OVER
PROBABLY A THOUSAND DIFFERENT
PEOPLE COMING FROM.
I SAW THE LEGENDS YES DIFFERENT
CULTURES I SAW THEM.
SO EVERYONE HERE HAS A STORY AND
IT IS THE DOCTOR PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP TO UNDERSTAND THAT
STORY CAN YOU DEFINE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE FOR ME
PLEASE.
PHONE.
SO WHEN YOU SAVE MEDICAL FRAGILE
BURST THROUGH THE MAY BE VERY
SIMILAR DEPENDING ON WHAT CRYING
I'M CLEAR THAT I OPENED THE MAIN
DOOR LET ME START OVER AGAIN LET
ME START OVER.
I'M CLEAR THAT SEMANTICS PEOPLE
MAY BE USING TERMINOLOGY
INTERCHANGEABLY I'M CLEAR ABOUT
THAT BASED ON THE TESTIMONY THAT
I LISTEN.
TO MY QUESTION TO YOU AS A
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL IT'S CAN
YOU DEFINE AND DEFINE DOWN AND
HELP.
US ALL DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN THE
TERMS THIS IS THE SHEET THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE IF YOU LOOK YOU KNOW
ON THE RIGHT SIDE.
THESE ARE NON COUNTRY INDICATED.
CONDITIONS THAT ANY ONE OF US
THIS IS ISSUE THAT WAS ALLUDING
TO A MINE YOU KNOW DURING MY
TESTIMONY SO HOPEFULLY YOU'LL
HAVE IT IF NOT WE'LL GIVE HIM TO
YOU.
ANY OF THESE CONDITIONS SOMEONE
WHO MAY HAVE CREE EMBRACE
SYNDROME I HAVE PATIENTS OF MINE.
WHO HAD SEIZURES DURING THE
FIRST?
IN A VACCINE AND YOU KNOW WITH
MOST MEASLES RUBELLA FOR EXAMPLE.
AND THAT IS A MAJOR MEDICAL IN A
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILD SO NOW.
THAT CHILD IS SIBLING MAY HAVE A
ONE IN.
TWO HUNDRED YOU KNOW ONE AND TWO
HUNDRED RISK OF HAVING SEIZURES
AND SOME OF THOSE SEIZURES CAN
BECOME EPILEPSIES.
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF PATIENTS
HERE TODAY A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE ONE CHILD THAT HAS BEEN.
MEDI MEDICALLY INJURED.
AND IF THEY HAVE ANY OF THESE
CONDITIONS HERE WILL NOW BE
EXCLUDED.
FROM THIS BILL WHICH PREVIOUSLY
A DOCTOR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP.
COULD STATE THAT THIS IS.
A MEDICAL.
NO AT A CHILD THAT HAVE HAS HAD
A IN TRAUMA.
THESE KIDS CAN BEING MEDICALLY
INJURED OR MEDICALLY FRAGILE
THANK YOU AND IT IS OUR JOBS
THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU
COULD NOT ON ALL OF US MAYBE I'M
NOT BEING CLEAR BUT I I'M.
I'M NOT GETTING THE ANSWER I'M
LOOKING FOR BUT THANK YOU I GOT
THE LIST NOW -- DOCTOR PAN HOW
DO YOU RESPOND. TO THE I BELIEVE
IT MAY HAVE BEEN THE FIRST
OPPONENT WHO TALKED ABOUT.
ON WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE FOR A MINUTE PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL.
AND THEIR OPINION IF YOU WILL TO
FOR THE LACK OF A BETTER TERM
TRUMP.
A CHILD [inaudible]
PHYSICIAN'S RECOMMENDATION SO
pPLEASE THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH
FOR THAT QUESTION SIR MITCHELL I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT THE
GRANTING OF A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
IS ACTUALLY TRULY PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNCTION.
IT'S NOT THE DIAGNOSIS OR
TREATMENT OF A PATIENT SO I
WOULD POINT OUT IS THAT ALTHOUGH
THIS IS OFTEN UP SICK KID -- BY
THE OPPONENTS OF POST THIS BILL
AND FOR USE IT.
TO SEVEN SEVEN IS THAT NO CHILD
WILL GIVE VACCINATED AGAINST
THEIR PARENTS CONSENT.
THAT NEVER HAPPENS.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT THE
CHILD THE FATE PARENT BRINGS A
CHILD TO THE PHYSICIAN.
THEY'LL HAVE A DISCUSSION -- THE
POSITION AND THEIR TEAM WILL
PRESENT THE INFORMATION OF THE
VACCINE THE PARENT WILL DECIDE.
WILL DECIDE WHERE TO GET CHILD
VACCINATED OR NOT VACCINATED.
THAT'S A DECISION THE PARENTS
THAT'S A CURRENT LAW AS I TURNED
WILL NOT CHANGE THAT WILL NOT
CHANGE UNDER THIS BILL DO NOT
CHANGE WITH TWO SEVEN SEVEN WILL
NOT CHANGE WITH THIS BILL.
RIGHT SO THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT TO POSE A PARENT CHOOSES
NOT TO VACCINATE THEIR CHILD.
RIGHT THERE'S A CONSEQUENCES.
AND THE CONSEQUENCES NOT BECAUSE
STEP PARENT MADE THAT CHOICE THE
CONSEQUENCES TO PROTECT THE
OTHER CHILDREN.
THAT'S WHY IN TWO SEVEN SEVEN AM
I WANT TO READ LITIGATE TWO
SEVEN SEVEN HERE BUT I JUST I
POINT OUT WE GAVE PEOPLE OPTIONS
THAT'S WHY THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE SAID THERE'S OPTIONS
FOR WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU DON'T
CHOOSE NOT TO VACCINES YOU CAN
STILL GET YOUR CHILD.
EDUCATED GET A PUBLIC EDUCATION
SO FORTH BUT BUT WE HAVE TO
PROTECT CHILDREN LIKE.
MY WITNESSES HERE WHERE YOU AVE
A CHILD WHO CANNOT TO BE
VACCINATED SO THEN THE ISSUES
THAT WE SAID OKAY FINE OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTION YOU CAN GO TO
SCHOOL.
BUT THAT MEDICAL EXEMPTION -- IF
IT'S NOT VALID WE END UP WITH
SCHOOLS WITH MEDICAL ATTENTION
RATES OF 30% 40% FIFTY FROM
THAT'S NOT REALISTIC I THAT
THAT'S THOSE ARE NOT REAL
EXEMPTIONS UNLESS IT'S A SCHOOL
FULL OF CHILDREN WHO HAVE.
CANCER ARE HAVE TRANSPLANTS OR
SOME OTHER PROBLEM AND THAT THEN
PUTS THOSE CHILDREN AT RISK
AGAIN AND THAT'S THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPAIRED AND THAT IS WHY.
BY THE WAY THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AMERICAN
KHAKI APTRIX YOU'VE HEARD
DISCOUNT COUNTY CHILDREN SPECIAL
TEACHER COALITION THOSE ARE
PEDIATRIC SUB SPECIALISTS WHO
SPECIALIZE IN TAKING CARE OF
MALCOLM MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILDREN DEBT TO THE TAKE CARE
ALL OF CCS KIDS.
RIGHT THE KIDS WHO ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND THEY'RE STANDING
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL BECAUSE
THEY KNOW IT'S THEIR PATIENTS
ARE MOST AT RISK WHEN WE LET
THESE FAKE MEDICAL EXCEPTIONS
HAPPEN.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING IS WE NEED PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENE TO SAY THAT WHAT WE
NEED TO SORT OUT THE PEOPLE WHO
GENUINELY NEED MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS FROM THOSE WHO DONT
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE A
HANDFUL OF PHYSICIANS.
WHO ARE BASICALLY GRANTING
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS AND
APPROPRIATELY AND -- THAT AND
ACTUALLY PERSONALLY ACTUALLY
PROFITING FROM IT YOU CAN SEE --
SO THIS THIS IS PUTTING PATIENTS
IN DANGER AND PARTICULARLY THOSE
MEDICALLY FRAGILE PATIENTS AND
THAT'S WHY.
THE PHYSICIANS ARE ASKING FOR
THIS BILL THE VERY PHYSICIANS
ARE OFTEN HERE SAYING WE NEED TO
PROTECT THE PATIENT DOCTOR
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE NEED TO
RELATIONSHIP.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE SAYING
BECAUSE AND WE NEED THIS BILL TO
BE SURE THAT WE DON'T HARM
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THAT MY
PATIENT CO ON TAKING CARE OF IS
ACTUALLY GONNA GET PROTECTED.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE YOU KNOW
THE TRUE GOAL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OF PREVENTION AS OPPOSED TO
REACTING AFTER THE FACT I MEAN
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
IT'S TOO IT'S TO PROTECT US AND
THEN REACTS AFTER THE FACT WHEN
WE HAVEN'T DONE A VERY GOOD JOB
ON THE FRONT END -- TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONAL ARE
CAN YOU GIVE ME OTHER EXAMPLES
NGUYEN.
KIND OF A CONCERN AROUND BROADER
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY PUBLIC
SAFETY -- PROCEEDS INDIVIDUAL
CHOICE.
A WILLOWS PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS
AND OFFICIALS -- THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE WE WILL
ACTUALLY ISSUE ILLEGAL ORDER FOR
ISOLATION FOR EXAMPLE SO IF WE
HAVE.
A PATIENT WITH TUBERCULOSIS THAT
IS INFECTIOUS WE WILL.
GENTLY ISSHIN ORDERS OF THAT
PERSON CAN BE TREATED AND MAKE
SURE THAT PERSON IS TREATED AND
NO LONGER INFECTIOUS TO THE
PUBLIC.
WE ALSO HAVE STORIES TO EXCLUDE
ACTUALLY [inaudible]
PEOPLE FROM.
A CERTAIN SITUATIONS SO CHILD
CARE'S AND WE HAVE HAD TO AGAIN
IN THESE MEASLES OUTBREAKS THAT
ARE ON GOING NOW.
WE SOMETIMES HAVE EXPOSED
INFANTS FROM AN AIRLINE FLIGHT
OR FROM BEING IN A WAITING ROOM
IN A CLINIC WHO'S BEEN EXPOSED
TO MEASLES CASES THEY'RE TOO
YOUNG TO BE VACCINATED.
AND THEN THEY ACTUALLY WE TRY TO
GET THEM POST EXPOSURE
PREVENTION THAT'S PART OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH ROLE SO WE GIVE
THEM AN ANTIBODY TO HELP PREVENT
THEM FROM.
GETTING MEASLES BUT THEN THEY
ALSO NEED TO BE KEPT AWAY
BECAUSE THE INCUBATION PERIOD
CAN BE A WEEK TO THREE WEEKS
LATER.
AND WE DON'T WANT -- PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT BE INCUBATING MEASLES TO
BE OUT THERE THAT'S WHAT WE DO
INPUBLIC HEALTH TO TRY TO
CONTAIN THE DISEASE.
SO THOSE ARE SITUATIONS WHERE WE
TRIED A WE EXCLUDE PEOPLE FROM
WORK SOMETIMES WHEN YOU DO SO
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE FOOD
HANDLERS ARE IN YOU.
THROUGH THAT COULD BE
CONTAMINATED RIGHT OR THAT THEY
HAVE TV OR WHATEVER -- GETTING
BACK TO MY POINT SO SO THIS LIST
THE TOP SAYS VACCINE REACTIONS
SO THESE ARE REACTIONS PEOPLE
MAY HAVE ONCE VACCINATED.
AND SO THAT IS SEPARATE FROM A
CHILD WHO MAY BE BORN MEDICALLY
FRAGILE BORN WITH A COMPROMISED
IMMUNE SYSTEM BORN WITH
UNDERDEVELOPED LUNGS ECCENTRIC
SETTER.
SO DOCTOR PAN ON THIS LIST WELL
THE PHILLIES ARE REACTIONS.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT AND THE
REASON I'M SAYING.
AND WE'RE COMBINING.
ALL OF THESE EXPERIENCES IN TWO
ONE RATIONALE ABOUT OPPOSING THE
BILL.
IN A PROPERLY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE -- WE HEARD
WITNESSES SAY -- THAT THEIR
CURRENT MEDICAL EXEMPTION. FOR
WHATEVER REASON WHETHER THE BABY
WAS MEDICALLY FRAGILE -- HAS IS
IMMUNE COMPROMISED HAS HAD A
PATH REACTION HOWEVER THEY
DEFINED IT WOULD NOT QUALIFY
UNDER.
TWO SEVEN SIX IS THAT --
ACCURATE.
THAT IS NOT ENTIRELY ACCURATE I
THINK WHAT I WOULD SAY IS IS
THAT.
PLEASE PLEASE ACTIONS AT IN MY
OPENING PRESENTATION.
DISK LEADERS TO PHASES OF THE
BILL FOR THE FIRST PHASES WE ARE
ASKING THAT EVERY MEDICAL
EXEMPTION THAT HAS BEEN GRANTED
UP TO DATE AND MAYBE FOR THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS BECAUSE THERE
SOMETIME FOR IMPLEMENTATION WILL
BE AROUND THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE.
FILED WITH THE PART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH -- THE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT NECESSARILY HALF WITH
DAVID ON MAC WOULD BE ACTUALLY
BE IN PLACE WE WOULD GIVE THE
AUTHORITY FOR THE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFTEN COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER -- TO REVIEW TO
POTENTIALLY INVALIDATE ONES THAT
ARE INAPPROPRIATE THAT PUTS
PUBLIC HEALTH A RISK BECAUSE
AND FORTUNE WE KNOW THERE ARE
MANY THAT FORTY MAY NOT
NECESSARILY BE APPROPRIATE --
BUT THERE'S NO ACTUAL
REQUIREMENT THE PUBLIC HEALTH GO
THROUGH ALL OF THE THAT BACKLOG
BUT NOW REMOVING FORD IN A
COUPLE YEARS WE WOULD HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IS A PHYSICIAN WOULD THAT APPLY.
TO THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND WITH THE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE PATIENT -- TH AT AND AGAIN
MAINTAINING THE PATIENT PRIVACY
LAWS AND THEN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER WOULD DECIDE WHETHER TO
APPROVE OR DENY THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS WEST VIRGINIA AND
THERE'S EVEN APPEAL PROCESS.
IN CASE OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER NIGHT TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION TO ENSURE THAT THERE
THAT THIS DECISION IS MADE IN
THE MOST.
APPROPRIATE WAY AND ALSO YOU
KNOW WE REALLY WANT TO GIVE --
INVITE A LATITUDE AS POSSIBLE
WE'RE WE'RE IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S TRULY IS AN ISSUE RIGHT
WITH -- THAT WITH -- WITH
VACCINES IN THOSE THEY REALLY
DESERVE MEDICAL EXEMPTION I
THINK IN FACT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CDC GUIDELINES WHICH ARE BASED
ON EVIDENCE.
THEY ACTUALLY TEND TO LEAN
TOWARD WELL IF IT'S POSSIBLY
MIGHT EVEN WHATEVER THEN -- WILL
PUT A PRECAUTION ON THEIR
IMPACTS OF THIS A PRECAUTIONS IN
CONTRADICTION SO WE ACTUALLY
WANNA GIVE AS MUCH LATITUDE BUT
ULTIMATELY WE ALSO RECOGNIZE WE
NEED TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND
WE DON'T WANT OUTBREAKS SO WHAT
WE CAN'T HAVE IS -- I MEAN SOME
OF THE THINGS ON YOUR HAIR LOSS.
OKAY IS CURRENTLY ONE OF THE
VACCINE REACTIONS LISTED ON YOUR
CELLULITIS WHICH IS AN INFECTION
OF THE SKIN.
ARE YOU COULD GET SO LIES FROM
INJECTION BUT IT'S PROBABLY NOT
REALLY AND AND THERE'S NO.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE --
AND THE RESEARCH HAS BEEN DONE I
MEAN YOU'VE HEARD ACTUALLY SOME
OF THE PEOPLE SAID MY CHILD HAS
AUTISM AND THAT'S OUR VIçT
EXENE REACTION THAT'S BEEN
DEBUNKED THAT'S BEEN DISPROVEN
AND THROUGH MULTIPLE STUDIES
MOST RECENTLY IN A STUDY THOSE
UNIDEN MARKET IS A GERMAN PLAYER
TO ACTUALLY SHOW.
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
UNVACCINATED WERE MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE BOXES AND THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE VACCINATED I MEAN IT WASN'T
SPECIFICALLY SIGNIFICANT BUT
THAT'S WHAT THE RAW NUMBERS
SHOWED.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO BASE OUR
EVIDENCE OUR OUR DECISIONS ON
SCIENCE AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS
IS NOT TO GET EVERYONE
VACCINATED BUT TO BE SURE WE
PROTECT THE PUBLIC TO PROTECT
THE MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND
THAT'S WHAT THE PURPOSES BILLS.
FOR SO SO HELP ME -- THE
GRANDFATHERING IN IS THAT --
SILENT IN THE BILL AND THEREFORE
THAT'S WHAT WOULD HAPPEN OR IS
THERE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
TALKS ABOUT THE FACT THAT YOU
WERE GRANDFATHERED IN SO WHAT
THE BILL SAYS IS THAT IF YOU
HAVE AN EXISTING MEDICAL
EXEMPTION YOU FILE IT WITH
APARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH ONE THE
REASONS.
WE ASK THAT IS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
THEY GO TO THE SCHOOL AND
THEY'RE NOT ACTUALLY AVAILABLE
TO THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT EXCEPT
AS WITH THE NAMES REDACTED SO
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT -- IF
THERE'S AN OUTBREAK WE ACTUALLY
SAW THIS HAPPENED LAST YEAR IN
THE BAY AREA.
THERE'S AN OUTBREAK AND AND THE
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
DON'T KNOW WHO HASN'T BEEN
VACCINATED IN THE SCHOOL.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET ACCESS TO
WHO EXACTLY WHO HAS WHO'S BEEN
VETS WHO HAS A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
OKAY SO WE WE NEED THAT
INFORMATION FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
PURPOSES.
FAMILY HELP YES EXACTLY AS
COMMUNITY OF THE FAMILY TO HELP
THEM TO BE SURE THAT -- WE WE
PROTECT THE CHILDREN WHO HAVEN'T
BEEN INFECTED YET AND GET IN AND
GET THEM RE TRY TO REMOVE THEM
FROM OUR OKAY SO I SEE THE
LANGUAGE YOU'RE AFTER THE
STATEWIDE STANDARDIZED MEDICAL
EXEMPTION REQUEST FORM.
DEVELOP.
PURSUANT TO SECTION IS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR USE AN EXEMPTION
PREVIOUSLY ISSUE INTO THE
SUBDIVISION IS VALID ONLY THE
PAIR TO GUARD HAS COMPLIED.
HAS COMPLIED WITH PARAGRAPH TO
SAID WITH THAT SECTION.
OKAY -- REMINDING ASKED THE
QUESTION WITH REGARD TO FAMILY
MEDICAL HISTORY.
THE IF THERE IS A PARENT OR
CHILD -- THAT HAS HAD.
A REACTION THAT THEY WHAT.
SO D. AS AGAIN THE THE CDC --
ADVISER COMMUNITY MUSICIAN
PRACTICES NOW THEY LOOK AT THE
SCIENCE AND THEY DETERMINED I
COULDN'T HE WAS ACTUALLY AT RISK
BECAUSE IDEALLY WHAT HAPPENS WE
DON'T ADMINISTER A VACCINE TO A
CHILD. TO WOULD BE AT RISK RIGHT
WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE WAIT FOR
SOMETHING BAD HAPPENED AFTER
VACCINE WE WANT.
TO PREVENT THE ACTOR SO WE WANT
TO BE BEFORE AND THAT'S WHAT THE
GUIDELINES -- ADDRESS.
FINAL QUESTION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR DILIGENCE -- MISTER VICE
CHAIRS SO.
THE CONCERN ABOUT DOCTORS WHO
ARE INAPPROPRIATELY BE THAT
FAILING OR WHAT HAVE BEEN THE
CASE MAY BE ISSUING EXEMPTIONS.
IS THERE ANYTHING THE MEDICAL
BOARD COULD CURRENTLY DO UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
COULD THE MEDICAL BOARD -- STEP
IN AND INTERVENE -- OR OR OR OR
OR IS SB TWO SEVEN SIX NECESSARY
TO PREVENT THIS AND ABUSE AND A
AN INAPPROPRIATE USE I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THE REASON -- THAT TO
THIS BILL IS SUBMITTED NOW AND
NOT IN THE IT IS MERELY WHEN WE
KNEW THE KNACK ASCENSION RATE
WAS GOING UP BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
MEDICAL PORTENT PARMA PUBLIC
HEALTH.
THE HOW TO ADDRESS THIS THE
CHALLENGE FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE CHARGE FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD
CALIFORNIA'S THE NORMAL PROCESS
IS THAT A PATIENT COMPLAINS
ABOUT THIS BEHAVIOR BY PHYSICIAN.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WHEN
THE MEDICAL BOARD INVESTIGATES
THAT PATIENT PROVIDES ACCESS TO
THE MEDICAL RECORDS NECESSARY
FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD TO DO THE
INVESTIGATION OF THAT POSITION.
IN THIS CASE THE FAMILY IS IN
CAHOOTS WITH THE DOCTOR IS NOT
BEHAVING PROFESSIONALLY AND
THEREFORE ARE NOT PROVIDING THE
MEDICAL RECORDS TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO EXAMINE -- SO IT'S IT'S
MAKES IT VERY CHALLENGING FOR
THE MEDICAL BOARD TO DO
INVESTIGATION THEY WOULD HAVE TO
GO TO A JUDGE TRY TO SUBPOENA
RECORDS THEY WOULD HAVE THE
NAMES OF THE CHILDREN THAT THEY
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THAT.
YOU'D HAVE TO GO AND SAY TELL
THE JUDGE OH BY THE WAY I WANTED
SUBPOENA THE ENTIRE MEDICAL
RECORD FOR THIS DOCTOR IN GOING
TO BUT SOMEONE PEOPLE MAY TERM A
FISHING EXPEDITION TO LOOK.
AND SEE WHAT'S GOING ON EVEN
THOUGH THEY KNOW THE STUFF
THAT'S GOING ON NOW I WILL POINT
OUT THE MEDICAL BOARD HAS ACTED
ON ONE POSITION.
THAT'S DOCTOR BOB SEARS WHERE
PAY OR A FAMILY MEMBER DID
COOPERATE AND IT TURNED OUT HE
WAS ACTING NEGLIGENTLY AND TO
HIS LICENSES ON PROBATION -- AT
FOUR FOR DOING THIS BUT IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO ACT THAT WHILE ONLY
HAPPEN BECAUSE A FAMILY MEMBER
ACTUALLY CHARLES TO HAVE THEIR
RECORDS MADE PUBLIC AND AND AND
NAMES MADE PUBLIC.
YEAH CAM FORWARD EXACTLY SO THAT
WHILE A CLAIM ABOUT NEGLIGENCE.
YES THAT'S THE PROBLEM RIGHT SO
YOU HAVE TO PERSUADE SOMEONE WHO
WHO BOUGHT MEDICAL EXEMPTION TO
WHY THE BACK OF THE ENGINE SAY --
NOW I FILE A COMPLAINT AND
REVEAL THE RECORDS.
AND SO THAT'S BEEN THE CHALLENGE
FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD.
NOW ACTUALLY WITH THIS BILL WITH
AND PUBLIC HEALTH HAVING THE
LISTS OF CHILDREN WHO GET
MEDICAL CENTERS A. C. PATTERN.
THEY ACTUALLY THEN CAN BE A DO
MORE TARGET INVESTIGATIONS TRY
SUBPOENA EVERY RECORD THEY COULD
GO SUBPOENA THOSE PARTICULAR
RECORDS AND GO AFTER PHYSICIAN
WHO'S BEING PARTICULARLY BEING
UNPROFESSIONAL AND AND AND AND
AND FOCUS ON THAT BECAUSE THEY
CAN GET THAT INFORMATION FROM
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I TOO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND I WANT THINK
EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN HERE TODAY --
IN OPPOSITION AND IN SUPPORT
THIS IS WHAT DEMOCRACY LOOKS
LIKE.
DOCTOR PM LAST TIME AROUND I DID
NOT SUPPORT THE BILL.
I DO NOT SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS
MOST PEOPLE THINK I'M FULLY
VACCINATED MY HUSBAND'S
VACCINATE OUR CHILDREN OR FULLY
VACCINATED I HAD A CONCERN.
OVER WORKING FAMILIES WHO DID
NOT VACCINATE THEIR CHILDREN BUT
NOT BILLS THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
TO HOME SCHOOL THEIR CHILD.
YOUR NEW BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
THAT -- SAYS STILL CONCERN FOR
ME BUT I THINK MY BIGGER CONCERN
GOES ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT --
CENTER MITCHELL WAS ASKING ARE
THESE DOCTORS WHO ARE.
WHO ARE A RONI IS FULLY --
REALLY CIRCUMVENTING THE SYSTEM
OR THEY FOUND A LOOPHOLE IN THE
SYSTEM.
AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR ALL OF US
AND FOR EVERYONE WE LEGISLATE TO
THE BAD ACTORS.
AND WE PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE HERE
WITH THIS BILL I'M GUESSING.
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE DOCTORS WHO
WERE DOING WHAT THEY'RE DOING --
I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP A
LITTLE BIT ON WHAT SENATOR
MITCHELL ASKED.
AND MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND IT IS
WELL BECAUSE I DID HAVE A
QUESTION TWO ABOUT THE DOCTOR'S
GOING TO THE MEDICAL BOARD AND
JUST GETTING RID OF THE BAD
ACTORS.
SO YOU HAVE EXPLAINED THAT THE
REASON THAT'S A PROBLEM IS IF I
SAY SURE YOU CAN LOOK AT MY
RECORDS BUT THEN EVERYONE ELSE
THE EVERITT APPEARANCES NO YOU
CAN'T YOU HAVE TO SUBPOENA THEM
THEY TAKE TOO LONG CORRECT.
IT'S A IT'S A I'M NOT THE
ATTORNEY -- BUT IMAGINE GOING TO
THE JUDGE AND SAYING I WANT TO
SUBPOENA EVERY MEDICAL RECORD OF
THIS PARTICULAR POSITION GOOD
I'M TRYING TO FIND THESE THINGS.
YEAH WE WE DO WANT TO PROTECT
PATIENT PRIVACY WE DON'T WANT
THE MEDICAL BOARD GOING
OFFICIALLY EXPEDITIONS AND I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD RAISE
CONCERNS IN THE JUDGE'S MIND
ABOUT WHAT IT'S GOING HERE DAVID
WHAT WHICH PATIENTS ARE YOU
LOOKING AT WHICH ONES.
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO DO A BROAD
SWEEP THROUGH THE ENTIRE MEDICAL
RECORD OF A PARTICULAR POSITION
GOT IT SO IF YOU COULD JUST
EXPLAIN TO US HOW YOU THINK THAT
THE THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
HOW THIS NEW SYSTEM UNDER YOUR
BILL WOULD WORK AND I IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO ME?
YES AND AGAIN I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT WE WOULD NOT BE THE FIRST
STATE TO DO THIS SO WE THERE IS
EXT.
OUT THERE IN ANOTHER STATE AND
IT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS IS THAT --
IS IT IS JUST TO PHASES AS I
EXPLAIN SO IN THE FIRST PHASE
BASICALLY PEOPLE JUST FILE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH IT
WOULD HAVE INFORMATION IN CASE
THERE'S AN OUTBREAK SO THEY CAN
ACT ON IT.
THERE WOULD BE THE ABILITY OF
THE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
AT PARTY COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER TO INVALIDATE
INAPPROPRIATE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS --
BECAUSE TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
RIGHT THERE'S AN OUTBREAK
THERE'S THERE'S A THIRD THE OUT
THERE CONCERNED THAT THE
MUSICIAN RATES TO LOVE ME WHY
EXAMINE THEM IN MORE DETAIL.
AT TO TRY TO TO TO ADDRESS THAT
AND THEN -- GIVEN.
I THINK IT'S TWO YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION TIME FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH THEN WE WOULD MOVE TO THE
MODEL THAT'S SAID USED BY --
ANOTHER STATE WEST VIRGINIA
WHERE VISIT INSTEAD OF THE
PHYSICIAN JUST ISSUING A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION THEY WOULD APPLY FOR
ONE THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE CULT THE TOP PART OF THE
HEALTH OF THE REVIEW -- THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED BY THE
PHYSICIAN -- LOOK AT IT THE
RELATION TO THE GUIDELINES AND
THEN ISSUE A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
OR DENY IT IF THEY DENY IT
THERE'S STILL OPPORTUNITY FOR
THAT POSITION TO APPEAL THAT AND
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CLARIFYING
INFORMATION.
IN CASE THE OUT THAT THAT THERE
THERE WASN'T ENOUGH INFORMATION
TO TO MAKE THE APPROPRIATE
DECISION SO WE WANTED WE DO WANT
TO TRY -- TO CREATE THAT -- TO
BE SURE THAT WE HAVE.
EXEMPTIONS ARE BASED ON SCIENCE
BUT ALSO WE WILL WE DO WANT TO
GET SOME LATITUDE BUT WE DON'T
WANT HAVE A SITUATION LIKE THIS
WHERE PEOPLE GOING AROUND IT AND
WE HAVE SCHOOLS IT'S NOT THE
OVERALL RATE RIGHT NOW IT'S
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS THAT'S WHERE
OUTBREAKS BEGAN.
RIGHT.
SO THANK YOU THAT WAS VERY
HELPFUL SO IF I DECIDE.
FOR ANY OF THE REASONS WE'VE
HEARD TODAY THAT I DO NOT WANT
TO VACCINATE MY CHILD AND I WANT
TO TRY AND GET IT MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
WHAT I DO THAT AS A PARENT WHEN
MY CHILD IS ONE TWO THREE YEARS
OLD BEFORE THEY GO TO SCHOOL?
SO WHAT I WOULD HAVE TIME TO GET
THAT MEDICAL EXEMPTION BEFORE
THEY STARTED SCHOOL.
YOU CAN CERTAINLY APPLY AT ANY
TIME AND I WOULD CITY OF AND WE
WOULD FROM CERTAINLY WANT TO
EDUCATE PHYSICIANS THAT WHEN IF
THE CHILD HAS A CONDITION.
EVEN PRIOR TO GOING TO SCHOOL
WHERE DAVID DEL MAR TO MEDICAL
EXEMPTION THEY SHOULD JUST GO
AHEAD AND APPLY SO THAT THEY
HAVE THE OPERATION THE
AUTHORIZATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH WE
HAVEN'T HAD A IN WEST VIRGINIA
HASN'T HAD A PROBLEM WITH PEOPLE --
GETTING CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE SAY
SAY IN A WAITING FOR THE THE
EXEMPTION WELL THAT SCHOOL
STARTING.
GOT IT SO IT SEEMS THAT YOU CAN
STILL GET A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
YOU HAVE UNTIL YOUR CHILD STARTS
SCHOOL TO GET THAT MEDICAL
EXEMPTION -- WHAT ALSO CONCERNS
ME IS YOU KNOW?
THE THE HERD MENTALITY OF THE
HERD -- IMMUNITY.
IN THE EVENT OF HEAT THAT THAT.
TOO I WORRY THAT WE HAVE SEEN
MORE OUTBREAKS OF DISEASES I'M
FIFTY TWO YEARS OLD AND I DON'T
EVER REMEMBER SEEING THIS IN MY
LIFETIME.
AND SO I WORRY THAT AS MORE MORE
PEOPLE DON'T VACCINATE THEIR
CHILDREN AND PEOPLE TRAVEL IN
AND OUT OF THIS COUNTRY WHICH IS
GREAT THAT'S WHY WE LOVE THIS
COUNTRY.
BUT IT IS DIFFERENT IN OTHER
COUNTRIES AND IF THEY'RE
BRINGING THINGS BACK AND AND AND
I HONESTLY WORRY ABOUT THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE NOT EVEN IS
IMMUNIZED.
BECAUSE THEY ARE AT GREATER RISK
SO -- WITH THAT AND AGAIN WE
LEGISLATOR THE BAD ACTORS WE
MIGHT NOT EVEN BE HERE TODAY IF
WE DIDN'T HAVE DOCTORS DOING
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND LOOKING
FOR THE LOOPHOLES.
SO WITH THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN.
THERE IS A GERMAN -- WE WE'VE
REALLY DONE A GREAT JOB I KNOW
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY BUT WE WE
JUST DON'T ALLOW ANY UPPERS SO.
THIS WILL BE THE LAST WARNING
BUT IF WE HAVE ANY OUTBURST WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GOING TO
CALL A RECESS AND WE'RE GOING TO
VACATE THE ROOM.
AND THEY WERE GONNA RECONVENE WE
REALLY WANTED TO BE HERE TO HEAR
THE DELIBERATIONS BUT WE GOT TO
BE RESPECTFUL TO THE PROCESS
HERE PLEASE.
SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AGAIN
I WANT TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES --
COMMENTS ON HOW YOU HANDLE THIS
HEARING AND AND THAT THE LENGTH
OF THE HEARING AND HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAD TO BE FACILITATED
THROUGH -- TO LET THEIR VOICE BE
HEARD SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AND YOUR PERSISTENCE IN
MAKING SURE IS AN ORDERLY
HEARING.
I DO -- HAVE SOME FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS BASED ON SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT MY COLLEAGUES MADE
AND DIRECTLY TO YOU SENATOR PAN.
IT WAS HERE WHEN TO SEVENTY
SEVEN WENT THROUGH AND AND I I
DO SHARE THE SENTIMENT OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT YOU KNOW YOU DID
GIVE YOUR GUARANTEE THAT THAT
BETWEEN THEIR DOCTOR AND THEM.
AND SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS IS
THAT I KNOW YOU'VE ANSWERED AND
SOMEWHAT BUT CAN YOU ELABORATE
ON THE FACT THAT.
THAT NOW WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
THAT GUARANTEE BETWEEN THE
DOCTOR AND THE PARENT FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO STATE THAT WHEN I
WAS TESTIFYING I WAS TRYING.
I WAS TESTIFYING ACTUALLY TO
WHAT WOULD BE THE STATE.
OF THE SITUATION AFTER PASSAGE
OF TWO SEVEN SEVEN AND BECAUSE
WE DO NOT -- SUBSTANTIVELY
AFFECT THE MEDICAL EXEMPTION --
IN THE BILL THAT WAS VERY
INTENTIONAL ON TWO SEVEN SEVEN
THAT -- EXISTING LAW WHICH WAS
THAT MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS WOULD BE
AT THE DISCRETION AND INDIVIDUAL
JUDGMENT THE PHYSICIAN.
WOULD BE IN PLACE THE
EXPECTATION WAS IS THAT FOR MOST
PART THAT WOULD.
BE THE CHILD'S REGULAR PHYSICIAN
AND THAT THEY WOULD BE FOLLOWING
THE STANDARD OF CARE -- AND IN
FACT -- THE HOPE WAS IS THAT THE
THE MEDICAL BOARD WOULD BE IN A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO ACT --
FOR THOSE FEW PHYSICIANS TO
UNFORTUNATELY WOULD ACT AND
PROFESSIONALLY -- AFTER
IMPLEMENTATION OF TWO SEVEN
SEVEN WE SAW THAT.
THAT WAS A FORTY NOT THE CASE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT POSITIONS OR
ADVERTISING DO NOT THE REGULAR
CHILD'S DOCTOR BE SEEN PEOPLE
POST ON SOCIAL MEDIA MY CHILD'S
DOCTOR WON'T GIVE ME A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
I HAD TO GO TRAVEL BY ONE RIGHT
THAT'S NOT HOW IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO WORK -- I WOULD ALSO POINT
OUT THAT IN CONVERSATIONS
MEDICAL BOARD TURNED OUT A
LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED AS I
EXPLAINED IN TERMS OF HOW THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO TRY TO ENFORCE --
AT PERFECT AND PERFECT AGAINST
UNPROFESSIONAL BEHAVIOR AND SO
IT IS ACTUALLY THE PHYSICIAN
COMMUNITY THAT SPOT THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED HI.
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS -- SO THOSE ARE
THE DOT AT THE ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING DOCTORS WHO ARE
HERE REPRESENT DOCTORS TALKING
ABOUT WE NEED TO PROTECT THE
PATIENT DOCOR RELATIONSHIP.
RIGHT AND AND AND DITION
ADDITION TO THOSE THAT'S ALSO
SUPPORT BY OTHER PHYSICIAN
GROUPS AS WELL SO YOU HEARD
LEADERS FROM THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION COME TESTIFIED.
PEOPLE WHO -- NOLLIE AT CMA IN A
P. BUT ALSO YOU KNOW THE FOR
PRESENTS A COUNTY MEDICAL
SOCIETY SPECIALTY SOCIETIES AND
SO FORTH BECAUSE PHYSICIANS
UNDERSTAND THAT.
WE NEED WE HAVE A PROFESSIONAL
DUTY TO PROTECT OUR PATIENTS AND
ALSO PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION THAT IT IS SPONSORING
THIS BILL.
I I APPRECIATE THAT BUT WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT THERE'S MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE ISSUE THAT ARE COMING TO
THEIR I I WITNESSED MANY MEDICAL
THERE'S A LOT OF RELATING. TO
SITTING HERE THREE AND THEN THE
PEOPLE THAT CAME UP TO TESTIFY
THEY WERE FROM THE MEDICAL
FACILITY YOU KNOW MEDICAL
PROFESSION THEY WERE NURSES --
THEY WERE EMERGENCY ESPONDERS
THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
MEDICAL FACILITIES ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE ARGUMENT.
SO -- I GUESS I I DID NEED TO
KNOW THAT I ON A SENATOR MONEY
HAD MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT THAT STEPPED ON SOMEONE
ELSE'S INDIVIDUAL CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT AND WHERE DO YOU DRAW THE
DRAW THE LINE.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS IS
THAT WE'RE WE IS LEGISLATORS
DRAW THE LINE IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT -- FOR OF
YOUR WITNESS THAT'S HERE WITH
THE A MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILD
THEY'LL BELIEVE A LIVER
TRANSPLANT YOU SAID YES A LIVER
TRANSPLANT THAT CAN'T BE ANYONE
IMMUNIZED OR BE EXPOSED. TO AUTO
WHO I BELIEVE IS STILL SITTING
THERE I CAN'T SEE HIM IS HE DOWN
UNDERNEATH THERE.
THERE YOU ARE.
WHO IS -- VACCINE -- I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY RIGHT VERY INTELLIGENT
YOUNG MAN BUT IN A WHEELCHAIR
BECAUSE OF THE VACCINE -- THAT
HE RECEIVED.
SO WHERE DOES HIS CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT MEET SOMEWHERE IN THE
MIDDLE WITH SOMEONE ELSE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT LIKE HE
DOESN'T HAVE A RIGHT TO GO TO
SCHOOL UNLESS HE'S VACCINATED.
TO PROTECT SOMEBODY WHO'S
MEDICALLY FRAGILE AND DOESN'T DE
CAN VACCINATED THAT THEY WANT TO
PROTECT THEM FROM AUTO BUT HOW
DO WE PROTECT AUTO.
FROM HIS AUTO IMMUNE DISEASE OR
WHATEVER IS CAUSING HIM. TO HAVE
AN ADVERSE REACTION TO THE
VACCINE AND WHERE IS AUTOS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
OKAY SO FIRST OF ALL IF -- IF A
CHILD.
HAS A TRULY A A TRUE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION -- THEN THEY WOULD GET
MEDICAL EXEMPTION RIGHT THERE
WOULD BE EXEMPTED.
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THE THAT'S
WHAT THE LAWS THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL INTENSE SO THEREFORE IF
THAT BUT IF YOU CHOOSE NOT TO
VACCINATE.
SO IT'S NOT THAT YOU DON'T BUT
YOU CAN'T GIVE ACTUALLY CHOOSE
NOT TO VACCINATE.
THENTHERE'S A CONSEQUENCE TO
PROTECT OTHER CHILDREN ISLAND
SINCE YOU MENTION
CONSTITUTIONALITY I SHOULD
MENTION THAT SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
FACED I THINK.
FOR BY CHALLENGES IN COURT --
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL COURT AND
IS ONE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
THE COURTS HAVE SAID
INTERPRETING THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
UNITED STATES.
THAT.
VACCINE REQUIREMENTS FOR SCHOOL
ART CONSTITUTIONAL DEBTS IN CASE
LAW.
THAT GOES BACK OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS AND SO THEREFORE THAT THE
COURTS HAVE RULED THAT SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN WHICH IS ACTUALLY
THE ONE THAT.
IF YOU WANT I WILL
CONSTITUTIONALITY.
IS IS IS DEFINITELY
CONSTITUTIONAL THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT AND THERE'S
CERTAINLY NUMBERS CASES ABOUT
THAT BUT LAWS IN OTHER STATES
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN IS CONSTITUTIONAL
IT'S BEEN THAT THE THAT IN THE
COURTS BOTH THERE AND IT'S BEEN.
A IT'S BEEN RULED UPON ITS BEEN
FINALIZED -- I WOULD THEN I
WOULD POINT OUT IS IS THAT.
THIS BILL WHICH IS ABOUT
ACTUALLY REGULATING PHYSICIANS
RIGHT AT AT AT AT A PUBLIC
HEALTH FUNCTION -- CERTAINLY
AGAIN I SAID IT'S MY LEFT IN A
STATE THAT'S BEEN FOUND
CONSTITUTIONAL.
BUT CERTAINLY -- THIS BILL IT IS
IT'S CONSTITUTIONAL AS WELL I
MEAN WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
REGULATE -- THE PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNCTIONS LIKE THE GRANTING
MEDICAL EXEMPTION JUST LIKE WE
CAN REGULATE HANDY OUT
HANDICAPPED PLACARDS -- FOR CARS
THAT FOR LIKE A OFFER PARKING OR
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS ARE
RELATED -- TO USING A PUBLIC
SERVICES ARE ARE PUBLIC SPACES I
MEAN THAT THAT IS THE FUNCTION
OF GOVERNMENT IS TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND SO WE'VE OFTEN PASSED
LAWS TO PROTECT PUBLIC TO WE
HAVE LOTS TO KEEP KIDS.
KIDS SAFE IN SCHOOL WE SAY
CERTAIN THINGS YOU CAN'T DO AND
NOT DO AND AND AND SCHOOL RIGHT
WE TELL PEOPLE YOU CAN'T DRIVE
DRUNK ON THE ROADS.
RIGHT THAT -- THAT YOU TAKING
THAT CHOICE AWAY BECAUSE IT'S A
DANGER TO OTHER PEOPLE YOUR
RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHAT YOU WANT TO
DO STOPS WHEN THAT CHOICE.
WELL IN DANGER AND HARM OTHER
PEOPLE AND SO THAT'S GENERALLY
BEEN THE CASE AND SO AGAIN THE
COURT HAS RULED DEFINITIVELY
THAT -- THE VACCINE REQUIREMENTS
FOR SCHOOL AND SB TWO SEVEN
PARTICULAR IS CONSTITUTIONAL CAN
I AND I UNDERSTAND THAT MY
APPRECIATE THAT BUT MY I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS IS THAT.
IT'S DIFFERENT THAN SAYING YOU
CAN'T DRIVE DRUNK ON THE ROAD OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT BECAUSE YOU
ARE SAYING THAT.
YOUR WITNESSES CHILD GETS TO GO
TO SCHOOL UNVACCINATED BUT IF
AUTOS PARENTS CHOOSE NOT TO
VACCINATE HIM BECAUSE HE DAVE
BELIEVE THE VACCINE OR THEY HAVE
PROOF THAT THE FAXING CAUSED HIM.
TO BE IN A WHEELCHAIR THE REST
OF HIS LIFE HE HASN'T GOT THE
RIGHT TO GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE
THEY'RE CHOOSING NOT TO
VACCINATE HIM IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING.
NO I WANTED TO ACTUALLY LET ME
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE -- THAT TO
CAME UP -- SO THERE I WHEN WE
WERE DOING TWO SEVEN SEVEN THERE
WAS A MOTHER WHO I COMMUNICATE
WITH ME HER CHILD ACTUALLY.
HAD A HEART TRANSPLANT BECAUSE
SHE HAD CAN GENERAL HEART
DISEASE.
AND THE REASON SHE WAS
COMMUNICATING SHE SAID MY CHILD
WAS SENT HOME FROM SCHOOL AND
TOLD TO STAY AWAY FROM SCHOOL
FOR TWENTY ONE DAYS.
WHY WAS MY CHILD THE NINE DIRECT
TO GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE ANOTHER
FAMILY?
WHO CHOSE NOT TO VACCINATE
WONDER CHILDREN GOT CHICKEN POX
THAT WOULD KILL?
POTENTIALLY KILL THE CHILD TO
GOT TO TRANSFER IN FACT SHE HAD
GOTTEN CHICKEN POX ONCE BEFORE
AND AFTER THE ICE YOU ALMOST
DIED.
SO THE SCHOOL IN FEAR FOR HER
SAFETY THEN SENT HER HOME --
CHILD HOME TO PROTECT HER CHILD
IN KEPT TOLD THEM THAT THEY
COULD NOT BRING HER CHILD'S
SCHOOL INNER CHILD WANT TO GO TO
SCHOOL BE WITH THEIR FRIENDS.
BUT THE FAMILY WHO CHOSE NOT TO
VACCINATE.
DESPITE FACTORS NO REASON THEY
COULD BE ACCINATED THEIR CHILD
STILL GUY GOT TO ATTEND SCHOOL
HE SAID WHAT'S THE JUSTICE
WHAT'S THE RIGHT THERE DAY MADE
A CHOICE BUT I DIDN'T I DIDN'T
HAVE A CHOICE I DON'T HAVE A
CHOICE.
SO IF THERE'S A CHILD WHO
GENERALLY HAS A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION THEN THEY WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO ATTEND SCHOOL THAT'S
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
AND THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF TWO
SEVEN SEVEN THEY GENERALLY HAVE.
A MEDICAL CONTRA EDUCATION A
PRECAUTION TO VACCINATION -- SO
I DON'T HAS ONE THEN HE WOULD
GET A MEDICAL EXEMPTION YOU CAN
GO TO SCHOOL.
OKAY.
EVAN I AM OF MOVE ON TO ANOTHER
QUESTION CAN YOU GIVE ME AND
CALIFORNIA EXAMPLE OF THE
VACCINE PREVENTABLE DISEASE
OUTBREAK THAT OCCURRED IN ONE OF
THE POCKETS.
OF UNVACCINATED CHILDREN ARE THE
AREAS WHERE THERE'S A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE I THINK SENATOR
BUNNING SAID 270% OF US SOME OF
THE SCHOOLS IN THIS DISTRICT
WERE.
ARE NOT VACCINATED OR ARE
VACCINATED BUT IT'S AT A 70%
THRESHOLD AND 796%.
SO IS THERE A IS THERE A
CALIFORNIA EXAMPLE DIRECTOR
SEVERAL CALIFORNIA'S SAMPLE SO
FOR EXAMPLE WELL FIRST OF ALL AN
EXAMINATION OF THE OUTBREAK THAT
START IN DISNEYLAND.
THAT -- BASICALLY MAINLY SPREAD
AND AMONG UNVACCINATED
POPULATIONS SO WHILE THERE IS A
SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE GOT
VACCINATED TO DID GET THE
DISEASE IT'S A BIT PRIMARILY
AMONG THEM VACCINATED.
WHAT WE HAVE FOR TESTIS OUTBREAK
IN TWENTY TEN HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT I'D LIKE TO
MENTION THAT -- INK -- NINE
INFANTS DIED SEVERAL HUNDRED
WERE OVER HOSPITALIZED -- DAY
AGAIN EXAMINED WHERE DID THE
WORD THAT PROCESSES OUTBREAK
SPREAD AND IT MAINLY SPREAD IN
AREAS WITH LOW VACCINATION RATES
IS BASICALLY IS DEFINED BY.
HI PERSONAL BET BELIEVE
EXEMPTION OUR LOW VACCINATION
RATES OF KIDS OF THE SCOPE OF
PEOPLE ATTACK OF SCHOOLS IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND SO THE
RESEARCH AFTER THE MAGIC
RESEARCH IS DEFINITELY IDENTIFY
TENS TRACE.
THAT THESE OUTBREAKS ARE RELATED
TO COMMUNITIES WITH LOW
VACCINATION RATES AND IS WERE
LOOKING AT OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE
STILL ON GOING SOME OF THESE
OUTBREAKS GOING ON RIGHT NOW
TODAY AND AS MEASLES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY -- BUT SO PEOPLE NEED TO
GATHER BUT THE CURRENT DATA
SHOWS THAT IT'S MAINLYSPREADING
AND COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN-TARGETED -- WITH LOW VACCINATION
RATES OF THE OUTBREAK GOING ON
IN NEW YORK AGAIN LOW
VACCINATION RATE COMMUNITY --
THE ONE TO HAPPEN MINNESOTA BUT
THE IN THE SMALL THE COMMUNITY
FOR THE VACCINATION RATE WENT
FROM THE 90% SOUNDS I THINK
AROUND 40% THAT THEY HAD A
MEASLES OUTBREAK -- THE IN
WASHINGTON CITY WASHINGTON
ACTUALLY THE OUTBREAK AGAIN AND
COMMUNITIES OF LOW VACCINATION
RATES I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
THOSE ATTORNEYS VERTICALLY
TARGETED WITH ANTI VACCINE THIS
INFORMATION -- SO THEIR ANTI
VACCINE GROUPS -- THAT WENT OUT
TO THIS COMMITTEES PRIOR TO THIS
OUTBREAKS AND DROVE DOWN THE
VACCINATION RATES AND NOT
SURPRISINGLY THEY NOW HAVE
MEASLES OUTBREAKS GOING ON SO IN
FACT THE TAUGHT TARGET THE
SLAVIC COMMUNITY AND AS A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND STOP THE COMMUNITY
HERE.
THE TARGET THE SLAVIC COMMUNITY
IN STATE OF WASHINGTON -- IS --
AND THAT'S WHERE THE OUTBREAK A
LOT THE OUTBREAK HAPPENED AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE DANGER THAT WE
HAVE WE HAVE AREAS WITH LOW
VACCINATION RATES.
THAT'S WHAT THE OUTBREAKS HAPPEN
IN TWENTY TEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAD INFANTS DIE OF THE
VACCINE PREVENTABLE DISEASE
BECAUSE OF THAT.
SAYS A MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL AND
I I RESPECT YOUR OPINION --
THERE WAS A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WHOOPING COUGH OUTBREAK
IN HARVARD WESTLAKE SCHOOLS IN
THE CASES -- WERE ALL VACCINATED
KIDS LIKE DATA ALL RECEIVED
VACCINATIONS -- THERE WERE
EIGHTEEN KIDS THAT WENT TO THAT
SCHOOL THAT WERE NOT VACCINATED
FOR WHATEVER REASON THE PARENTS
CHOICE THE MEDICAL EXEMPTION I'M
NOT SURE WHY BUT THEY WEREN'T
VACCINATED.
NONE OF THOSE KIDS WERE AFFECTED
BUT THE ONES THAT WERE AFFECTED
WERE VACCINATED KIDS.
HOW IS THAT HALF OF FIRST OF ALL
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND EACH
VACCINE HAS ITS OWN PROFILE SO
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN THE CHALLENGES
WERE HAVING WITH THE PROTESTS AS
VACCINE IN FACT THIS IS ONE OF
OUR RESPONSES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO THE PROTEST THIS OUTBREAK IN?
TWENTY TEN WAS ACTUALLY DO
REQUIRE FOR TOSSES VACCINATION
AT TWELVE YEARS OLDER ENTRIES
SEVENTH GRADE THAT'S WHEN THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED ACTED ON THAT.
BECAUSE THE THE PROTECTIVE
VACCINE THAT'S CURRENTLY USE THE
A CELL IN A PROTEST AS VACCINE.
UNFORTUNATE DOES NOT LAST AS
LONG -- AND IT IN FACT ACTUALLY
PROTECT THIS WAS A YOU CATCH FOR
TOSSES THAT THE ACTUAL DISEASE
YOU ONLY DEVELOP A LIMITED TIME
YOU IMMUNITY DEBT WAYNE'S.
SO -- THAT'S BEEN SO SAME WITH
THE VACCINATION AS WELL AND SO
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WHAT YOU
YOU DO SUPER TOSSES OUT BREAKS
AND SOMEONE WILL BRING UP MONTHS
IN RIGHT AND WE SEE THESE MOMS
OUTBREAKS.
THE GENERALLY AND FOR AND
POPULATIONS WHERE THE
VACCINATION ITSELF MIGHT HAVE
WORN OFF A BIT AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING PEOPLE LOOK AT THAT
ENTRY NEW RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
VACCINATION SO BEFORE LOOKING AT
THE PROTEST AS VACCINATION RIGHT
NOW WE RECOMMEND EVERYONE YOU
GET ONE VERY TEN YEARS AFTER
YOUR INITIAL.
SERIES BEFORE LOOK AT DO WE NEED
TO SHORTEN THE AMOUNT OF TIME SO
IT REMAINS EFFECTIVE BECAUSE THE
THE TIME THE STATE'S OTHER
PROTESTERS.
PROTECTION ACTUALLY LAST IS AS
LONG AS THE OLD ONE SO THE
RECOMMENDATION STILL BASED ON
THE OLD -- THE PERSISTENCE OF
IMMUNITY OF THE PREVIOUS
VACCINATION AND SO THAT'S WHY WE
REVISE OUR RECOMMENDATIONS BASED
ON IT AN IMPROVED DATA THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THE VACCINE DOESN'T
WORK IT JUST MEANS THAT THE
VACCINE.
WORKS IT WORKS THE WAY IT WORKS
SO AND THAT AND SO WE'VE SIZE
NEED TO MODIFY -- EXACTLY HOW WE
ADMINISTER VACCINES MMR ON THE
OTHER HAND -- ONCE YOU GET TO
VACCINATIONS FOR MOST PART --
WELL THERE'S THAT THAT WILL BE
PROVIDE LIFETIME IMMUNITY -- TO
TWO PEOPLE UNLESS YOU TO BECOME
A NEW COMPROMISE FROM CANCER OR
SOMETHING ELSE LATER ON IN LIFE
SO THAT IN THAT CASE YOU JUST
GET THE TO AND CHILDHOOD YOUR
GOOD IF YOU ONLY GET ONE THOUGH.
USE THAT YOU'RE MORE VULNERABLE
AND THAT'S WHAT WE SW FORTY
WITH THAT -- FLIGHT ATTENDANT --
WHO'S IN A COMA RIGHT NOW IT
ISRAEL THEY ONLY RECEIVED ONE
AND SO I TO AT ELEVEN ONE ELEVEN
CHANCE OF DEVELOPING THE DISEASE.
THANK YOU AM I JUST HAVE TWO
MORE QUESTIONS AND I DO
APOLOGIZE A BECAUSE I KNOW WE'VE
BEEN HERE.
A REALLY LONG TIME YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE THE ISSUES THE SIGN
BEHIND YOU THAT SAYS THAT THERE
ARE YOU KNOW BAD APPLES IN THE
PHYSICIAN INDUSTRY.
I AGREE WITH SENATOR LABOR THAT
WE TEND TO LEGISLATE.
YOU KNOW REGARDING THE ACTIONS
OF BAD APPLES OR PEOPLE THAT --
ARE BAD ACTORS IN IN PARTICULAR
INDUSTRIES AND THEN WE KIND OF
THROW THE BABY OUT WITH THE BATH
WATER I GUESS IS THE BETTER
STATEMENT THAT I WOULD THINK IF.
AND I A I REALLY THINK THAT THIS
IN MY PERCEPTION I BELIEVE AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD NOT
BEING ABLE TO GO AFTER THESE BAD
ACTORS.
BUT TO ME THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
THERE FOR I MEAN THERE THERE TO
GO AFTER THE BAD MEDICAL ACTORS
SO I DON'T SEE WHY THEY CAN'T
ONE FACE THAT CAN SEE THAT.
IN AND GO INTO THE THIS
FACILITIES AND CHECK THOSE BAD
ACTORS DOWN BEFORE WE VIOLATE
THE RIGHTS APPEARANCE.
AND TO CHOOSE WHETHER THEY THEY
WANT THEIR KIDS VACCINATED OR
HAVE THESE THESE VACCINES.
I MEAN JUST I MEAN INSERTED INTO
THEIR KIDS I GUESS -- WHEN THEY
FEEL THAT THEIR KIDS ARE --
MEDICALLY FLORA JEWEL OR LIKE
MISS MITCHELL SAID AND A VARIETY
OF REASONS THAT WILL -- PUT
THEIR KIDS AT RISK.
SO -- AND YOU SAY THERE'S NO WAY
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD CAN
REGULATE THESE BAD ACTORS WELL
IT SAYS IT AND SAY IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT WHAT HAD MULTIPLE
pBOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S IT'S SUCH AS I POINT
OUT THE REASON I'M DOING THIS
BILL.
IS NOT JUST TO STAMP OUT THE BAD
ACTORS THIS RESULT OF THE BAD
ACTORS WE HAVE SCHOOLS LIKE
CENTER MINE MENTIONED HE HAS ONE
THAT IT'S ONLY. 70% VACCINATED
WE THERE'S A SCHOOL THEIR
SCHOOLS ARE AS LOW AS 50% YOU
KNOW THE LA TIMES DOCUMENT
NUMEROUS SCHOOLS THAT HAD
MEDICAL EXEMPTION RATES ABOVE
20%.
SO THAT MEANS IN THE OUTBREAKS
OR ANYTHING IN THE SCHOOLS WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR ONE SOME DAY I
MEAN THAT ACTUALLY ONE WHAT
HAPPENED I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
I MEAN THAT THAT'S WHAT WE DO IS
OUR MITCHELL SAID WE DO THIS FOR
PREVENTION ONCE THE OUTBREAK
HAPPENS IT'S HARD TO CATCH UP
AND I THINK CERTAINLY A PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
EXPENSE TO THE TAXPAYER.
WHEN AN OUTBREAK HAPPENS AND WE
TRY TO TRACE PEOPLE AND HAVE TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO CONTAIN
IT AND THE DAMAGE IS DONE WE
WANT TO TRY TO PREVENT THE
DAMAGE NOT WAIT TILL IT HAPPENS --
I THINK TOO OFTEN WE DO THAT AND
GOVERNMENT WE WAIT TILL
SOMETHING BAD HAPPENS I THINK
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING THIS ARE
THESE RATES GOING DOWN I HAVE
DATA HERE THAT SAYS THEY'VE GONE
FROM TWO POINT 7% TO FOUR POINT.
7% -- IN THIS SMALL GROUP OF SO
THE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS OF MORE
TROUBLE THEY USED TO BE POINT TO
THEIR OVER WENT UP TO POINT.
SEVEN THAT'S WHAT THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION RATE HAS GONE UP THE
OVERALL VACCINATION RATE.
IN THE STATE BECAUSE A TWO SEVEN
SEVEN HAS GONE UP SO SU SEVEN
SAYS BEEN X. S. SUCCESS BUT THE
PROBLEM IS IT'S NOT THE STATE
WIDE RATE THAT MATTERS.
IS THE RATE IN PARTICULAR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES AND WHEN
YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE YOU
HAVE SCHOOLS OF VACCINATION
RATES AND THE SEVENTY FIRST
CENTS 50% 80%.
THAT'S WAY TOO LOW YOU GONNA
YOU'RE EXPECTING AN OUTBREAK
SOMEONE'S GOING TO TRAVEL
OVERSEAS AT ON A VACATION OR
SOMETHING TO ENGLAND ARE TO
ITALY ARE TO FRANCE -- TO
PHILIPPINES AND COME BACK AND
BRING MEASLES AND SUDDENLY --
SPREAD LIKE WILDFIRE THAT AND
THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS THOSE%
PEOPLE BY THE WAY YOUR
INFECTIOUS FOR FOUR DAYS BEFORE
YOU HAVE ANY SYMPTOMS YOU DON'T
KNOW.
RIGHT SO NOW YOU HAVE PEOPLE
GOING AROUND TRAVELING --
TRAVELING OF MEETING WITH
FRIENDS -- YOU'LL BE TENDING
BIRTHDAY PARTIES WRITING A
PUBLIC TRANSIT POTENTIALLY AL
SPREADING THE DISEASE AROUND FOR
THE FAMILY GET THE SYMPTOMS AND
SAUCES -- BOY THAT'S MEASLES --
AND THEN TRIES TO STOP IT PUBLIC
HEALTH IS GOING HAVING TO GO
BACK AND ASK FOR HAVE YOU BEEN
FOR THE LAST YOU KNOW FOR SIX
DAYS A TO AND AND TRY TO CONTACT
ALL THIS PEOPLE SAY OKAY NOW YOU
HAVE TO STAY HOME BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT.
THE YOUR INFECTIOUS NOW YOU HAVE
TO STAY HOME AND TO TELL US IF
YOU GOT AN INFECTION AND ON AND
ON AND ON IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S SO
TALKING ABOUT TAKING AWAY
PEOPLE'S FREEDOM.
THAT'S WHEN PEOPLE'S FREEDOM GET
TAKEN AWAY RIGHT WHEN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ASSN INTERVENE TO TRY TO
CONTAIN THE INFECTION PREVENT IT
FROM SPREADING THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PREVENT.
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND AGAIN MY SO MY LAST
QUESTION IS IS IT ON ON APRIL
FIRST THERE WAS -- SENATE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING.
WHERE YOU MADE THE STATEMENT
THAT IT WASN'T RIGHT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TRIP -- TO LEGISLATE
THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE -- IS
AT WORK BUT IS THAT WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW IS LEGISLATING THE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE NO OKAY
THOUGH BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS
FOR GRANTING MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
A PUBLIC HEALTH FUNCTION.
THE PRIDE IT'S NOT DIAGNOSIS OR
TREATMENT THIS.
DECISION TO GRANT A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION IS REALLY A FUNCTION
OF PUBLIC HEALTH -- THE MEDICAL-EXEMPTION IS TO THE STATE'S PLEA
TO KEEPS TO TO ALLOW CHILDREN.
WHO HAVE A CONDITION?
SO IT'S STILL ATTEND SCHOOL IN A
WAY TO KEEP THEM SAFE.
THIS IS ABOUT SAFETY RIGHT AND
SO THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT WHEN
PEOPLE FRAUD GENTLY.
RIGHT MEDICAL CENTERS ARE NOT
DOING IT FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
PATIENT TO DOING FOR THEIR OWN
BENEFIT THEY'RE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
UNDERMINING.
THE SAFETY OF THE SCHOOLS FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO GENUINELY NEED
THE MEDICAL EXCEPTION AND THAT'S
WHY THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY IS THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
IT'S THE CMA IT'S THE AMERICAN
CAVEAT GET A DOCTOR'S THE ONE TO
REPRESENT THE FEVER THE
POSITIONS OF THE STATE THAT SAY
WE NEED THIS.
THIS PARTICULAR BILL THAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT WOULD HAVE --
PULLED LICENSES FROM PHYSICIANS
THAT WERE BAD ACTORS.
THIS BILL NO THIS BILL THAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT WERE YOU SAID WE
SHOULD LEGISLATE STUFF LIKE THAT.
SO I GUESS I JUST THAT'S A
LITTLE GOES A RIVET I MEAN WHAT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN THAT
THAT CASE THAT'S ABOUT REMOVING
LICENSES FROM THE PHYSICIANS
RIGHT WELL I THINK THOSE PEOPLE
THAT -- YOU'RE REFERENCING
BEHIND YOU THAT WERE SELLING --
FALLS -- MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
SHOULD GET THEIR LICENSE THREE
RIGHT WELL.
I I I WOULD I WOULD AGREE BUT I
THINK AGAIN THE IN TALKING TO
THE I MEAN I WORK WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD.
AND WITH THE PART OF THE CELTS
AND PEOPLE FEEL THAT THIS
APPROACH IS THE MOST APPROPRIATE
APPROACH TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
THANK YOU YES SIR [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
BILL.
CROATIAN YOU NEED TO PUSH YOUR
MICROPHONE RIGHT THIS BILL HAS
COME INTO QUESTION BECAUSE
DOCTOR PAN KEEP STATING THAT.
THERE IS THESE ALLEGED YOU KNOW
FRONT FRAUDULENT CASES HERE.
IN PEDIATRICS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IN NOVEMBER THIS HAS
BEEN INVESTIGATED.
IT WAS PUBLISHED AT MOST
PARTICIPANT REPORTED.
SEEN FEW OR NO MEDICAL
EXAMINATIONS THAT THE BELIEVE
FOR PROBLEMATIC THIS IS BEEN
PUBLISHED IN PEDIATRICS IS AT
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD
THAT SAYS THIS WAS AT AM STANCE
IMAGES THAT HHS PUBLIC ACCESS
BONNIE IT EXPERIENCE AS A
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS FALLING THE
ELIMINATION OF THEIR OF NON
MEDICAL VACCINE.
EXEMPTIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION.
RIGHT OVER HERE THESE ARE THE
CONCLUSIONS FACED THAT HAD BEEN
PUBLISHED -- THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD HAS
RECEIVED SIXTY COMPLAINTS
REGARDING MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN THE MAJORITY OF
THE CASES HAVE BEEN CLOSE.
DUE TO NON VIOLATIONS BEING
FOUND.
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE BEING NO
PURSUE DISAPPEARING ACTION OR
INABILITY TO PERCY DUE TO THE
LACK OF SUPPORTING EVIDENCE.
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO BEING ABLE
TO SUBPOENA THERE THE MEDICAL
BOARD CAN AND ANYTIME SUBPOENA?
ANY MEDICAL CHART.
DOES HAPPEN WITH DR SEARS AS WE
KNOW AS NOON TODAY HAVE GOTTEN
TAKEN SEVERAL OF HIS.
CHARTS SO THERE IS A PROCESS TO
THERE'S A DUE PROCESS IN PLANES
IN ORDER TO INVESTIGATE ANYTHING.
THERE ARE ABSOLUTELY NO.
PROVING CASES OF MEDICAL
FRAUDULENT WITH REGARDS
[inaudible]
TO SO.
SUPPOSE IT SALES OF VACCINES
THEY'RE EASY TO DO PROCESS HERE
BANG ON SO IF THE IF THIS IS THE
REASON THIS HAS COME.
INTO FRUITION SHOWS ONE CASE AT
THIS MOMENT.
THAT YOU KNOW THAT HAS BEEN THE
CASE OKAY THANK ME YES MA'AM.
I'D LIKE TO RESPOND -- CURRY
PLAYERS I'M SORRY SIR DID YOU
WANT TO RESPOND SENATOR PAN SO --
SO I WOULD SAY FIRST OF ALL AND
TWO ZERO PRISON THAT'S THIS ITEM
ON OUR SIDE ARTICLE WHICH
ACTUALLY -- WORDS HE SURVEYED --
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS WHO THEN
DID REVIEW MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
THEIR D. INDEMNIFIED SO THE
CONTENT OF BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
GET INFORMATION WITH THE
PATIENT'S NAME ON IT.
AT WHAT THEY FOUND OTHER
NUMEROUS CASES OF OF VERY --
SAYS THE SUSPECT MEDICAL
EXEMPTION SO INTERESTING AFTER
PULLING FROM A PAPER WHERE.
THE SURVEY PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS NAY SAID WELL ACTUALLY
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF REALLY --
SUSPICIOUS MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH UP SAID WE HAVE CONCERNS
AND THAT'S WHY PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER HERE WE HAVE CONCERNS.
THAT WE SEE THE ADVERTISEMENTS
AND ALL THAT GOING ON AND WHAT
YOU HEAR IS THAT FROM THE
MEDICAL BOARD.
AND I TALKED TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD YES INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO GET THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE THE PARENTS
ARE COOPERATING WITH THEM
THEY'RE NOT WILLING TO BE GIVEN
ACCESS TO THE RECORDS THAT THEY
NEED TO DO THE INVESTIGATION
THAT'S WHY.
THE MEDICAL BOARD CAN'T GO AFTER
THESE -- DVDS -- PARTICULAR
POSITIONS THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE ON MY QUESTIONS AND
AND MA'AM I WOULD HAVE LET YOU
RESPOND BUT I HAVE TO LET THE
SENATOR RESPOND.
BEFORE YOU I POLITICS.
OKAY SO -- BUT WE NEED TO GO --
TO SENATOR UNDER RAZA.
THANK YOU IT'S IT'S MORE OF A
COMMENT BUT YOU COULD TIE IT UP
FOR ME -- IS YOU KNOW I'VE
ALWAYS.
I'VE BEEN AROUND AND GROWN UP IN
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE TOO POOR
TO HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH -- THE
HEALTH COVERAGE YOU KNOW BE ABLE
TO GET THE ATTENTION THAT THEY
NEEDED.
AND ALWAYS ANXIOUS TO BE ABLE TO
GET.
YOU KNOW THE PROTECTIONS AND
WE'VE HAD.
TO REALLY REALLY INVEST IN
REACHING OUT AND PROVIDING.
A PREVENTATIVE OF OF MEASURES TO
HELP THEM -- AND SO IN SOME WAYS
I'M REALLY.
I'M REALLY GLAD TO HEAR THAT
THERE ARE SO MANY FAMILIES THAT
HAVE THAT ACCESS TO THE HEALTH
CARE THAT THEY HAVE THE DOCTORS
WHO ARE CARING FOR THEM AND FOR
THEIR CHILDREN'S.
I AM SO I'M TRYING TO SEE THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN ALL OF THIS
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME IT CAN'T
BE ONE OR THE OTHER IT CAN BE.
YES WE WILL MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE
OF VACCINATIONS IN THIS COUNTRY
HOW MANY COUNTRIES.
AROUND THE WORLD WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE OUR RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT.
BUT I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS OF SOME
FAMILIES AND SOME CHILDREN SO I
GUESS YOU KNOW I'M TRYING TO SEE.
WHERE ONE COMMUNITY?
AND AND AND PEOPLE WE DON'T LIVE
IN ISOLATION FROM EACH OTHER --
AND SO WE HAVE TO HAVE THIS CARE.
FOR EACH OTHER.
AND A SO I'M I'M TRYING.
TO YOU KNOW REACH THAT AND I
HEAR IT AND MAYBE YOU CAN
SUMMARIZE THAT IN IN A WAY THAT
MAKES MORE SENSE SO LET LET LT
ME.
GO BACK A LITTLE BIT HISTORY
BECAUSE YOU'RE FROM LOS ANGELES --
THERE WAS A LARGE OUTBREAK OF
MEASLES -- IN LOS ANGELES IN THE
LATE EIGHTIES I THINK IT WENT ON
FOR ALMOST A YEAR AND A HALF OR%
TWO YEARS.
THE FORTY OR ABLE TO CONTAIN AND
THAT WAS BECAUSE AT THAT TIME --
WE DID NOT HAVE SUFFICIENT
ACCESS TO VACCINATIONS FOR LOW
INCOME CHILDREN IN FACT AS A
RESULT OF NOT ONLY THAT OPERATE
BUT OTHER OUTBREAKS -- THE
PROGRAM PASS VACCINES FOR
CHILDRENPROGRAM THAT PROVIDED
FREE VACCINATIONS THROUGH THE
MEDICAID PROGRAM TO MEDI CAL
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. TOO LOW
INCOME CHILDREN -- SO -- SO THAT
WAS THE PREVIOUS PROBLEM WE HAD
WE SAID -- MEASLES OUTBREAKS THE
PROBLEM WAS IS LOW INCOME
CHILDREN WERE GETTING ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE TO COULDN'T GET
ACCESS TO VACCINATION RIGHT AND
WE HAD THE THANK YOU VERY LARGE
OUTBREAK IN IN LOS ANGELES -- I
WAS ACTUALLY IS A MEDICAL
STUDENT IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
PRESENT IN A OUTBREAK OF MEASLES
AND PHILADELPHIA.
IN THAT CASE -- THERE WERE A
COUPLE OF I GUESS RELIGIOUS
GROUPS THAT -- DIDN'T BELIEVE IN
MEDICAL CARE AND SO THEY WEREN'T
VACCINATED NEEDS OF THEIR ENDED
UP THERE WERE LIKE NINE HUNDRED
PEOPLE GOT MEASLES -- NINE
CHILDREN DIED OKAY IT IS IS IS A
TERRIBLE OUTBREAK.
AND NOT THAT ANY PERSON DESERVE
TO GET MEASLES BUT I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT IN THE CITY AT THE TIME.
HALF OF THE PEOPLE WERE MEMBERS
OF OUR WAS SO SILLY AND WITH
THOSE RELIGIOUS GROUPS THE OTHER
HALF OR NOT BECAUSE YOU SAID
WE'RE ALL ONE COMMUNITY.
RIGHT AND ULTIMATELY I MEAN THIS
IS THIS IS WHAT IT'S ABOUT
BECAUSE THESE ARE VERY
CONTAGIOUS DISEASES THEY SPREAD.
SO I TALKED ABOUT WELL BADGING
YOU HAVE A SCHOOL THAT HAS LOW
VACCINATION RATE SOMEONE BRINGS
IN MEASLES THEY GO ON A TRIP OR
SOMETHING COME BACK NOW IT.
IS TRANSMITTED TO ALL THE OTHER
KIDS IN THE SCHOOL BECAUSE
BEFORE TO GET SYMPTOMS RIGHT AND
THEN THOSE KIDS ARE ALL GOING
OUT AND THEY'RE GOING HOME AND
THEN TO GOING GROCERY SHOPPING
WITH THEIR PARENTS ETCETERA.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS YOU HAVE A
HUGE OUTBREAK BECAUSE BASICALLY
THE LOW VACCINATION RATES AS I
MENTIONED MY AN OPENING IS LIKE
TO TENDER FOR A WHAT YOU KNOW
OUTBREAK WILD FIRE.
RIGHT SO THEY COULD DO WANT TO
GET BECAUSE PICKS UP STEAM AND
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN
PHILADELPHIA AND THAT'S ALSO
WHAT HAPPENED LOS ANGELES AND
WHEN HE PICKS UP STEAM IT'S
REALLY HARD TO CONTAIN.
BECAUSE THIS THING JUST SPREADS
RAPIDLY SO YOU WANT IS YOU WANT
STANFORD OUT RIGHT WAIT JUST
LIKE OF WILD FIRE YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT WHEN THE FLAME IS SMALL
BECAUSE I TIME IT'S RUSSIAN UP
THE HILL.
AND IT'S BURNING THE BIG TREES
RIGHT THE IT'S REALLY HARD TO
STOP AND THAT'S WHY WE WANT TO
TAKE THE STEPS TO BE SURE WE
DON'T HAVE THESE POCKETS OF LOW
VACCINATION.
THAT THEN BECOME THE TENDER TO
LEAD TO THE FUEL IT OUTBREAK
THAT TENDS GONNA TAKE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF EFFORT TO
STOP AND MORE IMPORTANTLY IS
GOING TO SECOND AND POTENTIALLY
YOU KNOW HOT WILL CERTAINLY
HOSPITALIZED MEUSEL HOPLITES OUT
ONE IN FIVE PEOPLE.
AND MAYBE EVEN KILL SOMEONE
WE'RE FORTUNATE SO FAR NO ONE
HAS DIED OF WELL LET'S SEE WE'VE
HAD A COUPLE PEOPLE DIED OF
MEASLES IN THE LAST SINCE.
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND BUT YOU KNOW
THANKS TO THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
BEING VERY AGGRESSIVE ABOUT
TREATING PEOPLE WE FORTUNATELY
NOT HAD.
OTHER DEATHS BUT I BUT I CAN'T
GUARANTEE THAT WON'T HAPPEN.
I WOULD HAVE TO BY THE WAY
SEVENTY EIGHTY DEBTS AND IN
EUROPE LAST YEAR FOR MEASLES.
DID YOU WANT TO SEND RUBIO.
AND I KNOW THIRTY BEEN A LONG
DAY SO TRY AND SPEAK FAST AND
KEEP IT SHORT BUT FOR SO I JUST
WANTED KNOWLEDGE OF THE PARENTS
AND EVERYONE THAT'S HERE.
SPEAKING EITHER IN ALL FOR IT OR
AGAINST IT I KNOW IT'S A YOU
KNOW PEOPLE COME FROM FAR AWAY
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
VALIDATE YOU KNOW EVERYONE
THAT'S HERE AND THEY'RE
CONCERNED SO.
I JUST HAVE TO VERIFICATION
QUESTIONS AND I AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE SAID SO MUCH THROUGHOUT
THE BEES HOURS BUT FOR ME
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT I KIND OF
MISS DAN DI CAN YOU CLARIFY FOR
ME -- HOW HOW DO YOU HANDLE THE
SITUATION WHEN THERE'S A FAMILY
THAT ALREADY HAS A HISTORY OF?
OF VACCINE INJURY LIKE HOW DO
YOU PROCEED IN TERMS OF THEIR
CHILD THE NEXT GENERATION IS
THERE SOMETHING ALSO CERTAINLY
DEPENDS -- IT DEPENDS ON THE SO
FIRST OF ALL YOU'VE HEARD SOME
PEOPLE SAY THE CHILD IS A
VACCINE ENTRY INTO MENTIONED
THAT THAT'S AUTISM AND
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE EVIDENCE IS NOT THE OF THE
EVIDENCE HAS SHOWN NUMEROUS
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT AUTISM
IS NOT REALLY TO VACCINES SO WE
I THINK WE HAVE TO SEPARATE --
THINGS THAT ARE ACTUALLY RELATE
TO VACCINES FROM THINGS THAT MAY
NOT BE -- THAT'S BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE -- THE THE OTHER THING
I WOULD SAY IS THAT WE DO HAVE
WE DO THERE IS EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH AND CONSUMING
MONITORING OF VACCINATIONS
VACCINES ARE MOST DOLLY
EVALUATED BEFORE APPROVAL
THERE'S CONSTANT MONITORING
AFTERWARDS THERE'S THESE -- BASS
VACCINE DATA SAFETY LINK THEIR
MONITORING TO OBSERVE LOOKING AT
RECORDS THROUGH -- LARGE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE KAISER SO FOR
LOOKING FOR ANY POSSIBLE PATTERN
OF ANYTHING THAT MIGHT BE
RELATED TO THAT TWO TWO VACCINES
AND THAT'S WHAT GOES INTO THESE
GUIDELINES IN THE CONTRIBUTIONS
AND PRECAUTIONS SO.
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO BE SURE
THAT ANY CHILD WHO ARE THERE'S
EVEN A HINT OF A POTENTIAL RISK
THAT MIGHT OCCUR BECAUSE OF ACTS
VACCINATION THAT WE SEE ANY.
CHANCE OF THAT THAT -- WE WOULD
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY -- FOR
FOR THEM. ONE IMAGES -- BETTER
BECAUSE I HEARD A LOT OF PARENTS
COME UP FOR THEMSELVES AND HE
SAID YOU KNOW IF THEY'RE ADULTS
THEY SAID I'D HAVE BEEN VACCINE
INJURED AND THEY HAVE TWO
CHILDREN SAYING.
THAT THAT ON A VACCINATE SO I
JUST WANT TO KNOW LIKE TO
DOCTORS TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION CREATIONISTS THAT
PERTAINS TO THE CHILDREN OF
PEOPLE.
IN ADULTS THAT ALREADY HAVE THAT
EVIDENCE CERTAINLY IF THERE'S
SOME IF THERE MIGHT BE SOME
CONNECTION THERE THAT SOMETHING
THAT WOULD -- BE TAKEN THAT
CERTAINLY STAKING ACCOUNT
LOOKING AT THE RESEARCH FOR
EXAMPLE -- YOU KNOW PEOPLE EVEN
BY THE WAY THEY DIDN'T STUDY.
AUTISM RATES IN.
CHILDREN AND SIBLINGS OF A
FAMILIES THAT THEY HAVE OR HAVE
AN AUTISTIC CHILDREN AND RELATE
TO VACCINES AND FOUNDERS AGAIN
NO CONNECTION BETWEEN VACCINES
AND AUTISM -- SO EVEN IN THE
SIBLINGS OF CHILDREN WHO HAVE
AUTISM THE STUDY THAT SAID WELL
MAYBE THEY MIGHT BE AT HIGHER
RISK. FOR AUTISM RELATED TO
VACCINES AND TURNS OUT THERE WAS
NO ATTRACTION SO I MEAN THESE
THINGS ARE BEING EXTENSIVELY
STUDIED.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE -- I KNOW I HAD A
CONCERN ABOUT AND WE SPOKE ABOUT
THE APPEAL PROCESS YOU'LL
PARENTS NOT.
A FEELING THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO BE HEARD AND SO CAN YOU JUST
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT WILL HAVE
WHAT THT PROCESS LOOKS LIKE --
SO SO BASICALLY -- YES I'M SORRY --
SO WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS IS THAT
NGUYEN IF THE APPLICATION IS
REJECTED THREE BILLION
OPPORTUNITIES POSITION TO
PROVIDE.
LOOK AT THE REASON PROJECTION
AND IT'S IT'S FRIED ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION -- PERHAPS IT DID
THE DAY FELT THAT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER DID NOT GET.
THE FULL PICTURE OF THE ITEM AS
YOU SENATE INITIAL ONE RIGHT AND
YOU GO I THINK I PROVIDE ENOUGH
INFORMATION AND THEN THEY'RE
LIKE WELL MAYBE.
AND IN VERSES THAT WILL KNOW AT
BECAUSE ITAND SAID WELL
ACTUALLY DIDN'T REALIZE ABOUT
THIS SO I MEAN WE WANT TO GIVE
THE OPPORTUNITY.
AS AN OPPORTUNITY -- FOR TO BE
SURE THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER HAS THE FULL PICTURE AND
THE IN TERMS OF THE VALUATION
AND WE DON'T WANT SOMEONE TO BE
DENIED A MEDICAL EXEMPTION WHO
MIGHT POSSIBLY ACTUALLY.
NEED ONE SO WE WANT FOR A TREAT
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES.
AND AND I KNOW I'VE HEARD IT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN ABOUT LIKE
THE PATIENT AND FAMILY
RELATIONSHIP BUT AT ANY GIVEN.
TIME A DOCTOR COULD INTERCEDE IN
THAT APPEAL PROCESSES AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
OR EVEN WRITTEN TESTIMONY OR
EVEN PERSONAL TESTIMONY THEY CAN
DO THAT RIGHT YES WELL THEY THEY
WOULD PROVIDE IDEA OF DID MANAGE
OF WRITING THINGS I THINK IN
WRITING OR ELECTRONICALLY.
THAT TO TO THE TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT BUT I MEAN I A
DAY IN THE ACTUAL INVITATION WE
CAN CERTAINLY I MEAN I DIDN'T
WRITE IT INTO THE BILL BUT I'M
SURE WE CAN HAVE THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT ALSO THE PERSON MUST
CALL UP AND TALK OVER.
THAT MIGHT BE ANOTHER OPTION AS
WELL I CAN'T THINK OF IT I WAS
JUST CONCERNED WERE AND HE
THOUGHT IT PERSONAL MEDICAL
DOCTOR THAT HAS THE PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP COULD THEMSELVES AS
MUCH AS THE PARENTS SO MANY BUT
THEY COULD ALSO BE PART OF THAT
PROCESS.
YES YES THEY ARE PART OF THE
PROCESS THANK YOU I'M ALSO I I
YOU KNOW I WAS CONCERNED WITH
THAT YOU KNOW THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THE ALL
FAMILIES AND THEIR YOU KNOW
PERSONAL RIGHTS BUT DID I HEAR
CORRECTLY THAT THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN CHALLENGED IN COURT SEVERAL
TIMES.
AS YOU KNOW THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
SUCCESSFUL RIGHT SIR SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN HAS BEEN --
CHALLENGING QUITE THINK FOUR
TIMES I DON'T KNOW THERE'S A
DRIVERS FOR FIVE BUT IT AND
WE'VE.
WON BASICALLY -- IS ONE HELL OF
HELD IN ALL THOSE CASES SO IT
THERE'S AN APPELLATE COURT
RULING A CALIFORNIA PUBLIC COURT
RECENT CHALLENGE BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL COURTS.
AND IT'S BEEN UP HELD.
THANK YOU AND TO MY LAST
QUESTION IN THE ARMY BUT HE'S.
ALSO PIVACY IS A BIG CONCERN
RIGHT AND DIE AND I ALSO KNOW
THAT FOR A YEAR I HEARD YOU SAY
THAT THE INFORMATION GOES TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
WHERE THEY KEEP TRACK OF ALL THE
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN -- GIVEN
EXEMPTIONS AND BY WAY OF THAT
THEY'RE ABLE.
TO PICK OUT MAYBE A PATTERN AND
SEE WHAT DOCTORS ARE BEING AN
ETHICAL BUT JUST.
THAT'S NOT MY QUESTION I WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE PRIVACY ISSUE LIKE
WHAT SAFEGUARDS FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING FAMILY INFORMATION SO --
POINT OUT THAT THE FIRST OF ALL
THIS BILL DOES EXPLICITLY SAY.
AND IT'S ALSO IMPLICIT THAT THE
THE THAT -- ALL HELP A AND TO
BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE AND AND
STATE PRIDE MEDICAL HEALTH
PRIVACY LAWS HAVE TO BE FOLLOWED --
SO THAT'S ACTUALLY EXPLICITLY IN
THE BILL -- HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
ARE BOUND BY SO THERE ARE -- IN
HIP BUT THERE ARE.
YOU HAD THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
PATIENT DATA OF COURSE THEY HAVE
TO KEEP IT CONFIDENTIAL THEY
CAN'T LIKE JUST BY THE WAY
THAT'S WHY SOMETIMES WHEN YOU
SEE THERE'S A REPORT ABOUT.
A MEASLES OUTBREAK IN YOU GO
WELL AS CHILD BACKS NEAR NOT
THEY DON'T SAY ANYTHING IT'S
BECAUSE BUT THAT WAS BECAUSE OF
HIP BUT THEY MAY NOT BE ABLE.
TO REVEAL -- ACCESS PRIVATE THAT
COULD BE PRIVATE HEALTH
INFORMATION UNLESS THE FAMILY
ALLOWS IT TO BE REVEALED SO --
SO BASICALLY HELP OF FLIES AND
AND THAT THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT
IS.
IS ACTUALLY RESPONSIBLE UNDER
LAW TO KEEP THIS INFORMATION
PRIVATE -- THAT THEY WOULD NOT
BE PUBLICLY -- DISSEMINATING
THAT INFORMATION -- ITS ACT
ACTUALLY FOR EXEMPTION FOR
EXAMPLE THE HEALTH OF OUR DANCE
EXEMPTION THAT EXEMPTION WOULD
GO TO THE PHYSICIAN WHO HANDED
TO THE PATIENT WHO THEN GIVE IT
TO THE SCHOOL IT'S NOT LIKE
WE'RE JUST GOING TO GO AND PUT A
PUBLIC POSTER BOARD SAY WELL
THESE ARE ALL.
THE CHILDREN GOT EXEMPTIONS.
OTHER OUT OF THE SAME GENDER AS
ANY MEDICAL DOCTOR ANY YES YEAH
THERE ARE STANDARDS THEIR HELL
TO UNDER FEDERAL AND STATE LAW.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR ANSWER MY
QUESTIONS REALLY APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL YOU
HAD A FOLLOW UP LAUGHS LAUGHS
LAUGHS I PROMISE MISTER VICE
CHAIR -- AUTISM A FIVE BECAUSE
I'VE I'VE HEARD YOU VERY CLEAR --
ARE THERE ANY OTHER IT OUT AND
I'M CLEAR THAT THIS IS A LIST OF
REACTIONS.
AND SO ARE THERE ANY OTHER --
REACTIONS THAT A PARENT MAY HAVE
OR SUFFER.
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE A CONCERN
FOR WOULD LIKELY MEET THE
CRITERIA OF YOUR OF YOUR CURRENT
LEGISLATION IN TERMS OF EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT CHILD THEREFORE BE
WITH BECAUSE WE HEARD LOTS OF OF
FAMILIAL -- WHAT'S THE WORD I'M
STRUGGLING -- FOR COMPROMISED.
EXPERIENCES WITH VACCINES I'VE
HAD ONE CHILD OR TWO CHILDREN.
MULTIPLE GENERATION WE HEARD A
LOT OF THAT IN THE TESTIMONY
STILL STICKING AUTISM OFF THE
TABLE -- ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
THAT THERE WOULD BE A CONCERN SO
THE MAIN -- SO FIRST OF ALL THE
MOST FREQUENT VACCINE REACTION.
IS THIS SOME SORT OF ALLERGIC
REACTION ALTHOUGH THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY FAMILIAL SO FOR
EXAMPLE YOU HAVE ONE CHILD IS
ALLERGIC TO PEANUTS DOESN'T MEAN
THAT.
ALL YOUR OTHER CHILDREN ARE
RIGHT -- THERE ALSO BE IMMUNO
COMPROMISED AND DEPENDS ON THE
REASON FOR THAT SO VISITS TO
YOUR IMMUNO COMPROMISED BECAUSE
OF A GENETIC PROBLEM THEN OF
COURSE THEN THAT MAY BE A
SITUATION WHERE WE WOULD SAY.
WE WOULD HAVE TO SAY WELL LET'S
NOT.
LET'S CHECK THE CHILD'S IMMUNE
SYSTEM FIRST BEFORE WE WOULD DO
THAT SO THERE THERE COULD BE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THAT THAT
REGARD YES DEL FIVE YOU THE MOST
LIKELY SITUATION GOT IT GOT AND
I JUST WANTED.
TO SAY ALSO MY COLLEAGUE YOU
KNOW REFERENCE THIS YOUNG MAN
WHO SAT FEARING HANDLE HIS
BUSINESS DURING THIS SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND OUR HEARINGS LIKED
IT MIGHT OUT TO YOU YES AND ALL
THE OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE AND
CHILDREN -- IN THE AUDIENCE I
TIP MY HAT -- YOU KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HAVE A RE
HAVING A REACTION.
TO THIS IS A CONCERN ABOUT A
POTENTIAL.
AUTO IMMUNE CONDITION THAT WOULD
PREVENT SOMEONE FROM BEING --
IMMUNIZED IN THE FIRST PLACE AND
SO AS WE TALK ABOUT WHAT CHILD
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT OVER THE
OTHER TO GO TO PUBLIC SCHOOL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS SOMEONE
WHO HAD A UNFORTUNATE REACTION.
VERSUS SOMEONE WHO HAS A
POTENTIAL AUTO IMMUNE CONDITION
OR SOMETHING THAT WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THEY NOT BE IMMUNIZED IN
THE FIRST PLACE FIRST.
THAT'S WHERE I STARTED MY
QUESTION REALLY TRYING TO GET
THAT CLEAR DISTINCTION AND LET
ME JUST SAY OF MADAME MR CHERRY
BUT DOING A FABULOUS JOB I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THIS IS NOT
WAVING.
I SEE THAT WE'VE LOST OUR
TRANSLATORS BUT THIS IS AMERICAN
SIGN LANGUAGE FOR APPLAUSE SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT IT IS WE'RE
DOING IS NOT WAVING.
IT'S A PLUS TO A A SALE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER MONNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
HAVE A FINAL QUESTION BASED ON
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
PRESENTED TO US -- THAT
UNDERSTAND YOU'VE ACCEPTED THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT ACT YES.
THERE'S ONE IT PAGE TWO IN BOLD
TALKING ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT IN
CONSULTATION WITH LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS SHALL DEVELOP A
PROCESS BY WHICH A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
CAN BE REQUESTED BY A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN IN THE DEPARTMENT CAN
APPROVE OR DENY THE REQUEST.
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND COMMUNICATE
THAT DECISION IN A TIMELY
FASHION TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
HIM PARENT OR GUARDIAN.
QUOTES THE INTERPRETATION OF
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND TIMELY FASHION.
AND WHAT'S THE CAPACITY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ACT EXPEDITIOUSLY AND IN A
TIMELY FASHION SO WE WANT TO BE
SURE THAT -- THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IS THINKING ADVANCE
DEVELOPING MECHANISMS TO BE ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE -- A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION TO THE SCHOOLS.
RECOGNIZING BY THE WAY THERE'S
PRIVACY ISSUES SO THAT'S WHY.
IT'S NOT JUST LIKE YOU CAN GO
AND BLASTED OUT TO THIS THE
SCHOOL DIRECTLY NECESSARILY YOU
KNOW YOU THE PARENTS NEED TO BE
IN THE LOOP SO FORTH AND AFTER
ALL WE NEED TO KNOW WHICH SCHOOL
THEY'RE GOING FOR BECAUSE FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU GOT A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION LET'S.
SAY WHEN YOUR CHILD'S FAIRLY
YOUNG YOU MAY NOT KNOW WHAT
SCHOOL THEY'RE GOING TO SO THE
TOP HEALTH CRISIS WILL YOU HAVE
A MEDICAL EXEMPTION IN THIS THE
MEDICAL ATTENTION ISN'T SCHOOL
SPECIFIC BY THE WAY MEDICAL
EXAMS AS A MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
IT'S TO THE STATE INDIVIDUATED
INDIVIDUAL SO WE WE WANT BUT WE
WANT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT THANK IN ADVANCE
BECAUSE THERE MAY BE SITUATIONS
WHERE SOMEONE WAITED TILL THE
LAST MINUTE WE DON'T WANT
CHILDREN IN THE SCHOOL.
SO WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT THE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT'S THINKING AT
THE PUMP.
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH WORKING WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THINKING
ABOUT OTHER PRIVACY LAWS AND
OTHER TYPES OF MECHANISMS WE
HAVE TO BE SURE WE HONOR TO BE
SURE WE CAN COMMUNICATE.
AS AFFECTED AS EFFICIENTLY AS
POSSIBLE TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN A WAY THAT HONORS ALL THE
FISH OTHER ISSUES BUT ALSO BE
SURE TO ENSURE IS THAT.
OUR CHILDREN CAN ATTEND SCHOOL
IN THE TIE IN ON TIME SO WOULD
THERE BE A MECHANISM TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE.
APPLICATIONS -- REQUESTS FROM
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
SO THAT THE TASTING -- WE ONLY
WANT YET THAT'S THAT'S
POTENTIALLY -- DID SOMETHING
THAT -- HEALTH THE THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT THAT MIGHT MAY DO
RIGHT SO SOMEONE IS APPROACHING
SCHOOL LATER IN IN SCHOOL READY
IN MY FEARS IF WE LEAVE THIS
LANGUAGE EXPEDITIOUSLY TIMELY
FASHION.
IT'S TOO VAGUE SO AS THINGS MOVE
FORWARD TO HAVE SOME TARGETS MAY
BE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES SCHOOL
AGE KIDS -- THE TURNAROUND IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BE. TO FIND
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I APPRECIATE
THAT AND WE WILL CERTAINLY WANT
TO WORK WITH THAT THE PART OF
THE CALL TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S A
A SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE --
BOTH YEAH.
MEET YOUR GOALS AND AND AND AND
AND AND WORKABLE SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IS ARE YOUR QUESTIONS.
IF NOT -- DOCTOR PAN IF YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
SO I'M FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
FOR SO I'M A THANK YOU -- THRICE
CHAIR FOR EXCELLENT JOB --
CHAIRING AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
IT I ACTUALLY WHAT I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
TESTIFIED HERE SO ALL PEOPLE I
MEAN I KNOW WE SAT AND WE LISTEN
FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND IT.
REALLY THANK PEOPLE TO FOR THEIR
INTEREST IN COMING DOWN HERE AND
AND AND EXPRESSING THEIR THEIR
THOUGHTS ABOUT THIS BILL.
EVEN AS WE WERE -- HEARING THAT
TESTIMONY UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH
AT THREE PM TODAY THE CDC IS NOW
INDICATED THAT WE HAVE NOW
EXCEEDED THE HIGHEST NUMBER ON
RECORD IN A SINGLE YEAR OF DIZZY
HAVE MEASLES CENTERS ELIMINATED.
TWO THOUSAND THAT HAPPENED WHILE
E WERE HERE LISTENING TO THIS
TESTIMONY I THINK IT IT
INDICATES THE URGENCY.
OF US ACTING WE DID ACT BACK IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN PASSING TWO SEVEN
SEVEN THAT IS HELPING US LIMóN
OUTBREAKS BUT WE NEED TO BE SURE
WE TAKE THIS NEXT STEP. TO BE
SURE WE CONTINUE TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA SB TWO SEVENTY
SIX I I I I URGE YOUR I THOUGHT
THANK YOU -- THIS IS -- DO
PASSED -- TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
AS AMENDED LAND OVERLOOKING
PROMOTION I'M SORRY.
SO -- BY CENTERED AROUND SO --
AGAIN AMENDED THAT TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- PLEASE CALL
WORLD.
PAN HI CAN I STONE NO STONE NO
DURAZO.
DRAWS A I GROWTH.
NO HER TADO.
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING I RUBIO.
RUBIO HI.
THAT'S FIVE TO TWO THAT HAS THE
VOTES.
TO MOVE OUT OF COMMITTEE AND
THAT GOES TO APPROPRIATIONS I
THINK OF A HOLDING THE ROLE FOR
THE OPEN AND WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THE ROLE FOR THE OPENING OF THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARE. SIXTY TO
SIXTY TWO WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
FIVE MINUTE RECESS TO ALLOW --
OUR GUESTS.
TO LEAVE AND I THINK THEY FOR
YOUR ALL YOUR PATIENCE
NINE ONE
OF THOSE EIGHTEEN DEL STEP
PLEASE THAT.
MOVE OUT OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE
THANK YOU
.
ACTUALLY IF I CAN ASK THE S.
SERGEANTS TO HELP GUIDE PEOPLE
OUT OF THE ROOM I A IT IT'S I
KNOW YOU I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN HERE
WITH US THE WHOLE TIED TO THE
NEEDS.
OF THE TIRED AS WELL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO I T. A. C. CENTER SINCE WE
GOT FARSI CENTER BILL HERE SO
THE SENATE BILL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO APPROACH THE PODIUM AND BRING
UP YOUR WITNESSES FOR ITEM
NUMBER TWO SP.
ELEVEN GO AHEAD GET EVERYONE
READY HERE [inaudible]
THERE ARE.
SO IT'S A PEOPLE ARE COMING UP
AND OTHER PEOPLE ARE LEAVING THE
ROOM I A AS I'M SURE THE MEMBERS
OF MY COMMITTEE WE DO NOT NEED A
REMINDER APART REMIND ME.
IT IS NOW 717- PM -- AND WE ARE
WE HAVE COMPLETED JUST THREE
ITEMS ON OUR AGENDA -- SO.
I HOPE.
WELL I CERTAINLY DO NOT WANT TO
SHORT SHRIFT ANYBODY'S
PRESENTATION OR THAT TESTIMONY I
ALSO HOPE THAT PEOPLE KEEP IN
MIND.
THE OF BREVITY AND BEING TO THE
POINT IS SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED -- BY THE
COMMITTEE.
SO WITH THAT.
EVERYONE READY OKAY.
SO I'M OKAY SPENCER BELTZ SO
WITH THAT ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
ELEVEN WELCOME.
AND THANK YOU FOR WAITING FOR
HER.
THE PREVIOUS BILL ALL RIGHT
WEEKS OR MONTHS WHEN THEY SEEK
HELP FOR MENTAL HEALTH OR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE IS UNACCEPTABLE.
TODAY -- I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR
ON OUR AMENDMENTS WE HAVE A
MEMBERS WE ARE GIVING TO YOU.
WE ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND NARROW THE PARITY
REPORTING PORTIONS OF THE BILL.
NOW AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE MOCK
UP IN FRONT OF YOU THERE'S IS A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IS A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION TO SB
ELEVEN SO WE'RE ACCEPTING --
THOSE REPORTING PORTIONS -- I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WILL COME
BACK LATER -- IN THIS SESSION
PROBABLY NEXT YEAR OR MAYBE
BEFORE THEN -- ON THIS ISSUE --
THE AREA THAT -- WE PREFER NOT
TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS --
SUGGESTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
ARE THE ONES THAT WOULD RESTRICT.
ACCESS TO LIFE.
SAVING MEDICATION.
THIS IS THE TREATMENT AND WE
BELIEVE THIS IS TOO IMPORTANT TO
WATER DOWN SO.
WE HAVE THEM -- WITNESSES
EXPLAIN THAT TO YOU -- SO WE ARE
ACCEPTING PART OF THE AMENDMENTS
BUT NOT OTHER PARTS.
ADDICTION IS KILLING COUNTLESS
PEOPLE OVERDOSE AND SUICIDE
RATES ARE RISING.
CALIFORNIA JONES ARE PLACED IN
FOSTER CARE.
THAT IN THEM IS AMAZING RATE --
RIGHT NOW AND THEY'RE BORN
ADDICTED OR FACING LIFELONG
HEALTH STRUGGLES BECAUSE THEY
FEEL TO HELP -- WOULD BECAUSE WE
FAILED TO HELP THEIR PARENTS AND
WE HAVE KNOWN WE'VE ALL KNOWN
SOMEBODY THAT HAS -- SOME FORM
OF ADDICTION AND TRY TO GET HELP
AND HAD TO WAIT FILL -- BECAUSE
OF BARRIERS TO TREATMENT.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE MEDICAID
IS ASSISTED TREATMENT PART
MEDICAID ASSISTANT TREATMENT
WORKS -- PATIENTS GO WITHOUT
TREATMENT BECAUSE OF PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION.
STEP THERAPY -- REQUIREMENTS
MEDICAL NECESSITY REQUIREMENTS.
AND OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL
ACTUALLY ISSUED A STATEMENT IN
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR SAID THAT
NEARLY 90% OF THE PATIENTS IN
THE NEED OF ADDICTION TREATMENT.
SERVICES DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
TREATMENT -- ONE IN TEN ONLY
THESE HURDLES KILL PEOPLE.
WHEN A PERSON HAS TO WAIT THEY
WILL USUALLY FAIL?
WHEN A PERSON STRUGGLING WITH
ADDICTION -- IS WILLING TO WORK
WITH THEIR DOCTOR.
AND TRIED MEDICATION WE NEED TO
JUMP AT THE CHANCE WE CAN'T WAIT.
SB ELEVEN REQUIRES PRIVATE
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
PRESCRIBE TREATMENT. FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TO SOARED
WITHOUT PRIOR AUTHORIZATION.
OR STEP THERAPY WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO FILL FIRST.
AND WE WANT DOCTORS TO HAVE AN
ABILITY TO GIVE PATIENTS A REAL
SHOT AT RECOVERY.
NOW JUST IN THE PAST COUPLE
MONTHS -- AND I'M ONLY TALKING
ABOUT THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS
KENTUCKY VERMONT IN YOUR TO PASS
LEGISLATION.
UNANIMOUSLY TO REMOVE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION BARRIERS
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ALSO BE A
LEADER.
AND ARCHER BOURBON ANALYSIS ON
SB ELEVEN SAID OVER THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE WILL GAIN ACCESS
TO TREATMENT -- FOR APPEARED
DISORDERS AND TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
WILL GAIN ACCESS FOR ALCOHOL
TREATMENT.
THIS BENEFIT WILL NOT JUST --
WILL NOT JUST BENEFIT
INDIVIDUALS BUT THE WHOLE STATE.
AND THE FAMILIES OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS AS WE SEE A DECREASE
IN SOCIAL COSTS OF UNTREATED
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
TURNED ON MY WITNESSES -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT.
YOU HAVE SIX MINUTES TOTAL BE
AND HOW ME WITNESSES WE HAVE
HERE -- I THINK WE HAVE -- THREE
OKAY SO YEAH EXCELLENT GUILLORY
SURE THANK YOU -- MY NAME'S
DAVID LLOYD I'M A SENIOR POLICY
ADVISER WITH THE KENNEDY FORM
WHICH THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
FOUNDED BY FORMER CONGRESSMAN
PATRICK KENNEDY -- UP TOWARD A
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
ISSUES SO WE'RE WE'RE STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF SB ALIVE AND HOW
PARTICULAR THE S. THE SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER -- MEDICATION
PROVISIONS WE BELIEVE THAT THIS.
THIS IMPORTANT -- LEGISLATION
WILL SAVE LIVES AND LAST IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN NEARLY TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS ARE
DIED OF APPEARED OVERDOSES.
AND MEDICATIONS AS THE TREATMENT
IS REALLY THE GOLD STANDARD FOR
OPIATE USE DISORDER AND AND
SAVES LIVES.
BUT BURDEN SOME PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION HYPOTHESES AFFECT --
40% OF PATIENTS WITH PRIVATE
INSURANCE WHO ATTEMPT TO ACCESS
MEDICATIONS SISTER TREATMENT AND
THAT IS WHY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE NATIONAL GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION RELEASED A COMPACT
TO FIGHT AT ALL THE HOPE YO'RE
CRISIS IN WHICH FORTY SIX
GOVERNOR'S.
CALLED FOR REDUCING -- PAYMENT
AND MINISTRY BARRIERS TO
MEDICATIONS TO TREATMENT.
THE MEDIC THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IS ALSO CALLED FOR
FOR HAVING PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
TO STEP THERAPY MEDICATION
SISTER TREATMENT DRUGS.
AND AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE AMA
BROKE JUSTICE JANUARY -- QUOTE
THERE IS NO VALID REASON TO
DELAY OR DENY MEDICALLY PROVEN
CARE THAT CAN HELP IN THE
NATION'S OPIOID EPIDEMIC AND
IMPROVE PATIENTS' HEALTH AND
LIVES.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS IN
RECOGNITION OF THIS A BOTH CIGNA
AN ANTHEM HAVE AGREED TO END
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION FOR
MEDICATION SYSTEM TREATMENT
NATIONWIDE.
AFTER INVESTIGATIONS BY THE NEW
YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL GENERAL'S
OFFICE.
I'M IN THE LIST OF STATES --
CONTINUES TO GROW THAT ARE
PROHIBITED PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
MEDICATIONS TO TREATMENT IN JUST
THE PAST YEAR ILLINOIS MARYLAND
ARIZONA -- THE PENNSYLVANIA
ARKANSAS AND VIRGINIA HAVE
ENACTED LEGISLATION TO PROHIBIT
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS
MEDICATION SISTER TREATMENT. TO
HIGHLIGHTING THIS PROGRESS IN
FEBRUARY -- CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL BECERRA HAS CALLED FOR
ALL INSURERS IN CALIFORNIA TO
REMOVE PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL MEDICATIONS
HAS TO TREATMENT.
THEREFORE THE CALIFORNIA
BELIEVES ASK YOU LIVE IN IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE CAN ACCESS HE'S
LIFESAVING TREATMENT -- IT
LIFESAVING TREATMENTS AND URGED
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS RYAN HAMPTON I'M A
PERSON RECOVERY FROM OPIATE
ADDICTION THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE HERE TODAY I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A LONG DAY.
IT IS BEEN A VERY LONG JOURNEY
FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO FIND
SUSTAINED.
RECOVERY A LITTLE BIT OVER FOUR
YEARS AGO -- I WAS ON THE
STREETS OF SOUTH LOS ANGELES PAN
HANDLING FOR CHANGE.
I WAS TOO SICK TO FREE TO ASK
FOR HELP -- I HEADED TENDED OVER
A HALF DOZEN -- TREATMENT
PROGRAMS IN THE YEARS LEADING UP
TO THAT MOMENT IN MY LIFE EACH.
ONE HAD BEEN KIND OF ITS OWN
SPIN CYCLE OF SERVICES AND NONE
OF THEM OFFERING.
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
WHICH WAS EVIDENCE BASED CARE
WHICH EVENTUALLY -- WOULD SAVE
MY LIFE.
BUT I HAPPEN TO BE ONE OF THE
LUCKY ONES -- IN LATE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN I WAS ABLE TO
ACCESS THAT KERR WAS ABLE TO
ACCESS MATT AND THAT ALLOWED ME
TO BEGIN MY RECOVERY JOURNALING
JOURNEY.
I'M NOT ONLY A PERSON.
WHO IS FOUND RECOVERY FROM
OPIATE ADDICTION AND DEFIED?
PRETTY MUCH ALL THE STATISTICS
THAT SAY I SHOULD BE DEAD RIGHT
NOW -- SINCE ENTERING RECOVERY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WRITE A BOOK
I'VE STARTED A NON PROFIT IN MY
COMMUNITY.
I PAY MY TAXES SOME OF ODOR --
AND I'M PLANNING TO START A
FAMILY WITH MY PARTNER -- VERY
SOON.
I AM HERE TODAY BECAUSE
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
ALSO KNOWN AS MATT.
ALONG WITH THE CRITICAL SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT MUST COME WITH IT.
SHOULD NOT BE A MATTER OF LUCK
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LIKE IT WAS.
IN MY CASE AT THE HEIGHT OF OUR
NATION'S MOST PRESSING HEALTH
CRISIS AND I BELIEVE OUR STATE'S
MOST PRESSING HEALTH CRISIS
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
REASONABLE EXPLANATION TO THE
EXISTING BARRIERS. FOR THESE
LIFESAVING TREATMENTS THAT HAVE
ALLOWED ME TO LIVE.
I AM NOT THE ONLY PERSON WHO
BELIEVES THIS AND FEELS THIS WAY
EVERY SINGLE FEDERAL AGENCY THAT
HAS ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE
OPIOID CRISIS.
THE N. I. H. N. A. S. FTA HHS
NIDUS ANSWER THERE ALL IN
AGREEMENT ON THREE THREE KEY
POINTS ALL THE FDA APPROVED MEDS --
MEDICATION ASSIST TREATMENTS ARE
EFFECTIVE IN TREATING HOPE
YOU'RE USED TO SORTER.
ALL OF THE FDA APPROVED
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENTS
ARE UNDER UTILIZED IN THE
EXPANDED USE OF ALL OF THE FDA
APPROVED MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENTS IS CRITICAL. TO
ENDING THIS CRISIS.
AS I SIT HERE I DON'T BELIEVE
IT'S IN THE NEWS THAT WE KNOW
THE DEATH TOLL CONTINUES TO GROW --
THIS IS A CRISIS I DO BELIEVE
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE OUR
LEGISLATURE HAS A MANDATE TO DO
THEIR JOB AND PROTECT THE MOST
VULNERABLE OF OUR STATE.
NO MATTER WHAT THE COST MAY BE.
SAVING LIVES HAS GOT TO BE
PARAMOUNT.
I URGE YOU AYE BAG -- THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE PASS THIS BILL SB ELEVEN
EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIAN SHOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE A
HEALTHY ANY PURPOSEFUL.
LIFE AND I BELIEVE THIS
LEGISLATION WILL HELP INSURE
THAT'S NO MATTER AN INSTANCE OF
LOCK RATHER AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO SEEKS IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIRTY
FIFTY SECONDS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT
HARRIS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE
I'M GOING TO WE HAD THE FIFTY
YEP PUBLIC POLICY CHAIR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SITE HE HERE AND HE
HAD TO LOOK LEAVE.
HE'S ALSO THE CO CHAIR OF THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE PUBLIC POLICY.
AND I THINK HIS MESSAGES EVERY
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
YES.
BEN ESPECIALLY IT'S CRITICAL FOR
PEOPLE WHEN WHEN THEY START
RECOVERY AND THEY NEED A PLACE
TO STAY.
THEY GET LONG ACTING THINGS LIKE
THERE IS -- NALTREXONE.
IN A LOCK LONG ACTING.
INJECTION NOW THERE'S PEOPLE
NORTH IN THAT WAY BECAUSE IF
THEY HAVE TO GO TO A TO A A
PLACE TO LIVE THOSE PLACES CAN'T
OFFER MEDICAL SERVICES LIKE
GIVING HIM KEEPING MEDICATIONS
IN A LOCK BOX AND STUFF.
SO.
SO PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
PLEASE.
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND SEE
SACK PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MILEY'S A CALL WITH CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CORD DOWDY AMERICAN FOUNDATION
FOR SUICIDE PREVENTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND SPORT THANK YOU.
BRIAN B. SEND WITH THE NATIONAL
UNION OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
ALL OVER OUR GREAT CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OUR TOP BY A COMMON SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
NICOLE WATERMAN NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE UNDERCARD KARBI ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KEVIN CLARK I'M HERE
IN BEHALF OF CYNICAL FAMILY
VACANCIES IN MARIN SUPPORT.
HE CHAIN ADCOCK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
KAREN VESSEL MENTAL HEALTH AND
AUTISM INSURANCE PROJECT IN
SUPPORT YOU.
SO MY AND HER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TAMERA JIMENEZ PERSON LONG TERM
RECOVERY AND ON BEHALF OF LIGHT
HOUSE TREATMENT CENTER AN ORANGE
COUNTY RECOVERY COLLABORATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING GOING BACK AS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I A PROGRAM WITH ALCHEMY SUPPORT
ROBERT HARRIS ON THE HAVE VIA
SEIU CALIFORNIAN ARE SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND FAMILIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHARACTERS KILEY FAMILY
PHYSICIAN A BEEPING OR IF YOU
PROVIDERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY SEE SOMEONE ELSE COMMITTED
MICROPHONE HERE.
OKAY YES PLEASE AS I GOT THE
WRONG LINE MACHAR RE THIS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SEE NO ONE ELSE INTHE
MICROPHONE -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU PLEASE MAKE
SOME ROOM.
FOR MAYBE JUST MOVE AROUND THE
TABLE LITTLE BIT.
AGAIN SIX MINUTES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS NICK
LOUISE US ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
POSITION ON THE BILL -- WERE
HAPPY TO SEE THAT AMENDMENTS ARE
BEING TAKEN TO THE REPORTING
PROVISION OF THE BILL -- WHICH
WE FOUND TO BE DUPLICATIVE AND
UNNECESSARY HOWEVER WE STILL
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
DRUG FORMULARY PORTION OF THE
BILL WHICH WE BELIEVE.
SETS A NUMBER OF BAD PRECEDENCE --
JUST TO BEGIN -- MISTER AND
MEMBERS I'M SB ELEVEN IS -- IT
ESTIMATED TO INCREASE PREMIUMS
FOR EMPLOYERS AND INDIVIDUALS BY
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND INCREASES MEDI CAL
EXPENDITURES BY OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS IN THAT'S ACCORDING TO
THE INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS -- WERE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF BENEFIT
MANDATES THIS YEAR WHICH AS A AS
A AS AS A TOTAL -- PACKAGE OF
ALL BILLS IF YOU ADDED THEM UP A
REPRESENTS ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AN INCREASE
PREMIUMS ACROSS THE STATE -- YOU
KNOW WHICH SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WITH
RESPECT TO THE AFFORDABILITY OF
HEALTH CARE.
NOW ON TO THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL -- IN A WHILE HEALTH PLANS
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORTING COVER
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS RELATED TO
SUBSTANCE ABUSE -- DISORDER I'M
SB ELEVEN AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
SETS A NUMBER OF VERY
TROUBLESOME PRECEDENCE.
IT REQUIRES TO COVER THESE DRUGS
IN A MANNER THAT HAMSTRINGS ARE
MEMBERS ABILITY TO MAKE SOUND
COVERAGE POLICIES AND TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE BEST CLINICAL
EVIDENCE AND THE COST OF THE
DRUGS.
OUR OBJECTION TO THESE
PROVISIONS IS NOT BASED ON THE
INTENDED GOAL OF THE BILL RATHER
WE OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE IT
REQUIRES OR THIS PROVISION OF
THE PILL.
A BECAUSE IT REQUIRES PLANS TO
COVER THESE DRUGS IN A MANNER
THAT PREVENTS US FROM BASING
COVERAGE POLICIES -- ON ON ON
REASONABLE CONSIDERATIONS NOW
JUST BY WAY OF A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES OF HOW REMOVING
COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY REMOVING
ANY.
MEDICAL MANAGEMENT UTILIZATION
MAN AND OF MANAGEMENT OF THESE
DRUGS I'M COULD HAVE --
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES -- ONE
DRUG THAT IS USED -- FOR THE
TREATMENT OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS BEEPING AFTER RAIN
WHICH IS ALSO AN OPIOID.
AND IS SUBJECT TO MISUSE -- IT
IT ALSO COULD BE DEADLY FOR
PATIENT IF IT IS MIXED WITH
ANOTHER DRUG -- WHERE IT HAS A
NEGATIVE INTERACTIONS SO YOU FOR
EXAMPLE MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT --
BEN'S WITH A DAY AS A TEEN IS IS
A DRUG THAT -- IS COMMONLY USED
FOR MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS AS
WELL -- YOU KNOW AS SUCH AS
SCHIZOPHRENIA IF THAT IS USED
WOULD BE DOT BEEPING AFRICAINE
THAT COULD BE A VERY VERY --
DISASTROUS SITUATION FOR THE
PATIENT TAKING THAT THOSE TWO
DRUGS IN COMBINATION THE HEALTH
PLAN MIGHT BE THE ONLY ENTITY
THAT HAS A LINE OF SIGHT ON TO
ALL OF THE DRUGS.
THAT A THAT A PERSON MIGHT BE
TAKING PARTICULAR THAT PERSON'S
GOING AT A NETWORK FOR TREATMENT --
ON THESE DRUGS WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT SIDE EFFECTS AND
WE THINK WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN REASONABLE MEDICAL
MANAGEMENT ON THESE DRUGS -- YOU
KNOW IN SOME CASES YOU KNOW NOW
TRICKS OWN COMMONLY KNOWN AS
VIVID TRAWL HAS A LOW
EFFECTIVENESS RATES -- HOWEVER
ACCORDING TO THIS BILL WE WOULD
HAVE TO COVER IT WITHOUT ANY
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION DESPITE THE
FACT THAT IN MANY CASES -- IT
MIGHT NOT WORK FOR A PATIENT --
IT'S ALSO VERY EXPENSIVE WHICH
GETS TO THE POINT OF THE
PROVISION OF THE BILL THAT
REQUIRES ALL SUBSTANCE ABUSE
RELATED DRUGS TO BE COVERED ON
THE LOWEST TIER.
WITHOUT ANY REGARD TO COST ANY
DRUG THAT WAS.
APPROVED BY THE FDA HAS TO BE
COVERED AT THE LOWEST HERE NO
MATTER HOW EXPENSIVE IT IS NO
MATTER WHAT IT WHETHER IT WORKS
OR NOT SO MANY.
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF OF A
NUMBER OF THE REALLY BAD
PRECEDENT SET BY THIS BILL WE'RE
WILLING TO WORK YOU KNOW WITH
WITH THE AUTHOR -- IN THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL TRY WORKS
ON THESE ISSUES OUT BUT TO
COMPLETELY ERASE ANY MEDICAL
MANAGEMENT F THESE DRUGS YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE -- IT PUTS THE PLANS
IN A POSITION TO COVER BAD
MEDICINE.
AT THE WRONG TIME FOR THE WRONG
PEOPLE POTENTIALLY AND SO-- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO MAINTAIN OUR
OPPOSITION TO THAT PROVISION OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. SEVENTY
WALKING THE MAP OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WE TO WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
TODAY I WOULD ECHO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS WE WOULD
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT.
ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL OUR SISTERS
SO SHE XIN A HIP ALONG WITH THE
AN AC ARE WORKING WITH HOSPITALS
PROVIDER GROUPS TO COME UP WITH
THE MORE STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION.
AND BEST PRACTICES WE THINK THAT
WOULD BE A BETTER OPTION FOR US
TO LOOK AT ESPECIALLY FOR A LOOP
LOOKING TO LIMIT ACCESS TO PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION OR LIMIT OUR
ABILITY FOR MEDICAL MANAGEMENT
TOOLS WE CERTAINLY WANT
PROVIDERS TO DO THEIR JOB WE
WANT THEM TO PROVIDE THE BEST
CARE.
POSSIBLE TO THEIR PATIENTS BUT
REMOVING COMPLETELY OUR ABILITY
TO USE ANY MEDICAL MANAGEMENT
TOOLS WE THINK IS A BIT SHORT
SIGHTED IN THE LONG TERM OF
MAKING SURE THAT.
PATIENTS HAVE THE BEST CARE
GIVEN THE FACT THAT OFTENTIMES
PLANS ARE THE ONLY ONES WHO HAVE
A FULL LINE OF SIGHT OF ALL THE
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE PRESCRIBED
AND THAT ARE BEING COVERED.
WE CERTAINLY THINK WE PLAY A
ROLE IN NOT AND FOR THAT REASON
STAY WE'RE STILL OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YEAH JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
EXACTLY POINTED OUT A HIP HAS
BEEN ON THE FRONTLINE NTIONALLY
WITH THE STOP INITIATIVE THE
SAFE TRANSPARENT OPIOID
PRESCRIBING INITIATIVE AND WE
ARE LOOKING TO REMOVE BARRIERS
ON PRIOR AUTHORIZATION.
AND INCREASING MATT --
UTILIZATION BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THIS BILL STILL THE GOES A
LITTLE TOO FAR WE LOOK FOR TO
HAVE AN FOR THE CONVERSATIONS ON
IT PURPOSE.
THANK YOU.
KAREN CIRCUIT SCENE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WERE OPPOSED DUE TO THE
INCREASED HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS
FOR EMPLOYER EMPLOYERS AND AN
ORAL LEASE.
THANK YOU.
CASEY NO OTHER.
WHAT IS THAT THE MICROPHONE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CENTER STONE [inaudible]
FIGURES CHAIR -- SO I GOT A FEW
QUESTIONSFOR YOU NEXT -- IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT SIGNIN
ANTHEM GREETER MOVE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT IN
RESPONSE TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IN NEW YORK -- AND THEIR PARITY
INVESTIGATIONS SO IF SICKENING
ANTHEM CAN AGREE TO MOVE THESE
BARRIERS WAY. TO OBJECT
PROHIBITING AUTHORIZATIONS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL IS NOT LIMITED TO
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
THIS BILL -- INCLUDES ALL
SUBSTANCE ABUSE RELATED DISORDER
DRUGS.
SO I MEAN I EN L. SO THAT'S THE
FIRST I'VE HEARD OF THIS SO WE
WILL LOOK INTO THAT BUT THIS
BILL IS NOT LIMITED TO MATT
[inaudible]
OKAY -- IT EVEN SAYS ON THIS ON
THE WEBSITE IF PROHIBITING PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION HARMS PATIENT
SAFETY WHITE IS.
CIGNA TODD ON ITS WEB PAGE THAT
TO SAVE LIVES AS A PART OF THE
OPIOID CRISIS THAT REMOVES PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS SO -- YOU KNOW IT
I THE PHARMACIST NOW FOR I HATE
TO ADMIT IT -- THIRTY SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS.
AN OLD TIME WENT.
AND I'VE ALWAYS -- HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS IT
KINDA DROVE ME FROM RETAIL
PHARMACY TO GOING TO COMPOUNDING
JUST DEAL WITH CASH CUSTOMERS
INSTEAD OF INSURANCE CUSTOMERS
PRESS SPENDING. 25% OF MY TIME.
DEALING WITH A PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS ARE PEOPLE THAT WERE
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THE DRUGS --
I HAD TO CALL ON BEHALF OF
PHYSICIANS.
IT OUT IN A LETTER THAT WE GOT
FROM.
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CBH THE EIGHT THEY CLAIM THAT
ONE IN.
TEN AMERICANS SEEKING A
MEDICATION FOR ADDICTION
TREATMENT ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
LARGELY -- DUE.
TO UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
POLICIES THE POSE SIGNIFICANT
OBSTACLES SO.
WE HAVE AN OP A CRISIS.
AND IT'S EXACERBATED BY HAVING
OPIATES A CLAIM TO BE ONE OPIATE-THAT AREN'T THAT OLD YET THERE
ACTUALLY ANOTHER OLD VIçT.
NUMBER FOR INTO HEROIN VERSUS
PH<c.cyan> N WE HAVE A A LOT BUT</c>
THEN AGAIN THIS COUNTRY
[inaudible]
AND I'VE HAD.
TO FAMILY FRIENDS OF LOS
[inaudible]
THEIR CHILDREN [inaudible] TO
OVERDOSES OF FENTANYL.
THINKING THAT THEY ARE BEING
TREATED WITH -- THEY WERE
UTILIZING WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS
HEROIN. ONE OF THEM HAD BEEN
THROUGH A PROGRAM -- METHADONE.
BUPRENORPHINE AND AND FAILED --
I'VE ALWAYS SEEN PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS AS A IS A WAY --
TO MORE THAN QUESTION THE
EFFICACY OF A DOCTOR'S DESIRE TO
USE A PARTICULAR DRUG.
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES --
OBSESSION IF YOU WILL WITH
SAVING MONEY.
AND IT COMES DOWN TO THE
QUESTION -- WHAT IS IT WHAT IS A
LIFE WORTH?
YOU KNOW YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
NOW TRACKS ON THEM IT'S FUNNY
YOU MENTION OF TRACKS ON BECAUSE
WHEN I WAS -- AN INTERNET -- USC
SCHOOL OF PHARMACY WE HAD
EXTERNSHIP PROGRAMS AND I WAS
INTERNING AT RANCHO LOS AMIGOS
HOSPITAL.
AND THE HEAD OF THE TREATMENT
CENTER THERE -- HE GAVE EVERY
STUDENT CAME THROUGH A A DRUG
THAT THEY HAD TO RESEARCH IT WAS
AND PROGRESS OF BEING APPROVED.
AND FUNNY WAS NOW TRUCKS ON THAT
WAS MY DRUG SO I I BECAME
INTIMATELY INVOLVED WITH NICK
NOW TRUCKS ON OVER THIRTY FIVE
THIRTY SIX YEARS AGO.
AND LEARN WHAT -- INCREDIBLE
DRUG THAT THAT IS IS YOU KNOW
IT'S RELATED TO NALOXONE
OCCUPIES THE OPIATE RECEPTORS --
HAD.
OUR FRIENDS OR FAMILY IF THEIR
KIDS WERE ON NALTREXONE -- THEY
WOULD PROBABLY STILL BE ALIVE
TODAY.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW.
SUSTAINED RELEASE NALTREXONE IS
NOT A CHEAP.
INTRACTABLE YOU KNOW YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH --
YOU KNOW I I GO BACK TO
HEPATITIS C. -- YOU KNOW WE WE
WE HAD A NEW DRUG THE CAME ON
THE MARKET -- QUITE A FEW YEARS
AGO CALLS OF ALL DAY RIGHT.
IF IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN I THINK A
NUMBER OF THE HEALTH PLANS
REQUIRED ACROSS THE RESERVATION
FIRST OF ALL DAY.
WHY NOT BECAUSE IT WAS
EFFICACIOUS IN CURING HEPATITIS
C.?
BUT BECAUSE WAS COSTING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR
TREATMENT.
SO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU COMPARE THE
COST OF WELL IF WE PUT PEOPLE ON
INTERFERE ON IN ANOTHER DRUG TO
TREAT THEIR HABSI -- THEY'RE
ULTIMATELY GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
A LIVER TRANSPLANT WHICH IS
GOING TO BE HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS AND UNDER GOING TO BE
PROBABLY ON A MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF ANTI REJECTION DRUGS.
AND SO -- I HAVE A CONCERN THAT.
THE PATIENT'S BEST INTEREST.
IS IS NOT ALWAYS FIRST AND
FOREMOST WHEN IT COMES TO
PICKING MEDICATIONS -- FOR THEIR
TREATMENT AND I I I AND I REALLY
GET UPSET BECAUSE WE TALKED
ABOUT BEFORE IN IN THE LAST --
ISSUE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF A
DOCTOR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT A
TECHNICIAN ON A TELEPHONE LINE
WHEN I'M GOING TO CALL AND GET A
DRUG WITH THIS DOCTOR CLAIMS IS
UNIQUE AND IMPORTANT FOR THIS
PERSON.
SHOULD NOT BE GRANTED. TO BE USE
WITHOUT GOING THROUGH MULTIPLE
BARRIERS ARE BUREAUCRACY WITHIN
A HEALTH PLAN TO SOMETIMES TAKE
DAYS -- TO TO ACCOMPLISH NOW I
CAN UNDERSTAND IF YOU HAVE A
BRAND NAME AND GENERIC.
I AM 1100% IN FAVOR OF GENERIC
SUBSTITUTION WHEREVER POSSIBLE --
OR IF YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
PHARMACOLOGICAL CLASSES OF DRUGS
WE GOT SOME ALL DO YOU GOT A FEW
OTHERS NOW.
YOU CAN MAKE YOUR BEST DEAL WITH
WHATEVER COMPANY AND GET YOUR
REBATES AND LOWER YOUR COSTS FOR
YOUR YOUR INCH IT YOUR INSURANCE
COMPANIES BUT THE PATIENT IS
GOING TO GET A STATE OF THE ART
MEDICATION.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS A
WE WANT A STATE OF THE ART
MEDICATION AND COMPLIANCE IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO TREATMENT OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE OPIATE.
ISSUES AND A CAT HAVE DELAYS THE
CAN HAVE BARRIERS AND YES YOU
KNOW -- AS WE SEE NEW TREATMENTS
COME ONLINE.
PREMIUMS MAY GO UP YOU KNOW I'M
SORRY THE PREMIUMS IN ABOUT
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT.
IF IT'S MY SON OR MY DAUGHTER
THIS GOT AN OPIATE ADDICTION AND
THEIR DOCTOR FEELS AT THEIR
MEDICATION SHOULD BE A COSTLY
MEDICATION.
THE COULD SAVE THEIR LIFE
INSTEAD OF USING SOMETHING THAT --
THEY COULD POTENTIALLY FAIL WITH
IN AS THE FILL WITHOUT THE THE
TRAGIC SIDE EFFECT IS THEY COULD
DIE [inaudible]
SO -- WE WE NEED -- TO IT
EMBRACE THE STATE OF THE ART
THERAPY -- FOR THESE EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE
THAT COME TO US THAT WANT TO GET
HELP.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THAT THAT
THAT'S A BIG STEP SIR YOU KNOW
AND I AND I WANT TO APPLAUD YOU
FOR FOR YOU FOR YOU.
SEEKING HELP IN TURNING YOUR
LIFE AROUND -- I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU IF YOU WERE START STARTED
OUT WITH STEP THERAPIES -- OR
WERE YOU MERELY PUT ON YOU KNOW
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THE TALL AND
HOW DID YOU MANAGE YOUR SUCCESS
SO I I ACTUALLY HAD TO FIGHT TO
GET ON TO IT -- MEDICATIONS TO
TO TREATMENT -- IT WAS VERY HARD
FOR ME TO GET ON THIS LAST TIME
AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT I WAS ABLE
TO GET ON IT BECAUSE IT SAVED MY
LIFE BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW I I I TRY TO KEEP MY
EMOTIONS OUT OF THESE HEARINGS
AND AND WHEN THIS COMES UP BUT I
HAVE.
PERSONALLY STOOD OVER THE GRADES
OF TWENTY SIX OF MY FRIENDS IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS WHO HAVE DIED
FROM OVERDOSES. TO TWO YEARS
MEDIAN AGE WE'RE PROBABLY
TALKING TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
YEARS OLD GOOD KIDS PEOPLE LIKE
SONS DAUGHTERS EMPLOYEES -- THEY
ALL WANT TO HELP A LOT OF THEM.
WERE THE NUMBER ONE STORY COMING
OUT WAS MY INSURANCE COMPANY MY
KIDS INSURANCE COMPANY OR MY
INSURANCE COMPANY WON'T PAY FOR
TREATMENT.
AND THEY CANNOT GET TREATMENT
BECAUSE OF THE BARRIERS THAT
STILL EXIST AND THAT IS WRONG
AND AND I UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WE
GET CAUGHT UP IN THE THEN THE
COST.
AND I HEAR FROM INSURANCE
COMPANIES THAT THAT THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE THEN THEY'RE GONNA
PUT THE COST ON TO CONSUMERS.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS --
THE THERE IS I I BELIEVE THERE
IS NO COST THAT IS THAT.
THAT MAKES A JUSTIFICATION FOR
JUST THE PEOPLE THAT ARE BURIED
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
IT IS WRONG AND AS A PERSON
WHO'S WHO IS ON THE FRONT LINES
WATCHING THIS I'M SO SICK AND
TIRED OF HEARING THAT ARGUMENT.
AS A JUSTIFICATION -- TO TO
PUTTING UP BARRIERS TO TO
TREATMENT LIKE THAT HAS GOT TO
STOP BOB THANK YOU AND I PER
PROCEDURE ANSWERED AND I'D LIKE
TO RESPOND ALSO I HAVE A GREAT
DEAL OF RESPECT -- FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND AND I UNDERSTAND SOME OF
THESE BIG PLANS OR OR MEMBERS OF
THE CHAMBER -- BUT I'M GONNA
QUOTE FROM THE CHAMBERS LETTER
THAT THE HIGHER PRICED DRUGS --
NOT PROVIDING BENEFITS
COMMENSURATE WITH THE COSTS YOU
KNOW -- SINCE WHEN DOES THE
CHAMBER ANDERS UNDERSTAND --
PHARMACOLOGY MEDICAL BENEFITS
BETTER THAN THE PHYSICIANS THAT
ARE WRITING FOR THE
PRESCRIPTIONS I MEAN I'M JUST.
OUTRAGE THAT -- THEY COULD MAKE
A COMMENT LIKE THAT THEY CAN
THEY CAN POSE IT CERTAINLY CAN
OPPOSE IT BUT DON'T DON'T
QUESTION THE THE THE
PROFESSIONALISM OF THE PHYSICIAN
THAT'S DOING THE BEST THEY CAN
TO PROVIDE THE THE BEST THERAPY.
FOR FOR IT FOR THEIR FR THEIR
PATIENTS -- IT LOOKS AS THOUGH
THAT -- COSTS SEEMS.
TO OVERRIDE -- CLINICAL EVIDENCE
AFFECT EFFICACY WHEN THESE
FORMULARIES ARE MADE AND I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND.
THE BENEFITS OF TO THE INSURANCE
COMPANY OF DOING THAT BUT IF WE
HAVE A DRUG AND AND IF YOU AND
PROBABLY WHEN YOU SEE THE HOW
THE HIGHER TIER DRUGS.
ON FORMULAR USE IN MOST CASES
THEY WERE UNIQUE.
THEY HAVE A VERY STE -- SPECIFIC
PHARMACOLOGY NOT FOUND WITH ANY
OTHER DRUGS THERE'S THERE'S
GENERIC.
SUBSTITUTE AND THEY PROVIDE
USUALLY A A QUICKER HIGHER
QUALITY OF LIFE FROM PROVIDE
HEALING AND AND TREATMENT.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THOSE OF THE
DRUGS AND HAVE THE HIGHEST
COPAYS ANOTHER ONCE THE HARD TO
GET FROM INSURANCE COMPANIES
BECAUSE OF THIS.
BUREAUCRATIC MAZE OF GETTING
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION AT YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES TAKE NOT DAYS BUT
SOMETIMES TAKE SIX WEEKS TO GET
THEIR SENATOR I I HATE TO
INTERRUPT BUT I JUST HAD SOME
BELOW CONSCIOUS OF THE I'M
ALMOST A TIME AND NICE REALIZE
UPRIGHT LAST PERSON BRING IT UP
WITH YOU.
BUT YEAH I APPRECIATE THAT
[inaudible]
SO.
YEAH IT IS GOING.
I'M SURPRISED THEY KNOW ANYTHING
OTHER THAN SAYING THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO.
SO I'LL JUST I'LL JUST CUT TO
THE CHASE YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT WE REMOVE
BARRIERS.
AND OTHER INSURANCE COMPANY
CIGNA MATH OF A RECOGNIZE THAT
WITH THIS CLASSIFICATION OF
MEDICATIONS FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE --
OPIATE OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PROBLEMS WE HAVE SOME GOOD
MEDICATIONS OUT THERE YES THEY
ARE EXPENSIVE I UNDERSTAND THAT --
BUT WE HAVE A GROWING EPIDEMIC
AND MY LITERATURE SHOWS THAT ONE
OUT OF TEN ARE SUCCESSFULLY --
GETTING OF THE MEDICATIONS THAT
THEY NEED AND EVEN PHYSICIANS OR
OR REPORTING -- DIFFICULTY LIKE
41% AND AND HAVING CHALLENGES IN
GETTING TH THEIR PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS.
THROUGH AND GETTING THEM
APPROVED IN SOME CASES THE
PATIENTS JUST COMPLETELY --
ABANDON THE EFFORT OF TRYING TO
GET THE DRUG BECAUSE OF SUCH A
PROBLEM TO ANYWAY NECK I I KNOW
I THROUGH A WHOLE LOT OF JUDAH I
KNOW YOU HEARD REPRESENT YOUR
CLIENT -- BUT WHAT WHAT CAN WE
DO.
TO THE ENSURE THAT WHEN SOMEBODY
AS HAS AN OPIATE PROBLEM WHEN
YOU GOT A CURRENT IT'S GOT A A
CHILD IN IT THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO.
AND WE'VE GOT THESE GREAT DRUGS
ON THE MARKET BUT WE WE WE WE
GOT A BREAK THIS BUREAUCRATIC
MORASS STUDY TO GET THEM THAT
THE DRUGS THAT THEY DESPERATELY
NEED AND DESERVE. ONE WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL.
AND SO I THINK IF WE ARE ABLE TO
RETAIN.
THE ABILITY TO USE A GENERIC
INSTEAD OF A BRAND WHICH THE
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM DOES
NOT ALLOW.
THAT WOULD GO A LONG WAY IN IN
THE VERY LIMITED CASES WHERE
THERE IS AN IMPORTANT CLINICAL
REASON. FOR US TO REVIEW THE
APPROVAL OF THE MEDICATION AND
FOR INSTANCE THE DRUG
INTERACTION WHICH CAN KILL THE
PATIENT THINGS LIKE THAT THEN I
THINK THAT WOULD GO A LONG WAY
IN ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS.
SO -- YOU KNOW OUR OUR POSITIONS
NOT JUST COST BASED.
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I'VE KNOWN
YOU TO BE A PROFESSIONAL
LOBBYISTS HERE IN SACRAMENTO THE
SHORT TIME THAT I'VE BEEN HERE
AND I WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO WORK WITH IT WITH THE
AUTHOR.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE GENERIC
SUBSTITUTION SEN -- YOU KNOW
THIS WHY WE WE URGE -- SINCE TWO
DOT ONLY USE THEIR DOCTOR BUT
ALSO CHOOSE ONE PHARMACY WHETHER
IT'S AN INDEPENDENT PHARMACY IS
CVS.
FOR A WALGREENS SO WE CAN
MONITOR THOSE THOSE DRUG
INTERACTIONS TO MAKE SURE.
THAT -- WE'RE WE'RE PROTECTING
THE PATIENT GIVEN THE THE MOST
HOLISTIC CARE THAT WE POSSIBLY
CAN THANK YOU MISTER.
OKAY THANK YOU OF ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY AND FORTUNATELY I DO HAVE.
WHICH I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS --
MYSELF -- AND I AT FIRST WILL
CENTER BY APPRECIATE -- OUR
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS BILL -- I
APPRECIATE YOU TOOK THE
AMENDMENTS REGARDING THE
REPORTING FROM A PARITY -- I AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP AS
A CHAMPION FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PARITY AND ALSO -- SUBSTANCE USE --
TREATMENT IN FACT -- YOU KNOW
THIS COMMITTEE DISAPPEAR
PRIORITY HEALTH INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THIS VERY TOPIC.
I AM.
CHALLENGED ABOUT THE TOTAL LACK
OF ANY FORM OF REVIEW ROUND THE
MEDICATION SO I'LL I SHARE YOUR
GOAL I MEAN I MEAN WE ABOUT
TRYING TO BE SURE WE HAVE A SET
OF MEDICATIONS.
WHERE THERE WERE THERE ISN'T FOR
IT IN DIFFERENT CLASSES SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET ACCESS WE DON'T
WANT WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE CAN GET
ACCESS? TO MEDICATION BUT I AM
CONCERNED THAT IF WE'D
COMPLETELY SAY WELL BY LAW WE'RE
GONNA REQUIRE YOU COVER
EVERYTHING NO MATTER WHAT.
A AND I'M A PHYSICIAN SO I I I
GET AND I I THINK THAT SOUNDS
GREAT.
UNTIL THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT YOU
KNOW I HAVE A BILL TO MANDATE
HEALTH COVERAGE WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO FUND SUBSIDIES FOR HEALTH
INSURANCE -- AND SO WE WANT TO
BE SURE PEOPLE GET ACCESS
TREATMENT WHY OF COVERAGE YOU
CAN GET ACCESS TREATMENT BUT YOU
ALSO WANT TO BE A HAVE SOME
MECHANISMS TO TO TO TO TO HELP
MODERATE. TO AN UPWARD PUSH ON
PRICES OF JUST FOR EXAMPLE --
YOU KNOW THE LOCKS ON WHICH
COSTS A DOLLAR A DECADE AGO IS
NOW A HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS AND
THEN NOT INJECTORS FORD FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED NOT WE CAN
GO AND DEVELOP THE PHARMACY.
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT WE DON'T
GIVE ANY MECHANISM. TO TO TO
PURCHASE OF FOR EXAMPLE I CAN
SEE THE THE HEALTH PLANS REPOSE
IF THERE'S A GENERIC AVAILABLE.
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU'D BE OPEN
TO OR IS IT ACTUALLY HAS TO BE
WHATEVER THE DOCTOR PRESCRIBES I
MEAN I IN SOME WAYS I KIND OF
LEAN TOWARD THAT BUT I HAVE TO
SAY AS A POLICY MAKER I'M NOT
SURE I CAN GO THAT FAR -- WHEN I
GOT THE -- COMMITTEE MEMBER AND
SO ON MONDAY DURING THE SESSION.
AND I HAD A COUPLE DAYS TO
REVIEW THEM -- AND I SAW THAT
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRETTY
MUCH GOT IT THE BILL -- I
DECIDED I WOULD ACCEPT.
PART OF THE AMENDMENTS AND NOT
ACCEPT THE PART OTHER PART OKAY
SO MY MY PURPOSE TODAY IS TO GET
THE COMMITTEE TO APPROVE.
THE BILL.
AS I'M SUGGESTING HOPEFULLY.
AND IF YOU HAVE SOME FURTHER
REFINEMENTS I'D BE HAPPY TO TALK
TO PEOPLE I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE OTHER AND NEVER HAVE.
BUT QUITE FRANKLY -- WHEN I SAW
THE COMMUNITY AMENDMENTS IT
ACTUALLY MAKES IT WORSE THAN THE
CURRENT SITUATION?
THEN -- WE HAVE NOW IT ACTUALLY
GOES BACKWARDS.
IN CALIFORNIA GIVEN THE FACT
THAT YOU ATTORNEY GENERAL'S HAVE
GOTTEN CIGNA AND THE OTHER -- AT
THE OTHER HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
BY A LAWSUIT. TO AGREE -- TO
FULL OF MEDICALLY ASSISTED
TREATMENT SO SO FOR ME -- YEAH I
I'LL TALK YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TALK
TO THESE GUYS -- FOR TWELVE
YEARS THEY NEVER SUPPORT ANY OF
OUR MENTAL HEALTH BILLS HOWEVER.
WE CAN STILL TALK TO ON FOOD BUT
AND AND I'M SURE THE OTHER
PEOPLE WILL TOO BUT THE
PRINCIPLE THAT I WANT TO I WANT
TO GET YOU TO VOTE FOR TODAY
THIS IS THE PRINCIPLE.
THAT YOU SHOULD NOT IMPEDE.
MEDICALLY ASSISTED TREATMENT FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO DO.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO HAVE THAT AS
THE THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION -- IF YOU HAVE
SOME REFINEMENTS ON ON GENERICS
ARE ALL THAT I'D BE WILLING TO
TALK TO THIS THE FIRST TIME I'VE
HEARD THAT THA'S AN IDEA LET'S
TALK ABOUT IT -- THOSE ARE
THINGS I CAN TALK ABOUT I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN ABLE.
TO WORK OUT TO THE ISSUES WITH.
MY COLLABORATION WITH EVERYBODY
IS CONCERNED ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
I THINK WE MADE SIGNIFICANT --
CONCESSIONS. TO BE HONEST ABOUT
IT I THINK THAT -- THE REPORTING.
IS INADEQUATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE GOT AN ELF.
IN TERMS OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS.
SO WE'RE NOT REPORTING.
AND WE'RE NOT ENFORCING MENTAL
HEALTH PARITY.
IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
BUT WHAT I'D LIKE TO GET THE
COMMITTED DATE IS SUPPORT.
MEDICALLY ASSISTED TREATMENT
WITHOUT PRIOR AUTHORIZATION JUST
LIKE ALL THE OTHER STATES ARE
DOING.
JUST LIKE ALL THE OTHER STATES
ARE DOING THEY'RE ALL DOING IT.
AND THEY'RE ALL DOING IT BECAUSE
EVERY SINGLE NATIONAL
ORGANISATION.
CALLING THE MEDICAL ORGANIZATION.
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IS
RECOMMENDING THAT.
SO.
THAT'S THAT'S MY RESPONSE I MEAN
A I IF I FAIL TO GET SUPPORT FOR
THAT -- JUST BE BACK NEXT YEAR.
THANK YOU WELL -- OKAY SO I I
FIRST OF ALL I WANNA MAKE NOTE
THAT -- I THINK THERE ARE.
ONLY TWO STATES TO HAVE LIMóN
AND SUCH ABOUT PRIOR OFF BUT NAY
JUST PUT IT THIS WAY -- CENTER
ABOUT FIRST OF ALL I I I DO
SHARE YOUR GOALS -- I I I I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF ANY.
EFFORT TO TRY -- TO YES TRUTHS
THE MECHANISMS TO TRY TO AT
LEAST TO BE SURE THAT WE
PRIORITIZE THE YOUNG WE WANT
WANTS THAT WORK I MEAN MANY OF
THEM WORK.
WE WANT TO BE SURE OF YOUR
PEOPLE OF ACCESS TO NEARLY I
DON'T WANT TO MEDICAID YELTSIN
FEATURES AT LEAST ONE IN EVERY
CLASS OF NOT MORE THAT PEOPLE
CAN ACCESS IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT
HAVING TO GO THROUGH ANY
BARRIERS.
I'M GOOD WITH THAT -- I THINK
THE ISSUE IS IT'S A SAY THAT ANY
SPLIT ANY POSSIBLE TREATMENT.
IS IS SO LET'S JUST PUT IT THIS
WAY I I APPRECIATE YOUR DESIRE
YOU EXPRESSED DESIRE TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS.
UNFORTUNATE I PERSONALLY AM NOT
UNTIL WE CAN FIGURE OUT SOME
KIND OF MECHANISM -- THEY CANNOT
DEAL NOT DENNIS ALTHOUGH IT WAS
WAS I I WANT THE BILL TO MOVE
OUT I'LL GIVE YOU IF IT TURNS
OUT YOU NEED COURTESY PHOTO DO
THAT -- BUT I ALSO BECAUSE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO CAN YOU TO WORK ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WE CAN PUT IN SOME
REASONABLE.
MECHANISMS THAT STILL ALLOW
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT ANY I WANT
PEOPLE NOT TO HAVE SEEN EVEN
BARRIERS TO GETTING TREATMENT SO
I I I I I CHAIR YET GOAL.
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN
STRIKE A BETTER MIDDLE GROUND
FOR WE STILL BE SURE PEOPLE
ACCESS REMOVAL WOULD JUST DON'T
LEAVE IT SO OPEN ENDED.
THAT OF WHATEVER DATA WE HAVE NO
OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO EXERT SOME
EFFORT -- TO TO BE SURE PEOPLE
BOTH GET QUALITY TREATMENT AND
ALSO SOME COST EFFECTIVENESS AS
WELL -- THEN AND IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT THE DOLLARS SO I SAW
CENTER MITCHELL'S HANDLES A IS A
RITUAL.
A YES OKAY.
YES.
A DIFFICULT QUESTION I
CLARIFICATION THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE COMMITTEE DISTRIBUTED.
ARE THEY THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS OR ARE%
THEY THE AMENDMENTS THAT --
SENATOR BILL HAS AGREED TO
ACCEPT.
OF THOSE AMENDMENTS FOR A I
THINK WHAT THE SERGEANTS AND
DISTRIBUTED ARE SENATOR BELLS
AMENDMENTS.
THAT M. HE SAID THAT'S PARTIALLY
WHAT THE COMMITTEES SUGGEST THIS
IS WHAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARSENAL OF THE DEMAND SO YOU'RE
THE DIMENSIONS THAT YOU ARE
ACTUALLY ACCEPTING OUR DAUGHTER.
ACCORDING -- REDUCE AGO TALKING
ABOUT THE REPORTING ISSUE.
IN THE FUTURE OF THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE I'M COMING -- STILL
PROBLEM -- BUT THE MEDICALLY
ASSISTED TREATMENT -- WE WOULD
LIKE.
TO HAVE YOU ADOPT ARE REQUESTED
AMENDMENTS OKAY THANK YOU ARE
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AYE AYE.
THE SENATE BILL -- I I AGREE
WITH.
A LOT OF WHAT THE BILL IS DOING
ESPECIALLY WITH PARITY IN.
NINETEEN YOU WERE WORKING ON
THIS LONG BEFORE I CAME TO THIS
INSTITUTION [inaudible]
SO.
I THINK THE MAYBE YOU MAY WANT
TO CONSIDER -- AN AMENDMENT. TO
WORK WITH THE STAFF THAT SAYS
THAT.
NUMBER.
ONE IF THERE'S A GENERIC
AVAILABLE FOR ANY DRUG.
UNLESS THE DOCTOR RISE DO NOT
SUBSTITUTE ON THAT PRESCRIPTION.
THAT PATIENT GETS THE GENERIC
DRUG UNLESS THEY OBJECT TO WANT
TO PAY FOR THE BRAND IN
THEMSELVES [inaudible]
SO -- I WON IT AND IT IS A PART
OF A POTENTIAL AMENDMENT.
I THINK THE AMENDMENT SHOULD
READ THAT -- THE THE COST. FOR A
UNIQUE DRUG. FOR WHICH THERE IS
NO GENERIC EQUIVALENT.
SHALL NOT REQUIRE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT I'M KIND OF LOOKING FOR AND
IF IF A DRUG DOES REQUIRE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION BECAUSE MAYBE FIND
A DRUG INTERACTION.
THAT WE IT IS INCUMBENT UPON.
THE PLANNED TO RESPOND BACK.
WITH AN APPROVAL OR DENIAL
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS BECAUSE
IT'S THESE DELAYS THAT GET IN
THE WAY OF PEOPLE GETTING THE
TIMELY TREATMENTS THEY NEED I
THROW THIS OUT THERE IS A
SUGGESTION SO MAYBE YOU WANT TO
CONSIDER.
BECAUSE I'D LOOK TRYING TO
BRIDGE THE GAP MINE BUT I I OF
OF I DON'T KNOW HOW TO REACT TO
THAT TODAY.
I'M SORRY AWESOME SUGGESTIONS
I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
AND PLANS ON THAT BUT I THINK IT
I THINK IT ACCOMPLISHES SIR WHAT
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
AND WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE YOU GET
ACCOMPLISHED HERE.
WITH THAT.
SO OKAY.
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
AT GROWTH.
OKAY THERE'S A MOTION FROM
CENTER MONEY AS OUR GROWTH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND I WASN'T GONNA ASK A
QUESTION ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN HERE LATE IN THIS AND
THAT CHAIR HAD ALREADY SPOKEN
BUT I WHEN YOU WERE TALKING AND
ANSWERING A RESPONSE AND ANOTHER
QUESTION YOU SAID THAT.
THIS BILL THAT YOUR BILL FOCUSES
ON THE IN MAY TEACH JUST THE
DRUG ITSELF -- TO GIVE SOMEBODY
AN OPTION -- LIKE THIS GENTLEMAN
RIGHT HERE BUT IN THE LANGUAGES
SAYS ALL.
ALL PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS.
NOT JUST A MEATY SO.
IS FOR FOR THAT PURPOSE FOR THAT
PURPOSE BUT IS IT IS ALL
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS AND NOT
JUST IMAGE ICE WANNA CLARIFY.
IT'S ALL.
YES SO IT IS ALL PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATIONS AND NOT JUST IN THE
THAT PURPOSE YET OKAY THANK YOU
SIR ON MEDICATION FOR MEDICALLY
MEDICATED THIS IS THE TREATMENT --
MEDICATIONS.
ARE USED FOR THAT FOR USE FOR
THAT PURPOSE.
SUDDENLY USES ORDER OF WHAT
SORRY MR LOUISE SO SIDE OF ME TO
CALL YOU NICK I APOLOGIZE MISTER
LOUISE'S CAN YOU PLEASE CLARIFY.
IS IT ALL.
AM I MISUNDERSTAND ALL SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDERS DRUGS SO OKAY
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT IS.
THE AUDIO TYPICALLY USED FOR
OPIATE ADDICTION OKAY.
SO IT'S NOT JUST MATT.
HE SAID THIS IS ALL PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
DISORDERS YEAH WHICH WHICH AND
ROUGHLY HOW MANY ARE THOSE YEAH
I KNOW GOES BEYOND MAP BUT LIKE
ROUGHLY.
GIVE ME A NUMBER.
YOU KNOW I'D HI IT WOULD BE A
WILD GUESS AND I WANT TO GIVE
YOU ANY WRONG INFORMATION AYE
AYE BUT I'D BE HAPPY.
TO I THINK IT'S AS I BURKE SAID
THIRTEEN DRUGS THERE'S THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN DRIVE THAT ENDED ABOUT
RIGHT THIRTEEN DRUGS YEAH IT'S A
SERVICE UP INTO THIS ORDER
THERE'S A THERE'S TOBACCO USE
DISORDER AND THIS OPIATE USE
DISORDER THIS ALCOHOL USE
DISORDER.
BUT THE PRIMARY OF MOST OF THE
DRUGS ARE.
FOR YOU JUST ORDER.
OKAY I I APPRECIATE AND I I JUST
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND IF IT WAS
JUST MATTER FOR SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE DIED OF DRUG
OVERDOSES.
IN THE COUNTRY.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND DIED.
SO WE'RE RISING AND RISING
QUICKLY [inaudible]
AND I THINK THE STATES ARE
TRYING -- TO OPEN THE DOORS TO
MEDICALLY ASSISTED TREATMENT. TO
STOP THE RISE -- CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE PART OF IT I REGION
ABLE ON THIS BILL THIS WILL HELP
STEM THE TIDE.
THE TIDE'S NOT WE'RE GOING THE
RIGHT WAY FOR US PEOPLE WERE THE
HOT MILK THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE
DYING.
IN OUR STATE.
WE NEED TO STOP THE TIDE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN.
RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
STONE.
STONE I DORADO [inaudible]
GROVE.
GROVE KNOW HER TADO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
AS OF IT.
YES YES AND MITCHELL AYE MONNING
AYE AYE MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I FIVE THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES -- IT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT
WE'RE GOING TO BE HOLDING THE
ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY THANK YOU -- NEXUS --
CENTER NIELSEN ITEM NUMBER THREE
SP.
ONE NUMBER OF PEACE BUT SB
[inaudible]
ONE FIFTY SIX THANK YOU
NEXT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
I WILL ENDEAVOR TO BE VERY BRIEF.
THESE TWO BILLS I'LL BE
PRESENTING RELATE.
TO DEALING WITH DISASTERS
[inaudible]
THE RECORD.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO OCCUR.
THE CAMP FIRE WHICH DEVASTATED.
PART OF THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT.
AND THESE OTHER FIRES AS WELL
BUT ON THE IN SPECIFIC THE CAMP
IN THIS REFERENCE.
AFFECTED THOUSANDS OF LIVES.
AND ALSO THE LOSS.
OF A SMALL HOSPITAL.%
THE CARED FOR THAT AREA
[inaudible]
THE RAGE.
PARADISE ANOTHER SMALL
COMMUNITIES IN BUTTE COUNTY.
THAT WAS CATASTROPHIC AND IT DID
NOT JUST AFFECT [inaudible]
THE RAGE [inaudible]
AND PARADISE.
IT REFLECT THE AFFECTED A
BROADER AREA.
THE ONE HUNDRED BED FACILITY
THERE IN PARADISE.
WAS ONE OF THE FEW ACUTE CARE
RESOURCES.
IN THE WHOLE COUNTY.
IT WAS INTEGRAL. TO THE PEOPLE.
THEIR PEACE OF MIND TO KNOW ON
OF THEIR ACCESS.
CLOSER. TO THEIR HOMES ARE
COMMUNITIES.
AND IT IS FAIRLY ISOLATED AREA
[inaudible]
THE ADVENTISTS WHICH RUNS THIS
FACILITY.
THEY HAVE A CONFIRMED THAT THEY
COULD GET THIS FACILITY UP AND
OPERATING WITHIN JUST A FEW
MONTHS.
THE WAS DEVASTATED AT IS BIN.
WE'VE WORKED WITH THE SPOT
SHERMAN.
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. TO
ENSURE THE VERY LIMITED SCOPE.
OF THIS BILL. TO PROVIDE THE END.
FOR THE FEATHER RIVER HOSPITAL
[inaudible] TO CONTINUE. TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES.
NAY.
BY FOUR BY THIS BURKE VIRTUE OF
THIS THEY WOULD COMPLY WITH THE
NURSE PATIENT RATIOS AND
STAFFING.
HAVE A PHYSICIAN CERTIFIED
[inaudible]
EMERGENCY CARE.
ON SITE AT ALL TIMES.
AND AT HERE TO ALL EMERGENCY
ROOM REGULATIONS.
CURRENTLY WITHIN THE STATE.
AS A PATIENTS SEEN AT THE
FEATHER RIVER HOSPITAL.
WOULD BE SERVICED ANOTHER
ADVENTIST HOSPITAL.
REASONABLY NEARBY RIGHT OUT.
IN MARYSVILLE.
BY THIS THE HOSPITAL COULD APPLY
FOR TWO YEARS SPECIAL PERMIT TO
OPERATE AT SEA ARE SERVICES.
AND ALSO RE APPLY TWICE FOR
PERMITS FOR UP TO A MAXIMUM OF
SIX YEARS.
IT'S BEEN THE POLICY IN THIS
STATE TO NOT ALLOW STAND ALONE
EMERGENCY CARE DEPARTMENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE NORMAL CONTINUUM
OF CARE.
BUT I BELIEVE THE NEWS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
THAT THIS MOMENT.
AT SUCH CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES AND IN LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES AS WOULD BE
IMPOSED BY THIS BILL
[inaudible]
ARE WARRANTED.
IT THE PURPOSE IS SIMPLY TO
ALLOW.
COMMUNITIES HOSPITALS
[inaudible]
SERVING AREAS. TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND. TO THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
IN A SAFE SETTING.
AND THEN.
IN THIS THIS PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY A GOOD WORKING TOWARDS
A MORE PERMANENT FACILITY.
WITH ME TODAY THAT THE KEPT
SHORT REPRESENTING ADVENTIST
HOSPITALS FOR HER TESTIMONY OKAY
THANK YOU -- I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT -- THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES IT IS EIGHT OH SEVEN PM SO --
YOU'LL HAVE SIX MINUTES TOTAL
BUT IF YOU WISH TO USE LESS IT
WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
HI THIS SAID SHORT MOVED
PRESENTING ADVENTIST HEALTH I'M
GOING TO DEFER MY TESTIMONY
EXCEPT TO SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE CHAIR
AND HIS STAFF -- IN WITH THE
REST OF THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE ARE HAPPY TO
TAKE TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
I'M RICK ROSS IN THE PRESIDENT
OF EVAN THIS HEALTH AND RIGHT
OUT WHICH INCLUDES HAVE BEEN
ASSAULTS OPERATIONS IN BUTTE
COUNTY.
PARTICULARLY FOR THE RIVER
HOSPITAL IN PARADISE.
HAVE BEEN A SELF INCLUDES
SEVENTEEN HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY HOSPITAL BASED RURAL
HEALTH CLINICS.
WE HAVE A DEMONSTRATED
COMMITMENT TO RURAL HEALTH CARE
ANSWERED SOME OF OUR STATES MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. FOR THE
RIVER HOSPITAL IN PARADISE IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT COMMITMENT.
BEFORE LAST FALL'S CAMPFIRE IT
WAS A ONE HUNDRED BED THRIVING
ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL THAT HAVE
BEEN AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE
COMMUNITY FOR NEARLY SEVENTY
YEARS.
THE HOSPITAL SERVED A RURAL
COMMUNITY WITH MORE THAN 80% OF
OUR PATIENTS COVERED BY MEDICARE
AL OR MEDICARE.
MANY WITH SUBSTANTIAL CHALLENGES
AND TRAVELING DISTANCES FOR THE
CARE THAT THEY AND THEIR
FAMILIES NEED.
WE EMPLOYED MORE THAN THIRTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
LIKE MOST OF THE COMMUNITY OF
PARADISE OUR HOSPITAL -- SUSTAIN
SUBSTANTIAL DAMAGE DURING THE
CAMPFIRE.
WHILE THE MAJORITY OF THE QUEUE
CARE FACILITY RECEIVE SUCH
DAMAGES TO BE CURRENTLY
INOPERABLE ARMOR AGENCY
DEPARTMENT WAS A NEWER
CONSTRUCTION AND SUSTAIN MORE
LIMITED DAMAGE.
OUR COMMUNITY WHILE DEVASTATED
AND CONTINUES TO HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
PRIOR TO THE FIRE THE FEATHER
RIVER EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT SAW
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY PATIENTS
PER DAY.
MANY OF THE AREA HOSPITALS HAVE
SEEN SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
THEIR EMERGENCY VISITS SINCE THE
CAMP FIRE.
WHICH HAS IMPACTED ACCESS TO
CARE ACROSS THE REGION.
PEOPLE FROM NEARBY TOWNS ARE NOW
TRAVELING AS LONG AS AN HOUR TO
REACH AN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
IN ADDITION LOCAL OFFICIALS ARE
ESTIMATING THE APPROXIMATELY TWO
THOUSAND UTILITY AND
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ARE COMING
TO WORK IN PARADISE EACH DAY AND
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS.
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THEIR
DIFFICULT WORK THESE WORKERS ARE
MORE AT RISK FOR TRAUMATIC
INJURY REQUIRING EMERGENCY CARE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE PEOPLE OF
PARADISE OTHER NEARBY
COMMUNITIES WOULD BENEFIT FROM
HAVING EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES IN PARADISE.
WE APPRECIATE THE UNIQUENESS OF
OUR REQUEST BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WE IN OUR COMMUNITY OR IN
AN EXCEPTIONALLY UNIQUE
SITUATION.
WE DO NOT YET KNOW WHICH OF OUR
NEIGHBORS WILL BE COMING BACK.
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN AND WHERE THE
REBUILDING WILL OCCUR.
AND WE WON'T FOR AWHILE HOWEVER
WE DO KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW.
OUR COMMUNITY IS IN DESPERATE
NEED FOR CARE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE.
ARMOR AGENCY DEPARTMENT WILL
PROVIDE NEEDED CARE THAN OTHER
TYPES OF CLINIC FACILITIES
CANNOT.
INCLUDING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
EMERGENCY CARE AND DIAGNOSTIC
SERVICES.
PROVIDED BY HIGHLY SKILLED AND
VALUED EMERGENCY SERVICES
PROFESSIONAL STAFF.
WHEN OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
PATIENTS NEED A HIGHER LEVEL OF
CARE WHAT STABILIZE WE ARE
EQUIPPED WITH THE HELIPAD THAT
CAN HANDLE ALL EMERGENT
TRANSPORTS?
HELICOPTER SERVICE CAN GET A
PATIENT TO NUMBER HOSPITALS
INCLUDING RIGHT OUT.
HOSPITAL WHICH IS PART OF OUR
SYSTEM IN TWENTY MINUTES IN THE
END LOW MEDICAL CENTER IN LESS
THAN.
TEN DURING THAT TRANSPORT
PATIENTS TO BE UNDER THE
CONSTANT CARE OF TRAINED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY SIX WILL
ALLOW HAVE BEEN A CELL. TO
RESTORE ROLE EMERGENCY SERVICES
TO OUR COMMUNITY WHILE
CONTINUING TO ASSESS WHAT THE
COMMUNITIES MEDICAL NEEDS.
ARE AS ARE KIND COUNTY REBUILDS.
WE REMAIN AS COMMITTED AS EVER
TO PARADISE AND TO BI<c.cyan> COUNTY.</c>
AS WE ASSESS WHO COMES BACK AND
WHAT KIND OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THEY NEED.
AS WE HAVE FOR MANY YEARS WE
WILL CONTINUE TO RESPOND AND TO
SERVE.
IN THE SHORT TERM HOWEVER
EVIDENCE HEALTH IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SENATE BILL.
ONE FIFTY SIX WHICH IS AIMED AT
BRINGING NEEDED EMERGENCY
SERVICES BACK TO THE DEVASTATED
COMMUNITY PARADISE.
AND WE ARE JURAI VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AGAIN WE HAVE SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES.
TRIMMERS ALEX SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO PLEASE COME UP. TO
MAKE ROOM FOR THEM PLEASE.
AND YOU CAN JUST MOVE OVER A
LITTLE.
AREA OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER TURN
MEMBERS BRIEFLY I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF THE
CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS LEGISLATION --
WE WERE STRONGLY OPPOSED AND
WITH THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY --
THE NURSES ARE HAPPY TO MOVE TO
AN OR NEUTRAL POSITION.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARK
WINDOWS A WITH US HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA -- AS A NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS WE WERE -- AT THAT
POINT AT AN OPPOSE IN THIS
AMENDED POSITION -- THE CURRENT
PROPOSED LANGUAGE I THINK WE'LL
BE IN A MUCH BETTER SPACE AFTER
LOCALS BELIEVE AT THE LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I THINK THERE'S A MOTION FROM
CENTER STONE -- SEND YOU
SOMETHING SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND WORKING WITH --
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE SAFF ON
THE SO WHICH IS LIKE THE CLOTHES.
URGENT NOT AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
NIELSEN MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN HI CAN I STONE STONE I
DORADO.
GROWTH GROUP I HER TADO.
LEYVA MITCHELL MONNING.
MONNING I RUBIO.
RUBIO I FIND THAT TO HAS FIVE
VOTES IT'S ENOUGH TO GET IT OUT
BUT WILL HOLD ON ROLE FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY SO YOU ALSO HAVE A SECOND
BILL WHICH I UNDERSTAND ALSO HAS --
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES IT'S ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB.
THREE EIGHTY TWO AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS AS THE FORMER BILL
COULD BE MODELS FOR FUTURE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF SUCH EMERGENCY.
AND TRAGEDIES.
IN TERMS OF SERVING.
THE PATIENTS.
MOST HEALTH PLANS OF THE SYSTEM
THE HOSPITAL'S DIRECTING
PATIENTS TO LOWER LEVELS OF CARE.
WHEN THAT CARE?
BUT THE HIGHER LEVEL IS NO
LONGER NEEDED.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
INSTANCES WHERE LITTLE POLLS
HAVE BEEN USED TO AVOID
[inaudible]
KAREN. FOR THOSE PATIENTS.
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO THEN.
IS CLARIFY EXISTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR HEALTH PLANS TO ASSIST THE
HOSPITAL IN IDENTIFYING AND
TRANSFERRING PATIENTS TO THE
LOWER LEVELS OF CARE.
SUCH AS SKILLED NURSING.
IF THERE'S NO AVAILABILITY THE
LOWER LEVELS OF CARE THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE HEALTH PLANS
TO REIMBURSE HOSPITAL AT
EXTREMELY LOW.
AND MODEST AMOUNTS.
ALLOWING THAT CARE [inaudible]
TO CONTINUE.
IN THAT MORE MODEST.
OR LIMITED.
FOR IT IS NOT TO BE LOOKED AT AS
A MANDATE.
BUT A TRANSITION TRANSITION AND
INSURANCE.
ASSURANCE NOT INSURANCE WITH AN
ASSURANCE TO THE PATIENTS.
ALL RIGHT HERE TO TESTIFY IS
MISTER ALEX HAWTHORN
[inaudible]
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL [inaudible]
ASSOCIATION.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS ON SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOSTILE SITUATION
PROUD SPONSOR THIS BILL LIKE TO
THINK THE SENATOR FOR BRING IT
FORWARD AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR HARD WORK -- IN MAKING IT
STRONGER WITH THE AMENDMENTS TWO
THINGS VERY BRIEFLY THIS IS A
NEW MANDATE ON HEALTH PLANS THIS
IS A NEW REQUIREMENT.
THIS CLARIFIES EXISTING
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER VERY
EXTREME SITUATIONS.
THE THING I POINT OUT IS THAT
THE REIMBURSEMENT OR ASKING FOR
IS IT CREDIBLY LOW IT'S THE MEDI
CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATE -- MORE
HOSPITALS DO NOT RECOVER THEIR
COSTS WITH MEDI CAL AND WE'RE
NOT INTENDING THIS TO PUNISH
HEALTH PLANS.
MOST OF THE HOSPITALS ARE
FACTORED IN RURAL AREAS -- IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO STAY IN
THESE SITUATIONS THE BILL'S VERY
MODEST TO WE WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I HEARD THERE'S A
MOTION FROM SERRA GROVE -- WHAT
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
FUNNY DELGADO ON BEHALF THE
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORM IN SUPPORT.
OKAY SEEN OWNERS OF THE
MICROPHONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME UP
.
SEVENTY WALKEN'S ON BEHALF OF
THE EFFICIENCY OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS WE HAD A VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION RECENTLY.
AND AND COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL
THAT.
TRIED TO CRAFT THE BILL IN A WAY
THAT WAS MEANINGFUL AND
IMPACTFUL TO THE PLANS I THINK
THE ONE ISSUE THAT WE STILL
REMAIN AND WOULD LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT IF THE BILL DOES MOVE
FORWARD IS A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PLAN IS A WHERE WHEN
SOMEONE IS NOT MOVING OUT SO
THAT WE CAN UNDER BETTER
UNDERSTAND PLACEMENT -- BUT WITH
THAT BEING SAID I THINK WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM AS
THE SETTLEMENTS FOR AND
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE DURING
THE STATE OF EMERGENCIES. TO
ASSIST OUR ENROLLEES IN
INSURANCE TO FIND APPROPRIATE
CARE AND THE FASTEST WAY
POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING JENNIFER ALI WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS ARE LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
HERE IN IN A DO ALSO APPRECIATE
THE WORK WITH THE AUTHORS AND
SPONSORS ON THIS BILL AND WILL
CONTINUE OUR OUR CONVERSATIONS
BUT AS OF THIS EVENING WITH.
WE REMAIN OPPOSED OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
INDEED OUR CONVERSATIONS WILL.
PROCEED AND I DON'T THINK ANY
ICCA RECONCILE THAT AND
RECONCILABLE DIFFERENCES ARE AT
PLAY HERE AT ALL I THINK IT CAN
BE EASILY IF THERE ARE MORE
REQUIRED CHANGES WILL DO IT OKAY
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER GROW I BELIEVE --
SO AGAIN THANKS SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND TAKING THE AMENDMENTS AND
APPRECIATE LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE CONCLUSION OF HOPEFULLY VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION AND
LANDING THIS BILL.
SO -- WITH THAT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CAN I CAN I STONE.
STONE I'D DORADO.
DRUGS -- I GROW.
GROW BY HER TATO LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL.
MORNING MORNING I RUBIO RUBIO
AYE.
HI.
SIX SEVEN THE BILL HAS SEVEN
VOTES -- WILL HOLD IT ON ON THE
ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANKS
VERY MUCH OKAY CENTER WIENER.
I NUMBER FOUR SB ONE FIFTY NINE
WELCOME
.
PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- THANK YOU DEAR
COMMITTEE STAFFER.
ARE WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
TO INCREASE.
ACCESS TO PRODUCT UNTAPPED WHICH
IS A CRUCIAL HIV PREVENTIVE THIS
BILL IS AN LGBT CAUCUS.
THE BILL -- I WANT TO START BY A%
ON THERE ARE A FEW AMENDMENTS SO
WE'VE AGREED ON WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND I GOT I DO WANT TO
THANK.
ME SEVERAL WORKING WITH US ON A
NOW I'M WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS
ARE.
THE FIRST -- IS -- AN AMENDMENT --
PROVIDING THAT HEALTH CARE.
PLANS -- SHALL NOT PROHIBIT --
OR PERMIT A DELEGATED --
PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGER TO
PROHIBIT PHARMACISTS FROM
FURNISHING PROPER POPPED -- THE
SECOND AMENDMENT -- IS THAT ARE
THE BILL WILL NOT REQUIRE --
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS AND
HEALTH INSURERS TO COVER PROPER
PAP FURNISHED BY A PHARMACIST
AND OUT OF NETWORK PHARMACY
UNLESS THE HEALTH CARE PLAN.
HAS AN OUT OF NETWORK PHARMACY
BENEFIT.
AND THE THIRD -- IS -- IS STATED
AND I COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ON AN
AMENDMENT TO PROHIBIT -- HEALTH
CARE PLANS -- OR PM'S FROM
REQUIRING A MAIL ORDER -- ACCESS
TO A PROP OR ABOUT US IT WAS A
THREE SADDAM WE WORK THROUGH
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON THAT --
WERE -- ACCEPTING.
MY COLLEAGUES -- SP ONE FIFTY
NINE FOR EXPAND ACCESS -- TO
PREP WHICH IS PRE EXPOSURE A FIX
SOCIAL PROPHYLAXIS AND PAP WHICH
IS A POST EXPOSURE.
PROPHYLAXIS BY ALLOWING
PHARMACISTS TO FURNISH -- THESE
PROVIDED AS WELL WITHOUT OF HIS
POSITIONS PRESCRIPTION.
SB ONE FIFTY NINE ALSO PROHIBITS
INSURANCE COMPANIES FROM
SUBJECTING CRAP AND PAP TO PRIOR
PRIOR AUTHORIZATIONS OR STEP
THERAPY.
WE WORK THROUGH THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE ISSUES IN THE BILL AND
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS --
COMMITTEE -- AND SIGNIFICANTLY
AMENDED THE BILL IN BMP -- TO
SETTLE -- SCOPE OF PRACTICE
ISSUES -- SO THOSE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE ISSUES ARE NOT BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE ON THE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION IS WOULD TRIGGER
THE REFERRAL.
AT THE HEALTH COMMITTEE -- BUT I
WILL BRIEFLY GO THROUGH THEM --
JUST AS A MATTER OF CONTEXT.
OUR PREP IS A ONCE A DAY A DAY
PILL FOR HIV NEGATIVE PEOPLE OF
AN ALMOST ENTIRELY ELIMINATES
THE RISK OF HIV.
INFECTION.
IS A ONE TIME TWENTY EIGHT DAY
COURSE FOR PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED. TO HIV YOU TAKE A
FOR TWENTY EIGHT DAYS AND THEN
YOU'RE DONE AND IT REDUCES THE
RISK OF THE VIRUS TAKING HOLD IN
YOUR BODY -- PREPPING PAP OR
BOTH ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
COMPONENTS OF OUR EFFORT IN
CALIFORNIA TO AND NEW HIV
INFECTIONS -- IT WILL BE
INCREDIBLY HARD AND PROPS
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO IT WITHOUT
BROAD ACCESS TO PROP UP.
ARE CURRENTLY -- BOTH PROBLEM
PAP -- BOTH REQUIRE A
PHYSICIAN'S PRESCRIPTION --
WHICH CAN DELAY OR PREVENT SOME
PEOPLE FROM ACCESSING IT.
SOME PEOPLE AREN'T COMFORTABLE
GOING TO SEE A POSITION --
OTHERS STRUGGLE TO ACCESS A
DOCTOR -- BECAUSE OF THE
POSITION SHORTAGE.
OR THEY'RE CONFRONTED WITH LONG
DELAYS TO OBTAIN AN APPOINTMENT
AND THEN THE ZERO CONVERT AND
BECOME POSITIVE.
IN THE INTERIM.
PARTICULARLY WITH PAT WHERE YOU
HAVE TO BEGIN AT WITHIN SEVENTY
TWO HOURS OF YOUR EXPOSURE AT
THE LATEST THE SOONER THE BETTER --
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE.
IN ITS CURRENT FORM AS AMENDED
AND BMP -- THE BILL WILL ALLOW
PHARMACISTS TO FURNISH AN
INITIAL THIRTY DAY SUPPLY OF
PROP.
THE PATIENT WILL THEN NEED TO
GET THE BLOOD WORK THAT'S
REQUIRED AND GO SEE OF A
PHYSICIAN.
AND GET A PRESCRIPTION FROM THE
POSITION IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
BEYOND THE THIRTY DAYS.
AND SO THAT THIRTY DAY LIMIT --
WE THINK BALANCES THAT WE NEED
FOR QUICK ACCESS AND MAKING IT
SUPER EASY FOR PEOPLE TO BE CAN.
AND THEN.
EVENTUALLY TRANSITION INTO A
PHYSICIAN'S CARE -- TO MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING IS GOING WELL WE
THINK THAT THE M. P STRUCK A
GOOD BALANCE IN THAT SCOPE OF
PRACTICE ISSUE.
AND FOR PAP -- THE PHARMACIST
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE FULL --
TWENTY EIGHT DAYS -- SO THE
OTHER PIECE OF THE BILL THAT
TRIGGER THE HEALTH COMMITTEE --
REFERRAL -- IS -- PUTTING IN AND
TWO USELESS AN OBSTRUCTIONIST
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS
CAN STEP THERAPY.
HARPER PROP AND POP.
THESE ARE REQUIREMENTS DO
NOTHING OTHER THAN LIMIT ACCESS
AND DELAY THE START OF
MEDICATION -- WE ARE AWARE OF
SITUATIONS WHERE BECAUSE OF A
DELAY DUE TO PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
SOMEONE TO KNOCK OUT ON THE PROP
AND BECAME HIV POSITIVE.
WE RECENTLY LEARNED OF AN
OUTRAGEOUS SITUATION WHERE AN
INSURANCE COMPANY TRY TO IMPOSE
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION FOR PAT
WOULD YOU HAVE TO START WITHIN.
SEVENTY TWO HOURS -- THIS IS AN
ACCEPTABLE.
BOND THEIR INSURANCE COMPANIES%
THAT DON'T REQUIRE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND WE SHOULD PUT IT
INTO LAW -- WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY -- OR DOCTOR BOB
GRANT TO SAY -- PHYSICIAN
FACULTY AT THE UNIVERSE A OF
CALIFORNIA AT SAN FRANCISCO UCSF.
IT IS -- POSSIBLY THE FOREMOST
PHYSICIAN EXPERT ON PROP AND PAT
AROUND.
NOT SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN WITH
THISISSUE AND INTO SAYS MORE
KNOWLEDGEABLE -- THAN JUST ABOUT
ANYONE -- IN ADDITION COURTNEY
MARIN PEARSON -- FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION ONE OF
OUR SPONSORS.
CLINT HAWKINS A PHARMACIST WHO
IS HERE LOCAL A LOCAL PHARMACIST
HERE -- CHEESE PHARMACY AND
HAVING MORE AND WITH OUR SPONSOR
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA I ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL.
WITNESSES SUPPORT YOU GOT TOTAL
SIX MINUTES SO THE PEOPLE FIRST
KEEP IN MIND -- LIKE IT TO THE
END THE LAST PERSON A ROUTE TIME.
WILL GO FAST -- MY NAME IS
ROBERT GRANT I'M A PRACTICING
PHYSICIAN AND A PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE I LED RESEARCH THAT LED
TO FDA APPROVAL OF PREP IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND BROAD --
CDC RECOMMENDATIONS IN -- TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN I WILL ARGUE
THE PREP IS SAFE PHARMACIES CAM
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY AND SAFE
PREP -- AND PAP AND THE
PHARMACIES ARE WELL POSITIONED
TO ADDRESS BARRIERS TO ACCESS.
AND THE PHARMACISTS AND
PHARMACIES ARE WELL SUITED TO
PROVIDE PREPPING.
IN URGENT SITUATIONS.
IS SAFE THE SAFETY OF TREVAN A
PREP IS CLEAR THERE'S BEEN NO
EPISODES HE CASES OF RENAL
FAILURE.
NO CASES OF LACTIC ACIDOSIS AND
NO CASES OF LIVER FAILURE I
MENTION THIS BECAUSE THIS --
BILL HAS -- RECEIVE SOME
TESTIMONY TO THE CONTRARY WHICH
IS NOT BASED ON EVIDENCE -- DRUG
RESISTANCE WITH PURPOSE IS
EXCEEDINGLY RARE.
AND REALLY MANAGE WITH MODERN
HIV THERAPY.
THE PHARMACIST CAN PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY AND SAFE HAPPEN PREP THE
MOST CHALLENGING ASPECTS OF PRO
PROVISION ARE ALREADY WITHIN THE
PHARMACY WE'LL HOUSE.
PHARMACISTS ARE WELL POSITIONED
TO IDENTIFY DRUG DRUG
INTERACTIONS AND TO ADDRESS THEM
PHARMACISTS ARE TRAINED TO
COUNSEL CLIENTS REGARDING SIDE
EFFECTS AND PROVIDE COACHING FOR
HUMANS.
OTHER REQUIREMENTS FOR SAFE
PROPER AS SERVICES ARE WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF PHARMACY EXPERTISE.
RAPID HIV TESTS THAT ARE CLEAR
WAVES ARE AVAILABLE IN
PHARMACIES MANY PHARMACIES AND
THERE'S PROOF OF CONCEPT THAT
THEY CAN DELIVER THIS TESTING
SERVICE SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY
TO PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT
OTHERWISE -- GET AN HIV TEST.
THEY'RE ALSO CLEAR WAVE TESTS --
THAT CAN BE DONE AT THE POINT OF
CARE FOR SERUM CREATININE.
PHARMACISTS ARE WELL POSITIONED
TO ADDRESS BARRIERS TO PREP
ACCESS -- YOU KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA ONCE SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE TO BE RECEIVING PREP --
AND TO ACCOMPLISH ITS GOAL OF
ENDING HIV TRANSMISSION AND YET
ONLY 15% OF THEM ARE CURRENTLY
ON IT.
AND THIS IS NINE YEARS AFTER
ACDC LETTER TO ALL PHYSICIANS AS
SAYING THAT THEY SHOULD OFFER
PREP TO PEOPLE AT SUBSTANTIAL
RISK THIS IS. SEVEN YEARS AFTER
THE FDA APPROVED IT SO THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITIES HAVE HAD
AMPLE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
PREP TO EVERYONE WHO NEEDS IT.
AND WE'RE NINE YEARS INTO THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ONLY 15% OF
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE ON PROPER
GETTING AT I THINK IT'S TIME
THAT WE DO SOMETHING ELSE.
AND THIS BILL I THINK IT'S A
PHARMACY IS NOT PERTINENT TO PUT
PREP AND PAP IN THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO NEEDED -- THE
BARRIERS TO PREP ACCESS INCLUDES
STATEMENT COSTS AN INCONVENIENCE
THE PHARMACY IS ESSENTIALLY
ADDRESS ALL OF THESE STATEMENT
IS EXPERIENCED IN MANY MEDICAL
OFFICES WERE PEOPLE WHO FINALLY
GET IN TO SEE THEIR DOCTOR OFTEN
TOLD.
NO YOU SHOULD JUST BEHAVE BETTER.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE BUT IT
DOES HAPPEN COMMUNITY BASED PREP
SERVICES BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL IN
PART BECAUSE THEY'RE LED BY NON
PHYSICIANS WORKING IN COMMUNITY
SETTINGS THAT REFLECT COMMUNITY
VALUES.
PHARMACIES ARE ALSO BASED IN
COMMUNITIES AND ARE SELECTED BY
CLIENTS LARGELY BASED ON
PROXIMITY AND CULTURAL TWO MEN
TO THEIR NEEDS.
THESE INHERENT STRENGTHS IN OUR
PHARMACIES CAN AND SHOULD BE
LEVERAGED TO PROVIDE HAPPENED
PROP AND LASTING.
OKAY.
SO FINALLY -- PHARMACIES ARE
BEST SUITED TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
PAP AND PREP SERVICE.
BOTH OF THESE ARE MEDICAL
EMERGENCIES PREP INCIDENCES HIGH
AFTER SOMEONE HAS ASKED FOR PREP
AND THIS IS BEEN DOCUMENTED IN
TRIALS AS WELL AS DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS WE ARE BOTH A REQUEST
FOR PREP SHOULD BE HANDLED AS A
MEDICAL EMERGENCY AND THE
PHARMACIST IS IN A GOOD PLACE TO
DO.
THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS CARDINAL
HER PEARSON I'M HERE WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION
AND WE'RE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
SB.
ONE FIFTY NINE WHICH WILL HELP
US TO INCREASE PROP ACCESS AND
MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS AVAILABLE
TO ALL WHO NEED IT.
AS DR GRANT MENTIONED PROP UP
TAKE IS CURRENTLY -- ADULT --
UNNECESSARY LEE LOW RATE IN
CALIFORNIA MUCH LOWER THAN WE
NEED IT TO BE IF WE'RE GOING TO
ACHIEVE OUR STATED GOALS.
OF GETTING TO ZERO NEW HIV
INFECTIONS PROP UP TAKE HAS BEEN
LOWEST AMONG POPULATIONS THAT
MONTH COULD MOST BENEFIT FROM IT
INCLUDING BLACK AND THAT NEXT
GAME BISEXUAL MEN WOMEN AND
YOUTH -- IN THESE COMMUNITIES
MAY ALSO EXPERIENCE MULTIPLE
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING PROPER
INCLUDING STIGMA MEDICAL
MISTRUST AN INSUFFICIENT NUMBER
FOR FIGHTERS WHO ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH -- PRESCRIBING HAPPEN PAT.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY INSURANCE
PLANS ACROSS THE STATE HAVE A
ARE AND IN PLACE AT UNNECESSARY
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS
THAT ADD AN ADDITIONAL BARRIER
TO CARE FOR THESE POPULATIONS
THAT ALREADY ARE -- NOT OF
TAKING PROP AS THEY SHOULD AS
THEY COULD. FOR EXAMPLE AS
SENATOR WIENER MENTION WE
RECENTLY LEARNED OF A PATIENT
HIS PLAN REQUIRED PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION FOR PAT AND HE WAS
INFORMED THAT THE PROCESS WOULD
TAKE SEVENTY TWO HOURS TO
COMPLETE.
WHICH MEANS THAT HE WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE HIS MEDICATION
UNTIL AFTER THE EFFECTIVENESS
WINDOW FOR PATH HAD CLOSED.
MEDI CAL REMOVED THE TAR FOR
PREPPING PAP IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
BECAUSE THEY SAW THAT IT WAS
CAUSING AN UNNECESSARY BARRIER
TO CARE.
IS WELL PAST TIME FOR THAT AND
PRIVATE INSURANCE PLANS IN
CALIFORNIA TO FOLLOW SUIT I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
IF FIFTY SECONDS.
MR KERRY COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
DOCTOR CLICK HOPKINS PHARMACIST
OWNER PURCHASE PHARMACY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE'VE BEEN A PART OF
THE COMMITTEE SINCE NINETEEN
THIRTY WE KNOW OUR PATIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS BY NAME.
AS YOU ALREADY KNOW THE HIV AIDS
CRISIS BEGAN NEARLY FOUR DECADES
AGO AND UNFORTUNATELY TODAY WE
STILL HAVE A CRISIS A
DISPROPORTIONATELY IS AFFECTING
HISPANIC AND BLACK COMMUNITIES.
AS WELL AS WOMEN THESE THE OFTEN
FORGOTTEN FACES OF HIV BUT I
ASSURE YOU THAT I SEE THEM EACH
AND EVERY DAY AT MY PHARMACY. TO
PICK UP THEIR HIV MEDICATIONS IS
HEARTBREAKING FOR ME TO DISCUSS
HIV MEDICATIONS WITH THE NEWLY
DIAGNOSED HER PERSON WHEN I KNOW
THAT THERE'S MEDICATION
AVAILABLE IN THE FORM OF PREP
WORK PAP WHICH COULD HAVE
PREVENTED THEIR HIV INFECTION --
WHEN THEY WERE EXPOSED THEY
DON'T THEY JUST AND HAVE ACCESS
TO IT WHEN THEY NEEDED IT?
AS MANY PHARMACIST CAN ATTEST TO
TAKE A HARPER PRACTICE AGREEMENT
WITH THE POSITION IS VERY
DIFFICULT AND CAN BE CONSIDERED
A BARRIER TO PREP AND HAVE
ACCESS.
LAWYERS HAVE TO GET INVOLVED TO
REVIEW EVERY MINUTE DETAIL WE
WERE OUT ACTIVE ISSUE TIME.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU WANT JUST NAME AND
POSITION ORGANIZATION POSITION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TAMMY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
PROUD SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES A
SUPPORT PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION.
MARIA LOPEZ OUR PHARMACIST
ADMISSION WELLNESS CENTERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YES VOTE
LET'S HELP.
DECREASE HIV INFECTIONS THAT
THIS NAME POSITION OR EXTENSION
PLEASE THANK YOU.
MELISSA WHEELER SANTA CLARA
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE ROMAN PRACTICING
PHARMACIST ADMISSION WALLACE
PHARMACY AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
FULLER SACRAMENTO VALLEY FARMERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ACTORS KILEY FAMILY PHYSICIAN
HIV PROVIDER HEARD SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI VERONICA BANDY COMMITTEE
PRACTICING PHARMACIST CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ATION SUPPORT HE I
DR CAROLYN CHU FAMILY POSITION
US OF EACH AND FAMILY HEALTH
CENTER CLINICAL DIRECTOR OF THE
PROBLEM AND UPLAND.
THANK YOU.
LARA THOMAS DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU PUT A WALL ON BEHALF OF
A SEAL YOU IN SUPPORT HE?
WHAT THE US CUSTER ON BEHALF
STOCK WITH LGBT COMMUNITY CENTER
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU?
I CALLS FOR A KELLY HEALTH PRIDE
CO SPONSOR HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ERIN FOX LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER
CO SPONSOR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LISTIA MCNEIL BLACK AIDS
INSTITUTE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHELLE REAVIS CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATIONS PART
BECAUSE SPONSORS THANK YOU.
MANY HERE CALIFORNIA LICENSES AS
USUAL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BROWN'S COURTNEY HIV EDUCATION
PREVENTION PROJECT OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
JENNA HEY WOULD HARM REDUCTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RAFAEL -- MARYLAND EMPIRE HARM
REDUCTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MR CHERYL QUICK -- TIM
VALDERRAMA WITH THE WEATHERMAN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS -- WE HAVE A
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION THAT
I'D LIKE TO DISCUSS REAL BRIEFLY
OKAY -- I I JUST WANT TO START
BY SAYING WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
INTENTION THAT SENATOR WIENER
HAS WITH THIS BILL -- WE BELIEVE
IT'S IMPERATIVE TO GET IT TO GET
AS MANY PEOPLE ACCESS TO THIS
LIFESAVING MEDICATION AS WE CAN
AND WE YOU KNOW WE FULLY BELIEVE
THAT THAT PHARMACISTS ARE
CAPABLE AND AND FROM WELL
TRAINED TO FURNISH THESE
MEDICATIONS -- WE DO OF ONE
AMENDMENT THAT WE THOUGHT TO THE
SENATOR'S OFFICE ABOUT --
THERE'S A PORTION OF THE BILL
THAT BASICALLY REQUIRES.
THAT THE BOARD OF PHARMACY --
CONSULT WITH ONE PHARMACIST
ORGANIZATION -- AS WELL AS THE
OFFICE OF AIDS AND WE'D LIKE TO
SEE A MORE INCLUSIVE -- IN
NEUTRAL POLICY THERE SO THAT THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY HAS THE
ABILITY TO TALK TO ALL RELEVANT
ACTORS -- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR ON THAT
AS THE BILL MOVES ON THANK YOU.
OKAY HOW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SIX MINUTES CCL STRICTER WAS
WITH THE PRO -- EQUALLY STRICT
ON THE CON.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
MORTON CARVALLO AT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ON BEHALF OF FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
MEMBERS ARE ACROSS THE STATE.
I'M HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION AS
TWO ONE FIVE NINE AND WHILE WE
HAD HOPED -- AT THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THE MEDICAL EXPERTISE
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT THIS BILL
ADDRESSED ACCESS IN A WAY.
THAT DIDN'T DO THAT DID NOT
JEOPARDIZE PATIENT SAFETY
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY THAT'S NOT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
SIMPLY PUT SB ONE FIVE NINE SIX
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO PREP AND
PET MEDICATIONS AT A LOWER
STANDARD OF CARE.
AT RISK FOR EXAMPLE THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW PATIENTS TO TAKE
SHORT TERM DOSES OF LONG TERM
REGIMENS WHICH IS LIKELY TO HAVE
THE RESULT.
OF INCREASING THE PATIENT
CHALLENGES FOR IT HERE AND SEND
THEIR FOR INCREASING THE
PATIENT'S OVERALL RISK. THIRTY
DAYS LET ME BE CLEAR THAT THIRTY
DAYS DOES NOT ENSURE THAT A
PATIENT WILL SEE A PHYSICIAN IT
DOESN'T SURE THAT THE PATIENT
MAY SEE A NOTHER PHARMACISTS TO
GET ANOTHER THIRTY DAYS WITHOUT
EVER BEING.
CONSISTENT OR EVER HAVING THEIR
BLOOD TESTED FOR RENAL FUNCTION
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
THAT'S A HUGE CONCERN FOR US.
AT HEARINGS IS THE KEY TO
PREPPING EFFECTIVE. TO BE CLEAR
PATIENTS CAN GET PRIVATE A
PHYSICIAN'S OFFICE UNDER
PRESCRIPTION NOW.
WEIRD WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS A BILL THAT SAYS IT'S OKAY
FOR PATIENTS AT A HIGHER RISK TO
NOT SEEK THE ADVICE OR THE
GUIDANCE OF VISITATION.
THE MEDICATION AND PREP CANNOT
BE TAKEN WITHOUT ONGOING
MONITORING AND TREATMENT TASKS
AND TREATMENT TASK THAT CANNOT
BE DONE AT A RETAIL PHARMACY AND
WHEN IT BE DONE UNDER SB.
ONE FIVE NINE AS THREE ONE FIVE
NINE FAILS TO RECOGNIZE AS AND
FAILS TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
SAFEGUARDS FOR PATIENTS WHO ARE
AT AN INCREASED RISK.
CMA HAD HOPED TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TO EFFECTIVELY EXPAND
ACCESS TO THE ME IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY. TO PAP MEDICATION WHICH IS
THE POST EXPOSURE MEDICATION --
UNFORTUNATELY ROOM REMAIN
OPPOSED WITH SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT PATIENT SAFETY
AND IT HERE AND COMPLIANCE
RELATED TO PROP.
I TODAY I HAVE DOCTOR CAN BASH
WITH ME WHO IS AN INFECTIOUS
DISEASE SPECIALIST AND ALL IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
FRONT OF YOU I'M ALREADY
INTIMIDATED AM HOW MAKE IT BACK
I'M AN INFECTIOUS DISEASE
PHYSICIAN I'VE BEEN PRACTICING
THE SACRAMENTO REGION. FOR THE
LAST NINE YEARS -- HE WHY'D YOU
KNOW PRACTICING EVERY DAY AND
HAVING TO TELL PEOPLE WHEN THEY
ARE DIAGNOSED WITH AT AND
ILLNESS THAT I DO NOT HAVE A
QUEUE FOR THEY HAVE TO LIVE WITH
ALL THEIR LIFE IT'S DEVASTATING.
ACTUALLY SOMETHING I HI I ALWAYS
AFRAID OF DOING EVERY TIME
HOWEVER -- I DID HAVE TO TELL
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE WHO CAME
SEEKING PREP THAT THERE AND
FORTUNATELY.
INFECTED THEY NEED TREATMENT NOT
PROPHYLAXIS -- I'M TRYING IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME TO GO WITH
OUTSIDE THAT TREATING POINTS.
SO THESE PEOPLE IF HE HAD
RECEIVED THE PREP.
TREATMENT WHICH IS NOW E. BACK
BORN INDEED GUIDELINES CALLED OF
TREATMENT THEY'LL BE RECEIVING
SUB OPTIMAL TREATMENT FOR
ESTABLISHED INFECTION THEY WON'T
BE PROFIT LEXUS.
AND THAT WOULD BE THE RISK OF
INFECTION.
ALSO SEE FREQUENTLY PEOPLE WHO
HAD BEEN RUSHED.
TO TREATMENT FOR AT THE HIV
VIRUS BOARD PROPHYLAXIS WHEN
THEY WERE NOT IN THE BRIGHT
STATE JUST TO SEE THEM IN AND
OUT AND REGIMEN WITH
INTERRUPTIONS.
AND THIS IS AN ENORMOUS FACTOR --
FOR RESISTANCE AND LOSING
DIFFICULTY OF THE TREATMENT AND
THE STUDIES THAT WOULD BE WHERE.
THE PIECES OF APPROVING PREP
TREATMENT BY THE CDC AT TERRENCE.
REEDY WAS THE MAIN FACTOR TO
DETERMINE EFFICACY.
AND OF COURSE LOSING THE
EFFICACY OF THE MEDICATION WILL
NOT ONLY -- MAKE A LOSS TO THE
PEOPLE USING FOR PROPHYLAXIS BUT
ALSO FOR THOSE TWO USING A FOR
TREATMENT.
THE SIDE EFFECTS ARE.
REAL.
AND ALTHOUGH THEY ARE NOT VERY
FREQUENT WHEN THEY HAPPEN
THEY'RE DIFFICULT TO TO
RECOGNIZE BECAUSE A PROVIDERS
WHO ARE NOT PRACTICING.
IN THE AREA OF A CHEVY MAY NOT
SEE IT EASILY AND IS NOT UNIQUE --
THE OTHER FACTOR THAT IS THE IT
IS THE USUALLY THE SERVICES ARE
BUNDLED WITH OTHER.
INTERVENTIONS AND COUNSELING --
TO REDUCE THE REST OF THE
PATIENT.
IN ADDITION TO LAB MONITORING.
AND I CANNOT IMAGINE A TOPIC
THAT IS MORE INTIMATE AND
SENSITIVE DISCUSSION THEN THE
RISK FACTORS FOR HIV INFECTION
FOR IT TO BE DISCUSSED IN A
PHARMACY SETTING.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION FIRST WE SUPPORT THE
PEP AND PRIOR AUTHORIZATION --
PIECES OF THIS BILL
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WE THINK THEY'RE
VERY IMPORTANT.
I'M SECOND H. US PERSPECTIVE ON
CRAFT HAS EVOLVED OVER THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS -- TO THE POINT
WHERE WE ARE NOW ONE OF THE
LARGEST DISPENSERS OF PREP -- IN
THE COUNTRY AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
THE LARGEST -- PREP PROGRAM IN
THE STATE OF FLORIDA WE HAVE A
SUBSTANTIVE PROGRAM -- HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF PREP
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE CDC THE P. H..
FTA AND EVEN GILLY ADS --
GUIDELINES RELATIVE TO WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE BEFORE PRESS IS
PRESCRIBED -- AND WE'RE VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE IDEA OF
ABANDONING THAT EVEN FOR THIRTY
DAYS -- IT HERE IN SAYS YOU'VE
HEARD IS A IS A MAJOR ISSUE I'M
IN OUR PROGRAM IN FLORIDA WE DID
A STUDY OF ELEVEN HUNDRED OF OUR
PATIENTS -- AND THESE PEOPLE
RECEIVE VERY INTENSE OVERSIGHT
BY OUR STAFF -- A THIRD OF THEM
IN THE FIRST THIRTY DAYS OF
TAKING PREP STOPPED BEING
ADHERENT -- TAKING THE POSITION
OF THE CLINICIAN OUT OF THE
PICTURE -- FOR THE FIRST THIRTY
DAYS AS SB ONE FIFTY NINE
INDICATES WHAT HAPPENED -- WE
BELIEVE -- REDUCES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PATIENT TO
TO BE IT HERE AND HERE IT IS
IMPORTANT NOT ONLY FOR THE
HEALTH OF THE PATIENT BUT ALSO
FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE IF
THEY BECOME EDUCATED.
AM I DONE.
I SEE YOUR FACE OKAY I THINK IF
YOU OTHER WITNESSES REPORT JUST
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION.
THE MADDEN REPRESENT OPPOSITION
SORRY.
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
BRENT SPENCER WITH AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THERESA START WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE A WE ALSO DO REMAIN
OPPOSED POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YES EARNS OF CENTER.
GROVE SIZE YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DO HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
CENTER WIENER I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ADVOCACY LET ME
SAY THAT FIRST.
ESPECIALLY IF THIS IS A
MEDICATION THAT WILL PREVENT --
HIV AND KEEP PEOPLE HEALTHY --
REGARDLESS OF ACTIVITY SO I DO I
DO REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
ADVOCACY FOR THAT.
I DID SEND YOU SO THAT YOU COULD
BE A LITTLE BIT PREPARED A
QUESTION THAT I HAD -- REGARDING --
WHAT'S THE GUARANTEE LIKE THE
OPPOSITION FROM I BELIEVE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
MA'AM YES.
SHE SAID.
I GUESS I WANT TO GUARANTEE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GO FIND A
PHYSICIAN AND GET TREATMENT
INSTEAD OF JUST GOING TO ANOTHER
PHARMACIST I HAVE TO GET A
THIRTY DAY SUPPLY DO WE HAVE A
MONITORING
SOMEONE IS GETTING THE SAFEST
TREATMENT POSSIBLE OR CAN THEY
GO.
JUST TO ANOTHER PHYSICIAN.
A PHARMACIST I APOLOGIZE NOT A
PHYSICIAN AND GET ENOUGH WEIGHT
ON IT WE'RE NOT PUTTING LIKE A
TAG ON YOU KNOW RIGHT.
ABOUT THE NOTES SO THAT THEY CAN
ADD ANOTHER PHARMACY -- YOU KNOW
I I THINK -- WHAT THE BILL
REQUIRESFIRST OF ALL IT'S IT'S
BIGGER THE BILL REQUIRES YOU
HAVE TO HAVE AN HIV NEGATIVE
TEST WITHIN SEVEN DAYS BEFORE --
AND YOU HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
TO THE PHARMACIST.
BY.
GUYS ARE JUST TO BE CLEAR THE
BILL AS A GUARD RAIL AROUND DIES
SO THAT TESTIMONY THAT YOU HEARD.
WAS A LITTLE ODD TO ME SINCE THE
BILL SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES AN
EIGHT SEVEN NEGATIVE SEVEN SEVEN
DAYS -- AND THEN THE PHARMACIST
HAS TO GIVE YOU.
A UNCH OF INFORMATION INCLUDING
INFORMATION ABOUT POSITIONS AGO
TOO AND IN ORDER THE BLOOD WORK.
AND SO YOU CAN GO DOWN THE
STREET IS A LAP CORE WHATEVER
DOWN THE STREET GET THE BLOOD
WORK AND THEN.
YOU HAVE TO GO TO A PHYSICIAN
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS TO CONTINUE.
ON YOU KNOW I THINK PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TAKEN THE STOCK TO OUT SHE
SAID I WANT TO BE ON CRAFT --
THESE ARE NOT YOU THE I THINK WE
AT SOMEONE NEED TO TRUST PEOPLE.
TO CARE ABOUT THEIR HEALTH --
AND KNOWING THAT AND GET
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NEED TO
SEE A PHYSICIAN AND A HALF OF
BLOOD WORK -- YOU PEOPLE COULD
THEY'RE ALWAYS GOING TO BE SOME
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE --
IRRESPONSIBLE AND LIFE.
BUT WE KNOW THATMOST PEOPLE
AREN'T AND PEOPLE WANT TO BE
HEALTHY AND THEY'RE GOING TO THE
PHARMACIST TO GET THAT PROP
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO STAY
HEALTHY.
THE PHARMACIST WILL GIVE THEM
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NEED TO
SEE A DOCTOR IF YOU WANT TO
CONTINUE IN THE GET THE BLOOD
WORK.
AND SO AT SOME POINT -- YOU KNOW
WE NEED TO I THINK THIS NEED TO
TRUST INDIVIDUALS. TO TAKE
OWNERSHIP OF THEIR OWN HEALTH
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT PRACTICE
ABOUT -- AND THAT'S WHY WE WORK
SO HARD TO REMOVE BARRIERS AND
YOU SAW SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SPENT THEIR LIFE TRYING TO
REMOVE BARRIERS TO PRACTICE.
AND THE UPTAKE IS STILL NOT
THERE I'M PARTICULARLY AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
COMMUNITIES.
IT IS.
IS HAS SHOCKINGLY LOW AND HIV
INFECTION RATES ARE HIGHER.
AND SO WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING
IN OUR POWER TO EXPAND ACCESS.
AND TO MAKE IT EASY FOR PEOPLE
TO START AND UNFORTUNATELY YOU
KNOW WHEN I WHEN I WENT ON THE
PRODUCT AND I PUBLICLY DISCLOSE
THAT -- ABOUT UNDER FIVE YEARS
AGO NOW -- I WAS VERY LUCKY I
WENT TO A POSITION WHO.
DOES IMMEDIATELY GOT IT DIDN'T
JUDGE ME THAT AND TRY TO SHAME
ME THAT AND TRY.
TO YOU KNOW TELL ME -- JUST BE
RESPONSIBLE -- AND I WAS LUCKY.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
THAT EXPERIENCE BECAUSE ALTHOUGH
MANY POSITIONS ARE VERY GOOD ON
SEXUAL HEALTH ISSUES WE STILL
HAVE TOO MANY PHYSICIANS WHO ARE
NOT COMFORTABLE EVEN TALKING
ABOUT IT -- AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO BALANCE THAT AND TO GIVE
PEOPLE AS MANY OPTIONS AS
POSSIBLE PEOPLE CAN STILL CHOOSE
IN A LOT OF PEOPLE WILL CHOOSE.
TO GO TO A PHYSICIAN HE SAID I
WANT TO SEE A POSITION BEFORE I
DO ANYTHING AND THAT'S GREAT --
BUT WE WANT TO JUST CREATE MORE
OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE SO THAT'S
WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN I
DO APPRECIATE YOUR I APPRECIATE
THE BILL I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THERE IS
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO.
SO I GUESS -- I DID A QUESTION
MY COLLEAGUE WHO IS A PHARMACIST
AND I ASK MINE INTERPRETATION OR
WHAT I THOUGHT AS YOU COULD GET
A PRESCRIPTION WITHOUT A A
PHYSICIAN SAYING YOU KNOW RIGHT
THIS PRESCRIPTION.
DOCTOR PAN WOULD TELL DOCTORS OR
PHYSICIANS DOWNERS PHARMACIST
DOWN TO GET A PRESCRIPTION YOU
WISH YOU BUT APPARENTLY.
MISTER A STONE IN HIS PHARMACIST
ACTED ISSUE PRESCRIPTIONS FOR
CERTAIN THINGS WITHOUT.
A PHYSICIAN'S AUTHORIZATION AND
AND I REALLY DIDN'T KNOW THAT SO
THAT WAS AN EDUCATION THING FOR
ME.
BUT SOMEHOW I THINK THAT.
SOMEBODY'S GOVERNING AS WHETHER
IT'S THE CDC OR WHATEVER
SOMEBODY'S GOVERNESS AND IF YOU
ADD PRESCRIPTIONS OR YOU ADD.
ADDITIONAL MEDICATIONS THAT CAN
BE DISTRIBUTED BY APART BY A
PHARMACIST WITHOUT.
A PRESCRIPTION FROM OF A
PHYSICIAN DOES THAT HAVE TO HAVE
NEW STATUTES GUIDELINES OR CAN
WE JUST AS LEGISLATORS SAY.
CENTERS THERE STONE IN HIS
PHARMACIST CAPACITY COULD ISSUE
ANY TYPE OF MEDICATION EVER
WITHOUT ANY OVERSIGHT.
OKAY THE THE THIRD LEGISLATION
THE BILL DIRECTS THE PHARMACY
BOARD -- TO ISSUE -- GUIDELINES
IN THE RULES AND REGULATIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S DONE
APPROPRIATELY -- SO THERE THERE
WILL BE AN ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS I AFTERWARDS AND AND
YOU'RE RIGHT AND CENTER STONE
WAS RIGHT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
FROM TIME TO TIME DOES AUTHORIZE --
PHARMACISTS TO PROVIDE
MEDICATION WITHOUT A
PRESCRIPTION -- YOUR VACCINES --
IS ONE OF THEM YOU CAN GO AND
GET A VACCINE FROM A PHARMACIST
WITHOUT SAYING A POSITION THAT
WAS A FIGHT.
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES AND THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
FOUGHT THAT AND OPPOSED.
TO AND THEN.
AND THEN THE LEGISLATURE PUT A
WHOLE BUNCH OF REQUIREMENTS ON
IT SO THAT IT WAS NOT A VERY
SUCCESSFUL BILL.
AND IN FIVE YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE REMOVED THOSE
REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE IT EASIER
AND MORE SEAMLESS FOR PEOPLE TO
GET A VACCINATION.
FROM PHARMACISTS PHARMACIST CAN --
PROVIDE -- THE LOCKS AND NOR CAN --
WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION TO
SOMEONE WHO IS EXPERIENCING --
AN OVERDOSE -- OF COURSE BIRTH
CONTROL THE PHARMACIST CAN
PROVIDE A BIRTH CONTROL.
PILLS WITHOUT A DOCTOR'S
PRESCRIPTION THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO DO IT THESE ARE
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND THEY'RE AN
IMPORTANT VOICE THEY OPPOSE THAT
BILL-- AND THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED A BECAUSE WE THOUGHT IT
WAS IMPORTANT FOR WOMEN TO HAVE
THAT ACCESS AND NOT HAVE.
TO YOU KNOW AND JUST TRY TO
REMOVE AS MANY BARRIERS AS WE
CAN WE TRUST.
YOU KNOW WOMEN TO MAKE THOSE
YOUR HEALTH DECISIONS SO WE DO
DO THAT FROM TIME TO TIME AND I
THINK THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE --
SITUATION BUT THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR -- PHARMACISTS ARE.
OVERLY TRAINING UNDER UTILIZED
AS WE'VE KNOWN THAT FOR YEARS
AND SO FAR MY COLLEAGUES WILL
WILL KNOW THE THE ENTRY LEVEL
DEGREE NOW AND AND PHARMACY AS A
PHARMACY DEGREE DOCTOR OF
PHARMACY DEGREE.
WHICH IS A CLINICAL PHARMACY --
POSITION WERE.
I ACTUALLY DID ROUNDS WITH
MEDICAL STUDENTS AT THE COUNTY
HOSPITAL AND WE ARE WE ARE
TRAINED WITH THEM.
AND WE TAKE A LOT OF THE SAME
CLASSES THAT THEY TAKE SOMETIMES
BY THE SAME PROFESSORS ANATOMY
HISTOLOGY PHYSIOLOGY.
PHARMACOLOGY BY A MEDICINAL
CHEMISTRY -- AND IN FACT --
WE'RE WE'RE TRAINED ACTUALLY.
READ BLOOD TESTS AND IS ACTUALLY
A PART OF THE BOARD EXAM THAT WE
CAN.
INTERPRET THESE TESTS AND WE CAN
EVEN ORDER THESE TESTS SO --
DOCTOR YOU MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT -- SOME OF THE WARNING SAID.
THE CMA AS PUT FORWARD IS SAID
TO YOU COULD OF RENAL TOXICITY
IN A PADDOCK.
TOXICITY AND AND USE ANY SCRAPS
OF YOUR NOT BEING TRACKED -- YOU
SAID YOU YOU YOU WE HAVE A
SINGLE ONE REPORTED CASE OF ANY
TYPE OF TOXICITY IMPROPER PAP
WHICH I WOULD TO ME WAS A WAS
VERY VERY POWERFUL HOWEVER.
NOW WE DON'T TAKE ANY CHANCES
WHEN A PATIENT COMES IN AND ONE
THING THAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT PEP
IN PRACTICE TIMELINESS AGAIN
ACUTENESS GETTING THE PATIENT ON
THEM.
ESPECIALLY WITH PREP RIGHT AWAY
AND WITHIN THREE DAYS ON ON A
PATH OF THE WISE THE THE THE
PATIENT IS AT RISK OF ACQUIRING --
AIDS TO SO -- SENATOR WIENER --
THIS IS NOT A A UNIQUE
[inaudible]
IDEA.
THE PHARMACISTS ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THESE MEDICATIONS --
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THIS IS
AVAILABLE.
AS YOU'RE PROPOSING IT AT THE
STATE'S IS THAT CORRECT.
ON IT IS -- IN NEW YORK.
AND WASHINGTON STATE -- NEAR
BECAUSE PAT.
AND WASHINGTON STATE IS MOVING
IN THE DIRECTION OF OF OF PROP
OKAY -- ALSO A RESPONSE ALSO TO
THE DOCTOR THERE'S RESERVE
SPECTER HAD ATTIC AND WERE IN
RENO TOXICITIES THERE IS A NEW
DRUG IS BEING PROPOSED TO BE
RELEASED BY THE FD AT OUR OFFICE
OUT YET.
BUT IS A MARKETED TO HAVE LESS --
READ ON HEPATIC TOXICITY COULD
BE COULD SPEAK ON THAT -- DRUG
IT ONLY.
I THINK YOU'RE REFERRING TO A
DRUG -- BRANDED AS DISCO V. IT'S
A ANOTHER VERSION OF TEN OFF OF
HERE THAT -- IS -- IN THE
TREATMENT SETTING KNOWN -- TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH LESS FREQUENT --
FACTS ON THE KIDNEY -- IN THE
SETTING OF PREP WE HAVE NOT SEEN
RENAL FAILURE -- ASSOCIATED WITH
PROVIDE A PROP THE CURRENT
FORMULATION THE NEW FORMULATION --
WILL HAVE TO BE EVALUATED BY THE
FDA TO SEE HOW MUCH IT ADDS IF
ANYTHING TO THE EXISTING
STANDARD OF CARE FOR NOW WE HAVE
PROVIDE A IT IS SAFE.
AND IT IS SIMILAR TO BIRTH
CONTROL PILLS AND VACCINATIONS
AS A PROPHYLACTIC INTERVENTION
THAT HAS BEEN SAFELY PROVIDED BY
PHARMACISTS SO IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF PATIENT CARE -- THE
PHARMACISTS IS GOING TO BE
ORDERING BLOOD TESTS AND AND A
MODIFIED LAB AND IS REFERRING A
PATIENT TO THEIR DOCTOR AND IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A DOCTOR THE BY
THE BILLIARD BEGINNING A LIST OF
PHYSICIANS AND THEY CAN GO SEE.
TO TO FOLLOW UP WE WANT THEM TO
FOLLOW UP THAT TO TO MAKE SURE
THE BABY COMING DISEASE FREE --
ALSO.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T JUST MAGICALLY
SAY THE PHARMACIST COULD START
DOING ALL THESE THINGS WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL TRAINING SO.
IN ORDER FOR PHARMACISTS TO TO
GIVE IMMUNIZATIONS WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH.
MORE COURSE WORK WE HAVE TO BE
CERTIFIED.
BEFORE WE CAN DO IT.
WE GET A CERTIFICATE.
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD.
THE STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY IS
GOING TO COME UP WITH A
CURRICULUM AND WORKING WITH
MAYBE SOME OF THE AGENCIES THAT
WERE DISCUSSED BEFORE. TO ENSURE
THAT THE PHARMACIST TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM
UNDERSTAND.
THE PROTOCOLS AND EIGHT IN AND
FOLLOW THROUGH IN ACCORDANCE
WITH.
PHARMACY LAW WHICH WILL BE
ENFORCED BY THE STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY.
THE PART THAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS
BILLS IF THERE'S FIVE THOUSAND
NEW CASES OF AIDS EVERY SINGLE
YEAR AND BE OUT ONE POINT ONE
MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT ARE POTENTIALLY INFECTED
AND VERY FEW LIKE 10% ARE EVEN
OUT THERE GETTING CRAP.
AND THAT'S AN ACCESS ISSUE.
WE HAVE OVER FIVE THOUSAND
PHARMACIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE PHARMACIES THAT ARE
OPEN TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
AND ONE DOESN'T PLAN ALWAYS --
ACTS OF PASSION SOMETIMES THINGS
JUST HAPPEN OKAY AND IF YOU DE
PREP -- EIGHTY PROPERTY THE TAP
YOU NEED PAP [inaudible]
AND AGAIN WE GET BACK INTO THE
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION TO TAKE TIME
THESE ARE NOW REALLY TIME
SENSITIVE.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU.
ARE GOING THROUGH YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU NEED TO PREVENT YOUR HEALTH
FROM -- DETERIORATING
[inaudible]
SO -- I WANT TO COMMEND YOU
SENATOR WIENER -- FOR BRING IN
THIS FORWARD -- I KNOW THERE'S A
GOAL TO HAVE WHO SHOULD HAVE
ZERO WE NEED ELIMINATE AIDS
MIKEY BUT LIKE WE ELIMINATED
POLIO -- WE WE'VE GOT THE DRUGS
THAT ARE ARE SAFE AND EFFECTIVE.
WE HAVE PROOF THAT PHARMACIST
CAN HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE ON
MORE PROFESSIONAL ROLES OF
PRESCRIBING IN AND GIVING
IMMUNIZATIONS AND I THINK THAT'S
LARGELY.
A SUCCESS THAT WE'VE GOTTEN MORE
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY ELDERLY PEOPLE
WITH FLU VACCINES GETTING THE
FLU THE FLU SHOT AND AND
PREVENTING MORBIDITY MORTALITY
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT OR
PNEUMOCOCCAL -- INJECTION FOR
ELDERLY PEOPLE WERE MANY THAN
DIE FROM PNEUMONIA WINTER
ELDERLY -- WE'VE HAD A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT IN THAT
ACCESSIBILITY I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT -- SO -- WITH WE WE
WE'VE GOT TO STOP SILO IN HEALTH
CAR.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE A
PRIMARY CARE SHORTAGE -- IN IN
THE STATE IN IN IN THE COUNTRY -
I THINK WITH THE APPROPRIATE
PROTOCOLS OF THE STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY CAN DO -- AND AND THE
INCREASE ACCESSIBILITY
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS OF COLOR
WHERE WE SEE A HIGHER PERCENTAGE
CHAU PREPONDERANCE OF OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE GETTING AIDS --
UNKNOWINGLY -- WITHOUT KNOWING
IT THESE THESE THESE
PREPARATIONS ARE AVAILABLE -- I
THINK WE CAN REDUCE THE
MORBIDITY -- AND AND AND LONG
TERM SATINS OF PATIENTS SAID IT
WILL COME DOWN WITH AIDS IT
DIDN'T HAVE TO COME DOWN WITH
AIDS.
AND SO -- CENTER THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING A FOR A AYE AYE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT TO TO
MOVE THE BILL I SUPPORT IT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY -- AND AND I KNOW
THAT -- THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION WAS HERE
THEY SUPPORTED I THINK.
I WANT TO COMMEND YOU -- DOCTOR
ON YOUR PHARMACY IN ALL YOUR
GOOD WORK.
AND ALSO ONE AND CAN SAN
FRANCISCO THAT I WAS VERY
IMPRESSED WITH THAT WAS -- DOING
A LOT OF GREAT WORK AS WELL
THANKS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS.
OKAY.
HE ACTUALLY SENATOR DRAWS SO THE
NEXT.
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS -- ONE IS
AN EXCUSE BECAUSE I'D.
DON'T KNOW ALL OF THE
TERMINOLOGY OR THE ISSUES --
SPECIFIC MEDICAL ISSUES.
BUT MY QUESTION IS -- THE WHAT
ARE THE RISKS INVOLVED TO GET
PREP AND PAP WITHOUT MEDICAL
SUPERVISION WITHOUT A DOCTOR'S
SUPERVISION.
I KNOW YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
NOT LOOKING TO DO SHORT CUTS I
KNOW YOU'RE NOT.
IGNORING THE HEALTH OF ANYONE
WHO ASKS FOR THE THE TREATMENT.
BUT HOWEVER YOU BALANCED.
ANY POTENTIAL RISKS WITH.
SO THERE ARE -- HE KNEW -- TO
RISKS TO BE MOST AWARE OF ONE IS
TO MAKE SURE YOUR ONE THE PERSON
TO BE HIV NEGATIVE.
WHEN THEY GO ON TO PROP --
BECAUSE AND THAT'S WHY WHEN
YOU'RE ON PROP -- YOU YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO GET TESTED FOR HIV
REGULARLY BECAUSE IF YOU BECOME
POSITIVE NEED TO STOP.
GRABBING GO ON TO HIV
MEDICATIONS -- AND THAT'S WHY --
THE CDC -- HAS THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU TEST
NEGATIVE WITHIN SEVEN DAYS
BEFORE AND THAT'S WHY WE PUT
THAT REQUIREMENT -- INTO THE
BILL I THE OTHER RISK WHICH IS
AN IMPORTANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THIS IT'S AN EXTREMELY SMALL
RISK.
IS AN EXTREMELY SMALL PERCENTAGE
OF PEOPLE WHO GO ON TO PROP OR
PERHAPS THEY CAN HAVE A CAN OF A
REGIONAL -- IMPACT THEIR KIDNEYS
I THAT IS VERY RARE -- THERE AND
AS WE KNOW ON PRETTY MUCH ANY
DRUGS THAT YOU TAKE INCLUDING
OVER THE COUNTER DRUGS THERE'S A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO
COULD HAVE.
THE HEALTH BECAUSE OF THE SMALL
RISK ON BY -- AND SO YOU ARE
REQUIRED TO GET -- BLOODWORK
TEST FOR RENAL FUNCTION AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE IN THE BILL IN
ORDER TO GO PAST THE THIRTY DAYS
ON ALL YOU HAVE TO SEE A DOCTOR
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE HAD.
THE BLOOD WORK ON FOR PATTODAY --
AND AND RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
HOW PEOPLE GET UP WHICH IS SUCH
AN INEFFICIENT WAYS.
ARE YOU GO TO THE ER. ZERO KERR
A WHOLE YEAR NOT EVERY RIGHT
THAT THE PEOPLE.
OFTEN DO YOU GIVE LIKE I THINK
I'VE BEEN EXPOSED TO GO TO THE
ER.
AND YOU GET UP TO ABOUT ONE AND
THAT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE WAY TO
DO IT -- AND THEN THEY WILL
ORDER THE BLOOD WORK AND YOU
KNOW IT TAKES AWHILE TO GET
BLOOD WORK DONE TYPICALLY SO YOU
START THE PAP BEFORE YOU HAVE
THE BLOOD WORK.
IN THAT SITUATION -- SO WE IN BE
MPV MEMON SO WE WORKED OUT WITH
THE COMMITTEE TRY TO STRIKE THAT
BALANCE -- AND THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT WITH -- YOU GET THIRTY DAYS
A PROP AND AND THEN IN THAT
THIRTY DAY PERIOD GET THE BLOOD
WORK GO SEE A PHYSICIAN IN ORDER
TO CONTINUE STRIKING A BALANCE.
ANOTHER QUESTION IS YOU MENTION
THE TREATMENT WAS IS FOR TWENTY
EIGHT DAYS -- CAPITA TWENTY
EIGHT DAYS AND THEN YOU'RE DONE.
OKAY I GUESS A I HEARD YOU
SAYING WELL YOU WOULD GET THE
TREATMENT FOR THIRTY DAYS THE
PHARMACIST TO GIVE YOU WHY WOULD
YOU GO BEYOND I DON'T UNDERSTAND
SO I'M SUCH AN EIGHT DAYS AND
THIRTY TWO OTHERS.
PRODUCT WHICH IS PRE EXPOSURE
MOBILE ACCESS -- PAT IS POST
EXPOSURE -- PAP POST EXPOSURE
IT'S A SOME PEOPLE MAY THE
COMPARISON TO THE MORNING AFTER
PILL.
IT'S SO YOU SOME SOMETHING
HAPPENS YOU THINK THAT YOU MAY
HAVE BEEN EPOSED SO YOU THEN
GET WHEN A TWENTY EIGHT DAY-COURSE YOU TAKE IT ONCE.
EVERY DAY FOR TWENTY EIGHT DAYS
AND THEN YOU'RE DONE.
AND IT REDUCES THE RISK OF THE
VIRUS TAKING HOLD THAT'S IF YOU
THINK YOU'VE BEEN EXPOSED A ONE
TIME THING FOR TWENTY DAYS. FOR
PRESS -- WHICH IS YOU DON'T
THINK YOU BEEN EXPOSING YOU TEST
NEGATIVE -- BUT YOU WANT TO STAY
NEGATIVE AND YOU WANT TO
INCREASE YOUR PROTECTION -- YOU
TAKE A POTENTIALLY INDEFINITELY --
AS JUST A REGULAR PILL THAT YOU
TAKE EVERY DAY -- AND SO I'VE
FROM FOR ME IF THE LAST FIVE
YEARS EVERYDAY I TAKE PILL IN
THE MORNING WITH MY COFFEE --
AND HI -- AND THAT'S AND AND
SOME PEOPLE GO ON AND OFF
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY ARE IN
THEIR LIFE -- AND BUT IT'S A
MORE ONGOING THING.
FINALLY JUST -- I JUST WANT TO
SAY WITH WITH ALL DUE RESPECT --
AND I'M.
YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SUPPORT --
THE BILL I ALSO HAS FRIENDS OF
MINE -- WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
ESPECIALLY IN THE VERY EARLY
DAYS OF EXPOSING THE URGENCY
BEHIND THE -- EIGHT HIV AIDS AN
EPIDEMIC -- AND THE FAILURE OF
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY TO RESPOND
AS QUICKLY AS THEY SHOULD OF
LIKE.
CLEVE JONES GOOD GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE AND ON OTHERS -- ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR BILL SO.
IN ADDITION TO EVERYBODY ELSE I
JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK --
BROKERAGE GENERATION OF OF
PEOPLE WHO WENT THROUGH THE THE
ABSOLUTE WORSE THE EPIDEMIC
UNDER LONG TERM SURVIVORS AND
YOU KNOW WAS WISHING THAT IN
THOSE EARLY DAYS WE HAVE HAD
ACCESS TO THOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ESPECIALLY CENTER RUBIO.
MY QUESTION HAS BEEN ANSWERED
THANK YOU RIGHT WILL CENTER
LEYVA THEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
GOOD EVENING SENATOR WIENER I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EXTREMELY HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
I SAID THROUGH THE DISCUSSION IN
BMP.
AND I THINK YOU'VE BEEN VERY
THOUGHTFUL -- BUT I ALSO HAVE TO
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT
THIS IS ABOUT ACCESS AND IT'S
ABOUT ACCESS.
FOR FOLKS IN THE LGBT Q.
COMMUNITY BUT I ALSO THINK ABOUT
A WOMAN WHO'S BEEN RAPED.
AND SHE WHAT WE HAVE FOUND AND I
THINK MOST OF US KNOW IS MOST
WOMEN ARE RAPED FEEL THAT IT WAS
THEIR FAULT AND THEY'RE
EMBARRASSED AND THEY MAY NOT
WANT TO GO TO THE DOCTOR.
SO TO BE ABLE TO GO TO A
PHARMACIST AND ACCESS PAP --
WOULD BE EXTREMELY HELPFUL.
I KNOW OF ONE WOMAN IN MY
DISTRICT WHO COULDN'T EVEN GET
PAP THROUGH HER AT THE EMERGENCY
ROOM.
AND BY THE TIME SHE WAS FINALLY --
GIVEN THE PRODUCT IT WAS PASSED
THE SEVENTY TWO HOURS SO IT WAS
NOT REALLY EVEN EFFECTIVE FOR
HER -- AND I THINK THAT.
IF IF WE IF THERE IS A WAY FOR
US TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
GETTING HIV WHY IN GOD'S NAME
WOULD WE NOT FIND A WAY TO DO
THAT.
I MEAN THAT IS INCUMBENT UPON
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US AND YOU
KNOW I KNOW THE OPPOSITION SAID
THAT THEY'RE WORRIED THAT THEY
MIGHT THEY MIGHT GO TO DIFFERENT
PHARMACIES AND THEY MIGHT NOT GO
TO THE DOCTOR.
IN MY MIND THAT'S A SMALL
CONCERNED BECAUSE IF THEY'RE
GOING AND THEY'RE GETTING
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO KEEP
THEM FROM GETTING SICK AND
POSSIBLY DYING.
THEN WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING
WITHIN OUR POWER TO MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
MEDICATIONS SO I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DOG AT WORK BECAUSE I KNOW THIS
HAS NOT BEEN EASY.
AGAIN I WOULD FOR SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY [inaudible]
SENATE MITCHELL.
THANK YOU -- I'M SORRY THAT I'M
THE ONE THAT KEEPS ATHLETES
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE MAMMOTH
[inaudible]
I'M I'M.
NOT AT MY PEAK.
I'M NOT ENVIRONMENT OFFICE IN.
ARE THESE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED BY THESE ARE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE THESE YOUR
MOVEMENTS.
SO THEY ARE -- I WOULD SAY
THEY'RE MORE OUR AMENDMENTS THAT
WE WORKED ON WITH THE COMMITTEE
ONE IS -- THAT APPEARS AN
ANALYSIS -- IS -- TO IS TO
PROHIBIT REQUIRING MAIL ORDER
YES IMPROPER THAT'S AN ANALYSIS
AND THEN TWO OTHER ONES THAT WE
WORKED ON WITH THE COMMITTEE
THEY'RE NOT IN THE ANALYSIS --
PROHIBIT -- HEALTH PLANS FROM
PROHIBITING PHARMACY. FOR HAVING
HEALTH PLANS AND TV ARMS.
FROM PROHIBITING PHARMACISTS
FROM.
BOB PROVIDING PROBLEM TOP GOT A
THERE IS A THE THE HEALTH PLAN
CAN SAY WE'RE NOT COVERING IT UP
THE PHARMACIST I DOES IT.
AND AND ALSO SOME -- ARE
CLARIFYING NUMBER OUT OF WORK --
SO WE WORKED WITH -- THE WINDOWS
AMENDMENTS WITH -- HEALTH MAY
STAFF TO HELP DISTRACT THEM.
AND THE THREE MODELS OF THE
THREE AND DID AND I I DIDN'T
HEAR ALL OF THE OPPOSITION
COMMENTS DID YOU HAVE ANY TWENTY
YEARS AT THIS REMOVE.
ANY OF YOUR OPPOSITION.
NO THERE WAS A ONE OF THE
PHARMACY ASSOCIATIONS -- IS
CONTINUING TO TALK WITH US THERE
IS SON THERE IS SOME ABOUT THE
MINISTER.
DURATION OF THE BILL IN TERMS OF
WHO'S INVOLVED VERY DIALOGUING
WITH US ABOUT THE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT THANK YOU.
AND JUST FOR CLARIFICATION THERE
WAS ANOTHER MOMENT THAT I SAW
FROM THE AUTHOR THAT YOU DO NOT
ACCEPT SO -- AND RIGHT SO YEAH
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT PRINT
RIGHT CORRECT AND MAYBE PERHAPS
I SHOULD ELABORATE ON THAT WAS
GONNA WAIT TILL THE END IS THE
CHAIR BUT I THINK THE CONCERN --
THAT -- THAT I HAD AND IT'S ARTS
THE US THE FOLLOW UP SO -- I
SHOULD CENTER WIENER I MEAN I
SHARE YOUR DESIRE TO TRY TO GET.
ACCESS TO THESE MEDICATIONS TO
PEOPLE'S QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE IN
MANY WAYS I THINK -- WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT WHERE CMA IS AND
MORE SO MY PHYSICIAN COLLEAGUES
ARE?
LITTLE MORE LEANING TOWARD WHERE
YOU ARE BUT THE PRT THAT I HAD
CONCERNED ABOUT AND SO.
IS THAT WHAT WE HAVE A
PHARMACIST TO YOU KNOW FIND GO
THE PHARMACIST HAVING DISPENSED
MEDICATION.
THE CDC GUIDELINES DO REQUIRE --
AND THAT'S WHY BEING P..
I GUESS INCLUDE IN THEIR
AMENDMENTS THAT RESEMBLE THE
PHARMACIST HAS TO ORDER A BLOOD
TEST FOR THE KIDNEY.
NOT OFFERS KIDNEY FUNCTION --
NOW.
THE I THINK TO ME THE CHALLENGES
IS THAT.
IT'S IF YOU ORDER A KIDNEY
FUNCTION TESTS IT'S NOT
NECESSARY JUST GONNA COME BACK
AS A CREATININE YOU MAY GET BACK
A CHEM SEVEN SO WITH ALL THAT
THE PARTS RIGHT -- THE STUDIES
THAT LOOKED AT KIDNEY
DYSFUNCTION SAID YES VERY LOW
RATES BUT ACTUALLY WENT THINGS
THEY POINT OUT IS IN THE STUDIES --
THAT DAY DID EXAMINE THAT THE
POPULATION IT LOOKED AT WHERE
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT HAVE PRE
EXISTING KIDNEY FUNCTION
PROBLEMS SO THAT WAS ACTUALLY
MADE NOTE OF IN THE TO REPORT.
AND SO MY CONCERN IS IN TERMS OF
CLOSING THE LOOP IS IS THAT OKAY
YOU HAVE SOMEONE COME IN TO GET
THE PRESCRIPTION PHARMACISTS
ORDER A TEST RIGHT.
THE TEST COMES BACK AND THERE'S
AN ABNORMALITY ON THE TEST AND
THE PHARMACIST MAYOR MAY NOT
PICK UP ON IT IF THEY'RE JUST
LOOKING AT THE CREATININE AND
THEY'RE NOT PAYING ATTENTION TO
THE BY CAR LEVEL OR TO POTASSIUM
OR SODIUM -- THEN WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT SO THAT'S NOW EITHER NOT
PAID ATTENTION TO OR NOT
UNDERSTOOD AS BEING PROBLEMATIC
SO THIS ISN'T AND AND I
APPRECIATE THAT WHAT YOUR FOCUS
ON HIV IN THAT SORT OF PRIMARY
THING BUT THERE COULD BE OTHER
CONDITIONS.
RIGHT THAT MAY HAVE THAT THAT
THAT THERE MAY BE WARNING SIGNS
ABOUT.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT NO
ONE PAYS ATTENTION TO IT AND
THEN FINALLY THE PATIENT COMES
AND SAYS -- SOMETHING HAPPENS
AND THEY'RE LIKE WELL GEE DOES A
TEST DONE BEFORE NO ONE PICKED
UP ON IT KNOWN COMMUNICATED TO
ME DOORS AN ABNORMALITY.
AND TO ME YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
TEAM BASED CARE -- YEAH I THINK
THE END THIS IS A PLACE FOR THE
PHARMACIST SHOULD HAVE A PRIMARY
ROLE BUT THERE SHOULD BE A BACK
UP THERE SHOULD BE A PHYSICIAN
TEAM PLAYER WHO IS.
AVAILABLE TO REVIEW THESE TESTS
TO ALSO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
PHARMACIST MIGHT HAVE BECAUSE
THESE AREN'T EVEN ADVANCED
PRACTICE PHARMACISTS WERE
TALKING ABOUT THESE ARE GONNA BE
FRONTLINE PHARMACISTS TO YOU
KNOW DO YOU HAVE TO DO A LITTLE
AYE STRAINING.
AS  MATTER AS THE PHARMACY
BOARD IS REQUIRED BUT THEY DON'T
YOU KNOW THAT I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO THINK MORE ABOUT THESE
TEAMS NOW I KNOW THAT THE THE
PROPONENTS ARE GONNA SAY WELL
IT'S HARD TO GET A COLLABORATIVE
PRACTICE AGREEMENT NIGHT.
FIRST OF ALL I'M NOT SUGGESTING
THAT WE EVEN SAY THAT A
PHYSICIAN CAN ONLY HAVE A CLASS
PRACTICE AGREEMENT ONLY ONE
PHARMACISTS AND IN FACT YOU HAVE
POSITIONS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND I SAID WELL.
DO YOU WANT TO HAVE A CLEVER
PRACTICE AGREEMENT WITH THE AN
OFF TWENTY THIRTY FORTY
PHARMACIES WHO ARE DOING THIS
AND THE AND IT BE AVAILABLE AS
THAT BACK UP PERSON TO THAT
COUNCIL PERSON TODAY WOULD HAVE
AN EXISTING RELATIONSHIP WITH.
I DON'T YOU KNOW I'M NOT LOOKING
FOR LIKE THIS WHOLE BIG BLOWN
THING BUT THAT -- THAT'S GONNA
BE OVERLY BURDENSOME BUT I DO
THINK WE DO NEED TO HAVE THAT.
THAT RELATIONSHIP AND THAT BACK
UP AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING WHERE
PHARMACISTS AS WELL I'M NOT SURE
THIS IS RIGHT NOW I GOT A CALL
AROUND A BUNCH OF DOCTORS A FIND
OF SOMEONE WILL HELP ME IT'S TO
BE A PRE EXISTING RELATIONSHIP.
SOME HOPING THAT WE CAN TRY I
MEAN THAT'S WHAT I LIKE TO SEE
WE GET TO SOME PLACE LIKE THAT
WHERE WHERE WE WERE THERE'S A
TEAM THAT CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
BE SURE WE HAVE ALL THE BASES
COVERED.
BECAUSE I DO ONE AND I I'VE BEEN
FULLY SUPPORT THE IDEA THAT
SOMEONE COMES TO THE PHARMACIST
AND THEY GET THE MEDICATION THEY
GET THE PATH TO GET TO PRESS
RIGHT -- I KNOW THE CMA'S ALSO
EXCITED ABOUT THE PREP SIDE OF
THINGS I'M FINE WITH THAT BUT I
DO FEEL THAT BECAUSE OF THESE
ISSUES AND THIS IS.
WHAT'S RECOGNIZE CC THAT WE HAVE
TO HAVE SOME KIND OF CLOSING OF
THE LOOP.
OTHERWISE I'M AFRAID THAT WHILE
THERE'S OPPORTUNITY
UNFORTUNATELY FOR A PATIENT --
TO TO HAVE SOMETHING YOU KNOW
NOT SO POSITIVE HAPPEN IN THE
NOT THE SO BE ABOUT THEIR HIV
STATUS COULD BE ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE.
AND SET AND SO I'M YOU KNOW I'M
I LOOK AT THE BIGGER PICTURE
ABOUT THEIR OVERALL HEALTH
BECAUSE I MEAN THIS IS.
BECOMING IN FOR THIS BUT AT SOME
POINT AND THE PHARMACIST CAN
CERTAINLY DO A LOT OF WORK WITH
THE KNIVES AND NOT DOWN.
BUT IT IS ABOUT BEING SURE THAT
WE GET ALL OUR BASES COVERED AND
SO THAT THAT THAT IS A CONCERN I
SUBMIT THAT I HAVE AND I
APPRECIATE BY WAY OF HAVE TO
MENTION THAT.
I KNOW WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN
DIALOGUING BACK AND FORTH AND WE
KIND OF INCHING CLOSER TOGETHER
WE HAVEN'T QUITE CLOSE THE GAP
YET THERE -- BUT AND I REALIZE
THAT YOU KNOW YOUR CONCERN IS
THAT CLAD PRACTICE ROOM ISN'T
THAT TOO MUCH OF A BARRIER I I
ACTUALLY.
THINK THAT WE CAN THAT THAT
THAT'S NOT TOO MUCH OF A BARRIER --
AND THAT IF YOU KNOW WE IF WE
CAN'T BUT IF WE CAN'T GET A
POSITION TO STEP UP AND SAY I'M
WILLING TO DO THIS AND IT'S
BECAUSE IT'S TOO RISKY OR THE
LIABILITIES TOO HIGH.
THEN WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR THE
PHARMACIST.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THAT BACK UP
WITH AS A PHARMACIST ONLY
RESPONSE WILL DO IN ORDER TO
TEST THEIR THE ONE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE RESULTS.
SO I JUST I JUST WANT TO MAKE
THAT SO.
ANYWAY.
SELECT FREE AND I KNOW THERE'S
SOME OF THE PEOPLE IN MIND BUT
NO I I I I APPRECIATE THAT --
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND AND I KNOW
YOU -- YOU KNOW -- A AND YOU
KNOW THAT I HAVE ENORMOUS
RESPECT FOR YOU AS A HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS AND YOUR YOUR
AGREE ON MANY MANY MANY ISSUES
AND YOU AND I RARELY DISAGREE --
BUT ON THE SPECIFIC ISSUE AYE
AYE WE DID GIVE A REAL
CONSIDERATION LOOKED AT AT AND
WE AND I AND AS I COMMUNICATED
TO AYE ON PORTS I CAN'T ACCEPT --
THAT AMENDMENT -- BECAUSE
REQUIRING TO BASICALLY WHAT THAT
MAN WOULD DO IS TO SAY OKAY THE
ONLY PHARMACISTS THAT CAN
PROVIDE -- PROPER PAP ARE
PHARMACISTS WHO HAVE A
COLLABORATIVE PRACTICE AGREEMENT
WITH POSITIONS.
AND WHAT THAT AS WELL CALL CPA --
FOR SURE -- A CPA IS A FORMAL
FORMAL LEGAL ARRANGEMENT -- THAT
WE TOOK WHEN THE ONE PHARMACIST
WERE AUTHORIZED -- TO PROVIDE
VACCINES IN THE NINETIES FIVE OF
A COLLABORATIVE PRACTICE
AGREEMENT WAS REQUIRED.
AND THAT WAS REPEALED THE
LEGISLATURE REPEALED THAT
REQUIREMENT BECAUSE IT WAS -- TO
ONEROUS AND THERE WERE NOT
ENOUGH PHARMACISTS WHO WERE
WILLING TO DO IT SO FOR AND AND
I'VE ALSO BEEN TOLD THAT THERE
ARE AREN'T A LOT OF DOCTORS.
WHO WANT TO DO IT BECAUSE THEN?
THE DOCTORS HAVING TO WORK
THROUGH SOMEONE ELSE.
TOWARDS THE PATIENT.
AND SO YOU YOU'RE GOING TO END
UP WITH VERY FEW PHARMACIES THAT
PARTICIPATE I'M AFRAID -- AND IT
WILL NOT AND AND THAT'S WHY I
BELIEVE IT WOULD REALLY
DRAMATICALLY UNDERMINE -- THE
BILL AND THAT'S AND FOR THAT
REASON I WASN'T ABLE -- TO TO
ACCEPT THAT OKAY WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M REALLY LOOKING AT
BECAUSE AND UNLIKE.
GIVING OF VACCINATION -- AND WE
TALKED A LOT OF ACCIDENTS A
READY -- THIS IS A THIS REQUIRES
IT'S NOT ONLY DISPENSING THE
MEDICATION -- IT'S ALSO WEARING
LAP THAT LAB TESTS AND ACTUALLY
NOT IN THIS.
THE NOT NECESSARILY LAB TESTS
THAT MAYBE THAT EASILY
INTERPRETED AS SOMEONE WHO HAS A
POSITION AS TO GET SO YOU ONE
COULD ARGUE THAT THEY SAID WELL
ALL YOU REALLY NEED TO DO IS GET
TO CREATE NAME BUT FLOW AT SAM'S
THE ORDER ENTRY AND YOU KNOW BE
ON TRAINING.
IN THE GUINEA TENSED CAM SEVEN
NOW YOU HAVE A SET A LAPSE
RESULTS THAT HAVE TO GET
INTERPRETED IN.
I THINK THAT -- IT AND DECIDE
WHAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
WHOLE PATIENTS AND SO I THINK
THAT THAT I I DO HAVE CONCERNS
THAT WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WE'RE
NOT REALLY CLOSING THE LOOP AND
IS THAT I'M.
WILLING TO LOOK AT AND I KNOW
THAT YOU'D AGAIN I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING
SOME BACK FORTH YOU KNOW.
THE NATURE OF THE AGREEMENT IN
THIS IS YOU CAN BE CONSTRUCTED
IN A WAY THAT -- THAT ACTUALLY --
FACILITATES -- THIS HAPPENING
WHICH DOESN'T CUT OUT HUGE
BURDEN ON THE PHYSICIANS AND AS
WELL AS ON THE PHARMACISTS AND
SO.
SO -- AND THEY DID IT SO ANYWAY
I I THINK THAT BUT HAVING SOME
PRE EXISTING RELATIONSHIP NOT
JUST SIMPLY A LIST OF PHYSICIANS
WHO DON'T HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE PHARMACIST I MEAN I
THINK THERE HAS TO BE RELATION
BETWEEN PHARMACISTS AND DOCTORS
SOMEWAY HOUSE.
HOWEVER WE WANT TO MANAGE THAT
BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
EXPECTATION -- STATE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO SO
THAT THE POSITION ISN'T BY FROM
THE PHARMACIST CALLS TO YOU LIKE
BUT WHAT WHEN EIGHT WHERE YOU
CALLING ME.
RIGHT I DON'T KNOW I KNOW YOU'RE
CALLING NEEDS AND FOR WHAT
PARTICULAR REASONS BECAUSE I
KNOW WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE AGREED IN
SOME WAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THIS KIND OF RELATIONSHIP.
DOCTOR GRAHAM WHO.
MAY BE ABLE TO COMMENT ON THAT
AS WELL.
YEAH THE THE CBC CALLS -- FOR
CREATE IN TESTING AND THE
INTERPRETATION OF THAT
PARTICULAR TEST ACCORDING TO CDC
GUIDANCE IS VERY.
SIMPLE IT'S EITHER -- ESTIMATED
CRANDON CLEARANCE OF GREATER
THAN SIXTY ARE LESS THAN SIXTY I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD.
BE -- PRETENDING ARE CLAIMING OR
ASKING PEOPLE TO BELIEVE THAT
IT'S MORE COMPLICATED THAN IT
REALLY IS I WOULD ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THESE -- THIS
BILL IS ENTIRELY CONSISTENT WITH
CDC GUIDANCE REGARDING HOW TO
PROVIDE PROP -- THEY
SPECIFICALLY DID NOT REQUIRE
THAT A PHYSICIAN BE INVOLVED
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY. TOO EASY
FOR PHYSICIANS -- ITS IT'S
ALGORITHMIC CARE OF LIKE MOUNT
MOST OF OUR PREVENTIVE CARE
STRATEGIESAND SO WE AND AND YOU
KNOW PHYSICIANS ARE NOT GOING TO
BE INTERESTED IN ESTABLISHING.
A COLLABORATIVE PRACTICE SCREAMS
BECAUSE THERE REALLY ISN'T -- AN
OF WORK FOR THEM TO DO THEY'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO JUSTIFY
THEIR EFFORT AND TIME -- IN
THOSE AGREEMENTS AND LEGALLY
THEY'RE JUST TAKING A LONG TIME
TO ESTABLISH.
I SHOULD PERHAPS THE OTHER
POSITION I MEAN WHEN DO YOU GET
A LAB TEST YOU SIMPLY SAY -- I
HI THAT'S NOT WHAT I DO BUT I'M
JUST -- I GET A LAB TEST AND I
TALKED TO THE PATIENT UNDERSTAND
WHY THEY WANT THE MEDICATION AND
WHY THEY'RE NOT AND IT'S JUST
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MAYBE NOT
PRACTICING THIS EVERY DAY.
POST EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS IS AN
URGENT SITUATION PRE EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS IS THE LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PHYSICIAN
TO DECREASE THAT PERSON'S RISK
OF ACQUIRING.
HIV INFECTION AND IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY THESE PEOPLE CAME
BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE RISK
FACTORS THEY WANTED TO REVEAL IT
TO PHYSICIAN SEEK HELP FOR IT.
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT
OTHER RISKS OF OTHER INFECTIONS
OTHER.
HEALTH ADVERSE CONDITIONS AT THE
ODD AT AND DISCOVER IT AND
ADDRESS IT.
AND IS THAT IT'S A IT'S A TAKE
SOME TIME FOR PEOPLE TO ACT TO
AGREE TO COME TO THE DOCTOR WITH
THIS CONCERN TO ACCEPT TREATMENT.
I IT I DO NOT KNOW IF IT'S GONNA
BE EASIER FOR THEM TO REVIEW
SUCH INTIMATE.
DETAILS OF THEIR LIFE TO A
PHARMACIST RETAIL PHARMACY
SITUATION SO WE TALK ABOUT
OTHERS FACTOR FOR FOR STDS DRUG
ABUSE PROBLEMS THIS THING SET UP
WITH THE METRIC OKAY ED PREACHY
TED BUT I AM CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE BECAUSE YOU'RE JUST LOOKING
VERY NARROWLY ABOUT THIS ONE
THING AND I'M TO THE PROBLEMS
THAT YOU HAVE A TEST RESULT YOU
LOOK MORE BROADLY BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T JUST SIMPLY SAY WELL.
I'D ONLY LOOKED AT THIS ONE
ASPECT AND SOMETHING ELSE IS
ABNORMAL AND THEREFORE SO I
DON'T PAY ATTENTION BECAUSE THIS
IS ONLY FOR TESTING FOR PRESS.
RIGHT.
AND TIMES WHEN THE POTASSIUM IS
IT'LL BE LOW OR THE BY COVERAGE
EIGHT REPEATED AGAIN TO MAKE
SURE OF IT TRANSIT OF REGRET
OKAY.
CENTER STONE DR GRANT.
SO -- IF IF THE PATIENT -- GETS
ON ON PROP.
WE ORDER THE BLOOD TESTS AND
CONNECTING DOCTOR PAN BRING SOME
SOME.
GOOD POINTS THAT YOU KNOW YOU
JUST CAN'T LOOK AT CREE AND THEN
YOU CAN JUST LOOK ABILITY --
NITROGEN YOU GOT A LOOK AT SOME
OTHER THINGS AS WELL AND WE EAT
AND USUALLY WHEN YOU GET THESE
TESTS BACK USUALLY SEE THEM
HIGHLIGHTED IF THERE'S SOMETHING
ABNORMAL USUALLY.
RIGHT AWAY.
BUT WITHIN THAT THIRTY DAY
PERIOD.
IF SOMEBODY WAS HAVING REAL
DIFFICULTIES.
WITH A BE A SYMPTOMATIC OR THEY
BE SYMPTOMATIC.
IN YOUR IN YOUR VIEWPOINT.
WELL THE THE RENAL INSUFFICIENCY
WOULD START OFF IN IN A
SYMPTOMATIC PHASE.
IT WITH -- TEN OFF OF YOUR WE
HAVEN'T SEEN RENAL FAILURE WE'VE
SEEN ABNORMALITIES IN SERUM
CREATININE.
A TYPICALLY THEY OCCUR THREE TO
FOUR MONTHS AFTER PREP IS
STARTED.
IT'S NOT N THE FIRST MONTH SO --
AND SO THE PERSON WOULD HAVE
TRANSFERRED THEIR CARE -- TO A
POSITION BY THAT TIME ACCORDING
TO THIS BILL OR THEY WOULD HAVE
STOPPED BRIGHT BECAUSE WHEN I'M
TRYING TO MAKE IS NOT GONNA GO
INTO RENAL FAILURE WITHIN THE
FIRST THIRTY DAYS OF TREATMENT --
BASED ON THE LITERATURE THAT YOU
ARTICULATED EARLIER THAT YOU
HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THAT
NEVER SEEN RENAL FAILURE AND IN
THE SETTING OF HIV TREATMENT WE
CAN SEE BEING A FAILURE AND
TYPICALLY CARS THREE OR FOUR
MONTHS INTO THERAPY.
THANK YOU AND THEN -- SENATOR TO
ROSS WE ASK SOME VERY GOOD
QUESTIONS ABOUT THOUGH YOU KNOW
ARE WE MISSING SOMETHING WHAT
CAN HAPPEN AND AND AND YOU KNOW
THUS FAR SIDE EFFECTS OF THESE
MEDICATIONS.
THERE'S AN OVER THE COUNTER
DRUGS.
THAT ACCOUNTS.
FOR MORE POISON CONTROL CENTERS
GETTING CALLS THAN ANY OTHER.
THAT SAME DRUGS.
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
HOSPITALIZATIONS.
AND FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
DEATHS DUE TO ACUTE LIVER
FAILURE.
DO NOT THAT DRUG IS.
DOES ANYBODY KNOW TETRICUS.
EVEN TIENEN ALL RIGHT SO.
TYLENOL IS MUCH MORE --
DANGEROUS.
BY FAR.
THAN CAPT [inaudible] FOR PRESS.
HOWEVER IF ONE DOESN'T GET PREP.
OR GET PAP IN A TIMELY WAY.
THEN THERE IN JEOPARDY OF HAVING
A LIFE THREATENING INFECTION IF
THEY DON'T GET.
THE PROPER -- MEDICAL CARE THAT
THE THEY NEED A AND DESERVE.
AND SO -- THE OTHER THING I
WANTED TO ALSO MENTION I KNOW
IT'S GETTING LATE -- IS IT.
THE RURAL AREAS I REPRESENT A
LOT OF RURAL AREAS OKAY AND YOU
MAY NOT HAVE A DISEASE.
WITH A SPECIALIST -- OUT THERE
THAT IS.
EVEN KNOWS WHAT.
PREPPER PET THIS.
OUT IN IN VALLEY CENTER ARMED
LIFE I GO ALL THE WAY TO THE
ARIZONA BORDER.
YET WE HAVE PHARMACIES THERE
ONLY A PHARMACY PROFESSIONALS
THAT WOULD HAVE GOTTEN THIS
CONTINUED EDUCATION THAT CAN.
INTERVENE IF YOU WELL AND AND
REFER THEM TO A LIST OF
POSITIONS AND HAVE TO DRIVE AN
HOUR AND A HALF IN TWO WEEKS
AFTER YOU GET THERE BUT TESTING
GO -- BUT THIS HAS.
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
BENEFITS FROM CHICO ALL THE WAY
TO CALEXICO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR THAT REASON I WANT TO
MOVE YOUR BILL AND I HOPE THAT
WE GET A UNANIMOUS VOTE
[inaudible]
CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU AND I KNOW IT'S LATE
AND I DO APOLOGIZE AND I THINK
THEY KEEP TURNING DOWN THE AIR
TO MAKE US LOOK LIKE IT'S YOU
KNOW AND GET THE LIGHTS UP SO
YOU THINK IT'S THE MIDDLE OF THE
DAY.
BUT I I DO HAVE A QUESTION SO IF
IF THE LAB WORK IS IS PRESENTED
IN THERE ARE THESE ISSUES THAT
DOCTOR PAN ADDRESS LIKE THESE
OTHER ISSUES -- WHO GETS THE LAB
WORK THE PHARMACIST OR THE
PHYSICIAN?
THE PHARMACIST WILL GET THE LAB
WORK.
WHO WANTS IF IF -- IF LAB WORK
COMES BACK AND IT'S DETERMINED --
THAT.
THERE'S SOME ABNORMALITY -- FOR
PATIENT PROTECTION.
HO REFERS DOES IS AT THE
INDIVIDUAL'S RESPONSIBILITY TO
GO SEE A PHYSICIAN OR DOES THE
PHARMACIST SEND A REFERRAL TO A
PHYSICIAN SO THAT THEY CAN?
GET TREATED HER THE PHYSICIAN
WILL ASK THE PERSON DO YOU HAVE
A PRIMARY CAREPROVIDER IF THE
PERSON SAYS YES OR NO SORRY.
WITHIN THIRTY YOU NEED TO GO TO
THE BLOOD WORK YOU NEED TO GO
SEE YOUR PHYSICIAN -- BECAUSE
AFTER THIRTY DAYS YOU CAN'T
CONTINUE UNLESS YOUR PHYSICIAN
PRESCRIBED.
IF THE PERSON DOES NOT HAVE A
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN THE THE
PHARMACISTS WERE VITAL LIST.
OF PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS IN
THE AREA THE PERSON CONTACT AND
THAT IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THAT PERSON. TO CALL AND MAKE AN
APPOINTMENT AND TO GET ON TO THE
NORMAL OUR REGIMENT.
DOES THAT MEAN IS THAT A
SATISFYING IN I MEAN I'M JUST
ASKING CMA OF THAT IF THAT IS AN
ANSWER.
I MEAN I GUESS MY ISSUE IS IS
THAT.
IF IT'S A IMMEDIATE MEDICATION
THAT NEEDS TO BE.
YOU KNOW DISPENSED IN ORDER TO
PREVENT OR SAVE SOMEONE'S LIFE.
AND MAKING IT AVAILABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE IS A REASONABLE
REQUEST.
I WOULD THINK.
I THINK MOST THE DICING SEVERAL
AND SPEAK FOR THEM.
YEAH AND THROUGH THE BUT I DO
HAVE A A REALLY BIG CONCERN THAT
AND I AGREE I THINK PERSONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY SHOULD BE PART OF
ALMOST EVERYTHING WE DO IN THIS
BUILDING BUT I GUESS YOU KNOW WE
DON'T DO IT MUCH OTHER CASES SO.
I GUESS HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU WE
DON'T TAG PEOPLE LIKE THE
SENATOR SAID SO HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT THEY DO FOLLOW UP WITH
A PHYSICIAN THAT'S MY HUGE
CONCERN.
YEAH SO -- ACTUALLY SEE MY WOULD
AGREE THAT IN THE EMERGENCY
SITUATION WHICH IS THE IN THE
PAP SITUATION -- THERE SHOULD BE
ACCESS AND WE HAVE PROVIDED
LANGUAGE AND PROVIDED --
AMENDMENTS TO TRY TO WORK WITH
THE SENATOR I TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES RELATED TO THE EMERGENCY
NEED FOR PAP.
PREP HOWEVER IS NOT AN EMERGENCY
NEED IT'S A PRE EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS SO IT IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE TIME TO SEE
A PHYSICIAN AND TALK TO THE
PHYSICIAN ABOUT YOUR CARE AND
TREATMENT -- I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S BEEN LEFT OUT IS
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THE
PHYSICIAN WILL INCLUDE IN THAT --
ANALYSIS ON THAT YOUR CARE AND
TREATMENT IS GOING TO BE A FULL
PANEL OF STD TESTS AS WELL SO
IT'S HIV BUT IT'S ALSO
ADDITIONAL -- ADDITIONAL TESTS
TO LOOK AT OTHER HEALTH FACTORS
AS WELL SO THAT'S THAT WOULDN'T
BE INCLUDED IN THIS BILL SO
AGAIN ON THE ON THE EMERGENCY
TYPE SITUATIONS WITH PEP
MEDICATION WHERE YOU HAVE TO
TAKE WITHIN THREE DAYS.
WE FULLY AGREE THAT THERE SHOULD
BE ACCESS TO THAT MEDICATION AT
A PHARMACY AND THAT THERE SHOULD
BE.
CERTAIN PROTECTIONS IN PLACE BUT
THAT THERE SHOULD BE ACCESS TO
THOSE MEDICATIONS THAT FORMS.
SIR WE ARE DO YOU SEE THAT IS
ACCURATE LIKE THE PEP IS IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE EMERGENCY.
FULLY ACCESS PHARMACIST COULD
ISSUE.
BUT ON THE PREP THEY HAVE TIME
TO PREPARE IS THERE I DON'T KNOW
THAT MUCH ABOUT IT SO IT IS
THEIR TIME. TO PREPARE AND WORK
WITH A PHYSICIAN SO COUPLE
THINGS CAME A PERSONAL TERMS OF
THE CMA DID MAKE BAY THERE OFFER
WAS TO STRIP PROP OUT OF THE
BILL.
AND TO LIMIT THE PHARMACIST
PROVIDING PAP TO SEVEN DAYS NOT
THE FULL TWENTY EIGHT DAYS.
AND AND I MEANS SO YOU WHEN YOU
ON THE PATH AFTER AN EXPOSURE
YOU NEED TO STAY ON FOR TWENTY
THREE DAYS I GET THE ANSWER TO
SO THEY ARE THAT IT IS NOT
OFFERED TO GIVE THE FOR THE FULL
TWENTY DAYS JUST TO BE CLEAR.
BUT TO YEAH IT PROP IS NOT AN
EMERGENCY IN THE SAME WAY THAT --
THAT HAPPENS BUT WHEN SOMEONE
SAYS I THINK I'M AT RISK FOR
WHATEVER REASON.
AND IT COULD BE THAT THEY
BECAUSE OF JUST BEAR THE LIFE OF
THEIR LIVING IT COULD BE BECAUSE
THE SEXUALLY OR BECAUSE OF
INTRAVENOUS DRUG USE IT COULD BE
BECAUSE PARTNER.
HAS -- IT HAS HIV AND THEY WANT
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES.
IT'S NOT AN EMERGENCY IN THE
SEMI PEPPERS BUT IT IS
ABSOLUTELY TIME SENSITIVE AND WE
HAVE SEEN SITUATIONS WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE THE LADIES.
AND GETTING ON CRAP AND THEY
BECOME POSITIVE IN THE INTERIM
AND SO YES IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE NOT TO HAVE LONG --
DELAYS AND YES YOU YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE ANY AN STD TEST --
BUT BUT IT IS NOT THE CASE THAT
HAVING AN S. T. D..
MEANS THAT IT'S SOMEHOW
DANGEROUS TO BE ON PROP -- WE
WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE STI TESTS
AND KNOW IF THEY HAVE SYPHILIS
OR CHLAMYDIA O GONORRHEA BUT
THAT THAT IS NOT A BARRIER TO
TAKING.
PROP THAT JUST MEANS WE WANT TO
GET YOU ON THE TREATMENT FOR
THOSE INFECTIONS.
AND YOU SEEM TO BE SHAKING YOUR
HEAD YEAH IF I COULD JUST TO
CORRECT THE RECORD SEE MAY DID
PROVIDE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
HAVE PROVIDED FOR A FULL TWENTY
EIGHT DAY COURSE OF PAT
MEDICATION IT EVEN REMOVED AT
THE EXISTING RESTRICTIONS OF THE
BILL THAT SAY THAT A PATIENT.
CAN ONLY RECEIVE PAP TWICE A
YEAR WE ACTUALLY STRUCK BACK
SEEING THE CONSEQUENCE OF A
PATIENT WHO IS EXPOSED TO A
THIRD TIME AND WOULD BE UNDER
THIS BILL TURNED AWAY FROM A
PHARMACY. TO RECEIVE UP
EDUCATION WE FELT THAT WASA
BARRIER AND WE SHOULD REMOVE IT
WE DID PROVIDE LANGUAGE FOR FULL
TWENTY EIGHT DAY ACCESS OF THAT
MEDICATION WITHOUT THE BARRIER
OF THE TWO DAYS SO WELL WE DID
AND ARE RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS
STRIKE THE PROPER MEDICATION.
WE DID SEE A A VALUE TO
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO THE PET
MEDICATION AT DOESN'T CURRENTLY
EXISTIN THE BILL AND IF I COULD
JUST CORRECT THE RECORD ON ONE
OTHER THING -- EARLIER IT WAS
MENTIONED THAT CMA WAS OPPOSED
TO CERTAIN BILLS ON EXPANDED
ACCESS. TO CONTRACEPTIVES AND
VACCINES IN THESE LIKE THAT.
IT SHOULD BE MADE CLEAR THAT --
THESE BILLS WERE ALL NEGOTIATED
AT THE TIME.
THAT THEY WERE PASSING THE
LEGISLATURE AND THEY IT WERE
NEGOTIATED WITH PATIENT SAFETY
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL -- SO WE JUST WANT TO
CORRECT THAT RECORD ENSURE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SAME
THING IN THE SENSE THAT WE ARE
WILLING TO COME TO THE TABLE AND
NEGOTIATE A SAFE.
MEANINGFUL ACCESS BILL -- DODGES
HASN'T BEEN ACHIEVED AND AGAIN
WE HAVE PROVIDED AMENDMENTS TO
TO GO THE FULL TWENTY EIGHT DAYS
UP HAVE MEDICATION SO.
AND IN ADDITION.
TO TAKE AWAY SOME OF THE TIES
THAT OCCUR IN THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE TO THE CDC GUIDELINES
WHICH CHANGECONSISTENTLY
THEY'RE ALSO TIES IN THIS BILL
THAT ONLY ALLOW FORMS IS TO
PROVIDE.
THE MEDICATION TO PROVIDE A SUIT
TO TO SENATOR STONE'S POINT
ABOUT ADDITIONAL MEDICATIONS
GOING THROUGH THE FTA CURRENTLY.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THOSE
MEDICATIONS TO BE PROVIDED AT A
PHARMACY WOULD HAVE TO COME BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND WE HAVE TO ADD THAT TO THE
STATUE BECAUSE THE STATUTE IS SO
IS NEARLY DROPPED IT TO ONLY
ALLOW THAT MEDICATION OF
PROVIDED TO BE PROVIDED -- THAT
PAT AND THE PARAMEDIC PRESS THE
MEDICATION IT ALSO TIED CLOSELY
TO THE CDC GUIDELINES TO THE
EXACT REPORT OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
THAT JUST CAME OUT.
WHICH WHICH COULD BE CHANGED AT
ANY MOMENT AND SO TAKING OUT
THOSE TIES THAT WE THINK IS A
BETTER -- WAY OF ADDRESSING A
MEANINGFUL ACCESS ON THE PAP
SIDE -- AND ON THE PREP SIDE.
JUST ON THEIR WE JUST ON THERE
AND SO E HAVE ASSET THAT
LANGUAGE BE TAKEN OUT AND THAT
WE EXPAND SOME OF THE STRUCTURES
THAT ARE IN THE CURRENT LAW.
OR IN THE CURRENT BILL TO ALLOW
FOR MEANINGFUL ACCESS ON PAT SO
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT SEEM IS NOT
OPPOSED TO THE PEP SIDE BECAUSE
THEY NEEDED IMMEDIATELY AND WE
DON'T WANT TO DENY PEOPLE ACCESS
TO SAID ESPECIALLY.
IF WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE TRY
TO SAVE THEIR LIVES BUT ON THE
PREP SIDE THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO IN AND AND
TALK TO A PHYSICIAN.
ABOUT THE THE THE RISKS THAT
THEY FEEL THAT THEIR AND AS A
PERSON AND THEN THAT COULD BE
ADDRESSED -- BY MEDICAL PROVIDER
RATE AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE TRIED
TO NEGOTIATE YEAH.
ARE YOU UNDER THE SAME AS OURS
OKAY SORRY.
MY APOLOGIES THAT IS THAT IS
BRAND NEW THEY DID -- I GUESS
TAKE THAT POSITION WE APPRECIATE
THAT MOVEMENT -- THEY WERE FOR A
LONG TIME SAYING SEVEN DAYS AND
SEVEN DAYS ONLY AND THAT'S THE
POSITION A TOKEN BMP WHY NOT BE
IMPEDED KRAUT THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE PROVISIONS -- BUT THE
THE TO THE STILL ASKING THE
PROPERTY REMOVED FROM THE BILL
ENTIRELY SO THAT'S PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT.
THANK YOU.
CENTER TOGGLE.
A SIMILAR WINNER JUST JUMP WANT
TO SAY THAT I I EVE SHARE THE
CONCERNS THAT OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ADDRESSED TODAY -- BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY I AM REALLY AN
EXTREMELY CONCERNEDABOUT.
A SOME OF THE NUMBERS THAT I'VE
SEEN.
THE PACIFIC WE IN MY DISTRICT
ACROSS THE STATE -- WE HAVE
THIRTY TWO TEENS THAT WERE
DIAGNOSED WITH HIV IN. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO THAT'S AN
ACCEPTABLE SHOULD BE -- ZERO IN
MY DISTRICT FRESNO COUNTY A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT PEOPLE
WERE DIAGNOSED NEWLY DIAGNOSED
WITH HIV.
THAT'S MORE THAN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY THAT'S JUST ABOUT THE
SAME AMOUNT AS SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
AND HE NOTES THAT'S FOR RURAL
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
THAT WE NEED TO REALLY BE
LOOKING OUT WE NEED TO BE REALLY
ADDRESSING THAT A TRUSTS SCENE.
AND YOU KNOW I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL TO MY
ATTENTION AND EDUCATING ME ON
THE FACTS WHEN IT COMES TO MY
DISTRICT AND BEYOND.
AND I MEAN THESE NUMBERS ARE
JUST.
I I'M JUST A IT'S IT'S AT NEW TO
ME IT REALLY IS AND SO IT SAID
SOMETHING THAT -- YOU KNOW.
MAYBE IT'S NOT PERFECT AND I
DON'T KNOW IF IF IT WILL.
PREVENT HIV AND IN MY DISTRICT
AND BEYOND.
BUT I THINK THAT WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN WITHIN
OUR WITHIN OUR POWER TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
THAT WE PREVENT IT AND THAT --
WE HAVE ACCESS IT'S REALLY AN
ACCESS ISSUE I THINK AND YOU
KNOW JUST GOING TO WHAT -- ARC
MY COLLEAGUES CENTER STONE
MENTIONED EARLIER AND SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO JUST LET YOU KNOW
THAT I SUPPORT YOU IN THIS
EFFORT.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SEEING NONE --
I KNOW THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STONE -- CENTER WIENER I
APPRECIATE -- OUR CONVERSATIONS
I HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE THEM
UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BECAUSE I
STILL FEEL THERE'S A PATIENT
SAFETY ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO
CLOSING THAT LOOP ON THE LAB
TESTS AND OTHER THINGS BUT I
HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION.
AND TO BE SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY
KEEP THAT WE KEEP.
AND SAFE SO WITH THAT -- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YEAH AND SO THE MOTION WILL BE
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AMENDMENTS STATE
YOU.
THAT YOU AGREE TO THAT I THINK
ARE THE ONES ARE PASSED OUT
RIGHT TO THE THREE AMENDMENTS
THAT I STAYED AT THE BEGINNING
BUT NOT THE ONE THAT I REJECTED.
RIGHT NOW THAT'S NOT THE ONE IN
PRINCE RIGHTS AND I THINK IT
MADE IT CLEAR SO THE AT THE
MOTION WOULD BE TO TO TO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PASSED OUT
WHICH I BELIEVE YOU AGREE TO ALL.
TO VOTE OR THE ONE THE THREE
THAT I STATED IT RIGHT WHICH IS
THE ONES WHICH HAVE BEEN PASSED
OUT ONLY THOSE HAVE BEEN ON AND
IN THE PRINT THAT WAS PASSED OUT
SO YES THE THREE THAT YOU HAVE
STATED.
THAT'S IT THERE'S NO OTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT WE THAT THAT'S
PART OF THE MOTION.
SO THANK YOU.
THAT THAT YEAH DON'T.
DON'T WORRY WE WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO BE YOUR INTENTIONS ARE NOT
TRYING TO PULL A FAST.
ONE OKAY SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
NO FAST ONES BUT YOU KNOW WE
KNOW THAT CONFUSING HAPPENS FROM
TIME TO TIME -- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVALS.
OKAY THANK YOU SO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AN AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
CAN.
STONE.
STONE AYE DORADO.
DRUG SO I'D GROW.
HER TADO.
RICARDO I LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
RUBIO.
REVIEW BY [inaudible] THREE
SEVEN AND THAT'S EVERYBODY RIGHT.
OKAY.
OKAY SO SO OKAY SO THAT BILLS
OUT.
SEVEN ZERO SENATE YOU'RE CORRECT
THANK YOU ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON
WE HAVE A SENATOR CAPPIELLO LACY --
NINETY ANSWER ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
SB FIVE THIRTY NINE I UNDERSTAND
THIS BILL HAS NO.
SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION THAT.
VISION NO OPPOSITION SO IT IS
NOW -- 931- I THINK I THINK
THERE'S SOME AMENDMENTS DESERVE
[inaudible]
THERE ARE.
NONO MEANT OKAY NO MAN IT'S WE
ACTUALLY MADE ALL THE CHANGES
PRIOR TO THE COMING AT THE
COMMITTEE AND I WANNA THANK YOU
CENTER CABRIO FOR WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE -- TO ON THAT IN
TERMS OF THE BILL IN TO TERMS OF
VERSION WE HAVE BEFORE US SO.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS SB FIVE THIRTY NINE
WOULD CREATE A TRUST FUND TO
SUPPORT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONS.
CALIFORNIA HAS A SHORTAGE OF
BEHAVIORAL MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS -- ACROSS THE
STATE BUT ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS THE CURRENT WORST
WORKFORCE.
IS SET TO RETIRE AT A FASTER
PLACE AND IT WILL BE PEACE THEN
IT WILL BE REPLACED. TO ADDRESS
THE SHORTAGE THE OFFICE OF STATE
RIGHT PLANNING IN RECENT SURGE
POSH PREZ HAS DEVELOPED A FIVE
YEAR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PLAN.
THIS PLAN ADDRESSES THE SHORTAGE
BY PROMOTING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS WHICH
INCLUDE LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS
STIPENDS FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CLINICIANS INCREASING CAPACITY
AT UNIVERSITIES TO TRAIN AND-SUPERVISE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
AND HIRING PEER TO PEER
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS --
PROMO THOUGHT IS PROMOTED AS
THESE PROJECTS HAVE BEEN SHOWN
TO BE EFFECTIVE AT ATTRACTING
PROFESSIONALS TO UNDERSERVED
AREA AS WELL AS CONNECTING MORE
PEOPLE TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
SO TO CUT TO THE CHASE -- ERR SB
FIVE THIRTY NINE WILL ESTABLISH
AN INNOVATIVE SUSTAINABLE
SOLUTION BY ESTABLISHING THE
WORK FORCE EDUCATION TRAINING
TRUST FUND OR WET TRUST FRIEND
WHICH WOULD SUSTAIN WORK BY
FORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
DEVELOPED BY OFSHE PAID IN THEIR
FIVE YEAR PLAN.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE VOLATILITY OF
THE TRUST FUND WE AMENDED THE
BILL TO ESTABLISH A MORE STABLE
FUNDING MECHANISM IT'S IN THE
BILL SO I WE DON'T HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THAT -- AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
OKAY DEVICES RIGHT TO BILLS BEEN
MOVED ACTUALLY THINK PLACER
GROVE READY.
THANK A GREAT -- SO WITNESSES
SUPPORT RECOGNIZE THERE'S NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION WHILE YOU DO
HAVE SIX MINUTES YOU CAN USE A
LOT LESS IT'S BEEN IT'S VERY
LATE NOW.
THANK YOU -- I AM DOCTOR LEE
UNDER CLICK HARVEY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES -- WE REPRESENT --
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE AND JUST WANNA LET YOU
KNOW THAT THE RETENTION OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORK FORCE AT
THE TOP ISSUE -- THAT OUR
MEMBERS CARE ABOUT AND WERE ARE
ALL AWARE OF THE WORK FORCE
CRISIS IS CURRENTLY IN OUR STATE --
AUSPICE PLAN REALLY LEYVA NICE
FRAMEWORK TO SOLVING THIS CRISIS
BUT THERE'S NO DEDICATED AN ON
GOING FUNDING FOR THE PLAN AND
THIS BILL WILL ESTABLISH THAT.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MY NAME IS JANE ADCOCK THEM WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL WE ALL KNOW
THERE'S A WORKFORCE SHORTAGE THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THAT
CALLS FOR A FIVE YEAR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN EVERY FIVE
YEARS WITHOUT LIMIT.
BUT THERE IS NO FUNDING THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES THAT THANK YOU.
THIS IS A SUPPORT JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION.
AND HOW I GOT INVOLVED WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SO MY IN HER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS
ARE ONE OF THE PROUD CO SPONSORS
OF THE BILL.
ALSO CONVEYING SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
XENON QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE -- WHICH TO IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR GROW WHICH
LIKE THE CLOTHES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU AND AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING FOR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF -- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND I CAN
AYE STONE. SEVEN I'D DORADO
TERRAZZO I'D GROW.
GROVE I HER TADO.
LEYVA MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING I
RUBIO.
HER TITLE HI HER TITLE AYE LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE [inaudible] EIGHT
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI.
OKAY YOUR BILLS OUT NINE ZERO
THANK YOU VERY RELATIONS THANK
YOU.
OKAY.
WE ARE GOING FILE ORDER SO I
KNOW CENTER BATES WE HAVE CENTER
JACKSON AND THEN -- AND THEN
WE'LL TRY TO GET CENTER MONEY
QUICKLY TO I KNOW HE'S A WITNESS
SENATE JACKSON ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
CLINICAL TRIALS ANY OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
YES.
OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY -- PLEASE
PLEASE AGAIN I WONDER USES THE
TIME AT WHICH WERE ON A DOUBLE
TIME PAY.
LOOKING FOR TO MY FAMILY LEAVE.
GOOD POINT MISTER CHAIR.
BE ON TIME.
BE ON TIME FOR JOKES MY
COLLEAGUE SAYS BECAUSE I'D LIKE
HER SUPPORT I WILL MOVE QUICKLY --
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
IT'S A BILL THAT CONFORMS
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH FEDERAL LAW
PERTAINING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. FOR ROUTINE PATIENT
COSTS RELATED TO CLINICAL TRIALS
I FIRST WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HELPING
INCORPORATE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS.
TO ADDRESS DISCREPANCIES IN THE
INTRODUCTORY LANGUAGE.
BASICALLY FOLKS FOR CALL OF
PEOPLE LIVING WITH CANCER AND
OTHER LIFE THREATENING DISEASE
CLINICAL TRIALS OFTEN OR THE
LAST RESORT THAT CAN MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH.
WELL WE TRIED TO DO HERE IS
RETAIN STATE -- PROGRAMS THAT
ARE HIGHER THAN FEDERAL PROGRAMS
AND IN AREAS WHERE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN.
HIGHER THAN STATE PROGRAMS TO
LIFT OUR STATE PROGRAMS TO MATCH
THE HIGHER FEDERAL PROGRAMS I
COULD GO INTO DETAIL ON THE
SPECIFICS THERE ALREADY IN YOUR
ANALYSIS SO I WOULD JUST SIMPLY
SAY.
THAT WHAT OUR GOAL IS HERE IS TO
MAKE SURE -- THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
DESPERATE TO FIND AT LAST EFFORT
TO STAY ALIVE ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE PROGRAMS THAT THE FEDERAL
LAW HAS THAT ARE BETTER THAN
OURS MAKING SURE THAT IN THOSE
AREAS WHERE STATE LAW.
IS HIGHER THAN FEDERAL WE
MAINTAIN THOSE STANDARDS AND
WITH THAT I HAVE -- JANICE ROCCO
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITNESSES SUPPORT YOU GOT
TOTAL SIX MINUTES BE CAN USE A
LOT LESS.
CHANNEL STRUCK THE DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE JUST TO
ADD WHAT SENATOR JACKSON SAID.
THE HEALTH INSURERS AND HEALTH
PLANS ARE ALREADY SUBJECT TO
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL LAW THAT
WE DO HAVE SOME MISMATCHES IN
TERMS OF HOW THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW WORK TOGETHER SO
THIS WILL HELP CLARIFY THAT --
AND IT'LL DO THINGS IN TERMS OF
FEDERAL PROTECTIONS.
LIKE PUTTING INTO STATE LAW THAT
THE COVERAGE FOR CLINICAL TRIALS
APPLIES NOT ONLY TO CANCER KIND
OF CLINICAL TRIALS BUT FOR ANY
LIFE THREATENING DISEASES OR
CONDITIONS.
AND THE BILL'S HELPFUL TO THE
STATE REGULATORS BECAUSE IT
GIVES US A EXPLICIT AUTHORITY --
TO ENFORCE THOSE PROVISIONS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN FEDERAL LAW BY
PLACING THEM INTO STATE LAW
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GETTING THE M. JDS HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA AT LEAST SUPPORT BUT
WE ARE HAPPY TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
WHICH WITH A LINE CALIFORNIA LAW
WITH FEDERAL LAW AND IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
CLINICAL TRIALS TO INCLUDE OTHER
LIFE THREATENING HEALTH
CONDITIONS -- THIS WOULD ENSURE
THAT PATIENTS ARE NOT IMPROPERLY
DENIED COVERAGE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN CLINICAL TRIALS
AND FOR THIS REASON WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU AND THE WITNESS
IS SUPPORT BACK MICROPHONE
PLEASE COME UP QUICKLY.
NO ONE DECK MICROPHONE OKAY I
DON'T SEE OKAY WITH THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
ANOTHER OF PLEASE MAKE ROOM FOR
THE MATTER OKAY USP FROM THERE.
LET ME WALK INS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
IN THE SPONSOR WE HAD SOME EARLY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WE
SHARE THIS INFORMATION WITH OUR
MEMBERS WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS JUST A SMALL POPULATION OF
GRANDFATHERED MEMBERS THAT.
MAY BE IMPACTED WERE WAITING
SOME FEEDBACK FROM OUR MEMBERS
BUT SO FAR WE'VE GOTTEN POSITIVE
FEEDBACK THAT THEY CURRENTLY
ALLOW FOR THIS EXPANSIVE
COVERAGE SO FOR THOSE REASONS.
TODAY WE ARE STILL OPPOSE BUT WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS AND POTENTIALLY
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU JENNIFER I WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
THANK YOU.
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE OUT TO MONDAY
HAVE AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS JUST DID OR WHAT THEY SAID
OKAY THANK YOU.
BYE ANY ASPEN MOVED THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER STONE -- THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR JACKSON FOR
WORKING COMEDIAN WORKING THE
OPPOSITION DO THAT WISH TO CLOSE --
JUST ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
PRECIADO JURORS SUPPORT IN THE
ASSISTANCE WILL KEEP WORKING ON
THIS AND HOPEFULLY EVERYBODY
WILL COME ON BOARD.
OKAY IMPORTANT -- FOR THOSE WHO
ARE FIGHTING HARD FOR THEIR
LIVES THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND I AND I
STONE.
STONE I AM DORADO.
DRAWS -- I'D GROW.
GROVE I HER TANTO.
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
RUBIO. ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX SEVEN OKAY TO SO THAT'LL IS
SEVEN ZERO OF THE THE THE TO GET
IT OUT FOR WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MBANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OKAY -- ALL RIGHT
SO I AM GOING.
TOI OWN EXERCISE PRIVILEGES
CHAIR -- CENTER MORLOCK I KNOW
YOU ARE EARLIER IN FILE ORDER --
BUT CENTER BATES HAS BEEN
WAITING A VERY LONG TIME SENATOR
MONEY HAS A WITNESS WHO NEEDS TO
GO SO IF YOU DON'T MIND I WILL
IT CENTER BATES GO FIRST AND
CENTER MONEY THAT WE WILL COME
TO YOU IS THAT ALRIGHT.
AND I UNDERSTAND BOTH OF THESE
BILLS HAVE DO NOT HAVE STRONG
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND.
SO SURVEYS PLEASE COME UP AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I'VE
SEEN YOU SITTING THERE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME EVEN THOUGH YOU
KNEW YOUR TOWARD THE END OF OUR
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN CON DOT DOCTOR PAN -- I
LEARNED A LOT SO FOR TWO HOURS
I'VE BEEN EDUCATED ON EVERYTHING
I DIDN'T NEED TO KNOW THAT I'M
VERY HAPPY NOW I DO.
AND I AM NOT AT MY PEAK SO
REMEMBER THAT MISS ME.
ANYWAY THANK YOU -- IT'S GRET
TO BE HERE THIS EVENING --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE SB
SEVEN FORTY SIX REQUIRES HEALTH
CARE INSURANCE PROVIDERS THAT
ALREADY COVER CHEMOTHERAPY AND
RADIATION THERAPY TO COVER ANTI
CANCER AND MEDICAL DEVICES AS OF
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TUMOR TREATING
FIELDS TTF THERAPY IS A
BREAKTHROUGH TREATMENT OF SOLID
TUMOR CANCERS HIS BEEN APPROVED
FOR THE TREATMENT OF G..
GEOL BLAST ALME GBM BRAIN CANCER
UNDER THE RIGOROUS FEDERAL FOOD
AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION
PREMARKET APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
CLASS THREE MEDICAL DEVICES.
GBM IS THE MOST COMMON AN
AGGRESSIVE PRIMARY BRAIN CANCER
AND PROGRESSES RAPIDLY.
TTF THERAPY HAS BEEN ARE PROVEN
TO SIGNIFICANTLY EXTEND THE
LIVES AND FUNCTIONALITY.
OF GBM PATIENTS GETTING CARE
EARLY AND IMMEDIATELY.
HE IS CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
THE DEVICE IN JANUARY TWENTY
NINETEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
FOUND THAT ANTI CANCER AND
MEDICAL DEVICES ARE A BASIC
HEALTHCARE SERVICE IN THE
TREATMENT OF CANCER IN SHOULD BE
COVERED.
THE BILL WILL MAKE IT CLEAR IN
CO THAT HEALTHCARE PROVE
INSURANCE PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED
TO COVER.
ANTI CANCER AND MEDICAL DEVICES
IF THE ALREADY COVER
CHEMOTHERAPY AND OR RADIATION
THERAPY THE BILL ALSO DEFINES AN
ANTI CANCER MEDICAL DEVICE IS A
DEVICE THAT IS APPROVED.
BY THE FEDERAL FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION USE PRIMARILY
OUTSIDE OF A MEDICAL TREATMENT
FACILITY.
AND DETERMINE TO BE NECESSARY IN
THE TREATMENT OF CANCER.
THE DEVICES HAVE BEEN FOUND TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IN REPEATED
STUDIES AND APPROVED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL FOR THEIR USE A
NATIONWIDE.
IT IS CRITICAL FOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO COVER THESE DEVICES
FOR INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
GBM OR OTHER TYPES OF CANCER
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
THIS EVENING JUSTIN KELLY.
WITH NO WILL CURE WHO CAN ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT.
THE DEVICE AND HOW IT OPERATES.
IT WILL THIS IS SUPPORT YOU CAN
HAVE UP TO SIX MINUTES BUT I
WOULD RECOMMEND AT THIS LATE
EVENING THAT WE CAN KEEP IT MUCH
SHORTER THAN THAT OF BE
APPRECIATED.
IN A MEMBERS THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY I KNOW YOU GUYS VERY VERY
LONG DAY.
A BUS FROM IS THE DISEASE THAT
KILLED SENATORS TED KENNEDY AND
JOHN MCCAIN.
AS WELL AS VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S SON BEAU.
OP TUNE IS AN FDA APPROVED.
ANTI CANCER DEVICE FOR BOTH FOR
CURRENT AND NEWLY DIAGNOSED
CLEAR BLAST FROM A BRAIN TUMORS --
THE FIRST FDA APPROVAL WAS
ISSUED IN -- TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
IT WAS ISSUED ON THE BASIS OF A
CLINICAL TRIAL DATA THAT SHOWED
THAT THE THERAPY WHEN USED ALONE --
WAS COMPARABLE TO CHEMOTHERAPY
AND THE COULD CONTROL ARM OF THE
STUDY -- BUT WITHOUT THE SIDE
EFFECTS AND TOXICITY ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT WHICH LED TO A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR PATIENTS.
A SECOND FTA APPROVAL WAS ISSUED
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
FOLLOWING A LARGE RANDOMIZED
TRIAL THE NEWLY DIAGNOSED CLEO
BLAST OVER WHICH USE THE
OPPORTUNE IN COMBINATION WITH
TEMOZOLOMIDE CHEMOTHERAPY.
THIS RESULTED IN A SIGNIFICANT
EXTENSION OF BOTH PROGRESSION
FREE SURVIVAL AND OVERALL
SURVIVAL COMPARED TO PATIENTS
RECEIVE CHEMOTHERAPY ALONE.
TODAY THE NATIONAL COMPREHENSIVE
CANCER NETWORK -- INCLUDES UP TO
TREATMENT FOR BOTH NEWLY
DIAGNOSED IN WERE CURRENTLY --
BLAST OMA AND RECOMMENDS THIS
THERAPY AS PART OF THE GIGLIO
BLAST ON THE STANDARD OF CARE.
MOREOVER VIRTUALLY EVERY MAJOR
INSURANCE CARRIER IN THE UNITED
STATES -- AND MANY STATE
MEDICAID PROGRAMS INCLUDING
MEDICAL HELP PUBLISH COVERAGE
POLICIES FOR TUMOR TREATING
FIELDS THERAPY.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
AMERICANS ARE COVERED FOR TUMOR
TREATING FIELDS THERAPY IN THE
EVENT OF A GLIOBLASTOMA
DIAGNOSIS.
WELL OPPORTUNITY OFTEN COVERED --
SOME PLANTS COVERED IN
CONSISTENTLY -- OFTEN TO THE
GREAT DETRIMENT OF PATIENTS WHO
PURCHASE THEIR PLANS ON THE
INDIVIDUAL OR SMALL GROUP MARKET.
THIS IS RESULT IN PATIENTS WHO
HAVE HAD TO FOREGO TREATMENT.
OUT OF POCKET OR SEEK ALTERNATE
FUNDING SOURCES FOR STANDARD OF
CARE TREATMENT THAT FOR MANY
PATIENTS MAY BE THEIR ONLY
AVAILABLE OPTION.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A LETTER
WITH THE COMMITTEE TODAY -- FROM
A WHAT SINGLE RESIDENT LIVING
WITH CLEAR WHAT'S GONNA HE
PURCHASES HEALTH PLAN TO COVER
CALIFORNIA.
ARRANGED RAN INTO THE ISSUE THIS
BILL INTENDS TO FIX.
I BELIEVE HIS LETTER UNDERSCORES
THE NEED FOR THIS LEGISLATION
AND THE REAL HUMAN IMPACT --
THIS ISSUE HAS ON SOME
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS RELY ON THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET TO AND TEEN
INSURANCE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR PATIENT
SITUATION IT TOOK THIRTEEN
MONTHS.
OUT GOING THROUGH THE APPEAL
PROCESS TO GET A FAVORABLE
RESOLUTION.
IN CLOSING.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS ISSUE
IMPACTS VERY FEW CALIFORNIANS --
BUT FOR THOSE THAT THIS DOES
IMPACT THE MAGNITUDE COULD BE
CATASTROPHIC BOTH FINANCIALLY AS
WELL AS MEDICALLY.
AND WITH THAT WE ASK THAT YOU
VOTE IN FAVOR THIS LEGISLATION
TO ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS INTO CANCER MEDICAL
DEVICES THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN LADIES AND GENTLEMAN --
MY NAME IS MIKE CROSS AND IT'S
MY HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO BE
COUNSELED COME OVER TO YOUR I'M
ONLY HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY I ASK I THANK
YOU OF OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ACT LIKE PHONE.
CAMERA JIMENEZ GRANDDAUGHTER OF
SOMEBODY WHO I WATCHED I HAVE
CANCER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I GUESS GOOD EVENING FIELDING
GRIEVES THE ADVANCED MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE SUCCESS -- AND
AND POTENTIAL FOR THIS
TECHNOLOGY AND PLEASE TO SPORTED
LIGHTER DRIVE OUT THANK YOU HE
GERMAN MEMBERS ALL OF ROCK RIGHT
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SEEN OTHER WITNESSES --
AND SUPPORT WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
YOUR COMMITTEE.
A DIFFERENT BACK OKAY.
JENNIFER HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS -- YOU
KNOW THIS BILLS ON OUR MANDATE
LIST THAT WE SENT OUT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR THE
FEEDBACK FROM OUR MEMBERS IS
THAT THEY ALL COVER IT RIGHT NOW --
WE'VE BEEN HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH SUPERB IT SAYS IN THE
REPORT AND 9% OF THE POPULATION
ISN'T COVERED WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO IDENTIFY THAT POPULATION
WE THINK IT MAY BE.
LACK OF RESPONSE RATE FROM THEM
SO WE'RE JUST YOU KNOW WE'RE
JUST LIKE WE DON'T THINK THAT
IT'S NECESSARY BUT WE DON'T WE
COVER IT RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU. SEVENTY WALKEN'S ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES WOULD ECHO
THOSE COMMENTS WERE WAITING FOR
FEEDBACK FROM OUR MEMBERS BUT
WERE HELPFUL WILL BE ABLE TO
REMEMBER OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
JOHN WINGER ON THE OF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLAN JUST GONNA
DO ANOTHER DATA.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WELL
I'M GLAD TO KNOW ALL THE HEALTH
PLANS COVER IT NOW OKAY -- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO I THINK I THINK THERE'S A
MOTION FROM CENTER.
GROWTH READY -- SO OKAY -- SO
IT'S BEEN -- MOVED -- AND AGAIN
THANKS SO MUCH FOR HIS BILL FOR
US WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES
SPECTRALLY ASKS FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
BATES ALRIGHT MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HAND NIGHT AND I STONE.
STONE AYE DORADO.
DRUGS -- I'D GROW.
GROVE I HER TATO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO. SEVEN SIX AND
UP SO THAT BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES
IT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT WILL
HOLD IT ON THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANKS VERY MUCH.
OKAY CENTER MONEY -- SO YOU THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER SIX AS BEFORE --
SEVEN RIGHT WELCOME [inaudible]
THIRTEEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COURTESY AND FOR SENATOR MORE
LOCK.
I DO HAVE A WITNESS WHO'S
DRIVING BACK TO SANTA CRUZ THIS
EVENING SO.
IN THE SPIRIT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
AND COURTESY.
I THINK YOU.
SENATE BILL.
FOUR OH SEVEN RECENTLY INSURERS
HAVE BEGAN ADDING NON MEDICAL
INNOVATIVE BENEFITS TO THE MOST
POPULAR MEDIGAP PACKAGE IN AN
ATTEMPT TO DISTINGUISH THEIR
PRODUCTS FROM OTHERS IN THE
MARKET PLACE.
WHILE THESE BENEFITS INCLUDING
VISION DENTAL AND HEARING. TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL COVERAGE
THE INCLUSION OF THESE NON
STANDARD BENEFITS INSIDE THIS
STANDARD MEDIGAP BENEFIT PACKAGE
HINDER THE ABILITY OF CONSUMERS
TO MAKE MEANINGFUL COMPARISONS
BETWEEN NON MEDICAL BENEFITS.
DUE TO THE COMPLEXITY IN
VARIATION OFFERED BY INSURERS
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES MUST NOW
COMPARE THE DEDUCTIBLES
COPAYMENTS ANNUAL LIMITS
PREMIUMS AND OTHER REQUIREMENTS
OF EACH VISION DENTAL AND
HEARING BENEFIT.
IN EACH MEDIGAP PACKAGE FROM
EACH INSURER.
IN ADDITION INSERTING THESE
INNOVATIVE BENEFITS INSIDE A
MEDIGAP PLAN WILL AFFECT THE
OVERALL PREMIUM COSTS FOR
COVERAGE AND LEAD TO PREMIUM
INCREASES LEADING TO AN
INCREASINGLY EXPENSIVE MEDIGAP
PLAN.
AS COSTS RISE FOR THESE
ADDITIONAL ITEMS AND SERVICES.
SENATE BILL FOUR OH SEVEN
PROHIBITS THE PRACTICE OF
EMBEDDING NON MEDICAL INNOVATIVE
BENEFITS.
INTO THE BODY OF A STANDARD
MEDIGAP PLAN WHICH MAINTAINS THE
ORIGINAL FEDERAL INTENT OF
STANDARDIZED MEDIGAP BENEFIT
PLANS TO COVER MEDICARE'S OUT OF
POCKET COSTS.
THIS BILL SETS CONSUMER FOCUS
STANDARDS WHICH WILL PROTECT AND
ALLOW SENIORS TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND ALL ASPECTS OF AN
INNOVATIVE PLAN THEY MAY SEEK TO
PURCHASE.
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I VOTED THE PROPIONATE SURE
THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
BONNIE BURNS SHE'S A POLICY
SPECIALIST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH ADVOCATES.
OKAY WELCOME THANK YOU I KNOW
IT'S LATE AND I'LL BE BRIEF.
BUT I DO WANT TO TELL YOU WHY
THIS BILL IS SO IMPORTANT
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
CALIFORNIA HEALTH ADVOCATES
SINCE TO THE HIGH CAPS THE
CALIFORNIA -- HEALTH INSURANCE
COUNSELING AND ADVOCACY PROGRAMS --
THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE EXPERIENCED
INCREASED TO AN INCREASED USE OF
THEIR SERVICES BY PEOPLE WHO
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE
POLICIES.
I SERVED ON THE TEAM THAT
STANDARDIZE THESE POLICIES IN
NINETEEN NINETY HAS ORDERED BY.
FEDERAL LEGISLATION.
I SERVED AS AN EXPERT WITNESS.
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
LAWSUIT BROUGHT BY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
AGAINST A LARGE BAY AREA
INSURANCE BROKERAGE.
FIRM MASSIVE SALES AND MARKETING
ABUSES THAT WORK FOR SYSTEM
DURING THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
THIS LAWSUIT AND OTHERS AROUND
THE COUNTRY LED CONGRESS TO
STANDARDIZE THESE POLICIES IN.
NINETEEN NINETY ALMOST THIRTY
YEARS AGO.
WITH THE STANDARDIZATION OF
THOSE POLICIES SALES AND
MARKETING ABUSES ALMOST
DISAPPEARED.
BECAUSE SENIORS COULD EASILY
TELL WHAT THE BENEFITS WERE IN
THOSE POLICIES.
AND COULD CHOOSE THE ADEQUATE
COVERAGE THAT THEY WERE LOOKING.
FOR EMBEDDING NON STANDARDIZED
NON MEDICAL BENEFITS INSIDE A
STANDARDIZED MEDIGAP POLICY
MAKES IT A LOT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TO CHOOSE
APPROPRIATE COVERAGE.
AND THEY CAN'T ADEQUATELY
COMPARE THESE ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS. TO THOSE BENEFITS
OFFERED BY OTHER COMPANIES.
SO IT'S OF IS A HARD CHOICE FOR
PEOPLE TO MAY.
WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
COMPANIES TO COMPETE WITH ONE
ANOTHER AND THE NEED TO COMPETE
WITH MEDICARE ADVANTAGE PLANS
AND WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THESE
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS THAT ARE
BEING OFFERED IN THESE MEDIGAP
POLICIES.
BUT THESE BENEFITS ARE NOT
STANDARDIZED AND THEY APPEAR TO
BE STANDARDIZED BECAUSE THEY'RE
INCLUDED IN.
A PRODUCT THAT DOES HAVE
STANDARDIZED THE BENEFITS.
WE KNOW WHAT WOULD BE EASIER FOR
CONSUMERS TO COMPARE AND
UNDERSTAND THESE BENEFITS IN THE
FORM OF A WRITER.
WITH SOME DEGREE OF STANDARDIZED
FORMAT AND TERMS AND CONDITIONS.
WITHOUT AFFECTING THE DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR MEDICAL BENEFITS.
AT LEAST ONE COMPANY OFFERING
THESE BENEFITS INSIDE A MEDIGAP
PLAN ALSO SELLS FOR SEPARATE
WRITERS.
WITH THE SAME BENEFITS HAVE
VARYING PREMIUMS COVERAGE LIMITS
AND COPAYMENTS.
WE URGE YOU TO HELP US MAINTAIN
THE STANDARDIZATION OF MEDICARE
BENEFITS THAT HAVE BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL FOR ALMOST THIRTY
YEARS.
AND HELP SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. TO SELECT THE MOST
APPROPRIATE COVERAGE AT THE MOST
APPROPRIATE COST FOR THEIR
MEDICAL NEEDS.
WE URGE YOU.
TO VOTE ON THIS BILL AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEE NINE WITNESSES OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
STEPHANIE WALKEN'S ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES WE HAD A PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION WHAT THE AUTHORS
OFFICE RECENTLY THIS WEEK WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THEM IN
THE SPONSORS TO SEE IF THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY FOR US TO COME
TOGETHER.
WE CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT CONSUMERS AND SENIORS
UNDERSTAND THE PRODUCTS THAT
THEIR PURCHASING BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE IDEA OF
TAKING THESE INNOVATIVE PRODUCTS
OFF THE MARKET WE THINK THEY
DEFINITELY GIVE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN OPTIONS TO SENIORS
AND WE THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
BUT WE WE'D LIKE TO HAVE A OPEN
DIALOGUE THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
TODAY AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM THANK YOU.
JENNIFER ALLY WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS ARE
LIKE TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU.
OKAY THANKS RIGHT SAY NO OTHER
WITNESSES -- ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IS THERE A MOTION.
OKAY IT'S MOTION BY SIR LEYVA I
THANK YOU SIR MONEY FOR BRINGS
FORWARD WHICH LIKE CLOSE -- TO
RESPECT US FOR AN AYE VOTE AGAIN
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COURTESY ACCOMMODATING OUR
WITNESS THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PAN.
HI AND I STONE.
STONE NOTE DORADO.
DRUGS OR I GROWTH GROVE KNOW HER
TADO.
HER TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE MITCHELL.
SO I MONNING.
MORNING I AM RUBIO.
RUBIO HI. SEVEN OKAY THE BILLS
OUT SEVEN TWO AND A SAFE DRIVE
BACK HOME.
ALL RIGHT -- CENTER MORLOCK YOU
HAVE.
I THINK CENTER ALLEN TRIED TO
SNEAK IN BUT YOU ARE HERE FIRST
STILL [inaudible]
SO.
ALL RIGHT THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN SB SIX EIGHTY
NINE MISTER MOORE Là WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND A GREAT WEEK I'M GLAD WERE
PAID BY THE HOUR.
MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS DOES
SOMETHING THAT SACRAMENTO
DISAGREES WITH WHAT IS OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL DO.
HE SUES.
SOMETHING SIMILAR IS HAPPENING
IN CALIFORNIA WHEN SACRAMENTO
REMOVES LOCAL CONTROL WHAT OF
WHAT DO CITIES DO THEY SUE.
LAST NOVEMBER THE CITIES OF
ORANGE ANAHEIM IN COSTA MESA.
IN A SAN DIEGO SUPERIOR COURT
ROOM.
SUE THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO STOP NONPROFIT
CONTRACTORS FROM OPERATING
MOBILE.
NEEDLE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN AB SIX OH FOUR
BY.
ASSUMING BEEN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
SKINNER.
TOOK LOCAL CONTROL AWAY FROM.
CALIFORNIA'S MUNICIPALITIES AND
GAVE IT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
BUT WHO T THE CITIZENS GO TO
WHEN THEY FIND A SYRINGE AND A
PUBLIC PARK.
WHICH ENDANGERS A CHILD.
THERE CITY COUNCIL.
BUT THAT CITY COUNCIL HAS ITS
HANDS TIED CAN'T DO ANYTHING.
SACRAMENTO NOW WANTS TO TAKE
AWAY SOME LOCAL CONTROL WHEN IT
COMES TO LAND USE DECISIONS.
AS A RESULT OF HAVE A HOUSING
SHORTAGE PERHAPS IT'S TIME TO
REEVALUATE WHAT IS GOING ON SB
SIX EIGHTY NINE ATTEMPTS TO DO
THIS.
SHOULD LOCAL CITIES DETERMINE
WHEN AND WHERE NEEDLE EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS OPERATE WITHIN THEIR
BORDERS OR IN THE CASE OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
SHOULD CIVIL SERVANTS FOUR
HUNDRED MILES AWAY DECIDE.
SB SIX EIGHTY NINE PROVIDES A
DECORUM THAT WILL HOPEFULLY.
AVOID FURTHER LEGAL COSTS
ESPECIALLY WHEN OUR CITIES ARE
FINANCIALLY STRAPPED FROM EVER
INCREASING PENSION PLAN
CONTRIBUTION COSTS.
THE CITY HAS AN ORDINANCE OR
RESOLUTION.
PERMITTING A NEEDLE EXCHANGE
PROGRAM THEN WE'RE GOOD TO GO.
IF THE CITY DOES NOT BEEN THE
CASE SHOULD BE MADE TO THE
MAJORITY OF THE CITY COUNCIL TO
DO SO.
WE ALL APPRECIATE AS THE JUDGE
IN SAN DIEGO SAID THE NOBLE GOAL.
BUT THE POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AS THE JUDGE PUT
SAID.
THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE HARM
OUTWEIGHS THE SOCIAL UTILITY OF
THE PROGRAM.
WITH THE RECENT EPIDEMIC OF
OPIOID ABUSE.
IN SOLVING ONE PROBLEM ANOTHER
ONE IS CREATED WHY SHOULD PARKS
BE RATE EACH MORNING WHY SHOULD
LIBRARY JANITORS FIND THEMSELVES
**** BY A CARELESSLY TOSSED
SYRINGE OR A PATRON FINDING A
NEEDLE IN A BORROWED BOOK.
HAVING LOCAL COOPERATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVIDES FOR A
PROPER COLLABORATION.
UNILATERALLY IMPOSING A NEEDLE
EXCHANGE PROGRAM PROVIDES FOR
SURPRISE CONFUSION AND
ULTIMATELY LITIGATION THIS
DOESN'T MAKE GOOD SENSE SB SIX
EIGHTY NINE AFFIRMS THE
APPROPRIATE ETIQUETTE.
IN ADDRESSING IMPORTANT HEALTH
ISSUES FACING OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO COLLEAGUES I HAVE TWO
WONDERFUL WITNESSES THAT HAVE
STAYED TELL THE TEN O'CLOCK HOUR.
I HAVE THE SERVICE DEAVER'S AND
I HAVE THE HEALTH CARE AGENCY
DIRECTOR FROM THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE RICHARD SANCHEZ.
OKAY THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT
YOU HAVE A MAXIMUM OF SIX
MINUTES BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU
ALTHOUGH GIVEN THE LATENESS OF
THE HOUR IF YOU COULD BE MORE
BRIEF THAT PROBABLY WOULD BE
APPRECIATED -- SO FAR -- THAT
HAS AS HE MENTIONED THE NEEDLESS
TO A MOBILE EXCHANGE PROGRAM WAS
APPROVED BY UNILATERALLY BY THE
STATE IN ORANGE COUNTY.
OVER THE OBJECTIONS OF LOCAL
ELECTIVES AND CITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BY WORKING WITH THE LOCALS WE
COULD ADDRESS ISSUES THAT WERE
EXPRESSED REGARDING DISPOSAL OF
NEEDLES.
INCLUDING -- MEDICAL WASTE
MANAGEMENT THE SIGHTING OF THE
LOCATIONS SYRINGE EXCHANGE
RATIOS THE AVAILABLE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES FOR HIV AND STD --
TESTING.
LINKAGES TO SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
SO THIS WOULD HELP US PARTNER
WITH ANY EXCHANGE FORMAT.
ONE COMMENT TO ORANGE COUNTY OR
ANY COUNTY OR CITY.
AND ALSO WORK IN COLLABORATION
TO MAKE SUCCESSFUL TO GET
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE OFF DRUGS.
SO FOR THAT REASON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND IN ORANGE COUNTY.
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THIRTY RICH FOR THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
PLEASE I GOT TO TESTIFY WHILE
IT'S STILL BEEN IN DAY.
SO WITH THE US CITIES HAVE AN
INTEREST IN SOME LOCAL CONTROL
IN SUPPORT IN THIS BILL IT AT
THE LITIGATIONS FOCUSED
ATTENTION ON THINGS LIKE DRUG
FREE ZONES SCHOOLS OTHER AREAS
WHERE THEY MIGHT HAVE LOCAL
KNOWLEDGE AND WANT TO PASS LOCALORDINANCES TO SAY THIS IS WHERE.
IS THE PLACE WE OUGHT NOT HAPPEN
YOU'D NEEDLE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS
THAT'S REALLY THEIR INTEREST.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON THEY'RE
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND BACK MICROPHONE.
NAME WORKSTATION POSITION.
THE BILL ACTUALLY CAME UP FOR A
TEMPER HE MEANT AS A STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I AM I AM A
MOM AND I AM A PERSON IN LONG
TERM RECOVERY.
AND I'M ALSO REPRESENTING THE
WHITE HOUSE TREATMENT CENTER AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY RECOVERY
COLLABORATION WHICH ADDRESSES
ADDICTION.
OKAY THANK YOU.
SEEN OTHER WITNESSES WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION YOU PLEASE COME UP
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY AGAIN A REMINDER -- SIX
MINUTES MAX BETWEEN ALL THE
SPEAKERS ALTHOUGH AGAIN GIVEN
THE LATENESS OF THE HOUR IF YOU
CAN BE MORE BRIEF THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED.
GOOD EVENING -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK -- MISTER M. DISTINGUISHED
FELLOW AT THE NONPROFIT HEALTH.
RESEARCH INSTITUTE CALLED RTI
INTERNATIONAL AND I'VE BEEN
DOING RESEARCH ON DRUG USE A
HEARING CALIFORNIA FOR TWENTY
SIX YEARS -- AND THAT RESEARCH
HAS INCLUDED OVER A HUNDRED
SIXTY PAPERS PUBLISHED IN PEER
REVIEWED MEDICAL JOURNALS OF
WHICH CLOSE TO FORTY OF THEM ON
TOPIC OF NEEDLE EXCHANGE PACIFIC
LEE -- ALMOST ALL THAT IT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA -- WITH VALUE
ADDED -- TWENTY THREE AND NEW
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS IN THE STATE --
SO WE'VE DONE QUITE A LOT OF
RESEARCH ON THIS TOPIC.
FROM A COUPLE THINGS THE FOR THE
FIRST IS WE KNOW THESE ARE
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY -- YOU KNOW
THE WITH WITH THE OPIOID CRISIS
RIGHT NOW -- THEY ARE QUITE GOOD
AT AN ALMOST EVERYONE OF THESE
ACTUALLY THINK ALMOST EVERYONE
OF THESE PROGRAMS IN THE STATE.
IS HANDING OUT AN UNLOCKS OWN
HANOI CAM TO TWO PEOPLE TO
PREVENT OVERDOSES WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT'S QUITE IMPORTANT --
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY THE HIV AND
VIRAL HEPATITIS THE NEW EXCHANGE
HAS SHOWN TO WORK.
AND SO THE THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
JUST VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND NOT
REALLY FOR CITY POLITICIANS TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT BUT READ
THIS IS A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE
THAT THE YOU KNOW THE PUBLIC
PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
ON THE OTHER THING IS -- ABOUT
THESE NEEDLES THAT THAT THAT THE
GERMANS TALKING ABOUT -- WE DID
A STUDY THAT WAS PUBLISHED IN
THAT -- IN THE JOURNAL CALLED A
DRUG AND ALCOHOL DEPENDENCE A
FEW YEARS AGO WE ACTUALLY.
WENT TO TO CITIES SAN FRANCISCO
WHICH HAS A VERY LARGE SCALE
NEEDLE EXCHANGE.
IN MIAMI FLORIDA WHICH DID NOT
HAVE ANY LOOKS CHANGE THE TIME.
AND WE DID A VISUAL WALKED BUYS
OF THOUSAND RANDOM BLOCKS IN
EACH OF THOSE AND IN EACH OF
THOSE CITIES.
AND WE FOUND WAS EIGHT TIMES
MORE SYRINGES ON THE STREETS OF
THE OF MIAMI THAN SAN FRANCISCO
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY LOW EXTENSION MIAMI.
AND SO -- THIS PAPER VERY MUCH
CLEARLY SHOWED THAT NEW EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS NOT ONLY ARE -- ARE
SAVING LIVES THROUGH HIV AND
HEPATITIS C. AND AN OVERDOSE BUT
THEY'RE ALSO ACTUALLY HELPING
THE COMMUNITY THAT BRINGING
NEEDLES OFF OF THE STREETS --
AND AND SO FORTH FOR US -- YOU
KNOW THIS IS THIS THAT THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING A COMMUNITY CAN
JUST DECIDE ON ITS OWN WHETHER
THEY SHOULD DO OR NOT TO DO --
BUT RATHER THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPERATIVE FOR US TO DO
AT THIS POINT -- AND SO -- I I
WOULD URGE OF THE VOTE --
AGAINST THIS AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS LAURIE THOMAS AND THE
DEPUTY STATE DIRECTOR OF THE
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE WE WERE ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX OH FOUR BY -- NOW
SENATOR SKINNER BUT THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SKINNER THAT
CREATED THIS PROCESS ALLOWING
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH -- TO HELP IDENTIFY AREAS
OF HIGH NEED -- THAT WERE
UNDERSERVED DIE IN TERMS OF HIV
AND HEPATITIS AN OVERDOSE RISK
AND SO THAT PROCESS THAT WAS
DELINEATED IN ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
OH FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER --
ALLOWS FOR COMMUNITY INPUT
ALLOWS FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND IT
HELPS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMUNITY IS ENGAGED IN THE
CONVERSATIONS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE.
TO HELP COMMUNITIES -- ADD THESE
SERVICES TO THEIR CONTINUUM OF
CARE -- THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
COUNTY SUCH AS KINGS COUNTY
SISKIYOU A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
COUNTIES SO -- YOU KNOW THE THE
PROCESS -- ALREADY ALLOWS FOR A
FAIR AMOUNT OF COMMUNITY.
AND FOR THE MORE DENTURES THAT
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
AND THAT THAT ACCESS IS NOT
LIMITED BASED ON WHERE THEY LIVE
THAT THE LONELY -- SEVEN NOT
ONLY ABLE TO ACCESS IT IF THEY
LIVE IN A LARGE CITY BUT THEY
THEY CAN ALSO ACCESS THESE
IMPORTANT A PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICES.
IN -- RURAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL --
THERE IS FREQUENTLY SO MUCH
STIGMA AROUND ISSUES OF DRUG USE
AND POLITICIZATION OF FROM THE
WAR ON DRUGS ON DOWN.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT THESE PUBLIC
HEALTH DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE
BY PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS WITH --
ALL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH --
EPIDEMIOLOGY AND SURVEILLANCE
DATA -- AND COMMUNITY INPUT AS
POSSIBLE AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS -- WE WOULD ASK FOR YOU
TO VOTE AGAINST THIS EFFORT TO
UNDO CENTER SKINNER SPELL THANK
YOU.
CATTY BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS LIKE WAY
SUPPORTERS OF THE ORIGINAL BILL
AND OPPOSED TO THIS CHANGE THANK
YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION A
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
OR SHOULD BE OPPOSITION AT THIS
POINT OKAY BACK MY FOOT.
MY NAME IS BRANDY WILLS AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
FOUNDER OF HUMBLE TERIA CENTER
FOR HARM REDUCTION CLEARLY FROM
HUMBOLDT AND WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
OPPOSE THIS.
THANK YOU.
RAFAEL -- MERA CO FOUNDER AND CO
DIRECTOR OF INLAND EMPIRE HARM
REDUCTION OUT OF RIVERSIDE AND
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KAREN CONNELLY I'M HIV
PREVENTION MANAGER AT FAMILY
HEALTH CENTERS OF SAN DIEGO I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BROWN'S COURTNEY ON
THE DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS FOR
THE HIV EDUCATION PREVENTION
PROJECT OF ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JENNA HEY WOULD WITH THE HARM
REDUCTION COALITION WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS FOR OUR TERRACE
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MAD MEDICINE.
IT TOOK.
BUT PROBABLY TWENTY YEARS OF
LITTLE TINY INCREMENTAL STEPS.
STARTING WITH DIANE WATSON. TO
GET TO THE POINT WHERE WE NOW
HAVE NEEDLE EXCHANGE IS
AVAILABLE.
I'M SORRY THANK YOU YES SORRY
WE'RE JUST.
I APPRECIATED THAT A TRYING TO
THE DEATH.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM YOU ABOUT THE HISTORY A
LITTLE LATER ALL RIGHT -- OKAY --
QUESTIONS YOU CAN EIGHTY MEMBERS.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR.
GROVE -- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
SEEN OF OTHER QUESTIONS -- SIR
MORE LIKE -- NO I APPRECIATE.
THE WHAT DO EAGER CONCERN ABOUT
TRYING TO BRING TOGETHER LOCALS
AND PUBLIC HOUSE AND I HEARD
FROM SOME OF YOUR WITNESSES.
SWELLED -- BUT I AM ALSO
CONCERNED AT THIS BILL BASICALLY
WOULD BE A MECHANISM BY WHICH WE
WOULD ESSENTIALLY ELIMINATE
NEEDLE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS WHICH
HAVE A STRONG EVIDENCE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH THE PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
SOME FOR HIM NOT ABLE TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY -- BUT HAD BEEN
MOVED WHICH LIKE CLOTHES I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- I'M NOT HERE TO ARGUE
ABOUT THE EFFICACY OF NEEDLE
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS.
SAN FRANCISCO'S APPROVED DIDN'T.
IT'S WORKING WITH THE TO DOING
ITS THING.
BUT RIGHT NOW THERE IS NO NEEDLE
EXCHANGE PROGRAM ORANGE COUNTY
BECAUSE IT'S LITIGATION.
SO I'M JUST SAYING LET'S GET
SOME COLLATERAL COLLABORATION
LET'S WORK TOGETHER.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW NEITHER SIDE
IS IS IS WINNING.
AND PEOPLE ARE BEING GIVEN THE
SERVICE THAT THEY NEED.
SO THAT BEHOOVES US TO THEN TAKE
A LEADERSHIP POSITION.
AND IF WE CAN EFFECTIVELY
COMMUNICATE TO ELECTED
POLITICIANS JUST LIKE OURSELVES
BUT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THAT IT'S WORTHY.
OF OF OF PURSUING OR WHERE IT
COULD BE DONE AT A LIMITED BASIS
THEN I THINK WE ALL WIN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
HEY THANK YOU.
SO THE MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS ETCETERA PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
CAN.
CAN NO STONE.
STONE I DRAWS -- DRAWS -- NOT NO
GROVE [inaudible]
GROVE I HER TARA.
LEYVA.
LEYVA NOW MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO NOW [inaudible]
NUMBER TWO OKAY SO RIGHT NOW THE
ROLES THAT TO FOUR I THINK
THERE'S STILL SOME ABSENT
MEMBERS -- IF IF THE IF DOES
FAIL IN THE END WOULD YOU --
REQUEST RECONSIDERATION LIKE
THAT PLEASE OKAY IT WITH ANY
OBJECTIONS RECONSIDERATION THAT
THE POINT OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WILL GRANT THAT WITHOUT.
OBJECTION THANK YOU THANKS FOR
MUCH.
IF IT DOESN'T.
WHEN WE FINALLY CLOSE ROLE ALL
RIGHT -- I SEE SENATOR ALLEN.
WELCOME.
SO -- WE HAVE I AM THEIR FIFTEEN
SB.
SIX SEVEN SEVEN AND AGAIN I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THE HOUR OF THE
NIGHT SO BREVITY AND FOCUS IS
ALWAYS APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU ESPECIALLY IN TALKING
ABOUT A SUBJECT SUCH AS CLUBS
AND RESTAURANTS SOMETHING I HAVE
SOME FAMILIARITY WITH RIGHT ALL
RIGHT WELL THEN -- THIS ONE
LITTLE PIECE OF INFORMATION
WHILE YOU WERE DEBATING CRAP AND
PAP -- THE IMPROBABLE HAPPENED
AGAIN.
LOS ANGELES CLIPPERS ONE TWENTY
NINE GOLD SAY WHERE IS.
ONE TWENTY ONE I'M SORRY NO
DEMONSTRATIONS BUT YOU CAN.
YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LA IS IN THE HOUSE TONIGHT.
SO I FIRST WANT TO JUST THINK
THE THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR FOR
WORKING IMPROVE THIS MEASURE AND
I I'M I'M VERY HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE MINUTES.
THANK YOU TO SIT IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT THIS IS A SIMPLE BUT
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
BASED ON LIES AND SIX OTHER
STATES -- SB.
SIX SEVEN SEVEN PROHIBITS THE
USE OF NATURAL LATEX GLOVES IN
RESTAURANTS AND OTHER FOOD
FACILITIES.
NOW WHY DID WHY WE HAD TO GET TO
THIS PLACE WELL I INCIDENTS OF
OF LATEX ALLERGIES ARE
INCREASING WITH AN ESTIMATED.
AS MANY 6% OF PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES DIAGNOSE THE
ALLERGY INCLUDING UP 270% OF
HEALTH CARE AND FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS AND 711% OF THE ELDERLY --
WORKERS TO USE LATEX GLOVES ARE
AT HIGHER RISK FOR DEVELOPING
THIS ALLERGY BECAUSE THE MORE
PERSON COMES IN THE CONTEXT OF
LATEX.
THE GREATER THE RISK FOR THOSE
SUFFERING FROM THIS ALLERGY EVEN
TRACE AMOUNTS OF NATURAL RUBBER
LATEX CAN BE DEADLY.
I AM ALLERGIC REACTION CAN BE
PROVOKED BY TOUCHING A PRODUCT
CONTAINING NATURAL RIGHT --
RUBBER LATEX AND HEALING
AIRBORNE LATEX PROTEIN PARTICLES
OR EATING FOOD PREPARED USING
LATEX GLOVES.
AND I'LL SAY ACTUALLY OUR FRIEND
WHO'S UP HERE FROM -- FROM THE
DISTRICT.
HAS ALREADY HAD TO HAVE A PEN
INJECTIONS TODAY ALONE WE HAD A
LOT OF OF MOMS WITH A LOT OF
BABY MATERIALS IN.
LATEX MATERIALS AND I'LL JUST
TELL YOU JUST ILLUSTRATE THE
PROBLEM SHE WENT OVER TO CHICORY
WHICH USED TO BE LATEX FREE.
START BUT IT STILL WAS IN I HAD
AN EMERGENCY -- BECAUSE
APPARENTLY THEY STARTED USING
LATEX AGAIN -- SO SO THERE THE
USE THAT THE SYMPTOMS CAN RANGE
FROM YOUR HIVES AND RASHES ALL
THE WAY TO LIFE THREATENING
ANAPHYLACTIC SHOCK.
NOW.
HERE'S THE THING THE I WOULD NOT
BE COMING TO THIS BILL IF THERE
WASN'T A REASON ALTERNATIVES AND
CLEANING CLINICS ARE MEMORIAL
OUT ALONG THE TO MORRELL JOHNS
HOPKINS HAVE BEEN.
COMING UP WITH WITH THE FOR
MATERIALS AND IN FACT.
YOU U. S. HHS DEPARTMENT OF OF
OF YOU TO HELP HUMAN SERVICES
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION AND THE IN A YEAH AND
I ALWAYS S. H. THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF OCCUPATIONAL.
SAFETY AND HEALTH RECOMMENDS
THAT WORKERS USE NON LATEX
GLOVES FOR ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
NOT LIKELY TO INVOLVE CONTACT
WITH INFECTED MATERIAL SUCH AS
FOOD PREPARATION -- AND WE'RE
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES LOVE TO BE
USE ALTERNATE SUCH AS NITRILE
GLOVES OFFER THE SAME OR BETTER
PROTECTION AND ARE MORE OFTEN
THAN NOT CHEAPER -- SO SINCE OF
INTRODUCING THE ALL OF THE
MEASURE WE'VE HAD A MASSIVE
OUTPOURING OF PEOPLE CONTACT OUR
OFFICE TO SHARE THEIR LATEX THE
STORIES.
ARE THE ONLY TWO THOUSAND
ALLERGY STORIES WE HAVE A STACK
OF LETTERS FROM INDIVIDUALS
WRITING IN SUPPORT PLUS A CHANGE
DOT ORG PETITION -- WE'VE WE
HAVE NEARLY A THOUSAND PEOPLE
WRITTEN IN JUST A YOU KNOW
ANNOUNCED.
MOST FOLKS INCLUDING OLIVER ONE
OF MY CONSTITUENCIES MOTHERS
HERE.
I BROUGHT THIS ISSUE TO MY
ATTENTION CONTENT -- TODAY'S
HEARING AND AND USES OLOGY SO
SEVERE THAT THE UNKNOWN AOUNT
OF LATEX THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
BE PRESENT TO THE CROWD HERE
TODAY.
AFTER TODAY'S HEARING WOULD HAVE
BEEN TOO DANGEROUS SO HERE'S THE
THING WE HAVE ALTERNATE GLOVES
THE COST THE SAME OR LESS THAN
LATEX WILL OFFER YOU SEEN
PROTECTION.
MANY MANY RESTAURANTS HAVE GONE
LATEX FREE -- WE REALLY DO WANT
TO PROTECT PEOPLE LIKE OLIVER I
ANTICIPATE JUST TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY I
DOCTOR TRAVIS MILLER NOW JUST
FROM SACRAMENTO KRISTEN SHE FROM
SANTA BARBARA.
OKAY -- BEFORE WE TAKE ON THE
WITH THE SIDES I CLEAR FIRE.
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO TAKE A
MINUTE SIX IF WE HAD NO ADVANCED
OFFER A WE WERE WILLING TO DRESS
THE BILL THE WAY IT IS.
SO AS LONG AS YOU HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH THAT WE'RE GOOD
WITH THAT.
OKAY WITNESSES SUPPORT YOU HAVE
A MAXIMUM TOTAL OF SIX AMENABLE
I MEAN YES YES OKAY SO I HAVE A
TOTAL OF SIX MINUTES FOR ALL THE
SPEAKERS.
THIS IS LATE HOUR IF YOU CAN
KEEP IT BRIEF FOR THAN THAT WE'D
APPRECIATE IT [inaudible]
THESE BEGIN.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME.
MY NAME IS TRAVIS MILLER
PRACTICING ALLERGIST HERE IN
TOWN.
I'M REPRESENTING OVER FIVE
HUNDRED PATIENTS OF MINE WHO
HAVE LATEX ALLERGY I'M ALSO THE
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ALLERGY ASSOCIATION.
THAT REPRESENTS TO UNDER THE
HOUR JUST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE OF
DELEGATES OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF ALLERGY WHICH
REPRESENTS SIX THOUSAND
ALLERGISTS.
ALLERGIC DISEASE IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS IT IS AN EPIDEMIC
LATEX ALLERGY IS ONE OF THOSE --
NEW DATA ACTUALLY SHOWS THAT THE
NUMBER OF 6% MAY ACTUALLY BE
HIGHER THERE'S NUMBERS PUBLISHED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE SHOW
THAT NUMBER MIGHT BE AS HIGH AS
NINE POINT 7%.
SO WE'RE JUST SEEING AN
EXPLOSION OF ALLERGIC DISEASE
INCLUDING LATEX SB SIX SEVEN
SEVEN A MAN'S A VERY IMPORTANT
HEALTH CODE.
THESE CODES ARE IN PLACE TO
PROTECT CITIZENS IMPATIENCE IT'S
SIMPLY NOT ACCEPTABLE TO LEAVE
10% OF OUR PATIENTS WHO ARE
HYPERSENSITIVE EYES THAT'S
EXPOSED AND VULNERABLE.
I WOULD ARGUE THERE'S NO OTHER
CODE THAT WOULD ALLOW THAT
AMOUNT OF EXPOSURE TO PATIENTS
ARE CONSUMERS.
SB SIX SEVEN SAM'S SIMPLY SEEMS
LIKE A WIN WIN A SAFE
ALTERNATIVES ARE AVAILABLE AND
I'LL.
SEE MY TIME.
GOOD EVENING.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN SHE AND I
FROM SANTA BARBARA CALIFORNIA.
I AM HERE TO TELL YOU ABOUT MY
FAMILY'S EXPERIENCE LIVING WITH
AND LOSING LOVED ONES WITH LATEX
ALLERGY AND ADVOCATE FOR US AND
OTHERS AT RISK FOR LATEX
EXPOSURE.
MY SISTER CARA ANDI BOTH
DEVELOP LATEX ALLERGIES WHILE
WORKING IN THE MEDICAL.
FIELD.
BE EXPOSED TO LATEX GLOVES.
THREE OF MY FOUR CHILDREN.
ALL HAVE THE SAME DEVASTATING
LIFE THREATENING LATEX ALLERGY.
HAVING AN ALLERGY TO LIFE TO
LATEX IS LIFE CHANGING.
WE MUST AVOID ANY CONTACTS.
CONTACT WITH LATEX WE CAN'T
TOUCH IT.
WE CAN'T BE IN THE ROOM WITH IT.
WE CAN EAT FOOD PREPARED.
WITH LATEX GLOVES.
AND WE ALWAYS CARRY EMERGENCY
KITS CONTAINING BENADRYL.
INHALERS AND AT THE AT THE PENS.
WE CARRY THEM ON OUR PERSON
EVERY DAY EVERY MINUTE.
IF WE WERE TO EAT IN A
RESTAURANT THAT USE ANY.
FORM OF LATEX GLOVES WE WOULD WE
COULD EXPERIENCE LIFE
THREATENING.
ALLERGY REACTIONS.
MY SISTER CARA WAS A REGISTERED
NURSE.
AND SHE BECAME.
I'M SORRY AND HER ALLERGY BECAME
DEADLY AND SHE TRAGICALLY DIED.
FROM LATEX ALLERGY.
ON JANUARY EIGHTEENTH.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN BECOME
EXTREMELY SENSITIVE TO LATEX.
PROTEINS THE SAME PROTEINS.
BETTER IN LOW PROTEIN LATEX
GLOVES.
DIDN'T HAVE TO WHERE THE WHERE
THE GLOVES SHE ONLY HAD.
TO AT IT WAS IMPORTANCE OF ALL
SHE HAD TO DO WAS HAVE IT.
OKAY.
SORRY I HAD A VERY MY SISTER --
IS VERY HARD. FOR ME BECAUSE
LAST WEEKEND WAS HER BIRTHDAY
AND I HAD TO TAKE MY MOM AND
IT'S A DEVASTATING THING TO DO
IS TO TO BURY A CHILD.
HOWEVER I BROUGHT MYSELF
TOGETHER AND AS I NEED TO SAVE
MYSELF AND MY CHILDREN FROM
EXPOSURE TO LATEX CONTAMINATED
FOOD.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE
PREVENTIVA LOSS OF LIFE DUE TO
LATEX ALLERGY IS ACTUALLY
DEVASTATING.
LIKE HEALTHCARE WORKERS THOSE
WORKING IN FOOD INDUSTRY ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO LATEX ALLERGY I
UNDERSTAND THAT LATEX GLOVES ARE
LESS EXPENSIVE.
SO WHY WOULD ANYONE CHOOSE. TO
TO THE MORE EXPENSIVE AND
DANGEROUS LIFE THREATENING LATEX
CONNIE I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
BUT I FEEL I HAVE A DUTY TO TO
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM DEVELOPING
LATEX ALLERGY AND EDUCATING THAT
LATE LIMITING EXPOSURES.
THIS IS PERSONAL TO ME BECAUSE
IT'S A MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH.
I SUPPORT SB SIX SEVEN SEVEN
PLEASE HELP CALIFORNIA'S SAFER
FOR ALL.
THESE ARE MY CHILDREN HERE I
JUST WANNA HOLD UP REALLY
QUICKLY.
AND THEY ALL HAVE ALL THESE
THREE HAVE THE LATEX ALLERGY THE
SAME AS MY SISTER.
THIS IS LAST WEEK WHEN I VISITED
MY SISTER AND HOPEFULLY THIS
WILL BE AFTER WHEN WE PASS IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN MY NAME
IS A LIST THIS BUT ONLY IN MY
SON ALL OVERLY COULD NOT E HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY BECAUSE OF THE
DANGERS OF NATURAL RUBBER LATEX.
MY SON IS NINETEEN THREE YEARS
AGO A LATEX BALLOONS HOT AND HE
WE HAD HE HADN'T UNDETECTED
LATEX ALLERGY HE WENT INTO
ANAPHYLACTIC SHOCK.
THE GUN TO SANTA MONICA UCLA
JUST IN TIME AND HIS LIFE WAS
SAVED.
SINCE THAT DAY.
HE HAS TO CARRY ON HIS PERSON.
EVERY MOMENT THIS AMOUNT OF
RESCUE MEDICATION.
HE HAS NO OTHER ALLERGIES EXCEPT
OVER EXPOSURE TO NATURAL RUBBER
LATEX HE CAN EAT FOOD AT
RESTAURANTS.
IF YOU ALK THE DOG AROUND THE
BLOCK HE STILL HAS TO KEEP THE
MESSENGER BAG SO HE CAN KEEP.
HE CAN STAY ALIVE HE'S NINETEEN
YEARS OLD HE'S IN COLLEGE.
I WILL -- I WILL JUST BE VERY
BRIEF -- LATEX IS THE IS A
HIDDEN ALLERGEN IT TRANSFERS TO
FOOD HANDLED.
BY ANYONE WHO USES A LATEX GLOVE
IT'S ON CONTACT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU --
WHEN -- CONNECTICUT PASSED A BAN
ON LATEX -- I WOULD LIKE TO READ
THIS TO YOU -- IN THE HEARING
CONNECTICUT REPRESENTATIVE
PRASAD.
SURE MONSON A BOARD CERTIFIED
ALLERGIST ASKED MEMBERS OF THE
MALAYSIAN LATEX PROMOTION
COUNCIL ONE SIMPLE QUESTION.
IF I AM ALLERGIC TO LATEX AND MY
SAFE WITH YOUR CLUBS AND THEIR
ANSWER WAS NO.
APOLOGIES WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
AND MEDICARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY THANK
YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND BACK MICROPHONE.
NO ALL RIGHT WHAT YES.
MICHELLE NUMBER A TâM
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR STONE
LATEX ALLERGIC I DEVELOPED
ALLERGY USING LATEX GLOVES IN
FOOD SERVICE.
AND NOW TWO OF MY FIVE CHILDREN
HAVE IT AS WELL.
I SUPPORT THE SPELL THANK YOU
RIGHT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
YES.
HI MY NAME'S MICHAEL MARLIN I
LIVE HERE IN SACRAMENTO MY WIFE.
IS -- LATEX ALLERGIC AND SO -- I
AM IN UNOFFICIALLY MY OFFICE
OCCUPATIONS LATEX COP.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
I A N. YES.
NAME NAME IN.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH SCOTT AND ON
BEHALF OF BOTH MYSELF.
BUT THE NO LATEX SUPPORT GROUP
WHICH IS A GLOBAL GROUP OF OVER
A THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE
SEVERELY ALLERGIC TO LATEX.
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL [inaudible]
AND SICK OF THE FIFTY PLUS ABUSE
THAT I'VE USED AND FIVE TIMES A
COMPLETELY STOP READING.
PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
RAIL FOR WE AT ALL -- I
APOLOGIZE WE GO OKAY SO FEW SL
RIGHT AS IN OTHER WITNESSES
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN A WITNESS OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
YOUR MOTION OKAY SO THAT'S A
MOTION FROM CENTER MITCHELL -- I
THINK YOUR BUTTONS MAKE
COMPELLING POINT WHICH LIKE THE
CLOTHES I'VE A DEEPER SHADE I
APPRECIATE -- THE YOU GUYS FOR
COMING UP IN FOR BEING A PART OF
THIS AND AND AND AND AND MAKING
ME AWARE OF THIS ENORMOUSLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
COMMITTEE I SAID I WANT THANK
YOU FOR I KNOW YOU'VE HAD TO
WAIT A VERY LONG TIME TO MAKE
YOUR CASE -- HOPEFULLY WE CAN
HAVE A RATE POSITIVE RESULT FOR
YOU TO SEE VERY SOON.
THE MOTION HAS BEEN MADE BY SIR
MITCHELL MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND I AND I STONE.
STONE AYE DORADO.
DRUGS SO I GROWTH GROUP I HEARD
TOTO.
TOTO AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
RUBIO.
RUBIO BY NINE THIRTY MEMBER KAY
THE BILL'S PAST NINE ZERO YOU
GOT IT OKAY NINE ZERO ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU I SEE CENTER NUMBER.
I THINK YOU'RE NEXT UP ON THE
FILE ORDER SO AN ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN SB.
SEVEN FOURTEEN AS CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS -- YOU'VE BEEN HERE SO
LONG THE CLIPPERS HAVE BEATEN
THE WAR YEARS THAT'S HOW LONG
YOU'VE BEEN HERE.
THEY ARE WELL AWARE ALL RIGHT --
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SENATE BEAT
BILL SEVEN ONE FOUR WOULD SIX TO
CLARIFY. TO SOME EXTENT A NEW
REGULATION PROMULGATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE
PERTAINING TO LICENSING -- I
WANT TO THANK AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THE STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
IMPROVING THE BILL -- WE ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS -- AS MOST OF YOU
KNOW KNOCKS KEEN LICENSORS
BECOME INTERVAL SAFEGUARD TO
CONSUMERS AND PATIENTS BY
ENSURING THE ADEQUACY.
OF HEALTH CARE PROVIDER NETWORKS
THE FINANCIAL SOLVENCY OF HEALTH
CARE PLANS.
ON MARCH FIFTH D. M. A. C.
ADOPTED REGULATION REQUIRING A
MULTITUDE OF NEW HEALTH CARE
RANGE MEN'S. TO BE SUBJECTED TO
KNOX KEEN LICENSURE EFFECTIVE
JULY ONE OF THIS YEAR -- THE
REGULATION REQUIRES FOR THE
CLARITY AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ALL ABOUT THERE IS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION WITH ME.
IS -- MISTER ALEX HAWTHORN WITH
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
OKAY WITNESSES FOR WITH THERE'S
A NOTION -- MEMBERS ALEX AUTHOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
SITUATION WITH THE SPONSOR OF
THE THIS VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
BILL -- BRIEFLY AT THE HEART OF
THIS IS WHO NEEDS TO BE
REGULATED AND LICENSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE
AND WHO DOES NOT -- THE PRODUCT
IN FRONT OF YOU IS FROM AN
INITIAL STAKEHOLDER MEETING --
WE HAVE NARROWED THE BILL WILL
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION I'M
WITH ALL THOSE INTERESTED IN
THIS PROCESS MOVING FORWARD AND
WE HOPE.
TO FINALIZE A PRODUCT THAT
STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
REGULATION AND INNOVATION AND
HEALTH CARE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT KAREN CIRCUIT KAREN SICK.
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS DAVID
IN SOUTH AMERICA'S VERSION
GROUPS WE HAVE A SUPPORT AMENDED
POSITION BUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CENTER'S WORK ON
THIS WITHIN CONVERSATIONS GOING
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WITH THE FOR
THE THE DIALOGUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO MY AND HIGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE MEMORIAL CARE I'M.
HEALTH SYSTEM HERE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLUS SHEPHERD ON BEHALF OF
STANFORD HEALTH CARE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT -- WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
MONEY COME UP.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAMBERS AND
JDS HERE ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA FIRST I WANT
TO BEGIN BY SAYING HEALTH ACCESS
IS NOT OPPOSED TO ANY RISK
SHARING ARRANGEMENTS WHETHER
THEY'RE BUNDLE PAYMENTS.
ACCOUNTABLE CARE ORGANIZATION OR
ANY OTHER ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
MODELS.
HOWEVER WE HAVE BEEN OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL AS IT IS AND IT IS IN
PAIN BECAUSE IT EXPOSES DOCTORS
HOSPITALS AND PHYSICIAN GROUPS.
TO EXCESSIVE RISK AND BECAUSE IT
ALSO DEPRIVES CONSUMERS OF A
POINT CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AS
ENUMERATED BY THE KNOX KEEN ACT.
JULIE WITH REGARDS TO FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY FOR AND TO SEIZE THAT
ACTUALLY BARE WRIST -- WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS --
CRAFTED BY THE COMMITTEE AND
ALSO THE WORK WITH THE STAFF AS
WELL AS THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
TODAY AND WE ARE REVIEWING OUR
POSITION AND WILL HOPEFULLY BE
CHANGING OUR STRAIGHT OPPOSE
POSITION TO OPPOSE THEM AS
AMENDED AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
TO A PLACE WHERE WE SHOULD SHARE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
WITH THAT SAID THANK YOU.
NICK LOUISE'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS -- LIKE HEALTH ACCESS WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE POSITION ON THE
BILL AS IT EXISTS TODAY WE HAVE
NOT SEEN THE AMENDMENTS YET BUT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING
THOSE.
AND YOU KNOW WE WE MIGHT BE IN A
POSITION TO CHANGE OUR POSITION
AND I OR I WE MAINTAIN OUR
OPPOSE POSITION DEPENDING ON HOW
THOSE HAVEN'T LANGUAGE LOOKS BUT
YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY YOU KNOW
THE BILL EXAMS ENTITIES -- FROM
PROVISIONS OF THE KNOX KEEN ACT
AS AS PREVIOUSLY STATED THAT
PUTS OUR MEMBERS AT A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE -- AND
IN THE CONSUMER PROTECTION
ISSUES -- WE SHARE AS WELL BUT
YOU KNOW LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS
AND WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED TO
THE YOU KNOW STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
HAS BEEN ON GOING ON THIS AND
LOOK FOR WORKING WITH THE OFTEN
SPONSORED THANKS.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SAYING ON QUESTION
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY A YES SENATOR ALSO.
YES CENTER MARK COULD YOU
RESPOND TO THE ISSUE OF THE
EXEMPTIONS AND HOW THAT WOULD.
IMPACT OTHERS AND THE THE REMARK
THAT WAS MADE ABOUT A CREATING
THE DISADVANTAGE ESPECIALLY
SINCE THIS IS.
AN ACTOR KNOWN TO BE CONSUMER.
FRIENDLY IT IS -- LET ME DEFER
TO OF MR HAWTHORNE.
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THE BILL IN FRANCE THAT
WE ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED.
DID SPECIFIED THOSE EXEMPTIONS
IT WAS VERY SPECIFIC THE
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKING TODAY
NARROW THAT AND IT SAYS THAT THE
REGULATOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE WHO.
SPECIALIZES IN PROTECTING
CONSUMERS SHOULD COME UP WITH
THOSE DETERMINATIONS. TO
INITIALLY PUT FORWARD SOME
EXEMPTIONS THAT WE OFFERED THERE
WAS CONCERNS FROM HEALTH ACCESS
OTHER GROUPS SO WE TOOK THAT --
WE'VE SAID THE DEPARTMENT SHE
AND SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TO THE AMENDMENTS
SHOULD ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
GOING ON ALL UP TO PLEASE THANK
YOU THREE CHAIR AND NOT I THINK
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE.
IS UP PROVIDES A GREAT FIRST
STEP FOR US TO FURTHER LOOK INTO
THE QUESTION AROUND FIRST THE
LEVEL OF RISK THAT ANY ENTITY
WOULD BE WILLING TO TAKE.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE ENTITIES ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE PROPER HEALTH CARE
AND SERVICES TO THE CONSUMER SO
THAT THE CONSUMER.
WILL NOT BE FINANCIALLY LIABLE
SHOULD THAT ENTITY NOT BE ABLE
TO PAY FOR THOSE SERVICES AND
THEN SECOND -- WITH WHAT THE
SPONSORS HAVE MENTIONED WE WOULD
HOPE TO ALSO ENGAGE WITH THE
IMAGE SEE ON THE GUIDELINES THAT
THEY ARE ABOUT TO PROVIDE
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO TO
FINALIZE RULED THAT.
WAS THE IMPETUS OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL.
I THINK IT IS THE IS THE BIT IS
THE BILL AS AMENDED OR EVEN AS
IMPRINT KING FISCAL THE GOING TO
APPROACH.
IT IS YES I JUST WANTED SINCE
SINCE -- SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
HAVE NOT SEEN THE MEMBERS I JUST
WANT TO KNOW.
HOW QUICKLY WILL BE COMING TO
THE SENATE FLOOR TO MAKE SURE
YOU HAVE TIME TO WORK OUT SOME
OF THE CELL I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL?
TONIGHT SIR BUT ALL THE
MONITORING IT JUST TO KIND OF
SEE WHAT WE WERE YOU FINALLY
LAND WITH -- THE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SEEING NONE
I CAN CENTER BURGER APPRECIATE --
YOU BRING THIS BILL FORD AND
ALSO WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
ONE OF THINGS THAT WE'VE.
TALKED ABOUT WITH AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS ABOUT
KNOWING IT AGREE CARE BUT VALUE
BASED PURCHASING.
I THINK WE WILL BE SURE WE
STRIKE THAT BALANCE -- WHERE WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO MAINTAIN
PATIENT PROTECTIONS WE DON'T
EVER WANT THE PATIENT TO GET
STRANDED WHERE THEY WERE
IDENTITY THAT'S BRING RISKS NOW
SAYS WHY DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY
AND I CAN'T PROVIDE THE CARE
SERVICES OFFICE PROVIDE YOU
WANNA BE SURE THAT?
PROTECTION IS IN PLACE -- WE ARE
LOOKING AT TO ACTUALLY VALUE
BASED ARRANGEMENTS WHICH I THINK
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLANS ALSO
LIKE AS WELL BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT TRAINED SAYS.
SET UP COMPETITORS TO THE HEALTH
PLANS DIRECTLY EITHER AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE I THINK IT'S GONNA BE
IMPORTANT FOR OUR STRATEGY
MOVING FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT -- AS REMISSION.
YES CENTER STONE OKAY RIGHT OUT
WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
I CONCUR WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LET ME CORRECT THE RECORD
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS OPPOSITION SO --
ORIGINAL VOTE.
OKAY SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND I AND I STONE.
STONE I'D DORADO DRUGS YOU AYE
GROVE.
GROUP I HER TADO.
TOTAL AYE LEYVA LIVE AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I NINE BILLS OUT NINE ZERO
OKAY THANK YOU SIR GALGIANI.
I SEE THERE.
WELCOME TEN THIRTY TWO NOW PM.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK.
SB SEVEN FORTY ONE WILL PROTECT
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE'S PRIVACY BY
UPDATING AND ALIGNING THE
PROCESS FOR WHICH MERITS TREATED
MARRIAGE CERTIFICATES AND BIRTH
CERTIFICATES ARE PROCESSED.
CURRENT LAW STILL DISCLOSES THE
REGIONAL OR BIRTH NAME ON THESE
OFFICIAL DOCUMENTS AND THEREFORE
ALLOWS FOR THE POSSIBILITY OF
DISCRIMINATION OF TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE.
SB SEVEN FORTY ONE WOULD FIX
THIS AND PROTECT.
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS FROM
DISCRIMINATION WHEN ROLLING
THEIR CHILD AND SCHOOL.
APPLYING FOR A LOAN OR SIMPLY
WHEN OFFICIAL DOCUMENTS NEED TO
BE DISCLOSED WITH ME TODAY IS
TAMMY MARTIN WITH THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA WHO WILL HELP ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MAY HAVE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TAMMY MARTIN
ONCE AGAIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA SPONSOR OF SB.
SEVEN FORTY ONE AND THE IMPETUS
FOR THIS BILL CAME FROM AMIR
HAZEN BUSH WHO RUNS A LAW FIRM
IN A LOS ANGELES COUNTY THAT
FOCUSES ON LGBT Q. INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES.
AND AMIR WAS UNABLE TO ATTEND
TODAY BUT ASKED THAT I SHARE A
FEW POINTS WITH THE COMMITTEE
REGARDING THE NEED FOR THIS BILL.
I'M IN THE LAST YEAR AMIR WORKED
WITH A CLIENT WHO ASKED IF SHE
COULD MODIFY HER CHILD'S BIRTH
CERTIFICATE. TO REFLECT HER
HUSBAND'S GENDER HE'D RECENTLY
TRANSITION TO MAIL.
AND ALL AMERICA TELL HER CLIENT
WAS THAT IT WOULD COST MORE
MONEY AND SHE COULDN'T GUARANTEE
THE OUTCOME.
SO THE CLIENT CHOSE NOT TO MAKE
THE CHANGE IT ALSO THE FATHER IS
STILL LISTED AS THE CHILD'S
MOTHER ON THE BIRTH CERTIFICATE.
ANOTHER CLIENT HIRED TO COMPLETE
HER NAME AND GENDER CHANGE ABOUT
ELEVEN MONTHS AGO.
AND AMIRA RECEIVED CONFIRMATION
THAT THE CLIENT FINALLY RECEIVED
HER AMENDED MARRIAGE CERTIFICATE
JUST EARLIER THIS MONTH.
IN ORDER TO GET HER CLIENT A NEW
MARRIAGE CERTIFICATE WITH THE
OLD ONE SEALED AND WITHOUT%
INDICATIONS OF HER FORMER NAME.
AMEERA DRAFTED IN SUBMITTED A
LEGAL MEMO TO THE COURT.
HAD A FORMAL HEARING FOR A JUDGE
FILED A SEPARATE MOTION GOT THAT
ORDER PARTIALLY APPROVED SENT
THIRTY EMAILS BACK AND FORTH
WITH VITAL RECORDS MAKE
COUNTLESS PHONE CALLS AND TOWED
A VERY CAREFUL LINE BETWEEN
BANKING AND INSISTING.
AMIR ULTIMATELY EXCEED SUCCEEDED
ON BEHALF OF HER CLIENT BUT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE DO NOT HAVE THE FINANCIAL
RESERVOIRS. TO HIRE PRIVATE
COUNSEL AND AMIRA DOES NOT THINK
THAT HER CLIENTS OUTCOME COULD
HAVE BEEN ACHIEVED WITHOUT THE
ADVOCACY OF A LAWYER.
AND FRANKLY AMERICA NOTES SHE
WASN'T EVEN INITIALLY SURE THAT
SHE COULD DO IT AND SHE'S NOT
SURE THAT EVERY LAWYER WOULD GET
THE SAME OUTCOME.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE THE PROCESS
THE CHANGES SMALL IN THE FIX IS
SIMPLE.
CALIFORNIANS OF TRANS EXPERIENCE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THEIR
LEGAL NAME AND GENDER REFLECTED
ACCURATELY ON ALL OF THEIR
ADMINISTRATIVE DOCUMENTS.
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO SENATOR
GALGIANI FOR HER ATTENTION TO
THIS ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT SB
SEVEN FORTY ONE AS WELL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT SEEN ON WHAT THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION SAYING ON QUESTIONS
WILL COME ANY MEMBERS.
THERE'S A MOTION FROM CENTER
DORADO.
NOW THAT THAT LEYVA SORRY. TO
HEAR FROM THAT YEAR ALL RIGHT
SIR.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS -- THANK YOU CENTER GO
DOWN MEANS BILL FORD WHICH LIKE
CLOSE.
WE ASK FOR YOUR VOTE OKAY THANK
YOU SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AS ACTORS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AM I AND I STONE.
STONE NO DRUGS SO DRUGS -- I'D
GROWTH.
GROWTH KNOW HER TADA.
TOTAL AYE LEYVA THEY'VE AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING I RUBIO.
RUBIO FIVE SEVEN SO THAT BILL IS
OUT SEVEN TWO THANK YOU CENTER
STONE I THINK YOU'RE NEXT UP
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP.
FOUR FORTY SIX WE DO CONSENT AT
THE END.
DISTRIBUTOR AUDIBLE CHAIR
COLLEAGUES I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SB FOUR FOUR SIX WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE MEDICAL COVERAGE FOR
HYPERTENSION MANAGEMENT.
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT SERVICES
PROVIDED BY AN ADVANCED PRACTICE
PHARMACIST HYPERTENSION CONTROL
THE UNITED STATES IS COVERED AT
A ROUGHLY 50% OVER THE PAST
DECADE DESPITE THE DANGEROUS
ROLE HYPERTENSION PLAYS IN
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE.
AND THAT THE FIRST FIVE LINES OF
MEDICATIONS HARPER ATTENTION ARE
GENERIC AND BROTHER AND
EXPENSIVE.
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS --
YOU PROGRAM STATED IN THEIR
STUDY THAT MOST PREVALENT
CONDITION AMONG NON DO A MEDI
CAL ENROLLEES IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WAS HYPERTENSION A 27%.
THE HOUSE IS ALSO STATED THERE'S
A PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE FROM
FIVE STUDIES AT THE RECEIPT OF
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT IS ASSOCIATED WITH
GREATER REDUCTIONS IN.
BLOOD RESSURE THAN THAT OF
USUAL CARE THIS INCLUDES ONE
STUDY PUBLISHED THIS YEAR IN THE
NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINE
DEMONSTRATING THAT PHARMACISTS
MANAGING MEDICATIONS IN LOS
ANGELES BARBER SHOPS. FOR
PATRONS WITH UNCONTROLLED
HYPERTENSION ARE NEARLY SIX
TIMES MORE EFFECTIVE THAN USUAL
CARE ENTERTAINING BUT PRESSURE
CONTROL.
WITH HYPERTENSION BEING ONE OF
THE MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE IN THERE
BY THE GREATEST DIRECTLY
ATTRIBUTABLE RISK OF DEATH
WORLDWIDE NUMBER.
ONE SB FOUR FOUR SIX IS NEEDED
HELP BRING DOWN BLOOD PRESSURE
AND LOWER RATES OF DEADLY CARDIO
VASCULAR DISEASE AS BEFORE FOR
SIX WILL CREATE MORE ACCESS TO
COMMUNITIES ARE CURRENTLY.
DON'T HAVE HYPERTENSION
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT SERVICES
READILY AVAILABLE.
ENGAGING PHARMACISTS IN THE
MANAGEMENT OF HYPERTENSION IS
CRUCIAL TO ACHIEVING GOALS FOR
ON CONTROL PATIENTS AS BEFORE
FOR SIX IS A REPEAT OF A BILL
THAT IRAN LAST YEAR SB.
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR WHICH PASSED
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY AND WAS HELD ON
SUSPENSE UNFORTUNATELY AND THE
ASSEMBLY.
I WAS -- GOING TO BE INTRODUCING
TODAY HAVE BEEN HERE EARLIER A
COUPLE OF DOCTORS FROM CEDAR
SINAI HOSPITAL BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THEY HAD TO CATCH A PLANE TO GO
HOME WHICH I DON'T BLAME THEM AT
TEN TWENTY BUT I AM HONORED TO
HAVE THE SHOW RE WAS HERE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA -- PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION WHO WILL BE MY ONE
AND ONLY PROBABLY WITNESS --
PLEASE -- I'D LIKE TO DO SPECIAL
REQUESTS OKAY THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU CAN MACHAR
REBUS WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION
ACCORDING TO THE CDC
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION AMERICANS OLD -- AGE
EIGHTEEN AND OVER HAVE
HYPERTENSION UNFORTUNATELY ONLY
ABOUT HALF OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THE HYPERTENSION IS CONTROLLED --
ONE OF THE STRATEGIES DEVELOPED
BY THE CDC HAS BEEN TO
INCREASING GAUGE MIGHT OF NON
POSITION TEAM MEMBERS AND
HYPERTENSION MANAGEMENT AND
INCREASE ENGAGEMENT AT
PHARMACIES IN PROVIDING
EDUCATION.
SKEWS ME MEDICATION MANAGEMENT
THERAPY FOR ADULTS WITH HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE.
UNFORTUNATELY WHILE THIS IS A
PROVEN METHOD THIS IS NOT
CURRENTLY COVERED UNDER THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL WILL HELP ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE HELP WITH INHERITS AND
HELP THESE FOLKS MAINTAIN THEIR
HELP THEM WITHOUT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
DAVID THEMSELVES AMERICA'S
VISION GROUPS HAPPEN TO BE IN
SUPPORT WE SUPPORT LAST HIS BILL
AND SUPPORT THIS ONE AS WELL
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THESE COMMA.
MEMBERS TO MADDEN REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY --
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO ASK BEFORE
FOR SIX ON WHEN IT COMES TO
HYPERTENSION -- PHYSICIANS GO
THROUGH A NUMBER STEPS WHEN
LOOKING AT ON HOW TO MANAGE IS
COMPLEX DISEASE STATE.
AND ALL THIS INFORMATION THAT WE
COMPILE GOES INTO THE PATIENT'S
MEDICAL RECORD ONE OF OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL IS THAT
THE PHARMACIST MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT PATIENT'S MEDICAL
RECORD.
WHEN IT COMES TO TRYING TO
EVALUATE WHAT TO RECOMMEND OR
WHAT TO INITIATE IN TERMS OF
TREATMENTS THEY WON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION -- WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT A PHARMACIST
AND THEIR TRAINING AND
BACKGROUND.
ARE NECESSARILY -- TRAINED
EXTENSIVELY IN THE MANAGEMENT OF
HYPERTENSION I THINK IT'S WORTH
MENTIONING THE SENATOR STONE'S
MENTION THIS BILL IS LIMITED TO
ADVANCE PRACTICE FARMER SAYS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT THAT'S
NOT THE CASE IT DOES APPLY TO
THE ADVANCED PRACTICE
PHARMACISTS.
BUT IT ALSO APPLIES TO A REGULAR
FARMS AS WELL AND THAT'S REALLY
WHERE I THINK WE HEAR MORE OF A
CONCERNS AS WITH THE PHARMACIST
IT ISN'T HAVE THAT ADVANCED.
DEGREE WEATHER THERE ARE TRAINED
IN MANAGING HYPERTENSION.
WE WORRY THAT THE PHARMACIST WHO
MAY NOT HAVE THAT TRAINING WILL
INITIATE -- TREATMENTS THAT ARE
NECESSARY OR APPROPRIATE AND
THAT A LEAD TO INCREASED
HEALTHCARE COSTS AT A TIME WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO DO QUITE THE
OPPOSITE -- IN FOR THOSE REASONS --
WERE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEE NINE QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY IS THERE A MOTION ON THE
BILL.
OKAY AS MOTION BY STERN GROVE
AND I I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY.
THAT THIS BILL.
APPLIES TO PHARMACISTS AND
FACILITIES HER WORKING IN
FACILITIES WHERE THERE IS ALSO A
PHYSICIAN SO THERE'S GOING TO BE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
PHARMACIST AND THE PHYSICIAN --
AND THIS IS STILL CORRECT
EXACTLY IN THAT WERE WERE
OPERATING UNDER THE PROTOCOLS OF
THE PHYSICIAN WE'RE NOT HANGER
SHINGLE OUT AN INDEPENDENT
PHARMACY BECAUSE SAYING COME ONE
COME ALL OVER TO TREAT YOUR
ATTENTION -- I I WILL RATE
THOUGH THAT -- EVEN WITHOUT THIS
AGREEMENT PHARMACISTS ARE
LEGALLY ALLOWED TO TAKE BLOOD
PRESSURES AND LET THE PATIENT
KNOW REGULAR HIGH OR LOW AND WE
WHAT WE DO REFER THEM TO A
PHYSICIAN.
THIS IS MORE IN A HEALTH CARE
SETTING WERE PHARMACISTS IS
WORKING IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
POSITION WITH ESTABLISHED
PROTOCOLS TO KEEP.
KEEP AN EYE ON THESE PATIENTS
AND STOP THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF
DEATH AND NOW IN THE UNITED
STATES BUT THE WORLD IN.
REDUCING MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY
ASSOCIATED HYPERTENSION AND I
WANT TO THANK-- SENATOR PAN THE
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS BILL I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE THE OPPOSITION
ON THIS AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
COME TO A CONSENSUS.
AND APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
TONIGHT OKAY SO THAT IT WOULD
THAT BE YOUR CLOTHES AND YES
OKAY THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE
YOU WORKING WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
BUILDING TO SCHOOL AT THIS
OPPORTUNITY -- FOR FOR FOR
FIFTEEN DAYS CARE WITH A WITH A
WITH A LEADING ROLE FOR THE
PHARMACIST THANK YOU.
SO WITH THAT.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER GROVE
THE MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI AN ICE STONE STONE I'D
DORADO.
DRUGS -- I GROWTH.
GROUP I HEARD TOTO.
TOTO AYE LEYVA THEY'VE AYE
MITCHELL.
HI MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING
AYE RUBIO.
REVIEW BY.
NINE BILLS OUT NINE ZERO OKAY --
CENTER STONE YOU -- GO ONCE MORE
GIVE YOU THE GAVEL AND WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB FIVE A THREE CONSULTING
[inaudible] ONE ONE YEAH YES
THANK YOU.
STRUCTURE SENATORS SB FIVE OH
THREE WOULD PRESENT IT WOULD
STRENGTHEN OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY OF MEDI CAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS WHEN THOSE PLANS
SUBCONTRACTS SERVICES AND
DELEGATE RESPONSIBILITIES.
MEDI CAL NOW PROVIDES HEALTH
CARE SERVICES FOR OVER THIRTEEN
MILLION PEOPLE MEDI CAL MANAGED
CARE PARTICULARS GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY PROVIDES CARE 482%
OF ALL ENROLLEES.
AND WHILE THE PART OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES CONTRACTS WITH
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS THEMSELVES
ARE PERMITTED TO SUBCONTRACT NOR
TO COORDINATE PROVIDE CARE TO
ENROLLEES.
MANAGED CARE PLANS MAY
SUBCONTRACT WITH A NUMBER OF
ENTITIES INCLUDING INDEPENDENT
PRACTICES ASSOCIATIONS MEDICAL
GROUP MANAGEMENT SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS AND EVEN OTHER
HEALTH PLANS.
AND SOME CASES THE DELEGATED
ENTITIES WILL FURTHER
SUBCONTRACT THEIR PATIENT CARE
AND ADMINISTRATIVE
RESPONSIBILITIES I THINK OUR
MEMBERS FROM LA PARTICULAR
FAMILIAR WITH THAT -- THE LAYERS
OF SUBCONTRACTING ARE COMPLEX
AND OFTEN LACK APPROPRIATE
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT
UNFORTUNATELY RECENT EVENTS
ILLUSTRATE THE PATIENT CARE CAN
SUFFER BECAUSE OF THIS.
A WHISTLE BLOWER COMPLAINT
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SHED LIGHT ON
THE SUBCULTURE TRACTOR
FALSIFYING DOCUMENTS RELATE TO
PATIENT THE NILES OF CARE THIS
IS FOLLOWED BY ANOTHER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALLEGING A DIFFERENT A
DIFFERENT ENTITY WAS PERFORMING
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
INAPPROPRIATELY.
SB FIVE OH THREE WILL HELP
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THE BILL WILL
STRENGTHEN BEACH CS IS ABILITY
TAKE ACTION WHEN THERE ARE
REPORTS OF PROBLEMATIC BEHAVIOR
BY HEALTH PLANS -- THEIR
SUBCONTRACTORS ESTABLISH AUDIT
RETIREMENTS INCLUDING REQUIRING
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
ANNUALLY AUDIT THEIR
SUBCONTRACTORS AND CONDUCTS
SURPRISE AUDITS REPEAT REPORT
WOULD SUBCONTRACTOR ACTIONS
RESULT IN THE BENEFICIARY
GRIEVANCE OR PEEL.
AND MAKE CLEAR THAT MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SERVICES
PROVIDED TO BENEFICIARIES
REGARDLESS OF ANY SUBCONTRACTING
DELEGATION OR SUB DELEGATION
PROTECT CONSTRUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND SUBCONTRACTING
ENTITIES I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
I SUSPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
I WITNESSES AND SUPPORT WELCOME.
GOOD EVENING LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
PROVIDE GREATER OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY OF MEDI CAL PLANS
THE DELEGATE RESPONSIBILITY TO
SUBCONTRACTS. TOO OFTEN WHEN
PLANS SUBCONTRACT TO ENSURE
ENROLLEES GET ACCESS TO REQUIRED
SERVICE THESE.
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PROVIDING THE
SERVICES GET LOST AS A RESULT OF
POORLY MANAGED SUBCONTRACTS MEDI
CAL ENROLLEES CAN EXPERIENCE A
LAYS IN THEIR KEY CARE AS SEEN
IN TWO DIFFERENT WHISTLE BLOWER
CASES IN LESS THAN A YEAR.
THAT IMPACTED THOUSANDS OF MEDI
CAL ENROLLEES.
AND REPORTED THAT PATIENTS WERE
IMPROPERLY DENIED OR DELAYED
CARE.
THE VARYING LEVELS OF DELEGATION
COMPLICATES MONITORING AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SO THAT MEDI CAL
ENROLLEES ARE LEFT TO RELY ON
WHISTLEBLOWERS RATHER THAN A
ROBUST OVERSIGHT MECHANISM.
THIS BILL STRAIGHTENED STATE
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY OVER MEDI CAL PLAN
SUBCONTRACT AND DRIVE VOTE
MEMBERS JESS CAM RANH WITHOUT
ACCESS CALIFORNIA THE STATE WHAT
CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION I'M
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE OH THREE OVER 80% OF MEN A
CALLOUS THIRTEEN MILLION
ENROLLEES RECEIVE BENEFITS
THROUGH MEDICARE MEDICAID
MEDICARE PLANS THIS BILL MAKES
IT CLEAR THAT MEDI CAL MANAGED
CLEAR PAT.
CARE PLANS BEAR RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE SERVICES PROVIDED TO
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES.
REGARDLESS OF SOME CAUGHT
SUBCONTRACTING DELEGATION AND
SUB DELEGATION.
SB FIVE OH THREE WOULD REQUIRE
THAT MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS.
TO CONDUCT INTO MY AUDIENCES OF
CONTRACTORS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PATIENT
CARE OFTEN SUFFERS IN THEIR
LAYERS OF DELEGATION AND SUB
DELEGATION OF THE APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT AND TRANSPARENCY. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB FIVE OH THREE AN
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
YOU.
GOOD EVENING BILL BARCELONA
AMERICA'S PHYSICIAN GROUPS -- WE
ARE AT THE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THESE -- DELEGATED
ENTITIES.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THEM IF
AMENDED POSITION ON THIS BILL
WE'VE HAD -- PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPONSORS.
AND THE AUTHOR AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE OF THAT.
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT A FEW
THINGS -- ABOUT THIS SITUATION --
FROM THE PROVIDER'S PERSPECTIVE
THE MORE AUDITS ARE NOT ALWAYS
BETTER -- WE HAVE ONE
ORGANIZATION IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THAT'S BEING AUDITED --
SLIGHTLY UNDER TWO THOUSAND
TIMES PER YEAR SOMETIMES THREE
TIMES PER DAY -- WE NEED --
STREAMLINED OTTER PROCESSES WE
NEED.
AUDITOR'S WHO WERE ACTUALLY
COMPETENT WHO UNDERSTAND MANAGE
CARE -- MECHANISMS.
AND WE NEED A CONFORMITY BETWEEN.
THE REGULATIONS AND LAWS BETTER --
IT MINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY
INCONSISTENCIES.
AND PROVIDERS ARE LEFT NOT
KNOWING WHAT STANDARDS THEY
SHOULD BE COMPLYING WITH SO WE
LOOK FORWARD -- TO FOR THE WORK
ON THIS BILL AND WE DO THINK
IT'S NECESSARY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE OTHER ANY
OTHER SUPPORTERS PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO AGAIN JENNIFER ALLEY WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS -- FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHORED SPONSORING HAD WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION WE'VE HAD ONE VERY GOOD --
MEETING WITH THE THE AUTHOR
STAFF AND AND THE SPONSORS AND
WE'VE DRAFTED SOME AMENDMENTS BY
MEMBERS ARE REVIEWING THOSE NOW
AND WE HOPE TO CIRCLE BACK TO
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
YOU KNOW OUR OUR OUR MEMBERS ARE
VERY TECHNICAL I WON'T GET INTO
THE WEEDS BUT YOU KNOW WE DO
HAVE I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CONTRACTING MEDI CAL MANAGED
CARE PLAN IS RESPONSIBLE. FOR
THE ENTITIES THAT THEY DO HAVE
SUBCONTRACTS WITH AND SO IT IS
SOMETHING THAT MY MEMBERS TAKE
VERY SERIOUSLY AND WE ARE.
HAVE SIMILAR CONCERNS WITH THE
THE THINGS THAT MR A BARCELONA
SAID BUT YOU WE WE DO WANNA MOVE
FORWARD IN AND COME TO A GOOD
SOLUTION. TO MAKE SURE THAT THEN
RELEASE OR RESPONSIBLE TO
PROVIDE CARE FOR I DO HAVE
ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY OTHER
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SING ON A COME BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR RAWSON [inaudible]
SO.
SENATOR LEYVA MOVE THE BILL --
WHICH LIKELY CLOSING STATEMENT
EXPECT THE ASSN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THIS IS -- GOING.
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
CAN.
I CAN AYE STONE AYE STONE AYE
DORADO.
DRUGS WHO I GROW.
GROW BY HER TOTAL.
TOTAL AYE LEYVA THEY'VE AYE
MITCHELL.
I MORNING FUNDING I RUBIO
[inaudible]
RUBIO BY [inaudible]
CONTENT. NINE NINE ZERO WORD OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- NEXT TACO
AYE LEYVA THEY'VE AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MORNING I
RUBIO.
HI CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT NINE
ZERO OKAY NOW WE'RE GOING TO
REOPEN THE ROLE ON BILLS THAT
ARE.
THAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING SO WITH
A START OKAY GOT A LETTER
SECRETARY ORGANIZED OKAY
STARTING WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
TWO SEVENTY SIX PAN ON
IMMUNIZATIONS SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS ARE
TADO.
HER TOTAL I SO THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN TWO OKAY NEXUS ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB ELEVEN BY SENATOR BELL --
SECRET PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS CERRADO.
DRAWS -- BY HER TANTO.
HER TOTAL BY [inaudible]
SOMEONE.
TO SORRY.
OKAY THAT BILL WAS OUT TO SEVEN
ONE THANK YOU.
THE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB ONE FIFTY SIX BY
SENATOR NIELSEN SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THAT MEMBERS.
TORONTO.
DRAWS I HER TACO.
TACO I IN LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MITCHELL I THAT BILLS OUT --
NINE ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB THREE EIGHTY TWO
BY SENATOR NIELSEN ACEKARD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT SIR
TADO.
TOTAL AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
MITCHELL HI.
THAT BILL IS ALSO OUT -- NINE
ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB FOUR FORTY SIX BY
CENTER STONE.
A DOWNTURN THAT IS OUT OKAY ALL
RIGHTS ONE OKAY THANK YOU SORRY --
NEXT ONE IS ACTUALLY ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR JACKSON'S -- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR TOTO HER TOTAL I'VE
RUBIO [inaudible]
REVIEW BY.
THE BILL IS OUT NINE ZERO SIX
ITEMS ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB
SIX HUNDRED BUT CENTER
PORTANTINO SIX THREE THESE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS RAZA.
DRUGS ARE A GROVE HER TAUGHT IN.
A TOTAL AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT
ZERO X. ITEMS I'M NUMBER --
FIFTEEN S. SAID DONE OR NOT.
SORRY I DIDN'T HAVE THAT IS.
FIFTEEN IS NOT HAD FIFTEEN OUT
OF FIFTIES ARE OKAY ALL RIGHT
SORRY I JUST -- THAN MARK OKAY
THANKS ITEMS I AND NUMBER
SIXTEEN SB SIX EIGHTY NINE BY
CENTER MORE LOCK -- CHAIR VOTING
NO SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARE TADO
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
MONNING.
NOPE SORRY MORNING NO. ONE TWO
SIX TWO SIX OKAY THAT BILL FAILS
TO SIX WERE GRANTING
RECONSIDERATION.
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR --
NEXT BILL THIS ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SP FOUR CITIES.
SB FIVE SEVEN FORTY SIX BY
CENTER BATES SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS ARE
TADO.
HER TOTAL I RUBIO.
RUBIO HI.
THAT BILL WAS OUT NINE ZERO AND
FINALLY ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE
SB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT BY CENTER
PORTANTINO SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT SOME MEMBERS
DORADO.
DORADO AYE HER TADO TOTO AYE
LEYVA.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO BY.
THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO OKAY
THAT'S EVERYTHING THAT'S OKAY
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA BEFORE
WE CONCLUDE SO I AGAINST THANK
US CENTER STONE I KNOW HE'S LEFT
FOR HIS WONDERFUL JOB THAT
SHARING IS VICE CHAIR.
AND WITH THAT WE COMPLETED THE
AGENDA FOR THIS HEARING THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND I
DO WANT TO YES THANK YOU CENTER
MITCHELL.
THANK YOU SERGEANTS FOR YOUR
AMAZING JOB TODAY AND IT WAS
VERY DIFFICULT I ALSO I THINK
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE STAFF FOR A
LOT OF VERY HARD WORK.
AS WELL AND WITH CHAIR WELL
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT THIS
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA OF THE CITY
AT THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU